THE CALL TO ORDER THIS HEARING
OF THE SENATE BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE.
NUMBER THREE ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES -- WE HAVE TWO PARTS TO
THE HEARING SO IN PART A WILL BE
DEALING.
WITH THE PAR REHABILITATION AND
DEPARTMENT OF AMOUNTS OF
SERVICES AND THEN PART B. WE
HAVE A VARIETY OF PROPOSALS --
FROM THE OFFICE OF SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION DEPARTMENTS HEALTH
CARE TO PHARMACY HOSPITALS AND
THE MENTAL HEALTH -- OVERSIGHT
ADVISORY COMMITTEE -- SO WILL
WELCOME EVERYONE -- WE ARE NOT
TAKING ANY ACTIONS AT THIS TIME
AT THE HEARING SO -- EVERYTHING
STILL ON HOLD BUT THAT THIS
PROBABLY RECKON GUESSES WERE
APPROACHING MAY THIS MADE NOW
BUT AFTER MAY REVISE THAT WILL
BE CHANGING -- WE HAVE -- THERE
ARE THINGS JUST TO REMIND
EVERYONE -- THAT -- WE WILL BE --
FIRST AFTER HEARING FROM THE
AGENCY MAY HAVE SOME STAKEHOLDER
PROPOSALS AND THEN ADD A COMMENT
AT THE MICROPHONE -- MAX BY
PHONE -- WE ASK THAT YOU TRY TO
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO A MINUTE
AND ALSO IF SOMEONE ELSE READY
SAID WHAT YOU'RE GONNA SAY.
ME TOO OR DID -- WHO WORKS -- AS
WE HAVE MANY ITEMS ON THE AGENDA
THAT WE NEED TO GET THROUGH --
JUST TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF THE
FLOW FOR PART A WE WILL HEAR
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION --
THREE ISSUES IN THE WILL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE END OF ALL
THREE ISSUES.
WHEN WE GET TO THE APARTMENT
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES WILL HEAR
THE OVERVIEW AND THEN ISSUES ONE
THROUGH -- THREE WILL DO PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THAT BECAUSE I THINK
PEOPLE MAY HAVE SOMETHING STABLE
ISSUE TWO AND THREE WILL DO THEN
DO ISSUES FOUR THROUGH -- EIGHT
BECAUSE THIS HAVE TO DO THE
STREET MANY OF THEM HAVE TO DO
WITH THE STRUCTURE OF THE
AGENCIES WELL AS THE CLOSURE THE
HOSPITALS AND THEN WE'LL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THOSE ISSUES
AS A GROUP AND THEN FINALLY.
WILL DO ISSUES NINE THREE
THIRTEEN WHICH INCLUDE SOME AT
THE POLLS ARE VESTMENT WILL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF
THAT -- SO JUST SO PEOPLE KNOW
WHAT TO EXPECT FOR PART A SO
WITH THAT -- WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND BEGIN WITH THE PARTNER
REHABILITATION SO A WELCOME UP --
REHABILITATION WITH THE FINANCE
IN THE ALLEY -- THANK YOU THREE
MUCH.
AND FOR THE RECORD.
ASK EVERYONE INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES.
RIGHT THE SAYS BECAUSE GO AHEAD
AND START WITH THE THE
REPRESENTS FROM THE PART
REHABILITATION.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU -- IS THAT ON A SONG
SINGLE A CLOSER.
SO THANK YOU WAS SENATOR SEVEN
GLAD TO BE HERE GLAD TO SHARE
WITH YOU -- OVERVIEW OF OUR
DEPARTMENT IS EXACTLY GOING TO
BE ABLE JUST INTRODUCTIONS
MILLION TO THE OVERVIEW I'M
SORRY TO SEE THE DIRECTOR FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION.
CAPPING HOURS MORE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION OF
SPEC A HE CAN REPEAT THAT FOR
THE MAKES SENSE A HAPPY HOURS
MORE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION.
IRENE WILL LAY LE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION JOCHEM DEPARTMENT
OF REHABILITATION HELLO.
TONY PETTITT KALLIO.
MARKET IN LA -- FINANCE WHICH
WAS WROTE APARTMENT FINANCE OKAY
THANK YOU SO WE'RE GONNA GO
pAHEAD BEGIN THE OVERVIEW WE HAVE
AN EXCELLENT RIGHT UP TO BUY --
STAFF SO WE CAN SORT OF HIT THE
HIGH POINTS OF WHAT'S GOING ON
IN THE DEPARTMENT AND ALSO.
WHAT YOU SEE COMING IN THE NEXT
BUDGET YEAR AND I THINK WE DID
HAVE -- AND WHEN THE DISH NO
QUESTION THAT YOU CAN TRY TO
ADDRESS AS WELL MORE SPECIFIC
QUESTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOUR THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE YOUR VIEW
AND AND I'LL BE BRIEF ON THIS
AND YOU HAVE A COMPRESS CASUAL.
SO US IS -- TO IS THE AGENDA
GIVES YOU THAT GOOD OVERVIEW OF
OUR DEPARTMENT IN OUR PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES YOU BEST THIS IS
SPEAK TO THROUGH QUESTIONS ALL
STAR WITH.
MORE ACCOMPLISHMENTS IN THE
CHALLENGES AND THEN THE
STRATEGIES TO CONTINUE SERVING
ADULTS.
SO.
IN TERMS OF OUR ACCOMPLISHMENTS
TEN THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS TODAY FOR ON THE
PATH OUT OF POVERTY COME THROUGH
EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE OF THE
SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE I THINK
IT'S A HALLMARK.
OF THE WORK THAT WE DO.
AS WELL AS THE WORK THAT WE DO
THROUGH OUR INDEPENDENT LIVING
SERVICES -- FIFTY ONE
INDIVIDUALS ARE NO LONGER
INSTITUTIONALIZED BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TRANSITIONED INTO COMMUNITY
LIVING IN THERE ARE THIRTY TWO
INDIVIDUALS OVER THE AGE OF ONE
HUNDRED OR BLIND.
WHO CONTINUE TO LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITY BECAUSE OF THE
SERVICES OF PROVIDE AND JUST A
SAMPLE OF THE WORK THAT WE DO?
ONE OF THE OTHER THINGS THAT WE
OFFER A PRODUCT THAT WE'RE DOING.
ISRAEL YOU ESTABLISHING A
SYSTEMS ALIGNMENT THAT ENSURES
THAT THE SERVICES THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING OR SEAMLESS TO THAT
INDIVIDUAL ENSURING THAT THAT
ALIGNMENT IS EFFECTIVE WE APPLY
THE PRINCIPLES OF PERSON
CENTERED IN PERSON DRIVEN.
WHICH ALLOWS US TO INDIVIDUALIZE
THE SERVICES TO EACH CONSUMER NO
MATTER WHETHER THEY'RE
INDEPENDENT LIVING OR IN A
VOCATIONAL BILL THE TATIAN.
AND OF COURSE THE WHOLE PERSON
CARE WHICH ALLOWS US TO ADDRESS --
MORE HOLISTICALLY WHAT THAT
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS TO EITHER.
BE EMPLOYED OR TO CONTINUE TO BE
INDEPENDENT AND THEN UNIVERSAL
DESIGN WHICH CONTINUES TO
ADVANCE -- ACCESSIBILITY AND
USABILITY IN ALL SYSTEMS FOR
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
WE OF COURSE CONTINUE TO
IMPLEMENT OF THE WORKFORCE
INNOVATION AND OPPORTUNITY ACT.
WE CONTINUE TO EVOLVE OUR
SERVICES TO YOU WHO WERE STILL
IN HIGH SCHOOL AND THOSE
SERVICES ARE AIMED TO ENSURE
THAT THEY ARE MAXIMALLY PREPARED.
TO BEGIN THE JOURNEY INTO THE
WORKPLACE.
AND PART OF THAT -- IS TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE.
SERVICES SO THAT THEY KNOW WHAT
TO POST SECONDARY OPTIONS OR
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION SAID
CETERA.
WE ALSO THEN OF COURSE CONTINUE
THE WORK -- TO ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE -- INSULTED
WORKSHOPS ARE RECEIVING THE
COUNSELING.
IN THE GUIDANCE IS THAT ALLOWS
THEM TO TRANSITION FROM THOSE --
INTO COMPETITIVE IN A GREAT
EMPLOYMENT.
THE OTHER PART TO WE'RE WORKING
ON IS MODERNIZING OUR
REHABILITATION EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES SO THAT WE ARE.
GOAL OF ENSURING.
THAT WERE MEETING THE COMMUNITY
OR THE TALENT NEEDS OF THE
BUSINESSES THAT ARE DOING THE
HIRING AS WELL IS MAKING SURE
THAT THEY'RE READY TO HIRE
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
ON OUR PROMISE SIDE BOB WAS VERY
PROUD OF THE FACT THAT WE ARE
KNOWN YOUR SIX OF THAT GRANT
WITH WRAPPING THAT UP BUT THAT
GRANT HAS BEEN INVALUABLE TO
INFORM OUR STUDENTS SERVICES.
AS WELL AS THE HIGHLIGHT NEED TO
SIZE THE CULTURE AND SYSTEMS
ALIGNMENT THAT WE NEED TO BETTER
SERVE THE YOUTH IN THE FAMILY.
THE COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
BLUEPRINT -- CONTINUES WARRANT
IN YOUR TO OF THAT
IMPLEMENTATION WE'RE MAKING
GREAT PROCESS PROGRESS WITHOUT
WORKING WITH.
OUR PARTNERS A DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES AS WELL AS A SPECIAL
EDUCATION -- AND THERE'S A
NUMBER OF ACTIONS THAT WE'VE
TAKEN THERE TO CONTINUE.
TO ADVANCE THAT INITIATIVE.
THE OTHER THING THAT I WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU IS THE WHAT WE
DO WITH OUR INDEPENDENT LIVING
SERVICES IN THEIR WE CONTINUE TO
ADVANCE YOU ALMOST A DECISION SO
PEOPLE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LIVE IN THE COMMUNITY -- WITH
DIGNITY AND PURPOSE -- FREEDOM
OF CHOICE.
WE ARE ENSURING THAT THEY'RE
CONNECTED TO HEALTHCARE SOLD --
THEIR HEALTHCARE IS RESTORED AND
AVAILABLE TO CONTINUE TO BE
INDEPENDENT ENSURING HOW.
INFLUENCE THE HOW HEALTH CARE
LOOKS AT THAT INDIVIDUAL SO THEY
CAN MEET THEIR NEEDS AS
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES.
AND IN A DENTAL FINE SYSTEMS --
AND HELPING EDUCATE PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE THOSE SYSTEMS TO BE
MORE INCLUSIVE OF THEIR SERVICES.
AS AN EXAMPLE OF SOME OF THE
ALIGNMENT THE AGING AND
DISABILITY RESOURCE CENTERS --
STAND OUT AS A IN ONE WAY OR
INDEPENDENT LIVING -- YES
PARTNERING COLLABORATING WITH
OTHER SYSTEMS.
SO YOU ASKED US TO BRIEFLY SPEAK
TO THE CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE.
I'M GETTING PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES EMPLOYED WHILE WE
COULD NOT BE MORE PROUD OF THE
FACT THAT WE TRULY FOCUS ON
LEAVING NO ONE BEHIND.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT WE RECOGNIZE
THAT TODAY WE'RE SERVING
INDIVIDUALS WITH MOST
SIGNIFICANT DISABILITIES AND IN
MANY CASES MULTIPLE DISABILITIES
COULD BE SENSORY LOSS
DEVELOPMENTAL -- ANY NUMBER OF
COMBINATIONS ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE CONTINUE TO
WORK ON IS THAT FOR STALLING
THAT INDIVIDUALS READINESS FOR
EMPLOYMENT.
IT'S REALLY HAVEN'T LIVED A LIFE
OF LITTLE OR NO EXPECTATION THAT
EMPLOYMENT WOULD BE A REALITY.
AND SO WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
ALL SYSTEMS AND ALL PARTNERS TO
CHANGE THAT.
WHY THAT'S AN ISSUE IS BECAUSE
OFTEN?
WHEN THAT INDIVIDUAL COMES TO US
FOR SERVICES IT'S THE?
IT'S NOT THE FIRST BUT IT'S VERY
CLOSE TO THE FIRST TIME THAT THE
REALLY ENGAGING IN THAT
CONVERSATION THAT SAYS WORK AS
POSSIBLE AND THEN OF COURSE THAT
SKILL DEVELOPMENT IS THEN
BEGINNING.
THERE WHICH IS A LITTLE BIT TOO
LATE FOR US SO WE'LL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THAT.
THE OTHER THING THAT'S WHICH
WILL CONTAIN ONLY CHALLENGED
WITH IS THAT INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES OFTEN DON'T START
AT THE SAME PLACES THEIR NON
DISABLED COUNTERPARTS.
IN THE OPPORTUNITIES AVAILABLE
TO THEM CERTAINLY ARE THE SAME
SO THEIR PATH AND THE LENGTH OF
TIME THAT IT TAKES A TRAVEL THAT
PATH CAN BE DIFFERENT SO PART OF
WHAT WE DO.
IS THAT WHOLE SYSTEMS ALIGNMENT
THAT WILL HELP -- TO CHANGE SOME
OF THOSE REALITIES.
SO FOR SOME CONTEXT THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE WITH PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES CONTINUES TO
PERSISTENTLY BE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF 70%.
BUSINESS IS BEING OPEN TO AND
HIRING PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES --
IS ANOTHER AREA THAT WE CONTINUE
TO BE CHALLENGED AND PART OF
THAT -- IS RECOGNIZING THAT A
BUSINESS REALLY IS ANYONE THAT
MAKES A HIGHER WHETHER IT BE A
GOVERNMENT FOR PROFIT FOR PROFIT
NONPROFIT DOESN'T MATTER IT'S
ANYBODY THAT REALLY MAKES A
HIGHER.
SO ADDRESSING.
FROM THEIR FEARS AND CONCERNS IS
PARAMOUNT -- AND WHAT SOME OF
THOSE FEARS AND CONCERNS CAN BE --
YOU KNOW WHAT'S THE RISK HOW AM
I GOING TO ACCOMMODATE WHAT IF
YOU KNOW ANY NUMBER OF TYPES OF
THINGS LIKE THAT MEDIC IT'S
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
WHILE TO DATE.
WE SEE PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
AND SOCIETY MUCH MORE THAN EVER
BEFORE ENTERTAINMENT IT CETERA.
WE STILL HAVE A WAYS TO GO WHERE
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES ARE
SEEN AS HAVING THE SAME TALENT
IN THE SAME POTENTIAL AND GIVEN
THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES SO -- IN
TERMS OF A CHALLENGE THAT'S AN
AREA THAT WE FACE SYSTEMS
ALIGNMENT AS I MENTIONED WE'RE
WORKING ON IT.
IT STILL HAS IN THE CHI.
WELL -- YOU KNOW THE THE WHAT IT
NEEDS TO BE IN ORDER TO HAVE THE
EFFECTIVE THAT IT NEEDS TO HAVE
SO.
AREAS THAT WE CONTINUE TO LOOK
AT THEM.
AND THEN FINALLY YOU **** TO
ADDRESS ONE OF THE STRATEGIES TO
CONTINUE TO GET INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES AND EMPLOYMENT
GIVEN OUR SHIFT TO SERVING
STUDENTS -- OUR MISSION BASED
REVIEW -- REALLY JUST FIRST OF
ALL THANK OUR COLLEAGUES AT
FINANCE FOR THE WORK THAT WE'VE
DONE COLLECTIVELY THEY ARE -- IT
REALLY FOCUSED ON OUR CORE
MISSION AND THE AND THE WORK
THAT WE DO TO DRIVE THAT MISSION.
AND THEN TODAY'S -- BUDGET ITEMS
CERTAINLY OUR REFLECTION OF THAT --
WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES AND
THAT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE
MORE THAT WE CAN GET THEM READY
FOR EMPLOYMENT THEY WHEN THEY
HIT ADULTHOOD.
THE BE LESS OF THE DEMAND ON THE
ADULT SYSTEM FOR THEM TO GET A
WORK.
AND HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A
LONGSTANDING.
COLLABORATION PARTNERSHIP OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION.
SO WILL CONTINUE TO EVOLVE THAT --
IN SUPPORT OF GETTING THE KIDS
READY FOR EMPLOYMENT.
WE ARE USING A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT MODELS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WITH A LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES TO DO THAT
WITHIN OUR ADULT SERVICES
SPECIFICALLY -- WE'RE LEANING
HEAVILY ON SYSTEMS ALIGNMENT SO
THAT WE CAN LEVERAGE THAT
WORKPLACES SUPPORTS AND WORK
READINESS SUPPORTS THAT EXIST IN
THE OTHER SYSTEMS.
AND THEN BE ABLE -- TO DO THEY
ARE WE ARE REALLY LOOKING AT OUR
FIELD -- STRUCTURE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WERE BETTER POSITION TO
ALIGN WITH THE SYSTEMS
PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT FLOW OF
THE LOCAL LEVEL SUCH AS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND WHAT HAVE YOU.
AND THEN I MENTIONED BUSINESS
ENGAGEMENT MORE PRADA THE FACT
THAT WE'RE WORKING ON THAT.
BUT WE REALLY NEED TO CONTINUE
TO SHAPE -- THOSE ATTITUDES THAT
EXIST OUT THERE AND SO PART OF
WHAT WE DO IS WE CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
EDUCATION. TO THE BUSINESS
PARTNERS AND AND TO HELP THEM TO
HAVE A WORKPLACE THAT IS A
DOMINATING IN WELCOMING FOR
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES SO.
STOP THEIR TAKING THE QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE OR WE CAN PROCEED WITH
OUR OTHER GENDER.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT -- COMMENTS FROM LA --
FINANCE QUESTION MANY MEMBERS --
I DID HAVE.
ONE I DO HAVE A QUESTION
REGARDING -- IN.
TERMS OF THE REVIEW -- THE THE I
GUESS IT'S CALLED SEE A PROMISE
GRANT.
BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND THAT ONLY
GOES THROUGH SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH
OF THIS YEAR -- IS IS THAT
ENDING THEN OR WHAT'S WHAT'S THE
FUTURE OF THAT -- SO THIS GRANT
IN ITS FIFTH YEAR AND IT'S GONNA
CONCLUDED THE AND THIS COMING
YEAR.
IS THAT WHAT WHAT'S THE FUTURE
OF THAT PROGRAM AS A GUN JUST
ENDERS AT IS THERE ARE SOME PLAN
FOR THE FUTURE AND SEE IF BUDGET
ITEM SOMETHING RELATE TO THAT SO.
SO SO PROMISE CONTINUES NOT IN
THE IN THE SAME CONTEXT TO IT
WITH THE SAME FRAME THAT IT THAT
IT EXISTED WHICH REALLY WAS A
STUDY. TO IDENTIFY THE
INTERVENTIONS THAT WOULD BE
SUPPORT OF OF REDUCING THE
RELIANCE ON KIDS.
WHO IN THIS CASE WERE ON SOCIAL
SECURITY SUPPLEMENTAL SECURITY
INCOME?
SO WHERE THAT CONTINUES AREAS OF
THAT THE LESSONS LEARNED THE
INTERVENTIONS BARBIE AND BLENDED
INTO OUR CONTINUED WORK WHAT
PROVIDING SERVICES TO STUDENTS.
ONE THING OF NOTE HERE IS THAT
ONE PROMISE WAS ISSUED.
SHORTLY AFTER THAT IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN THE
WORKFORCE INNOVATION AND
OPPORTUNITY ACT WHICH WE
AUTHORIZED WE HAVE BACKED CAME
OUT AND THAT'S WHERE IT MANDATED.
TO SERVICES TO STUDENTS SO IT
DOES THE SERVICES TO THE
STUDENTS TO DO CNTINUE.
IT'S NO LONGER CONTINUING AS A
STUDY WITH THE RIVERS OF THE
STUDY VERY MUCH HAS INFORMED AND
WILL CONTINUE TO INFORM HOW WE
SERVE THE YOUTH AND THEIR
FAMILIES [inaudible]
SO BASICALLY.
IN SOME WAYS THIS PROGRAM WHICH
SHE SAID WAS A STUDY IS REALLY
BEING FOLDED INTO THE WORKFORCE
INNOVATION OPPORTUNITY
ACTIVITIES CRISIS CORRECT ALL
RIGHT.
OKAY.
THAT'S HELPFUL TO KNOW ALL RIGHT --
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OKAY SO --
THANK YOU SO LET'S GO AHEAD AND
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO
WHICH IS THE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL FOR MISSION BASED
REVIEW VOCATIONAL REHABILITATION
TBI PROGRAMS.
I CAN GO AHEAD AND START ITEM TO
A IS IN REGARDS TO KERR OUR
COMMUNITY REHABILITATION.
RIGHT SO AS JOE MENTIONED -- WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN COLLABORATIVE IN
NATURE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS
ON THE MISSION BASED REVIEW.
AND ONE OF THE PRIMARY IN
CRITICAL AGENDA ITEMS THAT CAME
OUT OF THAT WAS THE NEED TO
INCREASE RATES FOR COMMUNITY RE
HAVE PARTNERS WHO PARTNER WITH
US ON A DAILY BASIS TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO OUR CONSUMERS.
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL INCLUDES TO
SPECIFIC ITEMS FIRST THERE IS AN
ACROSS THE BOARD 10% RATE
INCREASE FOR SERVICES PROVIDED
BY OUR COMMUNITY REHAB PROGRAMS
WITH SOME EXPECTED EXCEPTIONS
THAT ALL EXPLAIN IN A FEW
MOMENTS.
SECONDLY FOR THOSE SERVICES THAT
INCLUDE A CONSUMER MINIMUM WAGE
COMPONENTS SPECIFICALLY
SITUATIONAL ASSESSMENT.
AND WORK ADJUSTMENT THERE WILL
ALSO BE A RATE ADJUSTMENT THERE
TO ACCOMMODATE THAT.
THE SERVICES THAT WILL RECEIVE A
10% RATE INCREASE INCLUDE
VOCATIONAL ASSESSMENTS PERSONAL
VOCATIONAL SOCIAL ADJUSTMENT.
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES LEAD
SERVICES THAT WERE FIRM FORMALLY
KNOWN AS COMMUNICATION AND
LANGUAGE SKILLS TRAINING FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH HEARING
IMPAIRMENTS.
INDEPENDENT LIVING SKILLS
TRAINING ORIENTATION MOBILITY A
MERCHANT SERVICES REHAB
TECHNOLOGY WHICH INCLUDES
ASSISTIVE TECHNOLOGY EVALUATION
AND TRAINING SERVICES.
SITUATIONAL ASSESSMENT AND WORK
IT JUST MEANT.
THE LAST TWO SERVICES THAT I
MENTION SITUATIONAL ASSESSMENT
AND WORKING JUST MEANT HAVE A
CONSUMER MINIMUM WAGE COMPONENT
TO THAT.
WHICH MEANS THAT A CONSUMER
PARTICIPATES IN THE SERVICE AND
IS PAID FOR THEIR TIME IN THE
WORK THAT THEY ARE DOING WHILE
THEY ARE UNDER SERVICE.
OUR COMMUNITY REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN PROVIDING FOR
THE INCREASE IN MINIMUM WAGE FOR
THE CONSUMERS INVOLVED WITHOUT
HAVING A RATE CHANGE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE SO THIS
PROPOSAL SECONDLY -- PROPOSES TO
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS THAT
INCREASING BY FOUR DOLLARS AN
HOUR TO COMPENSATE FOR THE
INCREASE THE MINIMUM WAGE THAT
OCCURRED IT IS UP TO TWELVE
DOLLARS AN HOUR AT THIS TIME
[inaudible]
THE PROPOSED.
BUDGET DOES NOT INCLUDE ANY RATE
ADJUSTMENTS FOR SEVERAL SERVICES
FIRST OF ALL SENATE SIGN
LANGUAGE INTERPRETING AND THEN
SECONDLY NON SUPPORTED
EMPLOYMENT JOB COACHING
SUPPORTED EMPLOYMENT SERVICES
ALSO KNOWN AS JOB COACHING
SERVICES.
THE INTERPRETING RATES ARE NOT
PROPOSED TO HAVE A RATE INCREASE
BECAUSE THEY WERE LAST UPGRADED
IN APRIL OF TWO THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN TO ENSURE.
THE AVAILABILITY OF THE SERVICES
FOR CONSUMERS WHO REQUIRED IT
AND WE WERE UNABLE TO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES
WITHOUT INCREASING THAT RATE.
SECONDLY AS IT RELATES TO
SUPPORTED EMPLOYMENT INCLUDING
JOB COACHING AND NON SUPPORTED A
JOB COACHING SERVICES.
THESE WERE PREVIOUSLY INCREASED
BY THE DEPARTMENT IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN TO BE IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THE RATE
INCREASES FOR THE SAME SUPPORTED
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES IMPLANTED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES.
THIS WAS CONDUCTED THROUGH AB
TWO X. TWO DASH.
ONE THE SUPPORTED EMPLOYMENT
RATES MOST RECENTLY INCREASE IN
TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN ARE
HOUSED IN THE WELL FOR AN
INSTITUTION'S CODE AND WOULD
NEED TO BE DONE JOINTLY IF THEY
WERE GOING TO BE DONE BUT THEY
HAVE RECEIVED AN INCREASE SINCE
TWO THOUSAND AND IN. SIXTEEN FOR
AN IMPLEMENTATION PLAN ARE WE
HAVE SPECIALISTS ARE
COMMUNICATING AND ENGAGING WITH
OUR COMMUNITY RE HAVE PARTNER
STATEWIDE AND HAVE BEEN
ANSWERING QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS
REGARDING THIS PROPOSAL.
AND ADDITIONALLY IN PREPARATION
FOR THE SHIFT WE ARE PROPOSING A
pHAVE PARTNERS IN THE FIRST WEEK
OF JUNE OF TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN UPON BUDGET APPROVAL
THE PROPOSED DATE -- RATE
INCREASE WILL BE IMPLEMENTED IN
OUR CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM AND
WE'LL GO TO EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
ON JULY [inaudible]
ONE THANK YOU.
YOU HAD ASKED US -- TO SPEAK TO
A COUPLE OF ITEMS THE FIRST ITEM
IS IN REGARDS -- TO WHY WE
PROPOSE A RATE INCREASE OF 10% --
INSTEAD OF USING A DIFFERENT
METHODOLOGY WITH WHICH WAS A
COST DEVELOPMENT PURPOSE AND HOW
WE LANDED ON THE 10% AND I'M
GOING TO TURN TO MY PARTNER HERE
AT FINANCE FIRST.
THANK YOU.
YES -- ARE ALL JUST RESPOND TO
THE FIRST TWO QUESTIONS ON THE
AGENDA.
WE BELIEVE THIS IS REASON
APPROACH TO ADDRESS AN ISSUE
THAT WE COLLECTIVELY IDENTIFIED
AS PART OF THE MISSION BASED
REVIEW PROCESS.
THIS SERVES IN AN AS AN
INVESTMENT IN THE VOCATIONAL
REHABILITATION PROGRAM TO
MAINTAIN THE CRP PROVIDER POOL
AND CURRENT SERVICE LEVELS TO BE
OUR CONSUMERS.
IT ALSO BOUNCES THE NEED FOR
LONG TERM FISCAL SUSTAINABILITY.
AND PRUDENCE AN ONGOING SPENDING
COMMITMENTS WHICH IS THE THEME
OF THIS GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
AND 10% IS ALSO SIGNIFICANT
ADJUSTMENT GIVEN THE RATES OF
NOT INCREASES.
TWO THOUSAND NINE AS SUCH WE ARE
COMMITTED TO MONITORING THE
EFFECTS OF THIS INCREASE ON THE
NUMBER OF CRP PROVIDERS.
AND WILL DETERMINE IF ADDITIONAL
INCREASES NEED TO BE MADE WE'LL
ALSO ANALYZE IF THERE ARE ANY
REGIONAL WHICH GRAPHIC VARIATION
SINCERE P. PROVIDER NUMBERS DUE
TO VARIATIONS IN COST OF LIVING
OR OTHER SERVICE A PROVISION
COSTS.
AND THEN THE FOURTH QUESTION THE
FOURTH QUESTION WAS IN REGARDS
TO SOCIAL SECURITY
REIMBURSEMENTS -- AND YOU YOU
STATED AS FOLLOWS AS SOCIAL
SECURITY REIMBURSEMENTS ARE NOT
A STABLE FUNDING SOURCE.
HOW WILL THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION PLAN POSSIBLE
FUTURE -- REVENUE FLUCTUATIONS.
ULTIMATELY THE DEPARTMENT RE
HAVE MONTAGES OUR SOCIAL
SECURITY REIMBURSEMENT DOLLARS
IN IN A SPECIFIC PRIORITY ORDER --
FIRST OF ALL THERE WILL BE SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION FUNDING FOR
THE INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS
THREE POINT THREE MILLION
ASSOCIATED WITH OUR WORK
INCENTIVE PLANNERS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHAB WHO ASSIST
INDIVIDUALS.
OR SS I AND SSD I BENEFICIARIES
RECEIVE SERVICES TO BECOME
EMPLOYED WHICH RESULTS IN
REIMBURSEMENTS TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF REHABILITATION.
THIS THREE POINT FOUR MILLION
FOR COMMUNITY REHAB PROGRAM
RATES AND THEN ONE POINT SIX FOR
THE IT INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL.
OUR REVENUE OVER THE LAST FOUR
YEARS HAS MORE THAN PAID FOR THE
SERVICES AT OUR REVENUE
CURRENTLY FOR CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR UP THROUGH MARCH IS THAT IT
SEVENTEEN POINT SIX MILLION.
SO WE WILL CONTINUE TO LIVE
WITHIN OUR BUDGET WE WILL
MONITORING CONTINUE TO LIVE
WITHIN OUR BUDGET.
BUT WE PLAN TO UTILISE THIS
MONEY EFFECTIVELY CONSISTENT
WITH THE LAW [inaudible]
OKAY.
NOW COMES FROM ALEJO.
SONYA PECK ELIO.
WE WOULD JUST POINT OUT THAT --
THE THE MINIMUM WAGE COMPONENT
OF THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE TO US AND
WE DO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE RATES
HAVE NOT BEEN.
A INCREASED OTHERWISE FOR QUITE
SOME TIME -- AS HAS ALREADY BEEN
DISCUSSED THE 10% DOESN'T HAVE A
PARTICULARLY ANALYTIC BASIS AT
THIS POINT WE WE RECOGNIZE --
THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAVE
INDICATED THAT IT'S A FIRST STEP
YEAH -- TO PROVIDE SOME FISCAL
RELIEF -- TO THESE -- COMMUNITY
PROVIDERS -- AND WE'RE PLEASED
TO HEAR THAT THEY'LL CONTINUE TO
MONITOR THE EFFECT OF THAT
INCREASE ON SAY THE NUMBER OF
PROVIDERS BUT WE JUST ENCOURAGE.
THE YOU KNOW TO CONTINUING TO
LOOK AT THOSE TYPES OF METRICS
TO HAVE A GOOD SENSE OF HOW MUCH.
OF RATE INCREASES IN THE FUTURE
NEED TO BE.
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
FINANCE ON THIS OKAY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SO I GUESS FROM.
THE MONITORING AND SO FORTH AND
I APPRECIATE THE FUNDING FOR AN
INCREASE I THINK -- YELL
[inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
WELL.
IN TERMS OF BECAUSE I THINK
PRIOR TO TWO THOUSAND AND NINE
BASICALLY THERE WAS A THEY
LOOKED AT THE COST RIGHT
SERVICES RIGHT.
AND THEN THERE ON RECESSION HIT
WE SORT OF FLATTENED EVERYBODY
SO THE PROCESS SO I MEAN I GUESS-OF THE GOOD AND THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE WHO THE COSTS WERE LASSEN
THEY GOT MOVED UP TO AN AVERAGE
AND THEN OTHER PEOPLE GOT MOVED
TO REGULAR AND THEN.
DOWN RIGHT.
AND SO WERE STILL PRESERVING
THAT STRUCTURE IN MANY WAYS AND
I DON'T KNOW I MEAN IT IS SO ARE
WE AND I PRETTY SAID YOU'RE
MONITORING I MEAN.
THIS IS BEEN SINCE TWO THOUSAND
NINE I GUESS I'M.
D. E. ARE NOT CONCERNED ABOUT I
MEAN THE PEOPLE WHO PREVIOUSLY
E. L. WHO TOOK THIS ACTUALLY
MORE OF A CUT I MEAN A DAISY.
WE WERE NOT SEEN DISPROPORTIONAL
CHALLENGES IN TERMS OF THEM BILL
PROVIDE THE SERVICES - EVEN NOW
I MEAN THIS IS THIS IS NOW TEN
YEARS LATER SO IT'S SO WE CAN
SAVE MONEY TO FUTURE BUT IN
TERMS OF WE'RE DOING A 10%
ACROSS THE BOARD THAT'S GREAT --
BUT I MEAN RIGHT NOW SO YOU'RE
SAYING THAT SINCE WE DID TWO
THOUSAND NINE WE'RE NOT TOO
CONCERNED THAT WE FLATTEN IT OUT
THE DOES ANY.
SIGNIFICANT NEGATIVE EFFECT.
YEAH SALAMI START THAT OCCURRED
SENATOR SO -- AIDID.
GOOD OBSERVATIONS -- APPRECIATE
THOSE I THINK ONE THING THAT'S
WHICH CERTAINLY -- TRY TO KEEP
IN MIND AS WE KEEP LOOKING AT
ALL THIS IS.
WE OFFICER THE THE ISSUE BETWEEN
URBAN AND RURAL.
AMWAY FOR IN THE URBAN SETTING
YOU KNOW WE HAVE THE DENSITY --
WE HAVE THE DIFFICULTY OF TRAVEL
WHATEVER BUT WE ALSO HAVE THE
AVAILABILITY OF A WIDER RANGE OF
SERVICES IF YOU'RE IN A RURAL
SETTING.
YOU DON'T HAVE THE DENSITY BUT
TO CONSUMERS ARE SO MUCH FOR
THEIR SPREAD APART TO SUCH AS A
REDUCED.
LEVEL OF RESOURCES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE SO.
I THINK THERE'S A NUMBER OF
VARIABLES THAT YOU KNOW AS WE
LOOK AT THIS ACROSS THE STATE --
IN TERMS OF SETTING SORT OF A
FLAT RATE OR A COST RECOVERY
RATE OR EVEN MAKING SOME
ADJUSTMENTS -- TO SO MANY
VARIABLES GO INTO THAT -- I
THINK AS WE CONTINUE TO MOVE FOR
WHICH CERTAINLY GOING TO KEEP
ALL OF THIS IN MIND -- THUS FAR
THOUGH WE HAVEN'T SEEN -- COME
TO THE CONCLUSION THAT MAKING
THAT SHIFT TO A DIFFERENT
METHODOLOGY WOULD BE THE WISE
THING TO DO YET [inaudible]
HI.
AND THEN WHEN IT COMES -- SUE
THE SSA REIMBURSEMENTS -- I A I
DON'T THINK ANYONE WAS SAYING
THAT THE DEPARTMENT AND TRIED
SPEND THOSE FUNDS WISELY -- I
THINK WE'RE MORE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE VOLATILITY OF THE FUNDS SO --
YOU KNOW WE HAVE YOUR CHART FROM
200-082-2000 NINETEEN AND I MEAN
WHEN'S LOW SEVEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION AND AS HIGH AS FORTY
MILLION SO -- AND I GUESS THE
CONCERN IS IS THAT THE WAY WE'RE
DOING.
THE PAYMENTS -- IN TERMS OF THE
PAYMENT HERE I GUESS WE HAVE
THIS.
MECHANISM THAT WE'RE DOING SO
TRYING AVOID LOCKING IN THE
HIGHER LEVEL STATE EXPENDITURES --
FOR THE ON THE V. OUR PROGRAM SO
THAT'S WHY WE'RE USING THE SSA
REIMBURSEMENTS -- TO FUND THE
THE INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS
BUT I GUESS I I JUST.
IN TERMS SO.
IN TERMS OF WHERE FALLS ON THE
PART OF WHAT HAPPENED SO WHAT
HAPPENS IF THE SSA
REIMBURSEMENTS ARE LOW RATE WE
HAVE A DOWNTURN AND THEY AND
THEY DROPPED.
IT BUT YOU HAVE WE GOT TO MAKE
SOME DECISIONS ABOUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE DO WE JUST
STICK TO THE SSA REIMBURSEMENT
AND JUST SQUEEZE EVERYBODY ALL
THOSE DIFFERENT THINGS YOU TOLD
ME OURS ARE PRIORITY LIST AND
THEN WE THEN THINK ABOUT GENERAL
FUND OF FUNDS SOME OF THE THE
THAT SAID WE DON'T WANT TO CUT
IT THAT SEVERELY.
SO I THINK THAT'S THE ISSUE THAT
WE RAISING IN TERMS OF USING AT
THE SSA REIMBURSEMENTS BECAUSE
THAT THEY THERE IS SIGNIFICANT
FLUCTUATION FROM.
YEAR TO YEAR IN THE AMOUNT OF
REVENUE THAT'S GOING TO COME
FROM THAT PARTICULAR SOURCE.
I MEAN I THINK.
GOOD POINTS IF YOU LOOK AT THE
CERTAINLY THE INFORMATION THE
AGENDA THAT ROUTE.
UP TAKEN REVENUE HAS BEEN THERE
BECAUSE IT IT REALLY HAD GONE
DOWN.
WE ARE CERTAINLY VERY HOPEFUL
THAT REVENUE STAYS -- BUT THAT
YOU KNOW OVERALL WE ALWAYS LOOK
AT OUR RESOURCES YOU KNOW YEAR
BY YEAR WE HAVE A FISCAL
FORECASTING.
THAT ENSURES A WE'RE PROJECTING
IN BOTH THE REVENUE THAT'S GOING
TO COME IN IN THIS CASE ON THE
PROGRAM INCOME.
SUCH COOLEY REIMBURSEMENTS -- AS
WELL AS OUR EXPENDITURES AND SO
AS IT WOULD BE WITHIN THE OTHER
TIME WE ARE YOU KNOW OUR
RESOURCES WORE TIGHT WE WOULD
CERTAINLY BE WORKING -- THROUGH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND WITH YOU
AS OUR PARTNERS TO ADDRESS THAT
THE IT THIS TIME WE'RE NOT
SEEING WHERE THAT WILL
MATERIALIZE -- AS AN ISSUE OF
COURSE YOU KNOW THERE'S
TOMORROW'S ECONOMIC CONDITION
AND AND WHAT OCCURS WITHOUT BUT
WE WOULDN'T SEE THIS ANY
DIFFERENT VAN.
IF THE PRESSURE WOULD BE ON
GENERAL FUND AS AN EXAMPLE.
YES FINALLY I'D ALSO LIKE TO ADD
THAT SO SECURING PERSONS THEY
ARE CONNECTED TO THE ECONOMY SO
FOR EXAMPLE YOU CAN SEE IN
TWENTY TWELVE THERE'S A KIND OF
A LOW POINT AND THAT'S BECAUSE
THERE'S A ONE TO TWO YEAR LACKED
WHEN THE REIMBURSEMENTS COME IN
BECAUSE OF HOW.
SOCIAL SECURITY MINISTRATION
WORKS BUT NOW YOU SEE THAT AS OF
THIS YEAR'S FORTY MILLION AND
TWELVE FOR FIRST YEAR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHICH IS TIED TO A
STRONG ECONOMY AND GETTING
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
EMPLOYED SO -- I THAT THE
DEPARTMENT ACTUALLY HAS SOME
INFLUENCE OVER THE THROUGH THEIR
YOU KNOW WORK INCENTIVE PLAN IS
TRYING TO GET PEOPLE ON
EXERCISES DE I AM FLOYD.
SO THEY ACTUALLY HAVE CONTROL
OVER THIS INTO TO SOME DEGREE
WEST GENERAL FUND.
IT'S ON THE BROADER ECONOMIC --
CONDITIONS AND IT'S ALSO
NECESSARILY A KNOCK WALL TILE --
RIGHT ON BECAUSE OF OUR LINES OF
PERSONAL INCOME TAX RETURN SO AT
LEAST THIS WE HAVE SOME%
INFLUENCE OVER HOW MUCH WEEKEND
SO I GUESS I WOULD JUST SAY AND
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER LA -- WOULD
HAVE ANY COMMENT ON THIS IS THAT.
RECOGNIZING THE VOLATILITY BOTH
OF THE GENERAL FUND HAND OF THIS
SOURCE -- NOW I HEAR YEAR TO
YEAR I I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A
MAYBE A LITTLE MORE STRATEGIC
PLANNING ABOUT HOW WE WOULD IF --
AND IT'S A QUESTION SEE IF
BECAUSE OF PRIDE THE A WIN.
THERE'S A DOWNTURN THAT WE THAT
WE CAN SET SOME EXPECTATIONS
ABOUT WHAT THAT THE DEPARTMENT
WOULD YOU KNOW.
DO ARE PRIORITIZE IN TERMS OF
SOME OF THESE MONIES RIGHT SO
I'D SO THAT WE SENATE P. IS THE
SAYS I KNOW YOU WORK WITH A LOT
OF THE NONPROFIT SUPPORTS OF
PEOPLE CAN PLAN OBVIOUSLY NO ONE
WANTS TO CUT RIGHT AND DOWN ON
BUT I I I I I THINK.
THAT -- SETTING SOME
EXPECTATIONS ABOUT WHAT IN
GENERAL THE PRIORITIES ARE
STRATEGY I MEAN WHAT YOU THAT
WHAT WE ACTUALLY DO OF COURSE
THEN COMES TO A FUTURE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE AND FUTURE DECISION
BY FUTURE PARTS FINANCES AND DEL
AT AND MAYBE GOVERNOR SO WE'VE
REALLY LUCKY ON THE REVENUE
ALTERNATE.
DOWNTURN IN HIS -- EIGHT YEARS
IN OFFICE -- BUT BUT I THINK
THAT WE MAY WANT IT JUST THINK
ABOUT WHAT IT WHAT OUR
PRIORITIES GIVEN THE CURRENT
FUNDING STRUCTURE AND WHAT WE
MIGHT DO IS SO THAT WE CAN SET
SOME EXPECTATIONS FOR PEOPLE. TO
TO TO AT LEAST BUILD ANTICIPATE
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN.
AND SO WIDE THAT.
AND AND I THINK.
WE JUST ALL CONCERNED ABOUT
TYING SERVE THEM WHAT WHAT THE
IMPLICATION OF TYING THIS TO
THIS REVENUE SOURCE OF ALRIGHT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
MALES QUESTIONS OKAY WELL LET'S
MOVE ON TO ISSUE TO BE I. T.
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I CAN DRESS ISSUE TO BE.
AS KATHY MENTIONED A LITTLE BIT
EARLIER THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
ALSO INCLUDES ONE POINT SIX
MILLION.
DOLLARS FOR INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY MODERNIZATION
IMPROVEMENTS.
I DO ARE WE HAVE EIGHTY FIVE
DISTRICT AND BRANCH OFFICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WHERE MORE
THAN THIRTEEN HUNDRED DOOR
EMPLOYEES.
PROVIDE SERVICES TO OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND CONSUMERS EACH
YEAR.
I MEAN IN THESE OFFICES THE
TECHNOLOGIES ON THE TECHNOLOGY
IS OUTDATED AND NEEDS TO BE
UPDATED.
WITH THIS BUDGET WILL INCREASE
INTERNET BANDWIDTH IN THE
OFFICES WHICH WILL HELP ADDRESS
INEFFICIENCIES ASSOCIATED WITH
SLOW INTERNET RESPONSE TIMES.
AND ALLOW THE USE OF VIDEO
TRAINING FR CONSUMERS VIDEO
CONFERENCING WITH PARTNERS AND
ONLINE COLLABORATION AND SCREEN
SHARING.
THE SAME TIME WE WILL ADD WIFI
TO THE OFFICES.
THIS WILL GIVE CONSUMERS
CONNECTIVITY FOR THEIR OWN
LAPTOPS AND TABLETS WILL THEY
WORK WITH DOOR STAFF ON RESUMES
AND JOB APPLICATIONS.
IT'LL ALSO ALLOW THEM TO USE ANY
SPECIAL SOFTWARE TOOLS THAT THEY
HAVE ON THEIR DEVICES AND
QUICKLY GET TO THE DATA AND
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED TO TO
TO GET ACCESS.
TO WHO ALSO MODERNIZE CERTAIN
VOCATIONAL REHABILITATION
BUSINESS PROCESSES THROUGH THE
USE OF ELECTRONIC SIGNATURES AN
ELECTRONIC WORK FLOWS. TO
INCREASE EFFICIENCY AND OUR
INTERACTIONS WITH CONSUMERS AND
WITH OUR SERVICE PROVIDERS.
AND FINALLY AS WE MAKE THESE
CHANGES WILL BE IMPLEMENTING
CLOUD SERVICES TO INCREASE
RELIABILITY AND OPERATIONAL
FLEXIBILITY.
NOW CONCLUDE MY COMMENTS THERE.
THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS FROM L.
L..
A WE WERE JUST A NOTE THAT OUR
OFFICE RECOMMENDS APPROVAL OF
THIS -- PROPOSALS THAT WOULD
LIKELY INCREASE THE EFFICIENCIES
IN THE DEPARTMENTS PROCESS HE'S.
I THINK YOU FINANCE COMES
QUESTIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL CERTAINLY WE
WANT TO BE SURE YOU HAVE THE I.
T. INFRASTRUCTURE THAT YOU NEED.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT IT.
IN MAINLY I MEAN TO THIS IS
MAINLY LOOKS LIKE IT'S MORE.
IT'S THAT IT'S LIKE THE OF
FEDERAL STRUCTURE REAL QUICK
MEANT CLOUD STUFF LIKE THAT
RIGHT SO.
OKAY -- AND YOU WORK WITH THE
PARK TECHNOLOGY ALRIGHT SO LET'S
MOVE ON THEN TO ISSUE TO SEE THE
TV I PROGRAM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE TV I PROGRAM PROVIDE
SERVICES THAT ARE POST ACUTE
COMMUNITY REINTEGRATION SERVICES.
TO CALIFORNIANS WHO'S WHO'S WHO
HAVE SUSTAINED A TRAUMATIC BRAIN
INJURY -- THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION IS FINDING SEVEN
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY PROGRAM
SITES.
SERENA PROXIMALLY NINE HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS -- STATEWIDE IN
ABOUT TWENTY COUNTIES.
I EACH TV I PROGRAM SIDE HAS
HISTORICALLY RECEIVED A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
YEAR.
THROUGH THE MECHANISM OF THE-STATE PENALTY FUND TRANSFERRING
DOLLARS TO THE TV I FUND.
WITH THE DECLINE OF THE STATE
PENALTY FUND.
OF WHICH HAS GONE DOWN
APPROXIMATELY 40%.
THE DOLLARS NECESSARY TO SUSTAIN
THAT HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR HAVE NOT BEEN
AVAILABLE.
THIS PROPOSAL IS FOR ONE POINT
TWO MILLION OF GENERAL FUND
BASED ON THE MISSION BASED
REVIEW -- AND THAT'S PROPOSED AS
ON GOING EXPENSE.
THROUGH THE SUNSET THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED THROUGH SB THREE
NINETY EIGHT OF FOR EACH BUDGET
YEAR FOR THE OPERATION OF THE
TBI PROGRAM.
THE OF FUNDING ARE IN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN WAS DECREASED TO ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER SITE.
FROM THE HISTORICAL A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
SIDE -- AND THOSE ARE THE THE
THAT'S THE INFORMATION ON THE
HISTORY OF THE FUNDING -- WHICH
WAS THE QUESTION ASKED IN THE
AGENDA -- IF THERE'S MORE
INFORMATION I'LL HAVE HAPPILY
PROVIDED BUT LET ME JUST.
ALSO SPEAK TO THE CASELOAD
TRENDS WHICH WAS THE SECOND
QUESTION -- WE COLLECT DATA --
AS YOU KNOW FOR THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS SERVED AS WELL AS
THE INFORMATION AND REFERRAL --
SUPPORT SERVICES THAT ARE
PROVIDED TO THE COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE.
IN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN JUST FOR
COMPARISON -- NINE HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE INDIVIDUALS WITH TRAUMATIC
BRAIN INJURY WERE SERVED IN
THOSE TWENTY COUNTIES.
AND THERE WERE CUMULATIVE
INFORMATION AND REFERRAL
SERVICES PROVIDED.
OF EIGHT THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE AND THE NINE MONTHS
OF EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THAT HAVE
TRANSPIRED FROM JULY TO MARCH.
THE SITES HAVE SERVED FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE
INDIVIDUALS AND A CUMULATIVE
INFORMATION REFERRAL TO SIX
THOUSAND AND FIFTY TWO REQUESTS
FOR SUPPORT -- ALTHOUGH THEY DO
ARE IS NOT -- DOES NOT COLLECT
NUMBERS OF INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE.
ARE NOT CURRENTLY BEING SERVED.
I THINK THAT OF THE DATA OF
INDIVIDUALS SERVED AS COMPARED
TO THE NUMBER OF INQUIRIES.
DOES PROVIDE SOME INSIGHT INTO
SOME OF THE NEED.
BUT THE DEPARTMENT IS ALSO
WORKING ON THE TRAUMATIC BRAIN
INJURY ADVISORY BOARD HAS FUNDED
BY THE FEDERAL.
ADMINISTRATION FOR COMMUNITY
LIVING.
AND THAT BOARD HAS -- FOR
DELIVERABLES. TO COMPLETE BY
TWENTY TWENTY MAY OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ONE IS A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT TO IDENTIFY GAPS IN
SERVICES. FOR POST ACUTE OF IN
SITUATIONS AND COMMUNITY
REINTEGRATION.
THE SECOND WILL BE ED A TBI DATA
REGISTRY WHICH WILL IDENTIFY
INCIDENTS AND CAUSATION ANOTHER
DEMOGRAPHICS THAT WE CURRENTLY
DO NOT HAVE -- BEYOND THE SEVEN
SITES THAT WERE WORKING WITH.
THAT WOULD BE FOLLOWED BY THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A TBI STATE PLAN.
WITH OF I INFORMATION ABOUT
POTENTIAL SUSTAINED A
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING. TO ADDRESS
THE IDENTIFIED NEEDS AND GAPS IN
SERVICES AS WELL AS THE WHAT THE
REGISTRY REVEALS. FOR THE
NUMBERS OF INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY
NEED A COMMUNITY REINTEGRATION
SERVICES.
SO I'LL STOP THERE.
OKAY THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS
MILLENNIAL.
WITHOUT REGARD TO THE POTENTIAL
NEED FOR SERVICES AND THE FACT
THAT THERE ARE SEVEN SITES WHICH
MAY BE SOMEWHAT ARBITRARY AND IN
NUMBER -- IN TERMS OF THE
SPECIFIC PROPOSAL TO SHIFT THE
THE FUNDING SOURCE GIVEN THAT
THE PROGRAM HAS BEEN EXTENDED
THROUGH -- TWENTY TWENTY FOUR WE
RECOMMEND ADOPTING THE THE
PROPOSAL TO A CHANGE THE FUNDING
SOURCE TO THE GENERAL FUND
BECAUSE IT'S A RELATIVELY MORE
STABLE.
SOURCE OF FUNDING DESPITE WHAT
WE JUST DISCUSSED IN THE
PREVIOUS ITEM -- THEN THE THE
STATE PENALTY FUND.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
GEN OKAY MAY MEMBERS OF THE S.
CENTER ST FIGURES CHAIR --
ARTICULATE -- EXPLAINED WE HAVE
SEVENTY B. I. CENTERS A COVER.
TWENTY OF OUR FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES -- MY DISTRICT IS
EXCLUSIVELY IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
THE DOESN'T HAVE -- ONE MY WIFE
HAS A TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY
SHE'S HAD IT FOR ABOUT TEN YEARS
NOW -- WE HAVE TO SEARCH OUTSIDE
OF OUR COUNTY FOR SERVICES.
FOR SO -- WHAT WE DO IN THE
REMAINING COUNTIES HOW COME WE
[inaudible]
ENSURE THAT.
ANYONE IN CALIFORNIA THAT IS A
DRAMATIC BRAIN INJURIES SUFFERED
CAN GET.
GET HELP.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
CONSIDER THE SERVICE GAP WHEN
THEY WERE DOING THEIR MISSION
BASE REVIEW OF THE DEPARTMENT.
THANK YOU SENATOR STONE THE IT
IS.
DEFINITELY OUR HOPE IN THE PART
OF THE REASON WE APPLIED FOR THE
AT A. C. L. ADMINISTRATION FOR
COMMUNITY LIVING GRANT.
WAS TO INVESTIGATE THE GAPS THAT
WE ARE AWARE OF BUT DO NOT HAVE
THE DATA FOR AND SO THE TBI
ADVISORY BOARD TO COMPLETE.
A REGISTRY AND A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT WILL GIVE US THE DATA
TO SUPPORT OF THE NECESSARY
SERVICES AND DEVELOP A STATE
PLAN SO WE CAN MOVE TOWARDS.
THOSE SERVICES BEING AVAILABLE.
AND YOUR BREAKDOWN OF THE THE
IDEOLOGY OF THE DRAMATIC
INJURIES TRAUMATIC BRAIN
INJURIES ARE REPORTED HERE
DEPARTMENT OF THE COMING FROM.
CAR ACCIDENTS OF MOTORCYCLE
ACCIDENTS -- ETCETERA.
THE IDEOLOGY THAT WE ARE RELYING%
ON FOR FOUR BACKGROUND RESEARCH
REALLY IS COMING FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY ROOM ADMISSIONS.
WHICH IS LIMITED TO A CUTE OF
CARE.
ON AND THAT WOULD INDICATE THE
HIGHEST NUMBER OF BECAUSE OF
BECAUSE IS RELATED TO FALLS --
THEN OF ACCIDENTS MOTOR VEHICLE
MOTORCYCLE -- OTHER TYPE OF
SPORTING INJURIES AND SO FORTH --
HOWEVER THERE ARE OTHER THERE'S
OTHER DATA.
THAT COULD BE CONSIDERED -- AS
TO WHAT OCCURS FOR VETERANS --
FOR INSTANCE.
AND I THINK THAT THE AGAIN THE
THE TV I ADVISORY BOARD IS
CHARGED WITH REALLY.
FLESHING OUT THAT PICTURE.
OF WHAT HAPPENS AFTER THE
EMERGENCY ROOM ADMISSION. FOR
PEOPLE AND COLLECTING BETTER
DATA ON CAUSATION WITH OUR AGING
POPULATION IF YOU.
WOULD LIKE TO LOOK AT THE DATA
OVER THE PAST FIVE SEVEN YEARS
WOULD YOU SAY THAT YOU SEEN A
STEADY INCLINE WITH -- THE THE
GRAIN OF CALIFORNIA.
I WOULD HAVE TO LOOK FURTHER
INTO THAT I HAVE NOT LOOKED AT
THAT BUT THE CERTAINLY THE
INCREASE IN AGING.
AND THE POSSIBLE RELATIONSHIP TO
FALLS SHOULD BE LOOKED AT YEAH I
KNOW WE HAVE SOME BILLS IN THE
LEGISLATURE WHEN -- SENATOR FROM
SANTA BARBARA IS GOING TO PUT
SOME SAFETY EQUIPMENT AS WE HAVE
AN AGING POPULATION AND TRYING.
TO KEEP THEM FROM FALLING AND
HURTING THEMSELVES SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
UP SO JUST TO CLARIFY SO
BASICALLY IN TERMS OF THE
PENALTY FUND WHICH COURSES
SHRUNK TREMENDOUSLY NOW THEY'RE
STILL REVENUE COMING INTO THAT
FUND TRACTS.
YES OKAY REVVING BUT BASICALLY
BUT WE'RE NOT GONNA DRAW THAT
FUND AT ALL ANYMORE WE'RE
DISCONNECT.
NO THAT THAT FUND HAS FUNDED
MANY DIFFERENT PROGRAMS RIGHT
LOS VARIOUS AGENCIES SO WE JUST
SAID THIS PROGRAM IT'S A CASE
JUST DECLINE TOO MUCH FOR THIS
PROJECT TO MOVE THAT OUT OKAY.
OKAY THAT MAKES SENSE ALL RIGHT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SIR -- ALRIGHT LET'S GO AHEAD
AND MOVE ON TO NUMBER THREE THE
STRING LETTER -- CAL FOR SHOT
REACH VIA THE INDEPENDENT LIVING
CENTERS.
YES THANK YOU -- THE THE
PROPOSAL IS TO REQUEST A TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION IN
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY FOR ONE
YEAR -- FOR THE D. O. R. TO
ASSIST THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES WITH IMPLEMENTATION OF
TH CALPERS EXPANSION PLAN --
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES WOULD BE REIMBURSING
THE DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION.
FOR LOCAL OUT REACH --
APPLICATION ASSISTANCE FOLLOW UP
AND DATA COLLECTION -- WITH
THROUGH THE INDEPENDENT LIVING
CENTERS -- AS WELL AS CONTRACT
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS
WITHIN THE DEAL ARE -- THE
EXPANSION OF CALIFORNIA'S -- TO
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVING SSI R. S.
S. P..
COMES INTO EFFECT JUNE.
ONE TWENTY NINETEEN SO WHAT WE
WERE ODD DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES CAME AND ASKED THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION.
IN OUR ROLE AS ADMINISTRATORS
FOR THE INDEPENDET LIVING
CENTERS TO PARTNER WITH THEM.
SO THAT LOCAL ASSISTANCE COULD
BE PROVIDED TO THOSE --
CONSUMERS ALREADY WORKING WITH
ALREADY TRUSTED PARTNERS WITH
THE INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS.
WHO MAY BE RECEIVING SSI RECESS
P. SO THEY CAN BE PRE SCREENED?
RECEIVE HI TOUCH ACCESSIBLE
APPLICATION ASSISTANCE.
GET THEIR APPLICATIONS SUBMITTED
AND THEN FOLLOW UP ON THE OF
PERCENTAGE OF APPROVALS -- THE
D. O. R. WOULD USE TEMPORARY
HELP STAFF -- TO SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE CONTRACTS --
SINCE IT IS A ONE YEAR PROGRAM --
THE DO YOU ARE WOULD ALSO
COLLECT THE DATA.
HOPEFULLY TO INFORM THE THE
SUCCESS OF THE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU -- COMES FROM OHIO
FINANCE THE MEMBERS OKAY WELL
CERTAINLY I THINK IN A WHILE --
WE'VE SEEN LOTS OF BILLS AND
PROPOSALS AROUND GO INCREASING
OUR COW FRESH THIS IS US THE
THERE'S BEEN A I THINK A VERY.
IMPORTANT CHANGE THAT WE ARE NOW
GOING TO TRY.
TO PROVIDE COVERAGE -- TO TWO
PEOPLE ON SSI AND SO WITH SAID
HE'S VERY IMPORTANT -- THAT THAT
YOU ARE ABLE TO DO THEIR PART TO
HELP CLIENTS THAT YOU'RE SERVING
GET THEM ENROLLED IN THAT CELL --
PRE SHEET -- FERN VERY MUCH
HOPING THAT -- YOU'LL BE WHILE
LOOKING FOR TUTORS HEARING ABOUT
YOUR SUCCESS.
THAT REGARD OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THERE'S NO OTHER
QUESTIONS -- WHAT WE'LL DO IS
NOW MOVING TO PUBLIC COMMENT IN
RELATION TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION AND EACH OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE HEARD?
SO PEOPLE CAN -- INTO THE
MICROPHONE I ASK THAT YOU TRY TO
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO A MINUTE
OR LESS -- AND IF SOMEONE SAID
WHAT YOU ALSO WANT TO SAY SAYING
THAT I AGREE WITH HIM OR HER OR
HER OR HIM THAT WORKS TO SELL.
ALRIGHT SO THAT IS OF SURFING
INTRODUCING YOURSELF NAME IF
YOU'RE WITH AN ORGANIZATION AND
THEN -- TULSA THE LESS KNOW
ANYTHING OKAY VERY GOOD ALL
RIGHT WELCOME THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JORDAN IN THE WITH THE
OUR COMMUNITY NOT THROUGH THE
HOLES HE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATIVE JUST IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
FOR CALIPHATE SHALL REACH. TO DO
ARE IN THROUGH THE AISLES THESE
THANK YOU I THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
NANCY CHANCE -- I'M HERE AS A
FAMILY MEMBER RIGHT NOW I'LL BE
HERE FOR SOME OTHER THINGS LATER --
MY HUSBAND WAS INJURED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX AND STAINED
VERY SERIOUS.
A TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY AND I
GUESS WHAT I WANNA SAY IS ONE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS. TO
SERVE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
THIS AREA SEEMS WOEFULLY
INADEQUATE TO ME.
AND I I CAN'T.
I THINK WE HAVE TO FIND A WAY TO
FIND MORE RESOURCES OF MY
HUSBAND WE WERE LUCKY WE WERE
ABLE TO FIND RESOURCES ON OUR
OWN AND USE INSURANCE AND MANY
OTHER THINGS BUT BUT THERE ARE
PEOPLE THAT DON'T HAVE THT
OPPORTUNITY AND YOU KNOW HE HE
WAS FORTY FOUR YEARS.
OLD AND HIS HIS AND OUR LIFE
CHANGED SIGNIFICANTLY ON THAT
DAY.
AND WE REALLY NEED TO TO
REMEMBER THAT AND WHEN WE START
TO FUND PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME -- HI MY NAME IS KATIE
SHINODA -- I'M WITH DIGNITY
HEALTH MERCY GENERAL HOSPITAL WE
RUN -- ONE OF THE STATE TO BE
AYE PROGRAMS HERE IN SACRAMENTO
AND I WANT TO STRONGLY SUPPORT
YOUR THE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
OF THE ONE POINT TWO MILLION --
AND THANK THE DEPARTMENT FOR
THEIR WORK WITH THE ACL AND AND
GETTING THAT GRANT TO WORK
TOWARDS DEVELOPING A BETTER AND
MORE ROBUST PROGRAM FOR DRAMATIC
BRAIN INJURY -- I CAN'T EVEN
BEGAN -- TO TO TELL YOU THAT THE
CHALLENGES THAT PEOPLE FACE
AFTER THE RE HAPPEN AFTER THEIR
MEDICAL CARE AND TRYING TO
FIGURE THINGS OUT YOURSELF HOW
TO GET BACK INTO THE COMMUNITY
AND HOW TO BE INDEPENDENT AND
HOW TO BE PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS OF
SOCIETY.
AS REALLY CHALLENGING SO ANY
SUPPORT THAT YOU CAN GIVE TO
DRAMATIC BRAIN INJURY IS
APPRECIATED.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS OF ON THAT
MEASURE AND I ACQUIRED MAY TWO
T. BAD IDEAS THAT THOSE TODAY.
AND I WANT TO MAKE YOU PEOPLE --
WHERE AS TV AS AND THOSE OF THE
THE PROGRAMS THAT THE BILL TO
THEM?
TODAY THEY ENGAGE AT TWO TWO
THEY THEN THEY HAD MET.
MUSLIM A PART OF SOCIETY AND
WITH MOM MELANIE -- AND VISION
IS A FOR THE DEVELOPMENT.
OTHER THAN OTHERS -- PROGRAMS TO
HELP PEOPLE BUT THE TVA
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE YOU GOING TO DO IT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
KRISTEN THIS IS MY SON RAYMOND.
AND PLEASE FORGIVE ME AHEAD OF
TIME I STILL CANNOT GET THROUGH
THE STORY WITH OUR CURRENT --
APRIL TWENTY SECOND TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN PAYMENT WAS IN A
HORRIFIC MOTORCYCLE ACCIDENT
[inaudible]
THE END.
ASIDE FROM NUMEROUS PHYSICAL
INJURIES.
HE ALSO SUFFERED A SEVERE
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY.
I HAVE READ SEVERAL DIFFERENT
ESTIMATES.
BUT THE BRAIN INJURY ASSOCIATION
OF AMERICA ESTIMATES THAT THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION PEOPLE A YEAR
SUFFER BRAIN INJURY [inaudible]
THE AND THAT'S ONLY WHAT'S.
REPORTED [inaudible]
SORRY.
THAT'S MORE THAN NINE THOUSAND
NEW TV EYES JUST TODAY.
WHAT NUMBERS LIKE THIS IT'S MORE
THAN LIKELY AT ONE POINT OR
ANOTHER YOU?
IN YOUR LIFE ALSO BE TOUCHED BY
A TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY IF AND
WHEN THAT HAPPENS I PROMISE YOU
YOU WILL NEED A PROGRAM LIKE
BRIDGES AVAILABLE TO YOU.
WHETHER THE CAUSES FROM AN AUTO
MOTORCYCLE ACCIDENT A FALL HOME.
A FOLLOW AT HOME SPORTS DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE NO ONE IS UNTOUCHABLE
FROM US.
THIS CAN HAPPEN TO ANYONE OF YOU
AT ANY TIME AND I CAN SAY THIS
BECAUSE IT HAPPENED TO US.
THAT IS WHY I AM HERE TODAY TO
ASK YOU TO PLEASE PLEASE COME TO
CONSIDER CONTINUING THIS VERY
IMPORTANT FUNDING AND EVEN
CONSIDER INCREASING THAT.
BEFORE WE FOUND FOR THE BRIDGES
PROGRAM MY SON WAS QUESTIONING
HIS EXISTENCE ON A DAILY BASIS
AND OFTEN STILL DOES.
AS A MOM.
IT'S EXCRUCIATING TO WATCH A
CHILD WITH A PAIN DALY.
NOT TO MENTION LIVING IN FEAR OF
THE UNKNOWN.
AND ALL OF THE POSSIBLE HEALTH
ISSUES THAT COME AFTER THIS.
AFTER HIS FIRST VISIT WE KNEW
THE PROGRAM WAS CAN MAKE A
POSITIVE IMPACT ON HIS LIFE.
YOU DON'T KNOW PROGRAMS LIKE
BRIDGES OR SURVIVAL UNTIL YOU'RE
THE ONE DESPERATELY SEEKING HELP.
SIR I'M GONNA ASK YOU TO WRAP UP
THANK YOU.
PLEASE MAKE IT EASIER FOR LOVED
ONES OF TO BE AYE WARRIORS TO
FIND HELP AND KEEP THIS PROGRAM
GOING.
I PRAY THAT YOU NEVER NEED IT
FOR YOUR OWN FAMILY BUT IF YOU
DO I HOPE YOU FIND COMFORT
KNOWING THAT IT'S THERE.
BRAIN INJURIES ARE THE LAST
THING YOU THINK ABOUT MENTAL
BECOMES THE ONLY THING YOU THINK
ABOUT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY.
WELCOME NEW SENATOR PAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CRISTINA MILLS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION
FOR INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS
WE REPRESENT TWENTY TWO OF
TWENTY EIGHT CALIFORNIA'S
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS -- I
DO WANT TO COMMEND THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHAB FOR THEIR
CREATIVITY AND THEIR WORK TOWARD
SYSTEM ALIGNMENT -- WE HAVE VERY
MUCH VALUED AND APPRECIATED THE
WORK THAT HAS GONE INTO CREATING.
A REAL BLAST TO AGING AND
DISABILITY RESOURCE CONNECTIONS
AND CENTERS ACROSS THE STATE AS
WELL AS THE SUPPORT THAT HAS
BEEN PROVIDED TODAY AT R. C.
ADVISORY COMMITTEE STATEWIDE --
THE CREATIVITY THAT HAS GONE
INTO WORKING IN COLLABORATION TO
BRING A INDEPENDENT LIVING
CENTERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
INCREASE THEIR BUDGETS THROUGH
THE CALIBRATION -- GRAHAM HAD
BEEN IDEAL AND I HOPE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO SEE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES LIKE THAT
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS HAVE
GONE DECADES WITHOUT CONSISTENT
INCREASES AND TO YOUR POINT I
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED THAT YOU
ASKED ABOUT SOCIAL THIRTY
REIMBURSEMENT DOLLARS.
THEY ARE TIED TO INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTER SERVICES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS NANCY BITTNER AND ARE
I LOST MY JOB TO TBI OP FIVE THE
BENT AND BEEN ABLE TO GET HELP
THROUGH.
TV I PROGRAM AT MERCY AND I
THINK THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE A
LOT LOT MORE FUNDING AND THE A
LOT LOT MORE.
HELP FOR PEOPLE BECAUSE THERE'S
THERE'S A LOT OF PP PEOPLE OUT
THERE THAT ARE MISDIAGNOSED.
MY LIKE I WAS NOT SO NOT NOT
EVERYTHING LIKE YOU SAID
REPORTER RIGHT AWAY.
AND IT TOOK TWO HOSPITALIZATIONS
AN ANTI I A ON TOP OF THAT
BEFORE THEY FOUND ON MONEY
PROBLEMS -- SO SO -- AND I
APPRECIATE AND ANY -- ANY HELP
YOU THAT YOU COULD YOU COULD.
DO TO GIVE MORE HELP BECAUSE YOU
KEEP GETTING OUR US SOME PEOPLE
THAT HAVE A MILDER ISSUES ANYWAY
PROBABLY OTHER PEOPLE.
TOO BUT IS THIS NEEDS A LOT MORE
FUNDING SO YOU COULD GET MORE
HELP GET MORE THERAPY AUG.
IN NOW AND MANY CAN'T FIGURE OUT
HOW TO FILL OUT A FORM YOU KNOW
YOU GOT SOMEONE THERE TO HELP
YOU.
ESPECIALLY WENT WENT WHEN YOU
LIVE ON YOUR OWN AND DON'T HAVE
OTHER PEOPLE TO HELP YOU.
THESE PER PROGRAMS ARE VERY VERY
IMPORTANT AND IF IT.
IF IT WAS UP TO ME THE TV I
PROGRAMS WOULD HAVE. TWENTY
TIMES AS MUCH HELP AS THEY DO
NOW AND THERE NEEDS TO BE A LOT
LOT LOT MORE.
OUT OF PROGRAMS OUT THERE TO
HELP MORE PEOPLE AND AND THEY'RE
ALL ALSO NEEDS TO BE.
MORE OF PEOPLE AWARE OF TBI.
AND OF THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE A
LOT LOT MORE LEARNING.
BEING DONE SET SO -- I TOTALLY
SUPPORT THE TV I PROGRAMS AND I
HOPE TO GOD THAT THAT THERE
THERE'S A LOT MORE TO HELP MORE
PEOPLE BECAUSE BECAUSE NOT
EVERYBODY CAN.
GET HELP THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
WELL SEVERAL FEATURES EXPLORED
ARISE IN SUPPORT OF TWO A WHICH
WOULD BE THE 10% INCREASE PLUS
THE CONTRIBUTION ARE INCREASE TO
MINIMUM WAGE WHICH HAS SLOWED
DOWN OUR ABILITY TO USE THAT. TO
THE COSTS AS WE DON'T ABILITY TO
FUND THAT.
ALSO MAY THE SO SECURITY
QUESTIONS REALLY A MATTER OF YOU
WANT THE REVENUE YOU NEED TO
COMMUNITY RESOURCE PROVIDERS TO
BE AVAILABLE TO GET THE JOBS IN
WE NEED DIRECT SERVICE
PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE CURRENTLY
UNDER FUNDED. TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT IF YOU WANT PEOPLE TO GET
THOE JOBS AND MAINTAIN THAT
REVENUE YOU NEED TO SUPPORT IT
THERE WAS A RESERVOIR OF OF HIS
OFFICE HE TO BE WAS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
ANYTHING IT WILL ACCELERATE THE
OPENING OF CASES WITH DEPARTMENT
OF REHABILITATION CAM WHICH CAN
ALSO BE A BARRIER TO PEOPLE
GETTING JOBS.
IF THEY'RE NOT OPEN QUICKLY
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU.
WELCOME THANK YOU -- MARTY MOTOR
FAMILY MEMBER CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY A SENIOR COMMUNITY
ACTION NETWORK CALIFORNIA PERSON
CENTERED TO ADVOCACY PARTNERSHIP.
I JUST WANT TO FIRST SAY THERE
WAS SUPPORT ALL THE PROPOSALS IN
PARTICULAR THE TBI PROPOSALS FOR
ALL THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY
STATED.
YOU KNOW THERE'S MORE THAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE.
A PREVIOUS CERTAIN THE
STAKEHOLDER GROUP LOOKING AT
MEDI TRYING TO FIND MEDICAID
FUNDING OF THAT WAS SUCCESSFUL I
THINK WE NEED TO RENEW THAT
EFFORT.
LOOK PERHAPS LOOKING AT THE
SECTIONAL AND FIFTEEN WAIVER
TOWARDS THE WHOLE PERSON CARE
APPROACH LASTLY TOTALLY SUPPORT.
THE FUNDING -- FOR OUT REACH ON
THE EXPANSION OF THE CALIBRATION
RATE RESOURCE AND WE SHOULD USE
THE MORE UP FOR SIMILAR -- NEEDS
FOR OUT REACH THANK YOU THANK
YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
OKAY.
HELLO MY NAME'S DAN CLARK COMMA
COMMUNITY AFTER OF ACTIVISTS BUT
PRIOR TO RETIREMENT I WAS A
REHAB COUNSELOR.
THIS ISSUE THAT YOU HEARD FROM
THESE CONSUMERS HAVE BEEN GOING
ON FOR YEARS SINCE MY EXPERIENCE.
I FEEL THAT WE HAVE WE NEED
RETURN ON INVESTMENT WE DO A LOT
THE MEDICALLY TO KEEP ALIVE.
BUT WITH THE RESTRICTING DOLLARS
PEOPLE ARE TRANSITION BACK
COMMUNITY SOONER THAN A NEED TO
BE.
NAY LOOT THEY START TO LOSE
RESOURCES SO
I ONE OF A PLOT YOU AND APART
RECAP FOR THE WORK THEY'VE BEEN
DOING. TO HELP KEEP THIS PROGRAM
GOING AND AND GOING FORWARD FROM
HERE ON OUT WITH THE GENERAL
FUND MONEY FOR THE NEXT FOUR
YEARS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANNA -- GRIN I
WORK WITH FREED ARE WHERE AN
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTER WERE
ALSO ONE OF THOSE SEVEN SITES
THAT SUPPORT.
PEOPLE WITH TBI.
I'M WE COVER BUTTE SHASTA SETTER
NEVADA AND YUBA COUNTIES.
AM I JUST WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
APPROVAL OF THIS INCREASE.
AND I ALSO HAVE A LETTER FROM
ONE OF OUR PEOPLE THAT WE
SUPPORT.
SHE ASKED ME TO READ IT HERE SHE
COULDN'T COME TODAY.
HER NAME IS KATIE WILLIS.
SHE SAYS MY NAME IS KATIE WILLIS
I HAVE HAD A TRAUMATIC BRAIN
INJURY FOR FIVE YEARS.
I WAS THIRTY FOUR YEARS OLD WHEN
I WAS IN A VEHICLE ACCIDENT THAT
LEFT ME A QUADRIPLEGIC IN A
WHEELCHAIR WITH A TRAUMATIC
BRAIN INJURY.
PRIOR TO MY VEHICLE ACCIDENT I
ATTENDED COLLEGE HAD CAREERS IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT EMERGENCY
MEDICAL AND CREATED MY OWN YOUTH
GROUP FOR KIDS IN OUR COMMUNITY.
AFTER MY ACCIDENT THERE WAS NO
ONE AT THE REHAB FACILITY I WAS
AT THAT HAD ANY KNOWLEDGE WITH
TBI.
OR HOW TO EXPLAIN WHAT WAS
HAPPENING OR TO DISCUSS WHAT I
WAS FEELING.
OR EXPERIENCING I CANNOT
DESCRIBE IN WORDS HOW LONELY IT
WAS GOING THROUGH SOMETHING NO
ONE ELSE UNDERSTOOD.
OR COULD SEE LET ALONE HELP
GUIDE ME IN RECOVERING IN
HEALING.
IT WAS CONFUSING AND LONELY AND
LOST TIME FOR ME.
IT WAS NOT INTEL EIGHT CAME HOME
THREE YEARS AGO ENJOYING FREED.
THE END STARTED THE TRAUMATIC
BRAIN INJURY SUPPORT GROUP FOR
YUBA SUTTER COUNTIES.
IN THE PAST THREE YEARS I'VE
LEARNED WHAT TRAUMATIC BRAIN
INJURY IS HOW I GOT A AND HOW MY
SYMPTOMS AFFECT ME IN MY DAILY
LIFE I'VE CONTINUE TO HEAL IN
THIS GROUP.
AND A TENT. TO GET SOME BRAIN
STRENGTH BACK THIS GROUP DOES
HELP SAVE MY LIFE FROM MY BRAIN
WITHOUT.
I WOULD NOT BE AS SUCCESSFUL AS
I AM NOW.
IN RECOVERY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON STROKE ASIDE
FROM THE STATE INDEPENDENT
LIVING COUNCIL.
THANK YOU TENER AND THANK YOU
FOR THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THESE VITAL
PROGRAMS OFFER THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION THE
ASSIST CONSUMERS FROM ACROSS THE
STATE.
THANK YOU GIVE [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS RON A LOG IN THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR CREEL
COMMUNITY RESOURCES FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING REPRESENTING
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY AREA WE TOO
ARE IN SUPPORT OF ALL THE
PROGRAMS ARE PRESENTED.
ESPECIALLY FOR THE CAL.
THE CALIBRATION RUSS SERVICES
FOR A LOT OF THE ARKANSAS WHICH
ONES THAT WE WORK WITH -- THEY
ARE ON SSI AND THEY DON'T HAVE A
MEAL.
AND SO FINALLY.
STARTING JUNE FIRST WE'RE GONNA
BE GETTING AND SO VERY VERY.
MUCH IN SUPPORT OF THAT THANK
YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO -- MY NAME IS BRIAN SNYDER
I AM A DISABILITY COMMUNITY
ADVOCATE WITH FREED CENTER AND
IN A CENTER FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING.
I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF OUR
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY SURVIVORS --
I WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT ISOLATION AND WITH
DISABILITY I CAN SPEAK TO THAT
BECAUSE I'VE EXPERIENCED IT.
WHEN ONE HAS A TV I A OR
DISABILITY THEY BECOME ISOLATED
OFTEN?
AND I COULD NOT ONLY PROVIDING
PERSON CENTERED SERVICES FOR TBI
SURVIVORS WE ALSO PROVIDE A HOME
A PLACE WHERE THEY CAN.
FIND A PLACE TO TALK ABOUT THEIR
STRUGGLES THEIR CHALLENGES THEIR
LOSSES THEIR GRIEF.
AND AND FIND A PLACE WHERE THEY
FEEL SAFE.
AND FREEDOM'S PROVIDED THAT FOR
THESE TBI SURVIVORS AND I WE ARE
THEY ARE GRATEFUL FOR THAT AND
WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT HAVE BEEN
THERE WE HAVE ONE TV I SO I
REALLY COMES IN THREE TIMES A
WEEK.
BECAUSE THEY FEEL THEY CAN FIND
PEACE SAFETY COMPASSION IN
COMFORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
RAIN X. CALIFORNIA'S DISABILITY
RIGHTS I WANTED CALLY WITH NANCY
CHANCE HERE -- IT SEEMS TO ME
WHAT'S HAPPENED IS THE TV I
PROGRAM EVERY TIME THEY TRY TO
PUT A FUNDING PROGRAM TOGETHER
IT EASIER DIED IN THE BOOK IT
DIED IN THE PREPARATIONS.
OR IT COULD MAKE IT OFFERS TAX
IN REV AND SO IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT ONE POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S NOT A LOT
CONSIDER COMEY CLIENTS THERE ARE.
AND HOW MANY TIMES THIS PROGRAM
IS BEEN CUT I THINK YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE TO NEEDS MORE MONEY SO THEY
MAKE SURE THEY CAN GET IT EVEN
UP UP THERE.
AND AS FOR THE OTHER PROGRAM --
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT WHEN YOU TRY
TO GET PEOPLE BACK TO WORK YOU
ONE MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE AT A
WEIGHT SHOULD THEY CAN LIVE WITH.
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE YOU KNOW THE
YOUR TRAINING WAGE QUOTE
TRAINING WEIGHT DOES NOT HELP
AND I JUST WANNA LET YOU KNOW
THAT -- I KNOW PEOPLE IN
TRAINING WAGES AND THEY RATHER
STAND DISABILITY.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME JUNE HENRIK INSURANCE
WITH A CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS.
ARE TO REMEMBER I'LL SEATS ARE
PART OF SEVEN SITES AND I'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THEM AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR TPI
FOR THE PAST YEAR.
AND I WON'T ADD ANYTHING TO WHAT
OTHER CONSUMERS OF SAID BUT I DO
WISH.
TO COMMEND THE DEPARTMENT THE
DIRECTORY STATE YOU'RE IN IRAN
LAY LOW AND THERE AT THE STAFF
EVEN VARIANT WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH A STORAGE COMMON
COLD EXPANDING SERVICES THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI HARY BRAWL WITH A PATH POINT
OUR PROVIDER SERVICES IN THE
CENTRAL COAST AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AREA WE SUPPORT THE
RATE INCREASES THE 10% IN THE
MINIMUM WAGE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT.
I WOULD MENTION THAT THE CPI
CONSUMER PRICE INDEX HAS GONE UP
20% SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINE THE
RATE GOES UP 10% WE APPRECIATE
THAT THEY'RE STILL WE BELIEVE
ROOM TO GO.
OUR BIGGEST PROBLEM IS FINDING
STAFF THAT WE CAN PAY THE WAGES
WE CURRENTLY HAVE FORTY VACANCY
IS WE HAVE PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO
NEED SERVICES THAT WERE NOT ABLE
TO SERVE.
WERE PROVIDING A SMALL AMOUNT OF
THE HOURS THAT THEY NEED SO
THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU'RE DOING
AND PLEASE DON'T FORGET ABOUT
THE REST THE PEOPLE THAT NEED
THAT SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
TERRY VERY JUTTING YOU WITH A
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY SERVICES
ASSOCIATION WE REPRESENT
PROVIDERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND VERY MUCH STAND IN SUPPORT
OF THE INCREASE FOR PROVIDER
RATE FOR COMMUNITY WE HAVE
PARTNERS AND THANK THE
DEPARTMENT FOR BRING FOR THE
PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
CARLENE HOLDEN WITH EASTER SEAL
STANDING ALSO IN SUPPORT OF A
10% BUT ALSO VERY PASSIONATELY --
ABOUT THE TBI WE HAVE IT IN
SACRAMENTO WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE
TO SEE IT EXPAND ITS HUGE NEED
WE KNOW YOU KNOW THIS BUT TO
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO GET IT
EXPANDED WOULD BE LOVELY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI PATTY ANGER FROM PATH POINT
OPERATING IN FIVE COUNTY CENTRAL
AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND I AM
IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE T A IT'S
BEEN TEN YEARS SINCE THERE HAS
BEEN A RATE INCREASE AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH -- FOR PUTTING
THAT IN THE BUDGET AND ALSO
SUPPORT THE FOUR DOLLAR MINIMUM
WAGE INCREASE THANK YOU I THANK
YOU.
OKAY WELL -- THANK EVERYONE WHO
GAVE PUBLIC COMMENT I GUESS A
COUPLE OF OBSERVATIONS BEFORE WE
CONCLUDE THIS PART OF THE
HEARING -- ONE SO CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK YOU'RE
DOING TO TRY -- TO GET
EMPLOYMENT -- FOR PEOPLE WHO --
STABILITY IS AN BUT DO YOU DO
SERVE IT'S ALSO ABOUT THE ISSUE
ABOUT IN TERMS OF WELL.
WHAT KIND OF JOBS THEY HAVE HOW
MUCH ARE THEY BEING PAID RIGHT
WE HEARD ABOUT TRAINING WAGES
VERSES?
IT IS IS THERE'S SOME TRACKING
THEIR THAT'S GOING ON DESERVE
SOME POLICY THINGS YOU'D BE
LOOKING AT THAT.
IT'S IT'S SO -- FOR FROM YOUR
CARS PERSPECTIVES ARE YOU TRYING
TO GET PEOPLE INTO IMPLEMENT YOU
TALKED AT LENGTH ABOUT THE OF
MAY HAVE YOUR EFFORTS AND SO
FORTH.
BOSSES THE YOU LIKE OKAY SO
WHERE DID THE END UP AND WHAT
CAN WE TRY TO DO TO HELP BE SURE
PEOPLE ARE ABLE.
TO LIVE INDEPENDENTLY -- ALSO
RECOGNIZING SOMETIMES OR SOME
TENSION AND START YOUR
DEPARTMENT A SORRY BUT I'VE
HEARD ABOUT BETWEEN -- THE
SERVER INCOME REQUIREMENTS IN
ORDER TO GET CERTAIN SERVICES
THAT THEY NEED -- WONDER OF
PLAYED AND THEN NOT AND
SOMETIMES SOMETIMES NOT WHAT YOU
MAKE TOO MUCH MONEY BECAUSE THEY
LOSE A SERVICES VERSES AND
THAT'S ANOTHER POLICY ISSUE THAT
WE NEED TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
MORE AS WELL BUT COULD YOU MAYBE
JUST SPEAK TO YOUR SURF.
IF YOU'VE SORT OF MORE LONG TERM
FOLLOW UP IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
RESULTS ARE OF GETTING PEOPLE TO
POINT.
SO JUST REAL QUICKLY YES WE DO
TRACK THE WAGES OF OUR PEOPLE TO
GO TO WORK -- HAPPY TO SAY.
THAT IT'S AT LEAST MINIMUM WAGE
AND WE HAVE SOMEBODY GO TO WORK
AT THE OTHER DAY.
I'M RELATIVELY SPEAKING COUPLE
MONTHS AGO FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND A YEAR.
SO IT RUNS THE GAMUT WE VERY
MUCH INDIVIDUALIZED TO THE
PERSON TO THERE ARE -- SKILL SET --
AND GETTING THEM READY FOR THE
JOBS THAT THEY'RE SEEKING.
YOU KNOW AS YOU ASKED CAN WHAT
CAN BE DONE IN ONE OF THE THINGS
I MENTIONED IS.
GIVING VOICE TO THE POTENTIAL ON
THE TALENTED PEOPLE WITH
pCAN BE DONE THAT HELPS ALL OF US
IS A SOCIETY. TO REALLY LOOK AT
SOMEBODY AND SAY HEY THEY HAVE
THAT POTENTIAL.
THEY CAN GO TO WORK THIS HUGE --
IT IN -- AND THEN OF COURSE THE
JOB OF COURSE IS ALWAYS POLICY
CONSIDERATIONS ISSUE SAID THAT'S
PROBABLY A LONGER TERM
CONVERSATION.
BUT APPRECIATE ANYTHING THAT YOU
CAN DO -- TO GIVE BOTH
VISIBILITY -- AND VOICE TO THE
POTENTIAL AND TALENT OF PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES OKAY I
APPRECIATE THAT ALSO APPRECIATE
THE ANY GUIDANCE FROM YOUR PARK
IS YOUR TO PART OF IT IS THE ONE
THAT.
HAS THE MOST EXPERIENCE AND ALSO
AS THE POTENTIALLY THE DATA TO
HELP US -- TRIED ADDRESS ON THE
POLICY ISSUES RELATED -- TO TO
HELPING -- THIS POPULATION SO
APPRECIATE ANY SERVICE I GUESS
WE'RE CAUGHT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CAN BE PROVIDED --
AND AND THAT REGARD -- COULD
MAKE.
I THINK WE HAVE PERCEPTIONS WHAT
WE THINK'S GOING ON BUT WE Y.
GROUNDED IN REALITY OF PEOPLE'S
EXPERIENCES THAT -- YOU YOU MAY
KNOW MORE ABOUT AND I GUESS THE
OTHER QUESTION IS REGARDING TV I
I MEAN -- YOU KNOW WE WERE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL I THINK -- YOU KNOW
PEOPLE LIKE CENTER MONEY USED TO
SERVICE COMMITTEE THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR HIM -- AS
WELL AS MANY OTHER LEGISLATORS --
ONE ON THE FACE OF IT YOU KNOW
ONE POINT TWO MILLION IS IT'S
MORE THAN A WASN'T FAST HERE SO
THAT'S GOOD IT'S NOT A WHOLE LOT
BUT ALSO I IT.
I THINK OF IT IT'S NOT THE ONLY.
THE MANY WAYS THAT WE HAVE
MULTIPLE PROGRAMS RIGHT THAT
COME TOGETHER TO HELP TRY TO
SUPPORT SO THIS IS THIS PLACE
PARTICULAR ROLAND.
A THE MIGHT BE HELPFUL WE SERVE
TALKING ABOUT THIS PROGRAM A
LITTLE IN ISOLATION BUT MAY BE
ABLE TO HAVE AND I DON'T KNOW
THE SOME LA AS LOOK AT THIS OR
SOME.
SORT OF WHAT ARE THE NETWORK OF
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE -- THAT
THAT CAN HELP SUPPORT SOLIS TBI
AND THINKING ABOUT HOW THAT ALL
COMES TOGETHER SO WE'RE NOT JUST
LOOKING AT THIS PIECE IN
ISOLATION SO WHAT IS THE NETWORK
OF SUPPORT AND AND THAT OF
COURSE AND SPEAKS.
TO YOU KNOW HOW WHAT'S THE RIGHT
LEVEL SUPPORT WE NEED TO GET FOR
THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM SELF.
SOME.
GUIDANCE THERE ARE SOME THAT OF
SOMEONE TO LOOK AT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT -- THAT THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO SEE LIKE WHAT WAS.
HOW THE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS COME
TOGETHER SUPPORT?
OF TV I AND IN EXACTLYWHAT SHE
HOUSE DOWDY RIGHT SIZE THIS.
THIS PARTICULAR COMPONENT ARDOR
OTHER PARTS ARE MAYBE BUT SO WE
SHOULD BE PUTTING MORE SUPPORT
AND SOME OTHER PARTS TO SELL.
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY WELL THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION APPRECIATE --
THIS -- WE WILL HOLD ALL THE
ITEMS OPEN -- PER WAITING FOR
MAY REVISE -- BUT CERTAINLY VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF FOR THE PROPOSALS
THAT COME FORWARD FROM THE
DEPARTMENT THANKS VERY MUCH
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
SO -- I KNOW WE JUST STARTED
FAIRLY -- ABOUT AN HOUR AGO BUT
IT IS TWELVE FORTY ONCE I'M
GONNA TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF A
STRETCH BREAK FOR FIVE MINUTES
BEFORE WE DIVE INTO THE PARTNERS --
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SO NO
MIND WILL TAKE A FIVE MINUTE
BREAK AND THEN WE'LL.
GET RIGHT INTO DDS THANK YOU
PEOPLE CAN SIT DOWN.
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO RESUME THIS
HEARING OF THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE HELPED HIM SERVICES
WERE MOVING ON TO THE PART A
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AND SO I
EVERYONE CAN JUST RE INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES FOR THE RECORD SO
WE'LL START WITH DEPARTMENTS.
THE AGENCY PLEASE.
FINANCE DEPARTMENT DIRECTOR DDS
THANK YOU.
JIM NINETY DS THANK YOU PRONTO
EL DDS OKAY.
WHEN YOU PARTICULARLY -- AND
MARK NEWTON OHIO A FINANCE CHRIS
COOKED BERMAN FINANCE STEVEN
PUBLIC DEPARTMENT FINANCE OKAY
EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE
GOING TO FIRST BEGIN WITH OUR
OVERVIEW -- AND WE'RE PRETTY
GOOD RIGHT UP.
TO I THINK WE'VE SEEN EACH OTHER
BEFORE SO WE CAN TO SET THE
HIGHLIGHTS ON OF THE ISSUES THAT
ARE BEFORE THE DEPARTMENT AND
WITH O FOR OF THIS FARCE WHAT.
YOU'VE BEEN EXPERIENCING WHAT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT MOVING ON TO
THE EXPERT TO YOURSELF THANK YOU
WELCOME.
GREAT THANK THANK YOU SENATOR
PAN -- WHAT I DID WAS I TOOK A
LOOK AT OVER THIS LAST YEAR WHAT
ARE THE SIGNIFICANT ISSUES THAT
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON IN AREAS
WHERE WE'VE HAD CHALLENGES AND
AREAS WHAT -- SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'VE ACCOMPLISHED -- IT'S
IT REALLY IT WAS APPARENT TO ME
AS WE WERE -- KIND OF TAKING A
LOOK AT THOSE THAT MANY OF THE
THINGS THAT ARE OUTLINED IN YOUR
AGENDA AND THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
DISCUSSING TODAY ACTUALLY ARE
VERY CONSISTENT.
WITH MANY OF THE CHALLENGES AND%
THE SUCCESSES -- OVER OUR CHAIN
IS CERTAINLY ARE EVOLVING AND
CHANGING SYSTEM AS WE'VE --
MOVED IN CLOSE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS OVER THE MANY YEARS AND
MOVING TO SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS IN
THE COMMUNITY THE THINGS THAT
ARE TIED TO THAT TO BE
RESPONSIVE TO THOSE EVER
CHANGING NEEDS.
I JUST WANT TO GIVE YOU SOME
HIGHLIGHTS THAT BEEN GOING ON
OVER THIS LAST YEAR IN CLOSING
THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS WE'VE
BEEN -- CLOSING THREE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS AT UPON
THE ANNOUNCEMENT MAY.
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND SO IN DOING
SO THAT COMES WITH PARTICULAR
CHALLENGES CERTAINLY AT THE VERY
TAIL END OF OF THE CLOSURE WHEN
YOU WERE REALLY TAKING A LOOK AT
HOW WE'RE GOING TO BE KIND OF
MERGING THE TWO AS FAR AS MOVING
FOLKS TO THE COMMUNITY.
FINALIZING THE HOUSING TAKING --
CAREFUL CONSIDERATION OF THE
STAFF THAT ARE OVER THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS BUT I'M
HAPPY TO REPORT EVEN THROUGH ALL
THOSE CHALLENGES -- THAT WE
ACTUALLY -- DID ACHIEVE HAVING
LAST PERSON MOVE OUT A CINEMA
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER -- AND WE
ARE MOVING TOWARDS -- THE OTHER
INDIVIDUALS AND I'LL GIVE THAT
UP A LITTLE BIT LATER IN THE
AGENDA -- BUT ONE OF THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS THAT HAS BEEN
ACHIEVED OVER THIS LAST YEAR IS
THE FINAL DEVELOPMENT OF ABOUT
FORTY FOUR HOMES TO SUPPORT THAT
CLOSURE.
SO THAT'S JUST BEEN OVER THE
LAST TWELVE MONTHS ALSO WHEN WE
ARE TAKING A LOOK AT OUR TOTAL
POPULATION WHEN WE ANNOUNCED THE
CLOSURE WE HAD -- STARTED WITH A
POPULATION FOR CLOSURE PURPOSES
OF EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX AND
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS
WITH THE TRANSITIONS WERE DOWN
UNDER A HUNDRED AS FAR AS
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE MOVING OUT.
WE ALSO -- AS MANY CALIFORNIANS
THAT WE'RE FACED WITH THE NUMBER
OF FIRES YOU KNOW THE REGIONAL
CENTERS PORT A NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS IN THE COMMUNITY ONE
OF THE SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY IS IS BEING
RESPONSIVE IN MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE SERVICES ARE.
AVAILABLE ON EMERGENCY NEED
DURING THAT TIME THE REGIONAL
CENTERS AND I'M TRYING TO GIVE
THEM SUPPORT THAT THE EVACUATION
OF THE DIFFERENT FIRES WAS ABOUT
TWO THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS.
WHO HAVE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES
THAT WERE EVACUATED DURING THAT
TIME PERIOD?
THEY WERE -- A HIGHLY RESPONSIVE --
BUT IT WAS ALSO AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US IS THE DEPARTMENT TO PAY
IT FORWARD A LITTLE BIT -- AND
SUPPORT THE FOLKS THAT -- HAD
CHALLENGES DURING THIS TIME --
IF YOU RECALL -- DURING THE
FIRES IN CINEMA THAT WE WERE
EVACUATED OUT OF CINEMA
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER AND WE HAD --
JUST OVER TWO HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS AT THAT TIME A
COUPLE YEARS AGO THAT WE HAD TO
EVACUATE THIS YEAR WE'RE ABLE TO
DO SOMETHING A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT.
SO AS INDIVIDUALS NEEDED A PLACE
TO STAY AT SO NO MY WE'RE ABLE
TO SUPPORT ELEVEN INDIVIDUALS
WHY WERE STILL IN OPERATION.
THAT NEEDED A PLACE TO STAY FOR
A COUPLE OF WEEKS WERE ABLE TO
BRING THEM IN ON EMERGENCY BASIS.
OVER AT PORTER BILL WE WERE ABLE
TO BRING IN SEVENTEEN
INDIVIDUALS -- THAT WERE --
EVACUATED BECAUSE OF THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA FIRES -- SO
IT REALLY IS SOMETHING THAT'S
BEEN -- A SUCCESS FOR OUR SYSTEM
TO BE ABLE TO SAY EVEN DURING
THE CRISIS AND AND HAVING TO
FACE THESE CHALLENGES.
THAT COLLECTIVELY PEOPLE COME
TOGETHER TO PROVIDE THOSE
SUPPORTS -- SELF DETERMINATION --
IT'S IT'S AN A HIGH FOCUS FOR
OUR DEPARTMENT CERTAINLY FOR OUR
COMMUNITY.
I'M HAPPY TO SAY OVER THIS LAST
YEAR WE RECEIVED APPROVAL ON OUR
WAIVER TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH SELF DETERMINATION --
WHILE WE CONTINUE TO SEE.
PROGRESS AND AND HAPPY TO REPORT
THAT -- EACH REGIONAL CENTER
EITHER EITHER HAVE COMPLETED
THEIR ORIENTATIONS OR HAVE THEM
SCHEDULED. TO BE ABLE TO HELP
THE PARTICIPANTS MOVE FORWARD
YOU KNOW WHILE WE KNOW THAT THIS
HAS BEEN A PARTICULAR TO ALLEN
TO TRYING TO GET THINGS
OPERATIONAL IT'S A NEW WAVER.
YOU KNOW AND I KNOW THAT THERE'S
BEEN TIMES WHEN THERE'S BEEN
SOME CHALLENGES IN FRUSTRATION
BY OUR COMMUNITY AS TO HOW LONG
IT'S TAKEN -- BUT I DO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CELEBRATE THE
SUCCESS -- IN BEING ABLE TO MOVE
THAT FORWARD.
WE ALSO -- JUST RECENTLY --
RECEIVED APPROVAL ON A LICENSE
OF OUR COMMUNITY STAR HOME.
SO A Q. CRISIS SERVICES IS ONE
OF THE HOMES THAT WE ARE
DEVELOPING AS PART OF KIND OF
OUR SAFETY NET THAT STATE
OPERATED -- JUST TO KIND OF
REFRESH YOUR MEMORY THAT WE ARE
OPERATING -- ONE STAR HOME AT
CINEMA DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER AND
THEN ONE AT IF YOU WERE
CERTAINLY EXPANDING THEM BUT
BECAUSE OF THE DEVELOPMENT WE
ARE MOVING ONE OF THE HOMES TO
THE COMMUNITY.
THAT IS A HOME THAT JUST GOT
LICENSED YOU WOULD THINK
INTUITIVELY THAT THIS WOULD BE
AN EASY TASK FOR US TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO DEVELOP ONE HOME FOR
FIVE INDIVIDUALS GET IT LICENSE.
BUT YOU KNOW WHEN YOU COULD
YOU'RE YOU'RE GOING DOWN THAT
PATH AND TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO OPERATIONALIZE IT CAME
WITH.
INTERESTING CHALLENGES
EVERYTHING FROM TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO MANAGE TO SEPTIC
SYSTEMS HOW TO DO DIFFERENT
THINGS AND I KNOW IT SOUNDS LIKE
IT'S KIND OF A SMALL TASK BUT IT
IS THE FRAMEWORK. FOR ALL OF THE
DEVELOPMENT THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
DOING AS A STATE OPERATED IN OUR
QUEUE CRISIS AS WE MOVE TO THE
COMMUNITY -- I'D ALSO LIKE.
TO SAY THAT IN TAKING A LOOK AT
THE CHALLENGES THAT OUR
COMMUNITY IS FACING AS FAR AS
SUPPORTING INDIVIDUALS WITH CO
OCCURRING NEEDS TAKING A LOOK AT
THE GROWTH IN OUR SYSTEM.
WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK AT THE
GROWTH IN OUR SYSTEM IS VERY
SIGNIFICANT WERE GROWING BY
ABOUT TWELVE TO FIFTEEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK AT AN
AVERAGE SIZE REGIONAL CENTER?
IT IS ABOUT THAT SO WHEN YOU
LOOK AT ARE PROJECTED -- CENSUS
IN NINETEEN TWENTY THAT WE ARE
LOOKING AT SERVING APPROXIMATELY
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS.
KIND OF OF NOTE WHEN WE LOOK
BACK -- IN OUR HISTORY ABOUT TEN
YEARS AGO WE WERE JUST ABOUT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND LESS THAN THAN
WHAT WE ARE TODAY.
SO YOU CAN SEE THAT THE GROWTH
IS CERTAINLY THERE -- WE ARE
ALSO -- VERY PLEASED TO SAY THAT
THIS IS THE FIRST COUPLE OF
YEARS SAID WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
HAVE THE FUNDS AVAILABLE UNDER
OUR COMMUNITY PLACEMENT PLAN FOR
A DIFFERENT PURPOSE AND IT
SUPPORTING DIFFERENT ACTIVITIES
UNDER THE COMMUNITY RESOURCE
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT WE WERE ABLE
TO SEE SOME VERY UNIQUE PROJECTS
THAT THE REGIONAL CENTERS IN THE
COMMUNITY IDENTIFIED TO SUPPORT
THE LOCAL NEEDS -- AS A RESULT
WE SAW FIVE ADDITIONAL MULTI
FAMILY HOUSES HOUSING EFFORTS
THAT ARE BEING DEVELOPED -- TO
EXPAND OUR AFFORDABLE HOUSING --
UNITS WE'RE ALSO SEEING THAT
THERE IS SOME NEW -- PROGRAMS
THAT ARE BEING DEVELOPED ON
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING THAT IS
GOING TO PROVIDE SPECIFIC
EMPLOYMENT.
TRAINING TO THIRTY FIVE
EMPLOYMENT SPECIALIST AND THEN
THERE IS AN EXPANSION AN EARLY
START SO WE'RE REALLY PLEASED TO
SEE THAT WERE ABLE TO DO SOME IT
EXPANDED WORK WITHIN.
THE COMMUNITY SERVICES IN THE
COMMUNITY RESOURCE DEVELOPMENT
THERE'S TWO QUESTIONS THAT --
ARE ADDED IN THE AGENDA THAT YOU --
YOU WANTED US TO EXPAND ON AND
SO WE DO HAVE DEPUTY --
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR JIM
NIGHT HERE TO PROVIDE SOME
RESPONSES FOR YOU.
HI THANK YOU YES THE FIRST OF
ALL ON THE ELECTRONIC VISIT
VERIFICATION SYSTEM AND I KNOW
WE'RE GOING TO BE SPEAKING ON
THAT THE NEXT -- PART OF THE
AGENDA SO JUST BRIEFLY YOU KNOW
WE ARE WORKING WITH -- THE
OFFICES SYSTEM INTEGRATION
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY
AND OTHER DEPARTMENTS AS A A
COLLECTIVE APPROACH AND LOOKING
AT WHAT -- THE THE ULTIMATE
OUTCOME MAY BE SO THERE IS A
SPRING FINANCE LETTER THAT WE'LL
BE DISCUSSING LATER AND SO JUST
WANT TO MAKE.
SURE THAT A BIG PART OF THAT IS
REALLY THE STAKEHOLDER
INVOLVEMENT TO SUPPORT AND
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT'S A BIG PIECE OF
WHAT WE DO TO HELP INFORM US
MOVING FORWARD -- THEN ALSO NEXT
IS ON MINIMUM WAGE AND ABOUT THE
DECREASE IN MINIMUM WAGE AND AND
THIS CURRENT BUDGET AND SO SEVEN
AND AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE'VE SEEN -- OVER THE YEARS
WITH ALL THE MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASES THAT WE'VE DONE SOME
ADJUSTMENTS AFTER LOOKING BACK
AT WHAT THE ACTUAL IS HAVE BEEN
AND AND JUST MAKING DE.
IN AND DEVELOPING ESTIMATES FOR
WHAT THE MINIMUM WAGE IMPACT IS
GOING TO BE IT'S IT'S A BIT OF A
CHALLENGE FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS.
ONE WE DON'T HAVE WE DON'T HIRE
FOLKS DIRECTLY SO WE DON'T KNOW
HOW MANY EMPLOYEES THERE ARE AND
WHAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY GETTING
PAID.
AND THEN ALSO SME SOME
INTERMEDIATE THINGS THAT OCCUR
AS WELL WHEN WE START TO GET A
TREND WE ALSO HAVE SOME OTHER --
FACTORS SUCH AS RATE INCREASES
THAT CAME IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN WHERE WE SAW SLOW DOWN
THEN AND MINIMUM WAGE.
AND IN THE LIKE INTO ALSO
ANYTHING SO SOMEONE ASKING WHAT
ARE SOME OF THE REASONS BEHIND
THAT I MEAN IT JUST REALLY IS
THAT THERE'S A NUMBER OF
ASSUMPTIONS THAT WE PUT IN AND
THEN WE TRY AND IN THE ESTIMATE
AND WE TRY TO UPDATE BASED ON
ACTUAL AS AS WE MOVE.
FORWARD -- BUT IT IS IT IS A
CHALLENGE IN DOING THAT WE ARE
SEEING AN INCREASE IN THE NUMBER
OF REQUESTS THIS YEAR THEY'VE
BEEN ABOUT TWICE AS MANY THIS
YEAR'S THERE WERE LAST YEAR.
YEAH -- OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
MONTHS WILL HAVE AN IDEA OF WHAT
THAT FISCAL IMPACT IS.
IN THAT SOMETHING ACTUALLY BEEN
EXPECTING AND THAT'S WHY WE'VE
BEEN -- WITH OUR MINIMUM WAGE
ESTIMATE HAS BEEN -- DO WE WE
HAVE BEEN -- THE CAREFUL TO
BRING IT DOWN TOO MUCH KNOWING
THAT IS THE MINIMUM WAGE
CONTINUES TO GO UP IS GONNA BE
MORE MORE EMPLOYEES.
ALSO THERE'S A REQUEST FOR AN
ESTIMATE -- ABOUT WHAT IT WOULD
TAKE FOR THOSE.
PROVIDERS AND LOCAL MINIMUM WAGE
AREAS WE DID -- PROVIDE THAT
LAST NIGHT I BELIEVE ACTUALLY TO
THE LA -- AND CERTAINLY I KNOW
THERE'S SOME FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS
I WILL BE HAPPY TO WORK THROUGH
SOME OF THOSE WITH THEM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LA -- AND I GUESS HE JUST GOT
SOME STUFF LAST NIGHT.
WE DID WE CAN TALK ABOUT IT --
SONY PETTITTE KALLIO -- JUST
REAL QUICK A IN CASE YOU'VE
FORGOTTEN -- THIS IS AN ISSUE WE
BROUGHT UP LAST YEAR REGARDING
THE LOCAL MINIMUM WHAT WE'RE
CALLING IT THE LOCAL MINIMUM
WAGE QUIRK.
YES YES IS WHERE THE THE THE
SERVICE PROVIDERS IN AREAS THAT
HAVE LOCAL MINIMUM WAGE
ORDINANCES ARE NOT ABLE TO
ACCESS THE INCREASES ASSOCIATED
WITH THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE AND
THE I'M SORRY NOT ABLE TO ACCESS
THE READ ADJUSTMENTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE.
INCREASES SO THEY THEY'RE SORT
OF HIT TWO FOLD.
ONE THEY HAVE TO PAY A HIGHER.
WAGE BECAUSE OF THE LOCAL
MINIMUM WAGE ORDINANCE WITH NO
COMMENSURATE INCREASE IN
REVENUES AND THEN THEY ALSO ARE
UNABLE TO ACCESS THE RATE
ADJUSTMENT ASSOCIATED WITH THE
STATE MINIMUM WAGE.
SO WITH ALL THAT SAID -- WE
SUSPECTED THAT THIS COULD ALSO
BE ONE OF THE REASONS THAT THE
THE DEPARTMENT'S ESTIMATES OF
FOR THE COST OF STATE MINIMUM
WAGE HAVE COME IN A BIT LOWER --
THEY WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE US
LAST NIGHT WITH AN ESTIMATE SO
IF THE MINIMUM WAGE WAS PROVIDED
TO ALL SERVICE PROVIDERS
STARTING WITH THE JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASE IT WILL COST ABOUT.
SIXTEEN MILLION TOTAL FUNDS
ABOUT EIGHT MILLION GENERAL FUND
AMOUNT -- ONE OF THE THINGS THE
DEPARTMENT REMINDED US OF IS
THAT -- SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
PROVIDE RESIDENTIAL SERVICES IN
COMMUNITY CARE FACILITIES.
ACROSS THE STATE REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER THEY'RE IN AN AREA WITH
A LOCAL MINIMUM WAGE ORDINANCE
ALREADY BENEFIT FROM THE STATE --
THE INCREASE IS PROVIDED FOR
STATE MINIMUM WAGE BECAUSE THE
THE RATE IS SET AT A STATEWIDE
LEVEL BY THE DEPARTMENT -- SO I
GUESS IN CLOSING SORRY IDEA IT
DIDN'T REALLY SOME OF THE POINT
THAT ARE IN ALICE IN OUR
ANALYSIS WE HAD RECOMMENDED --
THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER WHETHER
THIS WAS THEIR INTENT TO CREATE
THE SYSTEM WHERE THE THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS IN THE AREAS WITH
LOCAL MINIMUM WAGE ORDINANCES
COULD NOT ACCESS THE STATE
PROVIDED -- READING TREES AND IF
THEY DID NOT INTEND THAT THAN TO
DO SOME STATUTORY CLEANUP THAT
WOULD ALLOW THEM TO ACCESS THIS
BENEFIT PERHAPS STARTING JANUARY
FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY OKAY ANYTHING
AMISS ABOUT ANY OTHER PARTS OF
THIS OVERVIEW -- NO NOT WILL GET
INTO THINGS AND OTHER ISSUES
THANK YOU OKAY FINANCE.
YES THE JUST AND AND COMMENT ON
THE FISCAL ASSOCIATED WITH THE
MINIMUM WAGE TO THAT WE WERE
JUST DISCUSSING I THINK I WOULD
HIGHLY CAN CARRY ON IT WITH YOU
KNOW A LOT OF THE ASSUMPTIONS
ARE BASED ON SOME POTENTIAL TAKE
OPERATES.
AND ALSO BASED UPON AND THOSE
ARE DEVELOPED BASED UPON THE
AXLES THAT WE DO HAVE AND THEN
AGAIN I MEAN JUST JUST THE ECHO --
MISTER NIGHTS -- COMMENTS
SPECIFIC TO THE UNKNOWNS OF THE
MINIMUM WAGE ITSELF IT SAYS
THAT'S OUR BEST GUESS AT THIS
TIME SO I JUST WANNA.
PUT THAT CARRY OUT OUT THERE
THAT [inaudible]
YEAH.
YEAH ROUGH NUMBERS BUT BASED
UPON OUR ASSUMPTIONS AT THIS
TIME SO I DID SO JUST TO CLARIFY
TO AND THAT FIVE MAKE IN A RAINY
ASSUMPTION PLEASE CORRECT ME SO.
BASICALLY YOU KNOW WE HAVE
PROVIDERS AND VARIOUS DIFFERENT
LOCALITIES THAT MAY HAVE
DIFFERENT LOCAL MINIMUM WAGES
RATE AND SO A PROVIDER WHO IS IN
A AREAS WITH HIGH LOCAL MINIMUM
WAGE -- YOU REIMBURSE THEM AT DO
YOU TAKE ACCOUNT OF THAT ONE IN
TERMS OF THEIR PAYMENTS ARE NOT.
SOME WEIGHT.
WELL YOU CAN ANSWER THE QUESTION
A I THINK THE AUDIENCE I HAS A
NO.
RIGHT YEAH BECAUSE THE THE LAW
RIGHT NOW AS FAR AS FOR A
MINIMUM WAGE -- SAYS THAT WE CAN
ONLY PROVIDE -- INCREASES IF
NECESSARY TO PAY THE RIGHT STATE
MINIMUM OKAY ALL RIGHT SO JUST
CUT BY THAT SO.
AND AND SO NOW OF COURSE WITH
THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE GOING UP
WE ALLOCATE SOME ADDITIONAL
FUNDS.
FOR THEM -- TO PROVIDERS TO JUST
FOR THE INCREASING STATE MINIMUM
WAGE SO.
THE PROVIDERS IN THE HIGH LOCAL
MINIMUM WAGE AREA REYES WHO'S A
READY HAVING TO BECAUSE IF THE
BAY TO LOCAL LAWS PAYING THE
HIGHER RATE.
ARETHE ABLE TO SO SINCE THEY'RE
READY PAYING A HIGHER RATE BUT
THEIR ACTUAL REIMBURSEMENTS
FACED ON THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE.
FIVE IT'S NOT BASED ON THE STATE
MINIMUM WAGES BASED ON WHATEVER
THEIR RATE WAS.
THANK AT AT AT AT OKAY AND THEY
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO ACCESS SO.
SO THEN THE FOR THAT THAT'S ONE
GET A AYE AYES SIDE OKAY SO SO
THE SO THE PROBLEM IS NOW THAT
WHEN WE SAY WE'LL HEAR SOME
MONEY TO ADDRESS THE STATE
MINIMUM WAGE.
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO ACCESS
BECAUSE OF ALL WILL YOU'RE READY
PAYING AT HIGHER AT THE HIGHER
RATE BUT YET.
WHATEVER THE RATE THAT WAS SET
BEFORE.
DIDN'T REALLY TAKE A CAB A LOCAL
MINIMUM WAGE RATES SO THAT'S THE
TWO FOR PROBLEM OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO -- SO I I HEARD
LIKE ESTIMATES AND STUFF LIKE BY
ME IN TERMS OF POLICY SHOULD AND
THEY HAVE ACCESS [inaudible]
TO V..
STATE MINIMUM WAGE THAT TO
INCREASE REIMBURSEMENT.
EVEN THOUGH THEY TECHNICALLY
AREN'T PAYING THEIR PEOPLE MORE
BUT I MEAN WE SAID A
REIMBURSEMENT IT WASN'T BASED ON
THEIR LOCAL MINIMUM WAGE.
I GUESS THAT'S THE QUESTION
HELLO WHAT'S WHAT'S WHAT'S
WHAT'S WHAT'S WHAT'S AYE AYE
CLARIFY WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S POSITION IS ON
THIS.
AS SOON HAVE MY OWN OPINIONS BUT
THAT.
IS NOT WHAT THE MINISTRATIONS
POSITION ON THIS [inaudible]
YES IT.
THE POSITION IS IS THAT TO THE
EXTENT THAT THEY ARE PAID BELOW.
THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE --
THAT'LL STATE MINIMUM WAGE THEN
THEY'LL ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE.
THAT INCREASE.
WILL.
IF THE RATES ARE BELOW THE
MINIMUM WAGE BUT THEY'RE PAYING
HIGHER BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO MEET
THE LOCAL MINIMUM RIGHT AGE BUT
AND THE RATE AT WHICH THEY'RE
BEING REIMBURSED DID NOT TAKE
THAT AND THE COUNTY JUST SORT OF
MADE IT WORK.
RIGHT OR OF THE AND THE STATE'S
POSITION IS WE DON'T FIND WE
DON'T SUPPORT THE LOCAL MINIMUM
WAGE.
OKAY BUT WE SUPPORT THE STATE
MINIMUM WAGERATE.
SO WE SHOULD AT LEAST IF WE HAVE
OUR STATE MINIMUM WAGE IS GOING
UP WE SHOULD MAKE SOME
ADJUSTMENT FOR AT LEAST THE
STATE MINIMUM WAGE INCREASE AND
IF THEIR RATES ARE BELOW THAT
THEN THEY'RE ELIGIBLE FOR THAT
INCREASE AND IF THEY'RE READY
PAYING HIGHER.
THAN THAT BECAUSE THE LOCAL
MINIMUM WAGE STATION.
EVEN THOUGH THE STATEMENT WAY I
REALIZE THAT TECHNICALLY THE
WAGES OF THEIR EMPLOYEES HAVEN'T
CHANGED BECAUSE THE SEED AWAY TO
STILL MAY BE BEHIND FOR THE
LOCAL MINIMUM WAGES.
BUT ALSO THE ORIGINAL RATE THAT
THEY WERE REIMBURSED LIST DIDN'T
TAKE ACCOUNT OF THE LOCAL
MINIMUM WAGE RATE WHICH IS
HIGHER CORRECT.
YEAH AND AND THAT'S WHAT THE
ESTIMATE I BELIEVE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT PROVIDED WAS SUPPOSED
TO REFLECT IS WHAT THAT.
COST WOULD BE TO FIND AT THAT
INCREASE.
OKAY SO THE ESTIMATE IS TO
INCREASE MATTER WHICH LOCALITY
URINE.
YEAH THAT WAS THE ESTIMATE --
THEY PROVIDED IT WAS LIKE
ALRIGHT PROVIDERS REGARDLESS.
FOR THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE IN
RIGHT NOT THE LOCAL MEN OKAY AND
THE NUMBERS THAT I GAVE YOU
WOULD BE A HALF YEAR COSTS
BECAUSE IT WOULD BE WITH THE
BRING THEM ON YEAH OKAY SO WE
WILL SO THE INTENTION IS THAN.
TO BOB SURE AMANDA ROVIDES LIKE
WILL WANT YOU JUST PAY IS
EXACTLY WHAT THAT BUT AT LEAST
WE'RE GOING TO GIVE.
THEM AN ADJUSTMENT BASED ON THE
INCREASE IN THE STATE MINIMUM
WAGE.
EVERYONE WHEN YOU SAY INTENT I I
THINK WE WERE ASKED TO PROVIDE.
ON THAT.
OKAY RIGHT RIGHT FISCAL ON THAT
OKAY BUT WHAT THAT WOULD COST
OKAY THERE'S CURRENTLY NO
PROPOSAL DID OKAY FROM HER EIGHT
MINISTRATION JUST TO BE CLEAR
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
SO I WOULD SUGGEST PERHAPS WE
ARE THINK ABOUT THAT.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO -- I I HOPE I HOPE
IN THE MAY REVISE SHOWS A FULL
HEAD OF A PROPOSAL THIS ON THE
TEACHER RELATED TO THAT ARE WE
WILL HAVE A DISCUSSION ABOUT
THAT I APPRECIATE THE
CALCULATION.
MORE THAN HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO
HAVING DISCUSSIONS OKAY ALL
RIGHT I GUESS I CAN ASK MORE
THAN THAT RIGHT NOW.
BUT IN THE WEEK I THINK WE CAN
TALK MORE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT BUT I MEAN DOES
THAT MAKE SENSE RIGHT BACK TO
YOUR SITE I KNOW YOU HAVE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S LINE BUT WHAT WHAT HE
WANTS I THOUGHT I WAS JUST GOING.
TO SHARE WITH YOU THAT YOU KNOW
WE WILL CONTINUE AS AS FINANCES
SAID OR WERE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN ANY
FISCAL AND HAVE A CONVERSATION --
SO WELCOME THOSE DISCUSSIONS --
WILL CONTINUE -- TO REVIEW I
WILL SAY THAT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE HAVE BEEN DOING TO WORK
WITH THE PROVIDERS IN THE
REGIONAL CENTERS IN THE
DIFFERENT AREAS THAT.
WERE PROVIDERS HAVE FACED
DIFFERENT ISSUES BUT ONE OF THEM
THAT HAS BEEN PRESSURES. TO DO
WITH WAGES WHETHER IT'S WITH
LOCAL MINIMUM WAGE RATHER
PRESSURES -- WHILE IT IS AN
ONEROUS PROCESS IN SOME
SITUATIONS THERE IS THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY -- OPTION BE ABLE TO
MAKE A REQUEST TO THE DEPARTMENT --
TO HAVE AN ADJUSTMENT -- WHILE
SOME MAY NOT FIND IT TO BE THE
MOST POPULAR PATH TO TAKE IT IS
AN OPTION -- TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
SURE THAT INDIVIDUALS ARE
RECEIVING SERVICES.
ALRIGHT WELL I AND I KNOW WE
DISCUSSED THAT BEFORE -- I GUESS
IN SOME SENSES -- TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW YOU HOW HE GETS
RATIONALIZE THE WE WERE DOING A
REIMBURSEMENT SO [inaudible]
ASSEMBLY OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WELL I HAVE A SECOND A
CONVERSATION TO BE CONTINUED
OKAY [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY WELL.
RIGHT IN THE RIGHT WELL LET'S GO
AHEAD AND MOVE ON THEN -- ISSUE
NUMBER -- TWO THIS RECIPROCAL IS
ON THIS FOR THE NOSE ACCIDENTAL.
OKAY SO ACTUALLY WHAT WE DO IS
MAYBE JUST ASK PEOPLE TO SHIFT
OVER -- AROUND SO WE HAVE SOME
SPACE THE FRONT SO WE HAVE.
A PROPOSAL -- THE PANEL ON
IMPLEMENTATION THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE IN HALF DAY
BILLING POLICY AND I THINK WE
HAVE A JORDAN LINDSAY IS A
DIRECTOR OF THE ARK CALIFORNIA
AND NANCY CHANCE EXEC DIRECTOR
OF CHOICES PERSON CENTERED
SERVICES [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
SO.
IF YOU CAN KEEP YOUR REMARKS TWO
UNDER THREE MINUTES.
I THINK IF THIS IS AN ISSUE.
YEP.
AND THAT SAID THAT THIS IS AN
ISSUE I THINK WE HAVE HEARD
BEFORE HER IN VARIOUS ITERATIONS
SO -- SO ANYWAY THAT THANK YOU
WELCOME THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
JORDAN AND SEE WITH THE ARK
UNITED CIVIL POLICY YES YOU HAVE
HEARD THIS LAST YEAR -- BUT I
WAS ASKED TO PROVIDE AGAIN A
LITTLE BACKGROUND AT LEAST TO
HOW WE GOT HERE I'LL BE VERY
QUICK ABOUT THAT -- BUT I DO
WANT TO GIVE THE OVER ARCHING
UMBRELLA THAT.
IN ADDITION TO EVERYTHING WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AND HOW THE SYSTEM
OF SUPPORTS AND SERVICES FOR
PEOPLE INTELLECTUALS ABILITIES
IS.
REALLY KIND OF IN A CRISIS MODE.
STARTING JULY FIRST WERE LORD
STERN AND ANOTHER CUT.
IN TIMES OF SURPLUS RIGHT NOW SO
THAT'S OVER ARCHING OF ALL THESE
COMMENTS -- IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
THE STATE FACE AN UNPRECEDENTED
BUDGET SHORTFALL OF COURSE AND
TO DO THE ULTIMATE REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT VITAL SERVICES TO
REDUCE OUR BUDGET BY THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES.
DRASTIC CUTS TO SERVICES WERE
REQUIRED.
AMONG THEM WAS THAT FOURTEEN THE
UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE AND
HALF THE BILLING.
IN SEPTEMBER TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
THE ARC OF CALIFORNIA AND UNITS
WILL PULL THE SAN DIEGO FILED A
LAWSUIT AGAINST THE CITY
CALIFORNIA BLOCKED
IMPLEMENTATION THE CUTS.
AT THE DEEMED HARMFUL IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE DISTRICT
COURT RULED AGAINST THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND IN OUR FAVOR AND
A FEDERAL LAWSUIT DECLINE THAT
THE STATE YOU LEGALLY CUT THE
FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS.
THE RULING AUTUMN WE FOUND THAT
THE STATE FAILED TO COMPLY WITH
MEDICAID REQUIREMENTS -- HOWEVER
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE
ORDER WAS VACATED AS YOU KNOW
WHEN THIRD PARTIES Là STANDING
IN MEDICAID -- SUITS HOWEVER WAS
NOT BEEN ENFORCED SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THEN LAST
YEAR -- PROPOSED IN THIS --
BUDGET COMMITTEE HEARING AS WELL
AS AN ASSEMBLY SIDE WAS THE RE
ENFORCEMENT OF THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE.
MAKE A NOTE HOWEVER THAT IN THIS
COMMITTEE THE HALF THE BUILDING
WAS NOT ACTUALLY HEARD LAST YEAR --
YOU MADE VERY POIGNANT REMARKS
LAST YEAR TALKING ABOUT FOR LOW
DAYS AND HOW YOU EXPERIENCE FOR
LOW DAYS TEN YEARS AGO WHEN
THINGS ARE BAD -- IS A REALLY
UNNECESSARY -- IS IT NECESSARY
TO CONTINUE TO FURLOUGH DAYS
WHICH IS WHAT WE CONSIDER THEM
TO BE -- THE HALF THE BILLION
WAS IN FORCE CAUSING IMMEDIATE
IMPACTS TO THE COMMUNITY LAST
YEAR AND AS I ALREADY SAID JULY
FIRST FOR STARING RIGHT AT A CUT.
TO FAMILIES SERVICES INDIVIDUALS
AND THE SUPPORT THAT THEY
REQUIRE.
A QUICK UPDATE ON THE LAWSUIT AS
WELL.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL ACTUALLY IN
THEIR OWN COMMENTS -- PAST
REQUEST OF THE COURT TO DELAY
THIS CASE BECAUSE IN THEIR OWN
COMMENTS THEY SAID WELL THE
LEGISLATURE ALMOST ACTED ON THIS
LAST YEAR.
THEY'RE PROBABLY GOING TO ACT ON
IT THIS YEAR SO LET'S NOT BOTHER
THE COURTS WITH IT.
WE SAID WELL WE WE HOPE THAT'S
THE CASE BUT WE CAN'T RELY ON
THAT SO ON JULY THIRTY FIRST
THERE IS A SETTLEMENT CONFERENCE --
ON THESE TWO ISSUES THAT WILL
TAKE PLACE -- AND WE HOPE
HOWEVER WHETHER IT'S THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS OR THROUGH
THE COURTS THAT I'M NOT ONLY
WILL WE SEE THE HALF THE BILLING.
ELIMINATED THAT BUT ALSO THAT OF
WHAT IS COMING RIGHT AT US WILL
BE STOPPED TOM WITH THE
REINFORCEMENT OF THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE THANK YOU.
A NANCY CHANCE I'M A FAMILY
MEMBER I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CHOICES PERSON
CENTERED SERVICES AND A MEMBER
OF CD CAN.
AND A PATH FORWARD COLLABORATIVE.
THANKS FOR THEM GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY I'M.
I AM ALSO HERE TO DISCUSS THE
FOURTEEN DAY UNIFORM HOLIDAY
SCHEDULE -- I THINK THE THE
THING THAT STRIKES ME FIRST IS
THAT AS A STATE THAT'S WORKING
TOWARDS THE HOME AND GET UP YOU
COMPLIANCE WITH THE HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES WAIVER --
THIS IS IN DIRECT CONTRADICTION
TO THE PRINCIPLES OF A CBS AND
AS IT IT DOESN'T ALLOW FOR
INDIVIDUAL CHOICE AND PROBABLY
LIKELY WILL -- AFFECT A PERSON'S
ABILITY. TO TO KEEP AN
EMPLOYMENT YOU KNOW IT'LL HINDER
THEIR OPPORTUNITIES.
BECAUSE IF THEY DON'T HAVE
SOMEONE TO SUPPORT THEM A TO GO
TO WORK ON AND THE DAY AFTER
THANKSGIVING OR YOU KNOW --
MEMORIAL DAY THEN THEY WON'T BE
ABLE TO WORK AND THEN THAT
THAT'S A PROBLEM SO THAT'S ONE
OF THE THINGS I THINK INITIALLY
JUST AS JORDAN SAID.
WHAT WE NEED TO CLARIFY THAT
THIS IS NOT A HOLIDAY THESE ARE
NOT PAID HOLIDAYS THIS IS THESE
ARE FOR LOTUS?
EATER FOURTEEN FURLOUGH DAYS IT.
TOO AND A SYSTEM THAT FOR YOU'RE
GOING TO HEAR TODAY AND A
SPECIALLY ON MAY NINTH THAT IS
IN CRISIS AND HERE WE ARE.
WE'RE GOING TO IMPLEMENT A CUT
AT A TIME WHEN WE'RE IN CRISIS.
I THINK IT'S A NECESSARY -- AND
AGAIN I DON'T THINK IT'S H. E.
B. S. COMPLIANT AND LASTLY -- I
THINK THAT I DO YOU KNOW WHAT.
WE NEED TO CONSIDER THE SYSTEM
IN THE SOUTH AND AND WE NEED TO
CONSIDER -- MAYBE NOT HAVING
HOLIDAYS AT ALL -- YOU KNOW THAT
ARE.
THAT ARE MANDATED -- SO I'D LIKE
TO ASK YOU TO REPEAT RESEND THE
THE THIS PROPOSAL -- AND THAT
THE STATE LAW THAT THAT WOULD
CAUGHT WOULD PUT THIS IN PLACE.
AND IF NOT AT THE VERY LEAST
DELAY IMPLEMENTATION -- UNTIL
THE RATE ISSUES AND THE H. CBS
ISSUES ARE -- KIND OF CLARIFIED.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MAY I APOLOGIZE
FOR HAD ONE WORD -- QUESTION --
REGARDING THE FIFTY POINT THREE
MILLION AND IT'S IT'S JUST A
QUESTION ON THE THE STAFF TO BE
MAYES JOB WITH THE AGENDA.
WE JUST WEREN'T CLEAR IF THAT IS
FOR ALL FOURTEEN DAYS IS IT FOUR
DAYS -- REGARDING THE BUDGET
ITSELF I DON'T KNOW IF THERE IS
AN ANSWER ON THAT.
I WAS JUST HOPEFUL TO GET
CLARIFICATION ON THAT.
YEAH ACTUALLY DIED PERHAPS A
YEAH DO YOU WANT CLEAR FIGHT
WITH THE THAT AMOUNT IS.
MISTER CHAIR -- THE THE FIFTY
POINT THREE MILLION IS DERIVED.
CAN BE DERIVED A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT WAYS YOU CAN WHAT
WE'RE ASSUMING BASICALLY.
IS THAT -- FOURTEEN REGIONAL
CENTERS.
HAD SEVEN DAY HOLIDAY SCHEDULES
PRIOR.
TO THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
ROLE.
AND SO SEVEN DAYS ARE BEING
ADDED BACK INTO THE ESTIMATE FOR
THAT.
AND THEN THE REMAINING SEVEN
REGIONAL CENTERS WHERE IT TEN
DAYS PRIOR SO.
THE ESTIMATE ASSUMES THAT FOUR
DAYS ARE BEING ADDED BACK FOR
THAT.
IN THAT AND THEN WE BASE IT ON
THE COST PER DAY OF PROVIDING
SERVICES BUT THE CLEAR FIVE IS
IT SAYS SO IF WE REPEAL THE
FOURTEEN DAY SCHEDULE TO COST IS
FIFTY POINT THREE MILLION.
THIRTY POINT ONE MILLION GENERAL
FUND OR IS IT JUST.
OKAY SO THAT'S NOT JUST DIALING
IT BACK.
TO THE DAYS AND FORTY ASSUME
THAT SOME REGIONAL CENTERS --
YOU HAVE TAKE HOLIDAYS IT
WOULDN'T IT WOULDN'T BE ZERO
HOLIDAYS IT WOULD ASSUME THAT ON
AVERAGE REGIONAL CENTERS ARE
TAKING SEVEN TO EIGHT HALL.
HOLIDAYS A YEAR.
BUT CONSIDERED STILL BE HOLIDAYS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SO IF I MAY ASK PLEASE FINANCE I
THINK.
LIKE MANY JOBS EVERYONE HOW IT
TAKES HOLIDAYS OFF I THINK WITH
THIS ACTION THAT WAS TAKEN
SEVERAL YEARS AGO THERE WAS TWO
THINGS THAT HAPPENED.
ONE IT'S THAT.
SPECIFIC DAYS IN WHICH HOLIDAYS
WERE TO BE TAKEN SO THERE WAS
SOME UNIFORMITY HENCE THE
UNIFORM HOLIDAY -- TITLE SO THE
SOME UNIFORMITY SO SAVINGS IN
THAT REGARD AND THEN IN ADDITION
THERE WAS SOME SAVINGS WITH
REGARDS TO HOW MANY DAYS WERE TO
BE TAKEN.
SO IT'S IT'S A IT'S A LITTLE TOO
FOLDED TYPE OF ISSUE OKAY SURE
BUT I THINK AS MISTER DOYLE
NOTED IS IS THAT.
THERE ARE STILL ASSUMPTIONS THAT.
SOME DAYS WILL BE TAKEN THEY
JUST WON'T BE TAKING UNIFORMLY
CRACKED YES.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO THE SO THE
AMOUNTS SOON'S THAT THEY'LL BE.
BUT STE FOR SEVEN DAYS -- SOME.
SEVEN EIGHT DEPENDING SEVEN THE
EIGHT HOLIDAYS AT THE WITH SALT
OKAY I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY WHAT
THE AMOUNT IS OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WELL EXCEED SO LET ME
JUST -- ANY OTHER COMMENTS ON
THE PROPOSAL FROM THE ADVOCATES
FROM THE AGENCIES MAY BE.
ON THIS -- MISTER LINDSEY AND
MISS CHANCE POINTED OUT YOU KNOW
THESE WERE IMPLEMENTED WHEN THE
STATE WAS TRYING TO SOLVE IT
TWENTY SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET SHORTFALL IN THE GENERAL
FUND.
SO MANY OF THE PROPOSALS THAT
WERE IMPLEMENTED THAT TIME
REMAIN IN FACT AND SO THESE ARE
PROPOSALS THAT.
WELL THEIR PROBLEMATIC NO
QUESTION ON THEY HAVE REMAINED
IN FACT OKAY.
ALL RIGHT AWAY OF SNATE PARA
KALLIO -- I JUST I ACTUALLY ALSO
WANNA JUST RAISE A A POINT OF
THAT MIGHT BE HELPFUL TO TO ALSO
THINK ABOUT IN TERMS OF THE THE
REGIONAL CENTERS OBSERVING THEIR
OWN HOLIDAY SCHEDULES EVEN IN
THE ABSENCE OF A STATE WIDE
POLICY -- I THINK SOMETIMES IT'S
EASY TO FORGET THAT THESE WHOLE
THESE HOLIDAYS ARE FERTILIZER
HOWEVER PEOPLE ON A REFER TO
THEM -- REALLY ONLY AFFECT A
CERTAIN SERVICE CATEGORIES SO
IT'S LIKE DAY PROGRAMS WORK
ACTIVITY PROGRAM SO.
IT'S NOT AFFECTING LIKE THE
CORNERS ARE RESIDENTIAL SERVICES
AND THAT SORT OF THING SO A LOT
OF THESE DAY PROGRAMS MIGHT NOT
BE OPERATING ON SAY CHRISTMAS
DAY ANYWAY -- SO THAT'S JUST.
ONE THING TO KEEP IN TO KEEP IN
MIND JUST FOR CONTEXT BUT IN
GENERAL ARE OFFICE -- YOU KNOW
pTHIS IS A BUT POLICY AT THE END
OF THE DAY IT COMES DOWN TO THE
PRIORITY OF THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE PRIORITY OF THE
LEGISLATURE BUT WE DID.
WE DO KNOW THAT IT WAS EIGHTY
POLICY THAT WAS TAKEN DURING A
RECESSIONARY TIME AND THAT WERE
IN DIFFERENT TIMES NOW -- I ALSO
WAS CURIOUS TO TAKE A LOOK AT
WILL HOW MANY HOLIDAYS ARE
OBSERVED BY STATE GOVERNMENT HOW
MANY OR OBSERVE BY FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
IT'S TEN AND ELEVEN DAYS --
THEY'RE NOT AT FOURTEEN DAYS
LIKE THIS POLICY YOU WOULD BE
FOR THIS THE SERVICE PROVIDERS
SO -- THE END OF THE DAY IT
COMES DOWN TO I MEAN THERE WOULD
BE A COST WITH REPEALING IT BUT
YEAH.
THANK YOU THANK COMES FINANCE.
OKAY.
SO JUST AGAIN I'D PUT ELIA SAID
SO CLARIFIED THE THE HOLIDAY
ISSUES REALLY -- FOR TWO DAISY
SERVICES PROGRAMS NOT.
LIKE THE RESIDENTIAL WHICH WOULD
BE TWENTY IS THAT IT'S LIMITED
TO LIMITED TO A CERTAIN TO
CERTAIN SERVICE CATEGORIES AND
THAT'S NOT TO SAY THERE AREN'T
IT DOESN'T CAUSE PROBLEMS FOR
SOME OF THOSE SERVICE CATEGORIES
FOR EXAMPLE -- SOME HE IS
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES ARE NOT
INCLUDED FOR EXAMPLE BUT SOME
PEOPLE GET THEIR JOB SUPPORT
THREE DAY PROGRAMS.
SO IF THEY HAVE THEIR JOB
SUPPORT THREE DAY PROGRAM AND
THEY'RE WORKING ON BLACK FRIDAY
THE DAY AFTER THANKSGIVING AND
THAT'S A REQUIRED HOLIDAYS THEY
DON'T HAVE THE JOB SUPPORT ON
THAT DAY.
SO THERE THESE TRICKY NUANCES
BUT I THINK THE REASON SOME OF
THE I I MEAN I CAN'T SPEAK FOR
ALL THE REGIONAL CENTERS BUT I
THINK ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
SOME OF THE REGIONAL CENTERS DID
HAVE.
A POLICIES LIKE SEVEN DAYS THEY
PICKED THE DAYS THAT MOST OF THE
SERVICE PROVIDERS WARRANT
PROVIDING SERVICES ANYWAY OKAY
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THE ANYTHING I MEAN SO I A HEAR
YOU TALK ABOUT THE CELL OF ANY
ANY OF THE OPINIONS ABOUT THAT
AND HIS IS A CERTAIN NUMBER OF
THAT.
I THINK I THINK THAT'S WHAT I
THINK I THINK WE'RE HEARING
FOURTEEN SOUNDS A LITTLE ONE
REASONABLE OBVIOUSLY
RECESSIONARY MOVE -- BUT
ALLOWING SOME.
SOME DAYS MAY MAKE SENSE JUST
BECAUSEDEL THAT'S FUNCTIONALLY
WHAT REALLY IS HAPPENING AND OUT
OF THE CAN YOU CAN YOU REIMBURSE
FOR SOMETHING WE ARE NOT
PROVIDING THE SERVICE ANYWAY SO
IT SO I GUESS THAT'S I THINK
WHAT'S I THINK THERE'S A COUPLE
OF THINGS THAT ARE IMPORTANT. TO
POINT OUT HERE AND AND AND ONE
OF THEM IS THAT WE'RE TOLD ON
MANY OCCASIONS THAT THINGS ARE
BUSINESS DECISION AND TRULY FOR
ANY OTHER BUSINESS.
WHAT HOLIDAYS YOU'RE CLOSED FOR
IS A BUSINESS DECISION?
IN IN OUR CASE THAT'S NOT TRUE
IT'S IT'S NOT A BUSINESS
DECISION IT'S WHAT WE'RE TOLD WE
HAVE TO BE CLOSED IF WE WANT TO
SUPPORT SOMEONE ON THAT DAY
WE'RE NOT GONNA GET PAID FOR
THAT.
MEANING THAT THE PERSON THAT'S
PROVIDING THAT SUPPORT WON'T GET
PAID -- SO I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW TO AND AND
THEN THE OTHER THING THAT AND
AND I APPRECIATE -- YOU SONNY AT
THE SHARING F THAT YOU KNOW
MOST PLACES THE STATE HOLIDAYS
ARE.
TEN THE THE THING THAT WE NEED
TO ALWAYS REMEMBER IS THAT THOSE
ARE PAID HOLIDAYS -- IT'S NOT
PAID HOLIDAYS FOR OUR FOLKS TO
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE PROVIDING
SUPPORT OUR DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS WHO WERE SO UNDER
PAID AS IT IS.
ARE ALSO NOW BEING FORCED TO
HAVE DAYS OFF UNPAID.
SO BUT IT'S THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER.
OKAY.
OKAY AND JUST TO AT AT ON WHAT
YOU WERE ASKING -- IT REALLY
APPRECIATE ELOISE COMMENTS --
THEY'RE VERY THOROUGH AND NO I
DON'T THINK ANYBODY IS ASKING IN
ADDITION BE ANY HOLIDAYS TAKEN
THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM AS A WHOLE --
BUT AGAIN THAT FOURTEEN DAYS
SEEMS TO BE EXCESSIVE IN ALL TO
ME ARE JUST ASKING. FOR LOW'S
FOR WORKERS OR FOR PROVIDERS TO
HAVE TO EAT THAT COST -- IF
THERE WERE SEVEN SOME REAL
CENTERS IT SOUNDED LIKE THERE
WAS A SURVEY OR SOMETHING TAKEN
WERE SUMMER TAKEN SEPARATE
SUMMER TAKING -- TEN I THINK WE
CAN.
LIKELY FIND A PLACE WHERE NOBODY
WOULD COME TO AGREEMENT ON THAT
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
THEN SO -- SO I HOPE THAT -- WE
CAN FIGURE OUT HOW TO WIN THIS
THING -- THIS FOURTEEN DOES SEEM
A BIT EXCESSIVE.
AND THE SAID I THINK
FUNCTIONALLY IT IS THAT DOES AT
THAT POINT.
SO LIKE A FORCE FOR LOW ARE ARE
ARE IN PAID WORK.
WELL FIRST FORCE FOR LOW SORTS
SO.
IT DOESN'T LINE UP WITH
CERTAINLY WHAT STATE S. OF WORTH
I THINK THERE IS A POINT I
RECOGNIZE THAT YOU COULD SAY
WELL EVEN AND EVEN THE BILL DOES
SHOULD BE EVEN PAID HOLIDAYS --
BUT THAT'S A FURTHER DISCUSSION
BUT AT LEAST I THINK -- LET'S IT
SEEMS LAW AND REASONABLE TO BE --
ASKING TELLING THEY HAVE TO DO
FOURTEEN AND WE DIDN'T REALLY
TOUCHED -- THAT THE HALF THE
BILLING ISSUE.
AT THE THIS IS.
SO USE.
YEAH WE DON'T REALLY TALK ABOUT
THAT SO.
ON THE THEY HAVE TO BILLING --
MISTER CHAIR IS IN EFFECT IN THE
CURRENT YEAR.
ON AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES TO KEEP IT IN FACT IN
BUDGET YEAR.
AND BASICALLY.
ON WHAT THE HAVE THE BILLING
ROOM THE SAVINGS ARE MINOR -- WE
WERE ESTIMATING COST SAVINGS OF
APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION TOTAL ONE TWENTY SIX
GENERAL FUND. TO THEIR MINIMAL
SAVINGS BUT WITH WHAT THE RULE
DOES -- IS IT ON IT REQUIRES
SPECIFIED PROGRAMS ACTIVITY
CENTERS ADULT DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS BEHAVIOR MANAGEMENT
PROGRAMS.
AND OTHER LOOKALIKE DAY PROGRAMS.
TO THAT CHARGE A DAILY BILLING
RATE.
ON IT REQUIRES THAT.
ACT CONSUMERS THEY'RE
PARTICIPATING THESE PROGRAMS BE
THERE AT LEAST 65%.
OF THE DATA BILL.
IF THERE IF THERE THERE'S LESS
THAN THAT THEY HAVE TO BEHALF.
TO ACT [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY THIS CHAIR FOR FREE ON ON
THAT -- SO WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE
FOR MINOR SAVINGS IS A VISITOR
PROVIDER AND WHILE THE PREVIOUS
YOU WERE GETTING PAID FOR A FULL
DAY.
NOW IN THE MINUTE SOMEBODY WALKS
IN THE DOOR THROUGH
TRANSPORTATION THAT'S BRINGING
THEM TO A PROGRAM OR TO A
DIFFERENT TYPE OF SERVICE FROM
THE COMMUNITY.
NOW THEY HAVE HAVE TO COMPLETELY
CHANGE OUR ADMIN WHERE THEY ARE
GET AN EXCEL SPREADSHEET BY TEN
A. M. XIN KNOWING EXACTLY WHEN
PEOPLE CAME IN.
BY HOPES THAT THEY CAN GET THEM
AND KEEP THEM THERE TO THE 65%
SO THEY GET PAID THE FULL DAY
WHAT MAN IS THAT BECAUSE THE
TRANSPORTATION IS COMING.
AND THE HONKING THE HORN CAN THE
STATE HERE I MEAN THAT'S
LITERALLY WHAT'S HAPPENING ON
THE GROUND AS A RESULT.
ALL RIGHT SO EGGS I GUESS ONE
QUESTIONS IT POSES THAT --
RECOGNIZE THE THERE'S SOME SMALL
SAVINGS BUT IT THE OVERHEAD
COSTS FOR I MEAN IS IT THE
OVERHEAD COSTS FOR THE FIVE
WE'RE HEARING ABOUT THE OVERHEAD
COSTS FOR THE PROVIDERS.
DO YOU JUST DO PEOPLE AT THE DO
YOU REVIEW AUDIT THEM ANYTHING
LIKE THAT OR ANY AND AND IS ONE
LIKE IS IT WORTH THE TROUBLE I
GUESS.
IN TERMS OF COST RIGHT WOULD
WOULD POSE A COST ON THE
PROVIDER'S AND WHAT CLASS IT'S
IMPOSING ON THE AGENCY.
AT SOME BILL IT WHETHER THAT THE
COST OF ENFORCING IT IS GOING TO
EXCEED THE COST OF THE SAVINGS
I'D SELL.
MISTER CHAIR AT THE AS FAR AS
REVIEWS THAT RESPONSIBILITY AT
THIS POINT IF THERE WAS GOING TO
BE ANY KIND OF LOCAL MONITORING
WOULD COME FROM THE REGIONAL
CENTERS -- WHEN I TAKE A LOOK AT
THE AUDITS THAT WE'VE DONE AS A
DEPARTMENT ON -- ANY OF THE
PROVIDERS I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY
RECENT REVIEWS THAT HAS TO DO
WITH REVIEWING ANY HALF DAY
BILLING -- MIGHT HAVE TO GO BACK
AND VERIFY THAT BUT THERE HASN'T
BEEN AND AND AND NUMBER OF YEARS
THE FOCUS OF OUR REVIEWS HAVE
BEEN ON ON OTHER AREAS AND IT
HAS NOT BEEN ON THAT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL IT IS SO I
GUESS WHAT CAUSES OPPOSES THAT.
IF FOR DOING THIS IS IT REALLY
IS THAT WHAT WORTH IT IN TERMS
OF MONEY I'M A REJECT BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE IN TERMS OF THE
OVERSIGHT AND SO FORTH AND WHAT.
BURDENS IT PLACES ON THE
PROVIDERS VERSES THE MOUSE
SAVINGS WERE GETTING FROM THAT
THAT BAG A SOON THERE'S A
FEDERAL IMPERATIVE FOR US TO DO
THIS.
SO -- SO DOES THAT MAKE SENSE
RIGHT IS THAT WE JUST IMPOSING
IS THIS A SAVINGS REALLY WORTH
THE COST.
AND THEN THE OTHER QUESTION IS
IS THAT RELATED TO THAT IF WE
ARE GOING TO DO ANYTHING LIKE
THIS [inaudible]
THE DELF 65% IS A DEAL LOWER 2%
MAKE IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO TO
IT HERE TO THIS AND THEN THIS --
BUT I GUESS THE FIRST QUESTION
REALLY ISN'T WORTH IT I GUESS
THAT'S MY QUESTION GIVEN THE
AMOUNT OF SAVINGS -- GETTING A
SENSE OF WHAT DOES THAT INVOLVE
WHAT DOES THAT REQUIRE OF THE
PROVIDERS WHAT DOES REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT AND AND IS IT WORTH
THE TROUBLE I GUESS.
BECAUSE AT CERTAIN POINTS IN
TERMS OF YOU KNOW JUST
BUREAUCRATIC EFFICIENCY DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE TO OPPOSE THIS FOR
THAT AMOUNT OF MONEY.
ARE IN THE END IF WE'RE TRULY
GOING TO DO THIS AND AND FORCE
IT IS IT END UP GOING TO COST
MORE THAN WHAT WE'RE REALLY
GOING TO SAVE [inaudible]
YES.
MR TERROR UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN
THAT YOU'RE SHARING AN INTEREST
WE'VE HAD NUMBER OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE PROVIDERS
AND AND UNDERSTANDING THE
CONCERN NOT ONLY OF THE HALF DAY
BILLING AND THE UNIFORM HOLIDAY.
THEY THEY DISCUSSIONS OFTEN
KINDA GO TOGETHER -- SO WILL YOU
KNOW WE CONTINUE TO HEAR THAT
THE CONCERNS WE'VE HAD THE
DISCUSSIONS -- AND I A A
UNFORTUNATELY I'M AND IT'S
WITHIN -- THE PROPOSALS THAT WE
HAD OUR NOSES ARE CONTINUING TO
MOVE FORWARD AS WE STATED OKAY
ALL RIGHT AND THANK YOU KNOW I
SO SO I JUST IMPOSE THAT I MEAN
I TO A CERTAIN EXTENT I CAN
UNDERSTAND PEOPLE SAYING WELL
GEE IF YOU ONLY PROVIDED.
HALF DAY OF SERVICE WHERE WE
PAYING A FULL DAY -- ALTHOUGH
THE 65% I GUESS YOU KNOW THE
QUESTION ANDBUT I I THINK
THERE'S ALSO THE PART ABOUT THE
SAVINGS.
THIS WAS A AND I GUESS A MINOR
BECAUSE A LOT OF MONEY -- FOR
PEOPLE BUT GIVEN THE SIZE OF THE
SAVINGS IN THE NUMBER PEOPLE
INVOLVED I JUST WONDER ABOUT
WHETHER.
HOW MUCH WORK IT WOULD TAKE TO
TRULY DO THIS MAKES IT REALLY
MEANINGFUL TO DO IT AT ALL EIGHT
AND DOES STERN LESTER'S?
YOU KNOW RAMPED IT.
EFFORTS BY PEOPLE THE NOT RIGHTS
SERVICES TO PEOPLE AND WELL SO
THEY GET PAINFUL DAY BUT ONLY
CAN DO HALF I'M GONNA GIVE BILL
THEM DOWN THAT.
BUT THAT'S NOT HAPPENING IN THE
WHITE IS THAT THE IN WIDESPREAD
WHICH I DON'T THINK IT IS YOU
NOT RAISING CONCERN THEN I'M NOT
SURE WHY WE'RE DOING THIS.
SELL.
IT AND I JUST WANTED TO ADD THAT
IT.
THE SOMEBODY MIGHT GO HOME AFTER
65% OF THE DAY BUT THE STAFF
WORK ON A REST ANPING RATIO SO
THE STAFF FOR NOT GOING HOME AND
SO THE COSTS TO THE PROVIDER IS
STILL THE SAME.
I MEAN UNLESS YOU SEND THE STAFF
HOME AND AGAIN WE SHOULDN'T BE
TREATING OUR DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE ALREADY.
YOU KNOW STRUGGLING BY SENDING A
HOME BECAUSE SOMEBODY IT GOT
WENT HOME EARLY.
BUT I WILL POINT OUT THAT I
THINK TO A CERTAIN EXTENT.
NO I THINK MOST OF THE TAXPAYER
PUBLIC SAYS WE ONLY PROVIDE HALF
DAY OF SERVICE NO ARE WE PAYING
FOR THE WHOLE THING BUT AT THE
SAME TIME IS THAT I DON'T THINK.
PEOPLE ARE REALLY INTO AND I I
HEAR WHAT YOU'RE SAYING RIGHT.
PEOPLE ARE SETTING UP THEIR DAY
TO ONLY PROVIDE A QUOTE HALF DAY
WHATEVER MONTH DOES SERVICE THEY
REALLY ARE INTENDING TO PROVIDE
A FULL DAY THERE MAY BE OTHER
FACTORS ARE INVOLVED.
BUT AND THEN ULTIMATELY WHETHER
MAKES SENSE. TO TO TO DO THIS OR
NOT SO OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO WE'LL LOOK AT THAT
TOO OKAY -- ALL RIGHT THANKS
RAMESH OKAY SO LET'S MOVE ON THE
ISSUE NUMBER THREE SOCIAL
RECREATION CAMP SERVICES I
BELIEVE A PANEL FOR THIS AS WELL
CAROLINE SELLOUT TOTAL ALLEN. TO
MISPRONOUNCE THAT -- BOARD
MEMBER DISABILITY VOICES UNITED
AND PARENTS AND BETH BURKE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AUTISM SIDE
CALIFORNIA ALSO FAMILY MEMBER
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
CAN I ASK YOU.
TO KEEP YOUR REMARKS TO THREE
MINUTE OR LESS EACH.
OKAY THANK YOU.
SO.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS MY DAUGHTER
MYRCELLA SIDE YOU SHOULD SEE HER
DANCING -- I'M CAROL INTO LAW IN
AN APPARENT.
AND A BOARD MEMBER OF
DISABILITIES VOICES UNITED.
BUT I'M NOT HERE TO TALK ABOUT
ME I'M HERE TO REPRESENT MY
DAUGHTER HI SHOULD YOU PICTURE.
IS NOT ABLE TO ARTICULATE.
A WITH SOCIAL WORK MEANS TO HER
I'M HERE TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT MY
DAUGHTER MARISSA WHO'S THIRTY
YEARS OLD.
LIVES WITH HER TWO BEST FRIENDS
AND A HOME THAT THEY RENT.
AND HAVE SUPPORTS IN THEIR HOME.
SHE ALSO HAPPENS HAVE DOWN
SYNDROME.
MY DAUGHTER'S GREATEST JOY AND
HIGHLIGHTED PER WEEK IS DANCING
SHE TENS AND TAKES DANCE CLASSES.
THE BEARS AN INCLUSIVE SETTING
IN FRESNO.
CHOOSE ON THEIR DANCE TEAM AND
TAKES HAVE POP.
SHE DANCES THREE AND A HALF
HOURS A WEEK.
SOCIAL RECORDS NOT JUST A
FRIVOLOUS EXTRA TO HER LIFE.
THE BENEFIT OF DANCING FOR HER
IS ABOUT EXERCISE INCLUSION WITH
THOSE AND WITH AND WITHOUT
DISABILITIES.
BEING IN THE COMMUNITY MOVEMENT
EXERCISE.
AND FUN.
MERCER DELIGHTS IN PERFORMING
FOR OTHERS.
THINK ABOUT WHAT YOUR LIFE WOULD
MEAN WITHOUT SOMETHING YOU LOVE
TO DO.
EACH YEAR I SPENT ABOUT FOURTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS TO FIND HER
DANCING.
SHE'S NOT ABLE TO FOR THIS ON
HER OWN WHILE RECEIVING HER ONLY
HER MONTHLY SSI CHECK.
IF I COULD NOT AFFORD TO HELP OR
SHOULD BE MISSING OUT ON WHEN
THE GREATEST JOYS OF OUR LIFE.
I WOULD NOT IF I WAS NOT ALIVE
SHOULD BE MISSING OUT ALSO.
THAT IS WHY I'VE FUNDING SOCIAL
WRECK PROGRAMS MISSY FIND IT FOR
HER AND HER FRIENDS AND FOR
OTHERS LIKE HER.
AND IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT DANCING
IT'S ABOUT SUMMER CAMP HE JIM
MASCOTS HORSEBACK RIDING MUSIC
KARATE SWIMMING AND OTHER
ACTIVITIES. FOR CHILDREN WITHOUT
DISABILITIES THAT THEY TAKE THAT
WE TAKE FOR GRANTED.
AND IS ALSO A ABOUT NON MEDICAL
THERAPIES SUCH AS AT KLINE
THERAPY MUSIC THERAPY WHICH
HELPS SO MANY CHILDREN AND
ADULTS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
WE KNOW THAT HISPANIC AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND ASIAN PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES FACE THE SPERY'S
AND WE SEE FEWER SERVICES THEN
ONCE.
WE BELIEVE THAT ONE OF THE
REASONS IS THAT THE LEGISLATIVE
KEPT FUNDING FOR SOCIAL WORK
PROGRAM SOMETHING THIS
COMMUNITIES REALLY NEED.
AND REALLY HAVE USE AFTER THESE
PROGRAMS WERE CUT FAMILIES WITH
THE FINANCIAL MEANS LIKE MINE
JUST PAID. FOR THE SERVICES OUT
OF THEIR POCKET FOR FOR CHILDREN
FROM LOW INCOME FAMILIES IS JUST
ANOTHER WAY THAT THEY FACE THE
SEVERITY.
SO THEY'RE STAYING HOME AND THEY
ARE NOT IN THE COMMUNITY AND
THEY ARE MISSING OUT ON WHAT
BRINGS SOME JOY IN THEIR LIVES.
IT HAS BEEN TEN YEARS SINCE THE
FUNDS WERE.
SERVICES WERE FUNDED A WHOLE
GENERATION OF CHILDREN HAVE
GROWN UP.
AND I'M NOT BEEN ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THESE PROGRAMS
WHEN I TELL OTHER PARENTS ABOUT
THIS IN A SUPPORT GROUP BY RANDY
GO ARE YOU KIDDING ME YOU GOT TO
DO THAT.
GET HELP FOR HER TO GO TO HER
CÃM.
HI TOM YES.
IS THAT YOU HAVE HARD BUDGET
DECISIONS TO MAKE BUT WE HAVE
BEEN WAITING A LONG TIME FOR
THIS FUNDING TO BE RETURNED.
THIS IS THE THIRD YEAR THAT WE
ARE REQUESTING THAT RESTORING
FUNDING FOR SOCIAL RACK AND NON
MEDICAL THERAPIES TAKE US A
PRIORITY.
RESPECTFULLY THE SERVICES MATTER
TO US.
THESE SERVICES MATTER TO MY
DAUGHTER MARISSA THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
THESE.
THANK YOU FOR PROVIDING THIS
OPPORTUNITY SENATORS UP WITH
AUTISM SOCIETY TO GIVE INPUT
REGARDING THE RESTORATION OF
SUCH A RECREATION AND CAMPING
SERVICES.
MY NAME IS BETH BURKE I AM THE
PRESIDENT OF AUTISM SOCIETY OF
CALIFORNIA -- PROUD MOTHER OF
TWO INCLUDING ONE WITH AUTISM.
THE AUTISM SOCIETY CONDUCTS A
SURVEY EVERY OTHER YEAR NINE
HOPEFULLY YOU'VE GOTEN YOUR
COPY I'LL BE REFERENCING PAGE.
TEN THIS YEAR OUR FOCUS WAS ON
UNMET NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITY.
THE NUMBER ONE UNMET NEED FOR
OUR FAMILIES AND ADULTS WAS
SOCIAL SOCIAL RECREATION.
PARTICIPATION AND INCLUSION AND
SOCIAL RECREATION SERVICES
INCLUDING ART MUSIC CULTURAL
EVENTS AND CAMPING ARE IMPORTANT
PART.
MANY OF US HAVE FOND MEMORIES
GROWING UP -- BEING ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THESE X. SERVICES
OUR SURVEY REPORTS THAT THIS WAS
THE MOST REQUESTED UNMET NEED
ONE OUT OF THREE OF THE PARENTS
OF CHILDREN AND ONE OUT OF FIVE
ADULTS PUT SOCIAL RECREATION
SERVICES HEAD OF ANY OTHER NEEDS
THAT THEY HAVE.
THE LACK OF SOCIAL ACCESS TO
SOCIAL OPPORTUNITIES IS HAVING A
DIRE CONSEQUENCE FOR BOTH
CHILDREN AND ADULTS.
AS ONE PARENT SEND OUR KIDS ARE
DYING OF LONELINESS ISOLATION
AND THE LACK OF ACCEPTANCE AND
OPPORTUNITIES.
THE AUTISM SOCIETY STRONGLY
SUPPORTS REINSTATING THE
SERVICES WE ALSO ASK FOR
CONSIDERATION OF ONE TIME
FINDING THAT WOULD ALLOW SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO HIRE STAFF.
THAT WOULD HAVE THE
QUALIFICATIONS TO HELP OUR
POPULATION.
OUR SURVEY ALSO SHOWED THAT 25%
OF OUR POPULATION HAS LITTLE OR
NO LANGUAGE 40% HAS SEVERE
BEHAVIORS.
AND WE'RE REQUESTING THIS --
FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO TRAIN.
THE STAFF TO BE ABLE TO SAFELY
TAKE ARE ADULTS AND CHILDREN
INTO THE COMMUNITY.
THEY ARE GOING TO NEED A HIGHER
LEVEL OF TRAINING BECAUSE OF
THEIR COMPLEX NEEDS.
BURNING MAKING FRIENDS AND
PARTICIPATING RECREATION ARE
PART OF A HEALTHY HUMAN
EXPERIENCE IT'S BEEN TEN YEARS
SINCE HE'S CRITICAL SERVICES
WERE SUSPENDED.
ON BEHALF OF OUR FAMILIES WE ASK
THAT YOU RESTORE AND FUND THE
SERVICES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- ANY COMMENTS FROM
THE PARMA DEVELOP SERVICES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- AS WAS
POINTED OUT THIS IS ANOTHER COST
SAVINGS PROPOSAL WAS IMPLEMENTED
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE AND OF THE
DEPARTMENT.
OF PROPOSES TO THE CONTINUOUS ON
WE HAVE HEARD THOUGH THAT EVEN
AS WE HAD.
DISPARITY MEETINGS THROUGHOUT
THE STATES IN A THROUGHOUT THE
STATE A YEAR AGO AND THIS WAS
ONE OF THE PRIMARY CONCERNS THAT
WE HEARD FROM FAMILY MEMBERS.
THANK YOU HELLO COMMENTS FINANCE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
RIGHT WELL I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS -- I'M
CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE.
SERVICES -- AS PEOPLE WILL SEE --
WHEN BAY REVISED COMES OUR HANDS
WHERE WHERE WE ARE WITH THINGS
SO -- RIGHT AND I UNDERSTAND IS
A ONE TIME REQUEST CORRECT OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND TAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS
ON THE OVERVIEW AND ISSUES AND
THE TO REQUEST THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE HALF THE
BILLING AND SOCIAL RECREATION
CAMP SERVICES SO.
AGAIN ASK THAT YOU TRY TO KEEP
REMARKS TWO UNDER A MINUTE AND
IF SOMEONE'S ARE YOU SAID WHAT
YOU WANNA SAY YOU CAN SAY I
AGREE WITH THEM.
TO SELL WELCOME.
HI RES HELLO.
MY NAME IS PAT HORN BAKER AND I
SERVE AS SECRETARY OF THE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS OF THE ARK.
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M HERE REPRESENTING BY
THIRTY NINE YEAR OLD SON.
JOSEPH WHO HAS ENJOYMENT
SYNDROME LIVES IN SAN FRANCISCO.
I'M SPEAKING TO THE FOURTEEN DAY
FIRST FORCED FURLOUGH DAYS --
AND DO AGREE THAT.
NO THAT THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
ENFORCED SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN HOWEVER -- IT NEEDS TO
GO OFF THE BOOKS PERIOD MY SON
HAS A TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
DISABILITY.
IT REGARDLESS OF WHETHER YOU AS
A JOB OR IS IN A DAY PROGRAM --
IT'S VERY HARD TO HIRE STAFF TO
RECRUIT STAFF TO TRAIN THEM AND
SAY BUT BY THE WAY YOU HAVE
FOURTEEN DAYS YOU WILL NOT GET
PAID.
AND YOU'RE NOT IN A IT'S NOT BY
YOUR CHOICE EITHER.
OF IT'S PRETTY HARD TO GET STAFF
JUST TO WORK WITH FOUR AND
ENHANCE THE LIVES OF PEOPLE LIKE
MY SON I JUST THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE REMEMBER THAT
THESE ARE.
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN DISABILITIES
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS A
YEAR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
MY NAME IS TIM HORN BAKER AND
I'M HAVE BEEN WITH THE ARK OF
THE EAST BAY AND ALSO FORMER CEO
FOR THE ARK OF SAN FRANCISCO.
AND I I JUST WANT TO SHARE WITH
YOU THE THE CHALLENGE OF HIRING
PEOPLE I MEAN I CAN'T I CAN'T
EVEN PAY FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR
EVEN THESE PAY LET ALONE SIXTEEN
DOLLARS.
I IN SAN FRANCISCO AREA AND AND
KEEP STAFF FIND STAFF HAVE THEM
APPLY AND THEN TELLING OH BY THE
WAY YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A AND I
REMEMBER TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
AND BEFORE.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A TWO DAY
UNPAID FORCED FURLOUGH DAYS SO
YOU JUST WE JUST GOT THROUGH
THAT IN THERE SO I REALLY AM.
OPPOSED TO THE CONTINUATION OF
THAT AND ALSO.
WHEN I HAVE IS A CLIENT WHO HAS
A SEIZURE HE HAS TO BE YOU KNOW
WE HAVE TO CALL UP NINE ONE ONE
HE GOES HOME OUR SHE GOES HOME?
AND THEN DO I SEND MY STAFF HOME
AFTERWARDS TO BECAUSE IT'S NOT A
FULL DAYS IT JUST DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE SO PLEASE I'M I'M CLOSE TO
BOTH OF THOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MARTY MOTO FAMILY
MEMBER ALSO SEE CAN CALIFORNIA
DISPLAY TO YOUR COMMUNITY ACTION
NETWORK CALIFORNIA PERSON
CENTERED AVERAGE PARTNERSHIP.
AND PATH FOR COLLABORATIVE THAT
WILL BE IT FOR MY MEMBERSHIPS
FOR NOW -- JUST SAY.
JUST STRONG SUPPORT OF FOR NOT
REINSTATING THE UNIFORM HOLIDAYS
BECAUSE SCHEDULES REALLY
IMPORTANT THIS IS A CUT THAT'S
NOT IN PLACE YET.
AND IS REPREHENSIBLE AND I I I
THINK PEOPLE IN THE STATE ARE
GOOD PEOPLE BUT IS REPREHENSIBLE
TO BE PUTTING FORWARD A
REDUCTION AT A TIME THAT WERE IN
THE BUDGET SURPLUS.
AT A TIME THAT NO OTHER SERVICES
ARE BEING CUT IN THE SAME WAY
THERE IS NO REASON TO PUT THIS
CUT FORWARD YOU CAN DELAY IT BY
ONE YEAR WHAT WE HAVE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT.
IS IT APPROPRIATE TO HAVE
UNIFORM HOLIDAY YOU YOU KNOW
YOU'RE A FURLOUGH DAYS ACTUALLY --
AND BY THE WAY AND I JUST SAYS A
7% REDUCTION HAS BEEN PUT OFF.
FOR THE SAME TYPES OF REASONS IS
NOT APPROPRIATE TO BE REDUCING
SERVICES AT A TIME WHEN EVERYONE
ELSE IS GETTING MORE RESOURCES
LASTLY JUST WANT TO SAY.
IT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO REEXAMINE
ITS POLICY REGARDING PAYING THE
LOCAL MINIMUM WAGE OR MINIMUM
WAGE. TO SIMPLY STATING THAT THE
POLICY IN THE PAST IS THAT WE
HAVEN'T DONE IT IS NOT POLICY
AND I THINK THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO
LOOK AT WHAT SHOULD BE THE
POLICY OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA REGARDING WHAT IS
FAIR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME S
BETSY KATE'S AND I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE ARK OF
CALIFORNIA I ALSO HAVE A THIRTY
SEVEN YEAR OLD SON WITH AN
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY -- AND I
WANTED TO COMMENT ON THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAYS HOLIDAY SCHEDULE IN THE
HALF DAY BILLING.
ARE THESE THINGS I WOULD CREATE
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP FOR SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND UNCERTAINTY AND
ANXIETY FOR SELF ADVOCATES AND
THEIR FAMILIES SUCH AS MINE.
FAMILIES HAVE TO SCRAMBLE TO
FIND ALTERNATIVE CARE ON HOLIDAY
CLOSURES IN AN ENVIRONMENT OF
SCARCE RESOURCES.
AND SELF ADVOCATES HAVE
INTERRUPTIONS IN THEIR PROGRAM
PARTICIPATION THAT DISSED
WRAPPED THE SKILLS THAT THERE
WERE -- TRYING TO LEARN -- THESE
POLICIES WOULD A CREEK CREATE
ADDITIONAL FISCAL PRESSURE FOR
LOCAL COMMUNITY SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND THE UNDERMINE AND
THREATEN THE CONTINUITY AND
RELIABILITY OF THE SYSTEM WHICH
IS VITAL TO THE WELL BEING.
OF THE INDIVIDUALS WE SERVE
THEREFORE WE OPPOSE THE
REINSTATEMENT OF THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE AND WE SUPPORT
ELIMINATION OF HALF DAY BILLING
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS RAYMOND HANSON
A PARENT OF A CHILD WITH THAT
MULTIPLE INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENT DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
BOARD MEMBER TREASURER OF THE
ARK A CALIFORNIA -- I SUPPORT
THE ADVOCATES THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE IN HALF A
BILLING.
I ALSO SUPPORT THE REINSTATEMENT
SOCIAL RECREATION CAMP SERVICES
CANCER IS SERVICES ARE VITAL
COMPONENT. FOR BOTH THE PARENTS.
OUR ADULT KIDS NEED THE RESPITE
FROM THEIR PARENTS.
THEY NEED THE ADDITIONAL
SOCIALIZATION THAT CAP AND
SOCIAL RECREATION GIVES OUR KIDS.
THIS PROGRAM HELPS REDUCE THE
ISOLATION OF OUR KIDS THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M JACQUI DILLARD FOSS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SUPPORTED
LIVING NETWORK AND THE PATH FOR
A COLLABORATIVE.
YOU KNOW I WAS THINKING WHEN YOU
SAID IS IT WORTH IT.
WE GENERALLY WHENEVER SESSION
HAPPENS WE ALL TAKE CUTS
TOGETHER BUT WHEN RECOVERY
HAPPENS WE ALL RECOVER TOGETHER
AND I WAS WONDERING WHY IS IT
THAT POPE FOLKS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES ARE
NOT PART OF THE RECOVERY.
BECAUSE ALSO RECKON TEN USED TO
BE CUT LIKE YOU SAID UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULES ARE PROPOSED
THAT WAS DURING THE TIME OF A
CUT.
SO I JUST WONDER WHY DO WE NOT
BE PART OF THE RECOVERY PROCESS
IF CALIFORNIANS ON A ROAD TO
RECOVERY ALLOW OUR SYSTEM TO
RECOVER AS WELL.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY ABOUT THE
MINIMUM WAGE I WHEN I TALKED TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IT WAS
FIFTY CENTS AT A TIME.
I APPRECIATE THE MINIMUM WAGE
FOR ENTRY LEVEL POSITIONS I
DON'T HAVE ENTRY LEVEL WORKERS.
YOU CAN CHANGE THE LAW TO TALK
ABOUT WE ARE NOW DEALING WITH
THE MOST SEVERE COMPACTION ISSUE
WE SAY IT'S A BUSINESS DECISION
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA CHOSE TO
RAISE THE MINIMUM WAGE WHAT YOU
NEED TO CHOOSE. TO RAISE THE
WAGE OF DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS BY UNDERSTANDING
WHAT THE IMPACT OF MINIMUM WAGES
TO OUR INDUSTRY WERE NOT AN
ENTRY LEVEL INDUSTRY OUR LOCAL
MINIMUM WAGE PROVIDERS DESERVE
BETTER WE NEED TO RAISE THE WAGE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
IRWIN HOLDEN WITH EASTER SEAL --
ZERO CLEARLY GET ALL OF THE
ISSUES AND WE CLEARLY APPRECIATE
THE AUDIENCE FOR A HIGHLIGHTING
THE ISSUES AS WELL AS AN BACK
TOGETHER AND I ALSO ESPECIALLY
APPRECIATE THE LA -- AS IT IS A
LATE AT OUR ISSUE WITH -- STATE
LOCAL MINIMUM WAGE IT IS AND AND
THAT COULD THEIR CONNECTION TO
THE FEDERAL THANK STATE.
YES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME MY NAME IS JJ JOHNSTON
AND I'M A PARENT OF TRIPLETS SO
I HAVE THREE GORGEOUS CHILDREN
THAT ARE NOW NINETEEN YEARS OLD
WHO EACH ONE HAVE THE DIAGNOSIS
OF AUTISM SPECTRUM DISORDER.
SO WE LIVE ON THE SPECTRUM WE
ARE SO GRATEFUL FOR THE PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE BEEN OFFERED THREE DDS
OUR FAMILY HAS MADE ACCESS.
TO EACH ONE DIFFERENT OF OUR
CHILDREN HAVING DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS THAT THEY'VE BEEN ABLE
TO ACCESS AND AS WE'VE SEEN THIS
WONDERFUL MOVING CHANGE IN
MINDSET TO TRULY BE INDEPENDENT
IN THE COMMUNITY.
WE'VE ALSO EXPERIENCE THE LACK
OF PROGRAMMING TO DO SO IN A WAY
THAT PROVIDES LIESER SKILLS AND
THE ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE WITH
pPEERS AND WITH OTHER PEOPLE IN
THE COMMUNITY SUCH AS THE SOCIAL
WRECK PROGRAMS IN THE CAMPS.
SO I WANTED TO JUST OFFER OUR
SUPPORT AS A FAMILY AND THE
YOUNG ADULTS THAT AREN'T HERE
TODAY I'M REPRESENTING THEM
HOPEFULLY I MAKE THEM PROUD.
I'M A TO TO THAT ONE TIME ASK
AND THEN ALSO FOR THE
REINSTATEMENT AND THE LAST THING
I WOULD ADD TO IS THAT THERE ARE
NO DAYS OFF FROM LIVING ON THE
SPECTRUM.
AND SO TO HAVE THE REINSTATEMENT
OF THAT UNIFORM SCHEDULE WOULD.
BE DEVASTATING FOR US ON THOSE
DAYS WHEN WE NEED HELP MOST
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND I'M SURE YOU DID
MAKE A VERY PROUD THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AS DOCTOR PAN
CENTER HOOD TADO AND
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THE
STAFF MEMBERS OF THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE REC
ROLLINS REPRESENTING THE ARCA SO
SHE XIN REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES
ON ISSUE NUMBER ONE WE SUPPORT --
THE LOCAL -- MINIMUM WAGE QUIRK
FIX -- WE SEE THIS AS A
TREMENDOUS -- IMPACT ON OUR
PROVIDER COMMUNITY AND AGAIN I
HOPE AND I KNOW YOU'LL BE
LOOKING AT ALL THESE CUTS AND
AND DETRIMENTAL PROPOSALS --
THAT ARE IN EXISTENCE -- IN
TOTAL AND NOT INDIVIDUALLY
BECAUSE WERE REALLY IS THE DEATH
OF A THOUSAND CUTS IN MANY WAYS
TO OUR PROVIDER COMMUNITY IN A
NUMBER OF THESE ISSUES -- ON
ISSUE NUMBER -- TWO THE FOURTEEN
DAY -- FOR LOW -- SCHEDULE --
ARCA SUPPORTS THE REPEAL OF ALL
FOURTEEN DAYS AND I JUST NEED TO
PARENTHETICALLY ADD AS A PARENT
OF A TWENTY YEAR OLD SON WAS
SEVERE AUTISM -- HIS DISABILITY
DOESN'T GO AWAY FOR FOURTEEN
DAYS OR NINETY FOR FOURTEEN
SECONDS AND WHEN HIS PROGRAM IS
CLOSED -- SO I HAVE TO SEEK
FURTHER SUPPORT FROM MY REGIONAL
CENTER IN ORDER TO MAKE UP FOR
THAT -- THAT LOSS OF UPS OF
SUPPORT ON PROGRAMS THAT ARE
BEING FURLOUGHED SO WE NEED TO
TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT AS WE AS
WE MOVE ON ALSO ON HALF THE
BILLING WE SUPPORT THE REPEAL OF
THAT AND OF COURSE THE SOCIAL
RACK AND CAMP SERVICES WHY THANK
THIS COMMITTEE FOR ITS.
WORK LAST YEAR AND PUTTING THAT
THE ISSUE FORWARD IN SUPPORT OF
RESTORATION OF THOSE OKAY THANK
YOU SIR THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER.
MISTER CHAIR -- CENTER HURTADO
VERY JUTTING CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SERVICES THE STATION
TALKING I WANT TO SPEAK ON THREE
ISSUES NOT TRY TO DO QUICKLY
FIRST ONE AND LOCAL MINIMUM WAGE
FIX CERTAINLY WANT TO SUPPORT
ANYTHING TO START ADDRESSING
THAT PROBLEM IT'S IT'S CURRENTLY
UNFAIR SIGNIFICANTLY FOR A LOT
OF PROVIDERS IN THIS.
HIGH COST AREAS IT ALSO HAS
KNOCK ON EFFECTS FOR THE
SURROUNDING AREAS AND EVERYTHING
SO FINDING SOME WAY TO MAKE
THOSE ADJUSTMENTS IS CRITICAL --
AS WANT TO ADDRESS A POINT I
KNOW THAT MISS BARTON MENTIONED
DIRECT ABOUT TO MENTION THAT THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY WAIVER PROCESS
IS AN OPTION TO SELECT AT TO
SOLVE THIS.
BUT IT'S REALLY NOT BECAUSE
THAT'S AN INDIVIDUAL BY
INDIVIDUAL PROCESS AND IS NO
LONGER BEING ALLOWED TO BE USED
TO ADJUST FOR LOCAL MINIMUM WAGE
FOR AN AGENCY SO WE REALLY DON'T
HAVE A FIX WE DO NEED THE
LEGISLATURE IN ADMINISTRATION
WORK TOGETHER TO SUPPORT THAT.
ON THE UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION THAT YOU HAD I I
THINK EVERYONE'S GOING TO COVER
THE WHAT THE IMPACT IS TO FAMILY
MEMBERS STAFF AND CONSUMERS I
WANT TO TOUCH ON THAT THE
CONVERSATION YOU'RE HAVING ABOUT
WHAT THE CORRECT BUDGET NUMBER
IS.
AND WHAT WHAT THE HOW MANY DAYS
WERE TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW I I
JUST SAW THE ESTIMATE THAT WAS
SENT TO LA -- THAT INDICATES
THEY ARE EXPECTING IT TO FUND
SIX DAYS -- THAT THAT FIFTY
MILLION COVER SIX DAYS OF
CLOSURES.
WE DID A POLL OF OUR PROVIDERS
ALMOST.
ALMOST UNIMOG UNIFORMLY WE'RE
LOOKING AT TEN AT TEN HOLIDAY SO --
WE THINK THAT THAT BUDGT
NUMBERS WRONG ON THE HALF DAY I
JUST WANT TO TOUCH ON THE PIECE
ABOUT WE WE TALK ABOUT 65% I
THINK YOU UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT THE OTHER PIECE OF IT IS
THAT THERE IS NO ADMINISTRATIVE
REQUIREMENT TO TRACK TIME AT
THIS POINT SO WHEN IT WENT BACK
INTO AFFECT PROVIDERS HAD TO
COME UP WITH SYSTEMS TO TRACK
THAT TIME.
IT WASN'T REQUIRED REGULATIONS
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
CLOSER FEATURES EXPLORED --
AGAIN I THINK ICE RISES YOU KNOW
SUPPORT OF WAY TO FIX.
OUR ABILITY TO ATTRACT AND
RETAIN DIRECT SERVICE
PROFESSIONALS.
THE SUPPRESSION OF THE LOCAL
MINIMUM WAGE HAS EXACERBATED
THAT WE ARE NOW A MINIMUM WAGE --
SYSTEM OR GETTING CLOSE TO IT
AND THE NEXT YEARS AS THAT WAS
MINIMUM WAGE GOES A FIFTEEN
DOLLARS THE BUDGET NUMBER NEED
TO GO UP SIGNIFICANTLY BECAUSE
MORE MORE AGENCIES THIS YEAR I
HAD FOUR PEOPLE WHO WOULD DO
THAT.
NEXT YEAR I'LL PROBABLY HAVE
CLOSER TO A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
STAFF WHO POTENTIALLY WOULD
QUALIFY FOR THAT INCREASE.
THAT NUMBER'S GONNA
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASES THE AS
THAT INCREASES ONE OBVIOUSLY THE
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE IS A CHALLENGE.
ALSO THE HAVE TO FULLY BILLING
HAS A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT --
WHILE THE STATE HAS BUDGETED
SLIGHT DOLLARS I'M WILLING TO
ACCEPT THEIR BUDGET THEY'RE
SAVING SIGNIFICANTLY MORE ON THE
BACKS OF CHOICE.
COMMUNITY OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE A
THREE ONE RATIO IF ONE PERSON
GOES HOME EARLY TO THE OTHER TO
HAVE TO GO HOME EARLY SO I CAN
SEND THE STAFF HOME.
DOESN'T HAPPEN.
WE SUPPORT CHOICE TO GO AND DO
THAT.
WE ALSO BELIEVE IN LIVE WORK
PLAY.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY
SUPPORT SOCIAL RECREATION.
PEOPLE THAN TO PLAY FALLOUT OF
EMPLOYMENT AS WE TALK TO DR.
PEOPLE NEED SOCIAL RIGHT TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
CARING FOR THIS MISTAKE COUNCIL
ON DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
RISING TO SPEAK ON ISSUE NUMBER
THREE AMONG THOSE PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO CAN REMEMBER SESSION
REX SERVICES.
THEY ARE AMONG THE MOST VALUE TO
CHERISH SOUGHT AFTER AND DESIRED
SERVICES AGAIN -- NOW IS THE
RIGHT TIME TO RESTORE THEM
ESPECIALLY SELF DETERMINATION
RULING OUT -- THAT ADDS UP
TERMINATION HAPPENS THOSE
REGIONAL CENTER CLIENTS WERE
EITHER IN TRADITIONAL SERVICES
FOR SELF DETERMINATION WILL BE
WITH ACCESS SOCIAL WRECK IN THE
SAME EQUAL WEIGH.
IN UNCOMPLICATED STRAIGHTFORWARD
WAY BY YOUR RESTORATION OF THEM
OF THE COUNCIL'S EXPERIENCE
ECHOES WHAT THE DEPARTMENT IS
EXPERIENCED AS IT RELATES TO
THOSE WHO WANT THIS MORE THOSE
WERE ALREADY EXPERIENCING
SIGNIFICANT DISPARITIES.
SO THERE IS AN EQUITY ISSUE THAT
WE WOULD SEE ALSO IN RESTORING
THIS IS CUT THE COUNCIL THINKS
THIS COMMITTEE'S SUPPORT OF THIS
ISSUE IN THE PAST AND ALSO --
FUTURE SUPPORT NOT ONLY IN A ONE
TIME AN ON GOING BASIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
NANCY CHANCE UP FAMILY MEMBER.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR CHOICES
PERSON CENTERED SERVICES
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY COMMUNITY
ACTION NETWORK AND PATH FOR COLD
COLLABORATION OKAY GET OUT OF
THE WAY -- I AM I I WANT TO ECHO
WHAT WAS SAID ABOUT THE MINIMUM
WAGE ON THE LOCAL MINIMUM WAGE.
MY AGENCIES WORKED HARD TO STAY
AHEAD OF THE MINIMUM WAGE IN
ORDER TO PROMOTE THE THAT THAT
PEOPLE ARE VALUED AND WELL WE'RE
NO LONGER THERE WERE A WERE A
MINIMUM WAGE EMPLOYER NOW AND
BUT LIKE NEVER RECEIVED ANY
INCREASE EXCEPT FOR MY OVERNIGHT
SLEEP RATE.
AT AT ALL BECAUSE I'VE ALWAYS
BEEN AHEAD OF THE MINIMUM WEIGHT
SO I CAN'T GET IT I HAVE TO WAIT
TO A MINIMUM AGE BRIGHTER THE
OTHER THING I WANT TO ADD TO
THAT IS THAT -- IN THIS STATE
YOUR HERE WERE EXEMPT EMPLOYEES
NEED TO BE MAKING DOUBLE THE
MINIMUM WAGE AND THAT JUST KEEPS
GOING UP AND GOING UP ANDWE ARE
NOT COMPENSATED FOR THAT IN ANY
WAY BUT THOSE PEOPLE ARE EXEMPT
EMPLOYEES NAY DESERVE THAT WAGE.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT I
SUPPORT -- A REINSTATEMENT OF
SOCIAL RACK AND CAMPS I THINK
THAT'S GOT TO BE ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS TO PEOPLE IN
OUR IN OUR FIELD AND SO.
I SUPPORT THAT I HOPE YOU'LL
TAKE THAT CONSIDERATION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME'S RON A LOG EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR CREEL COMMUNITY
RESOURCE FOR INDEPENDENT LIVING
AND ALSO THE VICE PRESIDENT FOR
THE DD COUNCIL FOR ALAMEDA
COUNTY.
I ECHO AND SUPPORT WHAT
EVERYBODY'S BEEN SAYING --
ESPECIALLY WITH SOCIAL
RECREATION IT'S BEEN SUCH A
VITAL PART I BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE WE WERE RUNNING A
PROGRAM AND ONE THAT GOT CUT.
THESE GUYS HAD NOTHING LEFT AND
SO IT'S SO IMPORTANT MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THAT WORK LIFE
BALANCE AND BY HAVING THIS IT'S
GOING TO PROVIDE THAT AGAIN --
AND THEN I ECHO WITH THE THE
MINIMUM WAGE -- THE COMPRESSION
BETWEEN EXEMPT EMPLOYEES AND
REGULAR THAN REGULAR STANDARD
EMPLOYEES WE WANT TO
PROFESSIONALISM THIS THIS
INDUSTRY AND IT'S NOT WE HAVE TO
BRING THOSE RATES UP.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
HI THANK YOU ARE DONNA FUNGAL
THE DIRECTOR OF ADAPTIVE
LEARNING CENTER -- ONCE AGAIN
ECHOING WITH EVERYONE SAYING --
I THINK THE REINSTATEMENT OF THE
FOURTEEN HOLIDAYS IS IS REALLY
INSULTING IN A TIME OF
PROSPERITY WHEN IT WAS A CUT AND
IT'S VERY DISAPPOINTING TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE TO SPEND ENERGY
ON THIS ISSUE.
BUT I REALLY WANT TO ADDRESS THE
MINIMUM WAGE ISSUE I KNOW WILL
BE DISCUSSED EVEN MORE NEXT WEEK
I APPRECIATE -- TRYING TO FIX
THE LOCAL MINIMUM WAGE PROBLEM
IT IS KIND OF RIDICULOUS WHAT
THE HOOPS PEOPLE HAVE TO JUMP
THROUGH BUT IT SADDENS ME
GREATLY SADDENS ME THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT MINIMUM WAGE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT OUR WORK FORCE.
THESE ARE NOT MINIMUM WAGE JOBS
THERE A LOT.
A LOT OF JOBS THAT ARE EASIER
THAT REQUIRE A LOT LESS SKILL
THAT PEOPLE CAN BE MAKING THE
SAME AMOUNT OF MONEY.
AND THE FOLKS WE SUPPORT DESERVE.
TO HAVE A SKILLED PROFESSIONAL
LIES WORKFORCE AND IF IT WAS
YOUR FAMILY MEMBER THAT IS WHAT
YOU WOULD WANT SO I HOPE THAT
THE DAY WILL COME WHEN WE DON'T
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT WHAT THE
MINIMUM WAGES BECAUSE WE'RE
MAKING SO MUCH MORE.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME I AM PADDY ANGER FROM
PATH POINT -- WE SERVE TWO
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
WE PROVIDE SERVICES IN FIVE
COUNTIES THROUGH CENTRAL AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA -- I'D LIKE
TO COMMENT ON THE UNIFORMS
CLOSURE DAYS.
AND WE ARE A SYSTEM IN CRISIS I
THINK EVERYBODY WOULD
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AND THE MAIN
REASON.
IS BECAUSE WE CANNOT ATTRACT
STAFF AT THE WAGE WE CAN PAY
THEM.
FISCAL THESE CLOSURE DAYS INTO
FACT.
BECAUSE FOR AN ADDITIONAL ONE
POINT SIX REDUCTION IN REVENUE.
WE CAN'T CUT OUR COSTS ANYWHERE
ELSE EXCEPT UNFORTUNATELY STAFF
WAGES.
MOST OF OUR COST OUR STAFF WAGES
THAT ONE POINT SIX REALLY
BECOMES ABOUT 2% SO IT SEEMS
VERY CONTRADICTORY. TO CUT STAFF
WAGES 2% WHEN WE HAVE A SYSTEM
IN CRISIS.
PRIMARILY BECAUSE STAFF WAGES
ARE TOO LOW.
WE HAVE TO SEND PEOPLE HOME
REGULARLY BECAUSE WE HAVE FORTY
OPENINGS IN OUR ORGANIZATION.
SO IT'S IT'S A BIG PROBLEM THE
OTHER THING I WANTED TO COMMENT
ON WAS THE MINIMUM WAGE.
AND IT FELT LIKE IF THE
DISCUSSION WAS AROUND.
OUR INDUSTRY BEING A MINIMUM
WAGE INDUSTRY IT'S NOT.
AND WE HAVE THAT STILL SORRY WE
HAVE SKILLED PEOPLE WE NEED TO
THINK OF IT AS A MUCH HIGHER
THAN THE MINIMUM WAGE INDUSTRY
WE HAVE NEVER ONCE APPLIED FOR
THE MINIMUM WAGE ADJUSTMENT.
NOT BECAUSE OF LOCAL MINIMUM
WAGE BUT BECAUSE WE CAN'T PAY
ANYBODY MINIMAL WHICH WE HAVE TO
PAY MORE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
WELCOME A GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY MY NAME IS MARIA
MOBERG I'M HERE AS A MOTHER OF A
SEVEN DIAGNOSED WITH CEREBRAL
PALSY I'M HERE IS THE SISTER OF
A FIFTY YEAR OLD BROTHER WITH
AUTISM.
WHO IN TWENTY ELEVEN WHEN MY
MOTHER PASSED AWAY I BECAME HIS
PRIMARY CARE GIVER BUT MOSTLY
TODAY I'M HERE AS A DIRECTOR OF
AN EARLY INTERVENTION PROGRAM?
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
SIR FORTY THREE THOUSAND PLUS A
YOUNG CHILDREN BIRTH TO THREE
WITH THIS AT RISK FOR
DEVELOPMENTAL DELAYS OR WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DELAYS.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN I LOST FIVE
TEACHERS BECAUSE OF OUR
INABILITY TO PAY A WAGE THAT
THEY NEEDED TO BE PAID AT THAT
TIME.
ON JULY WHEN WE ARE FACING THE
POSSIBLE RE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE IN
OUR AGENCY OF MILK IT WILL MEAN
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS PLUS CUT
TO WORK OUT TO OUR REVENUES.
WE DO NOT HAVE THAT FUNDING TO
SUPPORT THAT CUT.
BUT BEYOND THAT IT'S GOING TO BE
THE IMPACT TO OUR STAFF THESE
ARE NOT PAID HOLIDAYS SENATOR
PAN I SUPPORT THE STATEMENT THAT
YOU MADE EARLIER MAYBE WE SHOULD
CONSIDER.
THESE BECOMING PAID HOLIDAYS IF
THE STATE CHOOSES.
TO REINSTITUTE THAT THE PLEASE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE STATE NEEDS
TO SOMEHOW PROVIDE US WITH
FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THE TEACHERS IN OUR PROGRAM WHO
SUPPORT CHILDREN IN OUR STATE AT
A TIME.
IN THEIR DEVELOPMENT WHEN OUR
SERVICES HAVE THE GREATEST
IMPACT ON THEIR DEVELOPMENT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU FOR THAT THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY MY NAME IS AS AN
ADULT Là IS THAT LOCAL MISS I
AM I WAS VERY EXCITED I FLEW
HERE YESTERDAY BECAUSE THAT HE
WON IN THIS OPPORTUNITY I DON'T
KNOW HOW IT WORKS HERE SO HERE I
AM.
SO I WANTED TO SHARE THAT WITH
YOU -- AND THEY WENT STRAIGHT TO
YOUR OFFICE YOU WEREN'T THERE
BUT FAITH SPOKE TO ME AND I'M
SURE YOU GOT MY DETAILS ABOUT
ITSELF BUT I'M TO SUMMARIZE IT --
I'M AN INFILL DEVELOPMENT
PROVIDER VERY HAPPY I HAVE
DISCOVERED A PASSION AND A LOVE
EVERY SECOND OF IT.
AND WITH THAT.
I WANT TO SAY TO DATE I IT'S
WORKING WITH THE CHILDREN FROM
FIRST TO THREE YEARS OF AGE IT'S
A VERY AS YOU WOULD AGREE VERY
CRITICAL COMPONENT.
AND INTERRUPTIONS IN THEIR
CONSISTENCY WARRANTS A NEGATIVE
EFFECT NOT TO MENTION THE FORCED
IMPACT ON THE FURLOUGH DAYS.
AND JUST TO SUMMARIZE IT I KNOW
THE GOVERNOR IS INVOLVED WITH
HEAD START AND ALL THAT GREAT
STUFF YOU AS WELL SO GIVEN THE
PRIORITIES OF THE STATE.
THE CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES
AN START MUST ALSO BE A PRIORITY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
I THANK YOU HARRY PRO WITH PATH
POINT A A FEW KEY COMMENTS I AM
STILL CONFUSED ABOUT WHY WERE
DURING RECESSIONARY CUTS.
WHEN WE JUST AT A RATE STUDY
SHOWING WE NEED A 40% INCREASE
IN?
IN IN COSTS A FEW.
SPECIFIC POINTS ON MINIMUM WAGE
WE JUST SENT A LETTER TWO DAYS
AGO TO THE REGIONAL CENTER
SAYING WE CAN'T SUPPORT.
THE SAME NUMBER PEOPLE ANYMORE
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A ROTATING
SCHEDULE SENDING PEOPLE HOME
BECAUSE WE CAN'T HIRE STAFF.
WAS RE VACANCIES BETTER CAN'T
PAY PEOPLE ENOUGH AND SO THAT
BRINGS INTO QUESTION THE REAL
WEATHER WERE REALLY IMPACT AND
DURING THE LANTERN PROMISE.
ON HOLIDAYS OTHERS A COMMENT
THAT IT DOESN'T AFFECT
RESIDENTIAL PROGRAMS BUT IN OUR
CASE IT DOES BECAUSE WHEN PEOPLE
CAN'T COME TOWARD A PROGRAM THEY
HAVE TO GO STATE THE RESIDENTIAL
PROGRAM.
THE LAST POINT ON HALF DAY
BILLING NOT ECHOING SOMETHING
WILL SAID WHEN WE HAVE THREE
PEOPLE IN A GROUP AND ONE OF
THEM GOES HOME.
OUR OUR ONLY OPTION IS GOING TO
BECOME WE HAVE TO SEND THE OTHER
TWO PEOPLE HOME AND THE STAFF
MEMBER HAVE TO BILLING ISN'T A
BIG CUT FOR THE STATE FOR US TO
CUT A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
THIS YEAR.
MY LAST POINT ON THAT IS THAT
THE QUESTION ABOUT -- WHAT IS
THE PUBLIC THINKING THAT IF YOU
THINK ABOUT PUBLIC SCHOOL
FUNDING THEY DON'T CUT PUBLIC
SCHOOL FUNDING WHEN KIDS GO HOME
SICK AND AT UNDERSTAND WHY WE
WERE CUT FUNDING FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES WHEN THEY GET SICK
AND HAVE TO LEAVE EARLY?
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU CALLAWAY WITH THE BILL
ESPERANZA SERVICES SERVING SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY CHILDREN ADULTS
AND SENIORS IN LOS ANGELES AND
VENTURA COUNTIES.
I ECHO EVERYTHING THAT
EVERYBODY'S SAID OF THE LOCAL
MINIMUM WAGE IS REALLY REALLY
DESPERATELY NEEDS TO BE LOOKED
AT IT'S IT'S GETS KILLING
PROVIDERS AND WE ARE IN A CRISIS
I'VE HEARD THAT.
MANY TIMES AND SO ANYTHING THAT
THE LEGISLATION CAN DO TO HELP
US OUT GREATLY APPRECIATED TO
RECRUIT AND RETAIN REALLY GREAT
STAFF -- VERY MUCH -- IN SUPPORT
OF REPEALING THE FOURTEEN
UNIFORM HOLIDAY AND HALF BILLION
DAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
CATHERINE AGREED ON ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA MENTOR IN SUPPORT OF
THE PROPOSAL PRESENTED FOR
UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE AND
HAVE THE BILLING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
JAMIE DAVIS MY ADVENTURES IN
CENTER FILE -- I'M SUPPORT IN
SUPPORT OF NOT HAVING FOURTEEN
DAYS AND DOING AWAY WITH THE
HALF DAY BILLING.
AND I KNOW WHERE YOU CAN FIND
THE HALF DAY BILLING MONEY.
THERE IS A PROPOSAL IN THE
BUDGET TO FIND BEST BUDDIES
DIRECTLY AT ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION.
AND THIS IS A FIFTY BILLION A
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR GLOBAL
ORGANIZATION.
THAT'S RECEIVING SIR MONEY
DIRECTLY FROM THE STATE TO DO
WHAT MANY PROVIDERS IN THIS ROOM
CAN DO.
AND CERTAINLY I'D LIKE TO OFFER
THAT IF I WAS GETTING ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS I COULD DO
IT AS WELL AS BEST BUDDIES.
SO I SUGGEST THAT WE LOOK THERE.
AND NOT FUND THIS PROGRAM
DIRECTLY FROM THE STATE AND ASK
THEM TO GO THROUGH THE REGIONAL
CENTER LIKE THE REST OF US HAVE
TO DO [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI -- SENATOR PANELS CENTER
WITHOUT EXPERIENCE SPEAK INTO
THE MICROPHONE PLEASE THAT BILL
HI.
I HAVE -- ABOUT ISSUE TREES
SOCIAL RECREATION AND CALM
SERVICES -- MY NAME IS CLOUT
YEAH I AM HERE TO THEIR PRESENT
IN MICE ON PRINCESS GO -- HE
SAID NINE YEARS OLD BOY WITH
MULTI DISABILITY.
UNABLE TO WALK TALK AND SEE.
OUR HE CANNOT EAT BY HIMSELF AND
HE'S IN DIAPERS.
HE ALSO HAS INTO LOOKED
INSTABILITY AND SUFFERED
SUFFERED CAESAR'S ATTACKS.
HE'S LIKE A NOR NINE MONTH OLD
BABY.
I HE IS ONE IN ONE HUNDRED
ELEVEN IN THE WORLD WITHOUT A
RARE SYNDROME AND THE MOST
AFFECTED.
ONE EVEN WHEN HE GOES TO A
SPECIAL AT CENTER AND I GIVE HIM
AS MUCH.
THERAPIES AS I AS HE NEEDS SANTA
FE CAN AFFORD.
ART RECREATIONAL ACTIVITIES ARE
IMPORTANT FOR HIM BECAUSE HE
NEEDS TO HAVE FUN LIKE ANY OTHER
KIDS OF HIS.
EIGHT HE IS CURRENTLY IN THE
BASEBALL CHINESE DIVISION AND HE
LOVES IT -- HE ENJOYS STREAMING
MUSIC AND HE HAS CHAU
IMPROVEMENTS WITH A CAN OF
THERAPY IN THE PAST.
I I DON'T KNOW IF HE WILL EVER
ACHIEVE OLDER PURPOSES OF HIS
PHYSICAL AND OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIES.
BY I WANT TO MAKE SURE HE HAS
SUCH AS MUCH FINE IF HE CAN AND
ALSO BEING HAPPY ALL HIS LIFE.
OKAY THANK YOU.
YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SERRA
VERITY AND DIRECTOR OF
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FOR GATE
PASS THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
BASED PROVIDER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INQUIRY INTO
THE MINIMUM WAGE ISSUE.
WITH NO MECHANISM TO INCREASE
RATES WHEN LOCAL MANDATES ARE
AND FORCED ON US A IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN
STAFF I'M.
FULLY SUPPORTIVE OF FIXING THAT
QUIRK.
AT ALSO SUPPORTIVE OF RESTORING
THE SOCIAL AND RECREATIONAL
FUNDING.
THE FOURTEEN FURLOUGHS NEED TO
BE REPEALED PERMANENTLY NOT JUST
THIS YEAR AND A HALF DAY BILLING
NEEDS TO BE ELIMINATED AS WELL
THANK YOU.
OKAY MANIACS CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY RIGHTS I AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING THAT'S BEEN SAID IN
ROOM AND I LIKE GET TO THE POINT
THAT UNDER LANHAM ACT IT SAYS
UNDER THE LESS RESTRICTIVE
[inaudible]
SEEN POSSIBLE [inaudible] FOR
INDEPENDENCE.
I FEEL LIKE EVERY TIME WE BRING
THIS CONVERSATION UP ALL THE
TIME IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THE
KIND OF FORGET THAT ALSO ON YOUR
D. EIGHTY A ENTITLED TWENTY FOUR
THEIR TITLE PROGRAMS OUT THERE
TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THEY HAVE THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
PLACE POSSIBLE AND WE DON'T SEEM
TO BE HAVING THAT IF YOU'RE
GOING TO ONE GIVE THEM FOR
ALLOWS TO BUILD AND DOM DIED
INCREASE THE MINIMUM WAGE.
AND THREE DO HALF DAYS IT'S IT'S
JUST GOES AGAINST WHAT.
WE STAND FOR AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ALL THESE HARD
WORKING PEOPLE HERE IN ADVOCATES
BECAUSE THEIR PAY YOU.
DOESN'T GO UP BUT THERE BILLS
DON'T GO DOWN.
I THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR NAY
EVERYBODY -- BESSA PLEASURE TO
BE HERE.
IN YOU CAN HEAR MY I CAN BE THE
VOICE OF MY KIDS.
I HAVE TO ARTISTIC KIDS.
TWINS AND MY A LITTLE BOY A STAR
AND THEIR REGIONAL CENTER WHEN
HE WAS THREE AND A HALF HE
COULDN'T SPEAK.
A A. S. IS A LONG WAY.
HAVING A AND REGIONAL CENTER --
ALSO A BOARD MEMBER OF THE
REGIONAL CENTER I'M A PARENT OF
THE TWO KIDS ON THERE THERE.
IS SPECTRUM OF UP TO SOME.
IN HAVING -- SO POOR ALSO FOR
THE COME SERVICES SOCIAL
RECREATIONAL SERVICES
[inaudible]
WITH THE WHAT THE PEOPLE FOR THE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
AND TO HEAR MY VOICE I'M RIGHT
HERE I'M COMING FROM NOT DELAY
LOS ANGELES COUNTY COMING FROM
THE BODILY.
HARM.
THANK YOU AGAIN TO HEAR MY BOYS
AND REPRESENT MY KIDS AND MY
COMMUNITY THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
A CARE MY NAME IS CHRISTINE
REYES I'M A PARENT OF AFOURTEEN
YEAR OLD SON WITH SEVERE AUTISM
FROM NORTH LESS ANGELES COUNTY.
REGIONAL CENTER SANTA CRETA AREA
I SUPPORT SOCIAL RECREATION CAMP
SERVICES BECAUSE OUR CHILDREN
HAVE LIMITED ACCESS TO COMMUNITY
A LARGE.
OF BESIDES SCHOOL MY SON GOES ON
AND COMMUNITY BASED OUTINGS
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH IT FOR HIM
HE'S TO GO TO A SUMMER CAMP ON
FROM THE AGE OF THREE TO TWELVE
AND THEN AFTER THAT.
THERE IS NOTHING ELSE FOR HIM --
HE'S FOURTEEN AND EVERY SUMMER
HE ASKED TO GO BACK TO THAT CAMP
AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO TELL
HIM EXCEPT I'M SORRY YOU KNOW.
SO I JUST WANT TO LET YOU KNOW
THAT WE DESPERATE WE NEED THIS
FUNDING AND AS A PARENT I THINK
YOU FROM THE BOTTOM MY HEART FOR
LETTING ME SPEAK OKAY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MY NAME'S MICHELLE
HIDE -- I'M A BOARD CERTIFIED
BEHAVIOR ANALYSTS HERE TODAY
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM FOR BEHAVIOR ANALYSIS.
AND AS A REPRESENTATIVE FOR
BEHAVIORAL SERVICES SERVICE
PROVIDERS WE'D LIKE TO SHARE OUR
SUPPORT FOR REPEALING THE
FURLOUGH CHEDULE HERO SERVICES
ARE OFTEN PROVIDED TO
INDIVIDUALS WITH SEVERE
BEHAVIORAL DEFICITS.
WHO REQUIRE SERVICES TO LEARN
SKILLS AND AT TIMES MAINTAIN
THEIR SAFETY AND THEIR HOMES AND
COMMUNITIES?
THAT THE SEAT SERVICES ARE
NEEDED AND IT SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE WHEN THESE PEOPLE ARE
HOME AND IN THEIR COMMUNITIES WE
SUPPORT THE REPEAL OF THE FOR
LOW SCHEDULE WE ALSO SUPPORT
RESTORATION OF SOCIAL RECKON CAM
SERVICES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M KATIE HARBOR
GRAHAM THE DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE OF CLIENTS RATES ADVOCACY
IT DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
AND OUR OFFICE REPRESENTS OVER
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR
UNDER CONTRACT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT.
AND I WILL TELL YOU IN REGARDS
TO SOCIAL RECREATION IN CAMP
THAT IS ONE OF THE MOST COMMON
THINGS THAT WE HEAR THAT
FAMILIES WITH LIKE AS WE TRY TO
ASSIST THEM THROUGH IPP PLANNING.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY TRUE IN OUR
TRADITIONALLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES WHERE THE
AVAILABILITY OF THOSE SERVICES
OUTSIDE OF THE REGIONAL CENTER
FUNDED SYSTEM IS UNAVAILABLE TO
THEM.
AND SO WE BELIEVE THE
RESTORATION AND IS VITALLY
IMPORTANT TO THESE COMMUNITIES
AND AS A FORMER EARLY
INTERVENTION AND SPECIAL ED
TEACHER -- I I SORT OF EE IN IN
BELIEVE IN IT -- AND MANY PEOPLE
IN THIS ROOM HAVE HEARD ME YEAR
AFTER YEAR SAY WE HAVE TO
RESTORE SOCIAL CAN COUNT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JOSEPHINE NEMS AN I. F. TO
ADULTS -- FROM EASTERN LOS
ANGELES REGIONAL CENTER -- BUT
THE FIRST THING I WANT TO SAY IS
THAT. SEVEN OF US DROVE SINCE
THREE THIRTY THIS MORNING FROM
ELAINE -- FROM DOWNEY AND FROM
SOUTH GATE JUST.
TO LET YOU KNOW HOW IMPORTANT
THE SERVICES THAT FOR OUR KIDS --
THIS IS MY SON MR IN DANIEL.
THE BENEFIT FROM THE SERVICES OF
CAMPING AND AND IN SWIMMING
BECAUSE MY OTHER SON IS MORE
SEVERE HE WAS VERY -- IN DANGER
WHEN HE WAS IN WATER WELL THIS
IS MY SON NOW MY LITTLE GUY.
THIS IS AMY AND THIS IS NOW MY
PLAN.
THOSE ARE GARY.
SO -- AND HE KNOWS THE
IMPORTANCE MY HE WILL TELL YOU
ON HIS MINUTE.
BUT I JUST WANTED TO SUPPORT.
IN TELL YOU THE IMPORTANCE OF
THESE SERVICES NOT ONLY TO
SAFETY BUT AND ALSO FOR SOCIAL
SKILLS.
WHICH IN AUTISM IS ALL THE
LABELS THAT YOU CAN THINK OF
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
FARM [inaudible]
HI -- SOURCE RECREATION IN
CAMPUS MUCH MORE THAN JUST.
HAVING FUN -- FOR ME AT HE GAVE
ME A MEANINGFUL SOCIAL
INTERACTIONS AND SOMETHING TO
FOCUS ON LIKE -- THEY GET ME
[inaudible]
SINCE THE DOZENS OF MEANING LIKE --
IN THE SAME WAY LIKE -- JOT
COMPLAIN BECAUSE MEANING LIKE --
I GET TO INTERACT WITH OTHER
KIDS OF THE CAMPS AND BIKE --
WORK TOGETHER TO DO SOMETHING.
AND THAT THAT HAS -- HELPED ME --
BECOME THE PERSON I AM NOW.
OKAY THANK YOU -- I THINK THERE
IS SOME I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S
ANY.
TRANSLATION RIGHT NOW -- BUT IF
NOT THEN.
I CAN HELP BUT I'M NOT A
TRANSLATOR.
SO.
YOU HAVE SOME OF THE SERVICE
SPEAKING YES AND YOUR SOME OF
THE LADIES THAT CAME FROM LA
OKAY YEAH THEY THEY CAN TESTIFY
IN IN SPANISH [inaudible]
IN.
YEAH WE CAN TO HAVE SOMEONE WHO
CAN INTERPRET.
I I CAN TRY BUT IS VERY SIMPLE
WHAT THEY HAVE OKAY WELL DISEASE
PLEASE GUN AND IF YOU CAN
TRIGGER SOMEONE CONCERT AND TO
ACTUALLY AND ACTUALLY CENTER
TADO CAN DEFINITELY UNDERSTAND I
A SOMETIMES CAN UNDERSTAND A
LITTLE -- BUT WE WILL HEAR YOU.
IT IS FOR THE RECORD SO.
SO PLEASE BUT I SEVENTY NUMBERS
ON HELICON AGAIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SAM
HEY WE GOT A YEAH I KNOW.
SO MOTHER THE HOGAN OF THESE ONE
OUNCE ANIONS I'M A MOTHER OF A
SON WITH A TO SOME HE'S ELEVEN
YEARS OLD.
YOU GET A LOT OF THE SOMEONE A
SECOND A LITTLE SAID WITHOUT
REQUEST ON MY LIST.
I WANTED THIS TO FIVE WHAT
REGION ERIC YOUR RECREATIONAL
SERVICES.
IT'S IN THE MOOD TO PEDDLE SOME
MOVING THE MOST HONEST FEDERAL
BUT I'M ME AS THIS WOULD BE TO
SELL YOUR IDEA WHICH IS AMONG
THE WHOLE.
I'M SORRY THAT I GET.
A LOT OF FEELINGS BUT THE
SERVICES WOULD DEFINITELY HELP
MY SON.
A HARASSMENT THAN IS IS IT'S
ANOTHER SORT OF BASIS.
BAHRAIN BUT ARE. SEVEN MILLION
PARTICIPANT.
THEY REALLY NEED TO SERVICES IN
ORDER TO PARTICIPATE IN BEING
SOMEBODY IN THE COMMUNITY.
SIMPLE OF THOSE LAWS.
COMMON IN ENGLAND ARE CONSIDERED
GOING TO MOTIONS AND YOU'RE
LISTENING TO THE FOOD AND THE
STATE WON'T FEED IN A LOT OF
PLACES EVEN IT WOULD TRY TO GET
I MEAN.
IN IN PLACES.
ESTIMATES ARE YOU I'M WHICH IS A
MORE ARE YOURS AS WITH
COMPORTAMIENTO SODOMY AND SWITCH
IT WOULD BE THAT IN WHICH IS
CAUSE FOR MONTHS.
IT WILL HELP THE KIDS IN THEIR
SECURE IN THEIR SAFETY.
AND TO SLEEP AND A LOT OF OTHER
WICKS.
BUT AS HE HAS BEEN ALWAYS
THOUGHT LIZ ARE YOU THEM LESS
ARE YOU READY I'M WHAT YOU
SYMBOL I AM BIZARRE ARTICLE
EITHER PUT IN THE PHOTO REPORT
COLONEL PARTICIPANT AND LOCAL
MONEY THAT'S NOT MY THANK YOU --
THAT SAID BUT THERE WAS THIS
WILL HELP THEM -- IN
PARTICIPATING SOMETHING IN THE
FUTURE BEING THE INTEGRATED IN
THE COMMUNITY [inaudible]
WELCOME LOW INCOME ALSO LOOK AT
SOME OF THE CAN AND SENT THEIR
ACE WITH RESPONSIBLY THOSE.
IN NINETEEN EDUCATING MYSELF
ABOUT THE REGIONAL CENTER AND
THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES -- ONE
THAN THE THE OKAY Là STYLE
THOUGH NEEDLES MILES'S MOTOR
CONTROL PHONE THIS BUT I'M
ASSIDUOUS ADVOCACY MALICE.
AND NOW I'VE LEARNED THAT IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE THE STATE CUT
THE SERVICES FOR RECREATIONAL
SERVICES FOR A KID.
ARE YOU LET'S GET OPEN LEICA
BEFORE WATER PUT OVER THIS
LITTLE A PRINT AND WHAT WAS THE
SERVICES BUT GAVE ME BECAUSE
SEVENTY FIFTH ANNIVERSARY UP
BASTANTE THAT THEY USE.
I'M ASKING YOU IF IT'S POSSIBLE
TO READ -- BRING THEM BACH
BECAUSE I KNOW MY DAUGHTER WOULD
DEFINITELY BENEFIT FROM THEM.
YES YES THANK YOU BASS IS
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
OKAY FOR BACK FOR THE SECOND
TIME I'M JUST GONNA SAY DID OUT
EVERYTHING AND A DOUBLE DATA.
TO THAT REPEAL OF THE FOURTEEN
DAY HOLIDAY ARE FOR LOW DAY.
AFTER A BILLING AND THE
COMPRESSION ISSUE THAT'S
HAPPENING REGARDING -- OUR
EMPLOYMENT THANK OKAY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI.
DOUG PASSED OVER FROM IMAGINE
SUPPORTED LIVING AN APT TO US
AND WE SUPPORT THE RESTORATION
OF THE SOCIAL AND RECREATIONAL.
OKAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
FOLLOW ME WHEN THE STATUS OF
THOSE THE NUMBER IS MEDI AYE
LOPEZ IS LIMITED THEIR OWN
YOU'RE GOING OUT THESE MONTH.
HOW YOU DOING MY NAME IS MARIA
LOPEZ AND I'M MOTHER OF -- KIDS
WITH AUTISM.
AB I KNOW YOU'RE LOOKING GET ME
COMMENT I DON'T KNOW SEE AND
THEY GET OPEN THE TO COOPER FOR
WAR ANALLY SENATOR CONCEDED AND
ALSO TO BE STILL LIKE THIS
YOU'RE NOT LESS -- BUT GET THE
AND THEN -- BUT I CASE THAN THAT
IT IS SO THAT OBVIOUS WORK IS
SONG LABASA FUNDAMENT THAT'D BUT
I LÏNG THINK IT AS YOUR OWN
LINE CLOSELY ON THE NOSE DOES HE
THE NURSES COUNSEL ME THOUGH IT
IS AND ALSO SEE THAT.
YOU LISTED ON THIS SITE
ELIZABETH AND THE SENATE BE
THAT'S MUST SETTLE UP PLEASE.
S. GROUP.
I ASK YOU CAN THE PLEASE COME A
LAYS AND RECONSIDER.
THE RESTORATION AB OF THE
WRECKAGE RECREATIONAL SERVICES
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE FUNDAMENTAL
AT THEIR FUNDAMENTAL FOR THE
INTEGRATION AND INCLUSION FOR
OUR RELATIVES AND CONSUMERS.
SOCIETY AND GUARANTEES OUR
MENTAL AND PHYSICAL HEALTH.
WENT TO THE S. YES.
CRISIS [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS EVAN
AND DOING THIS AND I'M HERE TO
REPRESENT MY SON AVENIR IN TUNIS.
AND ALSO -- PART OF A DELIVERY
OF BOYS THE UNITED AND I'M PART
OF ALSO THE ICC.
MAN GROUP IN LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA.
I AND I'M HERE TO ASK YOU TO
PLEASE RECONSIDER THE
RESTORATION OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
THESE WILL DEFINITELY BENEFIT.
ALL DAY THE COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY
MY SON ALSO.
IN A IN A GRADE LEVEL HE WILL
HELP SOME THE HELP SOME -- YOU
KNOW GIVE THEM JOY.
IT'S LIKE A BREAK.
GIVEN THE ENERGY AND THE
STRENGTH TO KEEP GOING ON THE ON
THE ALL THESE ACTIVITIES
[inaudible]
AND I THAT CREATES A IT GIVES A
HUGE IMPACT ON THEIR SELF ESTEEM.
FOR SOME PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND
THIS IS A LITTLE BIT DIFFICULT.
BUT I UP I WANT TO SAY IT IN A
WAY THAT THE REST OF THE
COMMUNITY COULD POSSIBLY
UNDERSTAND THAT.
EARLIER WE ASK FOR A FIVE MINUTE
BREAK.
AND THAT WE DEFINITELY NEED IT.
WHEN WE COME BACK WHEN WE CAME
BACK WE FELT?
REJUVENATED.
WE FEEL MORE ENERGY TO KEEP
GOING BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE A LONG DAY TO GO.
THE AONG WITH A TO IS THERE
LIFE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
WELCOME I A JUDY MARK -- I AM
THE PARENT OF JOSH WHAT WHO THIS
IS TAKEN FROM.
TWO THOUSAND NINE I DUG IT OUT
IN HIS SWIM CLASS THAT WAS NO
LONGER FIND DEAD HE'S NOW TWENTY
TWO YEARS OLD.
SO -- I IT THIS WAS A REALLY
IMPORTANT TIME FOR HIM TO BE
ABLE TO BE IN A GREAT SWIM
PROGRAM INTENT LEARN WATER
SAFETY.
ON BUT I JUST WANT TO MAKE TWO
ADDITIONAL POINTS BECAUSE SO
MANY THESE PARENTS WERE SO
PERSUASIVE -- AS THE PRESIDENT
DISABILITY VOICES UNITED WE WANT
TO ASK TO ADDITIONAL THINGS --
FIRST OF ALL -- I A POINT THAT I
WANT TO MAKE IS THAT LAST YEAR
THE LEGISLATURE WAS VERY
GENEROUS AND RESTORED.
OR REMOVE THE CAP ON RESPITE I'M
I KNOW THAT IT WAS A TOUGH
CHOICE BETWEEN RESPITE SOCIAL
RECORD THE TIME.
AND I THE LEGISLATURE I'M AND
THE GOVERNOR READ THE CHOICE OF
OF RESPITE WE IN OUR WE HAVEN'T
DONE A FULL STUDY BUT WE IN OUR
ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE RESPITE HAS
ACTUALLY NOT REALLY BENEFITED.
THE COMMUNITIES AND LIKE WE
THOUGHT THEY WHAT -- WHILE THE
CAP WAS LIFTED PEOPLE ARE NOT
ACTUALLY GETTING A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN A RESPITE SO IT
HASN'T HAD A MAJOR BENEFIT.
SOCIAL WRAPPED IT WILL HAVE THAT
BENEFIT THERE'S NO OTHER OPTION
THE SECOND POINT I WANTED TO
MAKE IS THAT -- WE ALSO REALLY
ASK THE LEGISLATURE TO LOOK AT
RESTORING NON MEDICAL THERAPIES
IT'S A VERY SMALL AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT VERY NARROW GROUP OF
OF THERAPIES.
BUT WHAT IT INCLUDES ARE THINGS
LIKE ECHOING THERAPY SO INSTEAD
OF JUST GOING ON HORSEBACK
RIDING YOU'RE ACTUALLY GETTING
THERAPEUTIC IMPLIED.
I'M ABLE ALSO INCLUDES THINGS
LIKE NEUROLOGIC MUSIC THERAPY
WHICH HAS BEEN GREATLY BENEFITED
MY SON SO -- I HOPE THAT YOU'LL
CONSIDER THAT AS WELL THANK YOU
THANKS VERY MUCH.
PEOPLE ALWAYS MADE COMMENTS IN
WRITING TO SELL THANK YOU.
WELCOME HI I'M DORIAN TANAKA
MARIN VENTURES AND ALSO APPARENT.
I'M TOWARD THE END OF A PRETTY
LONG LINE HERE WHICH I THINK
SPEAKS TOWARD THE IMPORTANT
STUFF AND THE EYES ON THE ISSUES
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY.
IN MY JOB I'M COMMUNITY SERVICES
DIRECTOR I'M REALLY WORKING TO
INCREASE THE QUALITY AND
QUANTITY OF COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
FOR THOSE WE SERVE.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO DO WHEN
WE HAVE TROUBLE JUST RETAINING
STAFF -- AND THE ADDITIONAL
FURLOUGH DAYS WILL JUST MAKE
THAT.
AND EVEN MORE DIFFICULT
SITUATION.
AS A PARENT I AM A PARENT OF A
KID WHO IS.
G. JR REGIONAL CENTER ELIGIBLE
AND THE WORD ELIGIBLE IS KEY
HERE BECAUSE WE REALLY CAN'T USE
THE SERVICES WE ARE ELIGIBLE --
FOR BECAUSE OF THE RATES WE
HAVEN'T FOUND SOMEONE WHO IS
WILLING TO DO RESPITE -- FOR
THAT PAY.
ON THE OTHER HAND MY SON.
DOES ALL KINDS OF SOCIAL AND
CAMP ACTIVITIES HE DOES HAVE POP
DANCE HE DOES MARTIAL ARTS
SEASON CAMP ALL SUMMER.
SO IF WE COULD HAVE BENEFITTED
FROM THAT WE WOULD BE GETTING
SOMETHING THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
CENTER HURTADO FOR BEING HERE
TODAY AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND HEARING A BUDDY.
OF MINE IS CARL LUNDEN AMIR
REPRESENT THE ALLIANCE
SUPPORTING PEOPLE WITH ADD.
A VERY BRIEF COMMENT -- AN ECHO
WHAT YOU'VE HEARD THUS FAR
RELATIVE TO THE MINIMUM WAGE
ISSUE AND ITEMS TWO AND THREE I
JUST LIKE TO ADD THAT IT JUST.
FEELS BORDERLINE DISINGENUOUS TO
HAVE TO MAKE A PITCH ON THIS
YEAR AFTER YEAR ON A RECESSION
ERA CUT.
THAT STILL LINGERS IN THE
SITUATION AFFECTS PEOPLE THE WAY
DOES IT FEELS LIKE.
WE'RE BEING PUT IN A POSITION
HERE WE'VE GOT A STILL HAGGLING
NEGOTIATE FOR THIS ITEM.
WHILE WE CAN'T EVEN GET TO THE
REAL ITEMS OR TALK ABOUT WHICH I
KNEW OR ON THE AGENDA NEXT WEEK.
BUT IT FEELS LIKE A BARRIER TO
GET TO THOSE ITEMS AND IT'S
UNFORTUNATE TO BE IN THIS
POSITION THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER TERRY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THERESA
ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE
PARKING NIGHT CIRCLE POLICY
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION I KNOW
YOU KNOW OUR POSITION ON UNIFORM
HOLIDAY IN HALF DAYS MISTER
LINDSEY POINTED OUT EARLIER ON
THE PANEL SO -- I DON'T NEED TO
GOING TO THAT BUT WE WOULD ALSO
LIKE -- TO REALLY STRESS THE
IMPORTANCE OF FIXING THE LOCAL
MINIMUM WAGE ISSUE AS WELL AS
RESTORING SOCIAL WORK IN CAMP.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN POUND AND
THANK YOU SENATOR HER TOTAL FOR
LISTENING TO US TODAY I'M
HEATHER FLORA'S I'M THE DIRECTOR
FOR CENTRAL VALLEY REGIONAL
CENTER I COVER SENATOR HEARD HOW
DOES DISTRICT -- I JUST WANTED
TO BRING UP A COUPLE ITEMS I
HADN'T HEARD YET TODAY ON ISSUE --
TO IN OUR AREA WE HAVE A HIGH
LEVEL OF POVERTY AND WHEN
FAMILIES HAVE TO TAKE THE TIME
OFF TO COVER -- FOR THE CARE
DURING THOSE UNIFORM HOLIDAY
SCHEDULES IT CAN HAVE
DEVASTATING CONSEQUENCES ON
THOSE FAMILIES.
SO I WANTED TO MAKE THAT POINT
ADDITIONALLY WHICH IT WITH ISSUE
THREE OF THE SOCIAL RECKON CAMP
WERE TAKEN AWAY SO LONG AGO IT'S
HARD TO REMEMBER ALL OF THE
BENEFITS BUT WITH SOCIAL RECKON
PARTICULAR AND SPECIALIZED
THERAPEUTIC SERVICES THERE WERE
EXTRAORDINARY HEALTH BENEFITS
FOR THE INDIVIDUALS WE SERVED.
IT HELP PEOPLE MAINTAIN AND
REDUCE WEIGHT -- AND THAT
ADDRESSES YOUR ISSUES OF
CONTRACTURE AND ALL THESE OTHER
SORTS OF THINGS -- THAT IMPACT
THE LIVES OF THE PEOPLE WE SERVE.
FINALLY WITH CAMP CAMP WAS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR RESPITE
FOR A LOT OF OUR FAMILIES
ESPECIALLY FOR CHILDREN WHO ARE
MEDICALLY FRAGILE CHILD.
AND THIS WORK TO SUPPORT CARE
GIVERS AND CON GOT COMBAT CARE
GIVER BURN OUT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS MY NAME
IS DAVID MULTI I'M REPRESENTING
THE SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
COMMITTEE -- AND I'M SPEAKING
INTO ANY OTHER HAVE CONTENT IN
SUPPORT OF THE REMOVAL OF THESE
RECESSIONARY.
ERIC CUTS -- PARTICULARLY -- IN
OUR PERSONALLY WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT I BEGAN MY FIFTY YEAR
CAREER IN DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AS A CAMP COUNSELOR.
AND I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THAT
OPPORTUNITY [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS KEVIN ROTH.
AND THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR MINUS
WE SERVE FIFTEEN HUNDRED PEOPLE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
SERVICE GOES BAY ALSO WITH A
PATH FOR COLLABORATIVE SEE
SOMEONE IS HEARING.
UP DO THAT DEAL FOR EVERYTHING
ELSE I WANT TO FOCUS ON THAT THE
QUIRK THAT -- MINIMUM WAGE QUIRK
UNFORTUNATELY THE MINIMUM WAGE
QUIRK SOLVING THAT COMES DOWN.
TO HOW WE'RE GOING TO FILL OUT A
FORM.
AND SO.
WE CAN HAVE ALL THE LINE
LANGUAGE THAT WE WANT IN THE
LEGISLATURE BUT IF THE FORM IS
NOT FIXED.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO SUFFER.
SO WHEN WE FILL OUT THE FORM WE
PUT IN WHAT WE PAY A WORKER AND
WHAT THE MINIMUM WAGES AND WE
GET THE DELTA.
RIGHT -- THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE.
WHEN THERE IS A LOCAL MINIMUM
WAGE INCREASE?
IN IN THAT AREA THE FIX FOR THE
FORM NEEDS TO BE.
IF THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE GOES
UP X. YOU GET X. PLUS 23% FOR
BENEFITS IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
AND UNLESS BUT UNLESS THAT
HAPPENS.
THE NOTHING WILL CHANGE AND
PEOPLE BE CONTINUE TO PAY THE
MINIMUM WAGE.
AT A HIGHER RATE AND THEN GO TO
FILL OUT THE FORM AND NOT GET
ANYTHING.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON FITTING
UNDERGARMENTS SO I REPRESENT
DISABILITY VOICES UNITED IN THE
INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE PUMPS MORE
IMPORTANTLY REPRESENT MY SON WAS
TWELVE YEARS OLD WITH DOWN
SYNDROME.
AB AT TWELVE YEARS OLD HE'S PART
OF THAT GENERATION WHOSE MISSED
OUT ON ANOTHER AMAZING
OPPORTUNITY ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES SENATOR AND ENCOURAGE
US.
TO WHEN YOU LOOK AT SOCIAL
RECKON CAMPING.
WE GENERALLY.
THINK ABOUT SUCH A FUN THING TO
DO TO LEARN HOW TO SWIM HANG OUT
AND MAYBE SING SOME CAMP SONGS
SO FORTH.
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AND I KNOW WE'VE HEARD IT.
TIME AND TIME AGAIN FOR NUMEROUS
PEOPLE FOR MY SON IT'S ALL THE
DIFFERENCE IN THE WORLD AT
TWELVE YEARS OLD HE DOES NOT
HAVE A FRIEND.
WHO COMES OVER IN PLACE WHAT HE
DOES NOT HAVE A PLACE TO GO OUT
AND?
HAVE SOME FUN WITH OTHERS
APPEARS ABOUT INDIVIDUALS OF HIS
AGE OR IN THE SAME SITUATION SO
HE'S MISSING OUT ON SOMETHING
THAT I BELIEVE IS.
NOT ONLY LACKING BUT IT'S
ESSENTIAL TO HIM WHO HE IS AS A
PERSON SO I WOULD APPRECIATE YOU
RECONSIDERING.
REINSTATING THE SURGERY PROGRAM
THANKS VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RIGHT ONE THANK ALL OF OUR
WITNESSES -- AS I MENTIONED IN
THE OPENING WE WILL BE HOLDING
THESE ITEMS OPEN AND UNTIL WE
RECEIVE THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISED PROPOSAL.
AND SO I THINK AGAIN EVERYONE
FOR PRESENTING.
RIGHT SO WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS
THE B. C. P. ON HEADQUARTERS
RESTRUCTURING RESTRUCTURING
REORGANIZATION SO.
AND WE HAVE OUR RE ORGANIZING.
OKAY ENGINE THAT JUST.
PERCENT THE AGENCY ON THEIR
THING.
RIGHT HAVE HEALTH RECORDS OKAY
YES SO WE WILL FIRST HAVE AN
AGENCY PRESENTATION AND WE DO
HAVE A PANEL -- TO COMMENT ON
THIS -- SO -- SO WE HAVE THREE
PEOPLE ON THE PANEL AND I'M --
DO YOU NEED OTHER PEOPLE YOUR
AGENCY HERE WITH YOU OR NOT.
YEAH I HAVE BRAND WHEN FILLED UP
OKAY -- DIRECTOR AND THEN --
RIGHT WE MAY HAVE THAT'S OKAY IF
SOMEBODY ELSE IF WE HAVE A
QUESTION THAT WE NEED TO CLARIFY
WE CAN CERTAINLY BRING OKAY --
GREEN PEOPLE UP OKAY ALL RIGHT
SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND LET'S --
DOCTOR HAVE YOU FIRST -- PRESENT
ON THE PROPOSAL AND THEN -- WILL
HAVE COME IN FROM MILLION
FINANCE AND THEN WE HAVE A PANEL
WHO ALSO WISHES TO COMMENT AS
WELL OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- I
WANTED TO JUST MAKE NOTE IN THE
AGENDA IT'S A VERY NICE
DESCRIPTION STAFF DID A
WONDERFUL JOB IN PROVIDING AN
OVERVIEW AND AND I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
TO YOU TODAY.
SO IN THE AGENDA ON PAGE TWENTY
IT DOES APPROPRIATELY NOTE THAT
WE'RE REQUESTING -- EIGHT POINT
ONE MILLION IN TOTAL FUNDS THAT
WOULD BE SIX POINT FIVE MILLION
IN GENERAL FUND FOR A SUPPORT OF
A REORGANIZATION WITHIN OUR
HEADQUARTERS OFFICE -- AS I
NOTED EARLIER IN IN THE WORK
THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING -- OVER
THE MANY YEARS IS THAT WE REALLY
HAVE STARTED SEEN A SHIFT AS FAR
AS SERVICES.
I'VE INDIVIDUALS IN CALIFORNIA
AND THE GROWTH WITHIN OUR
SERVICES SO ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
CURRENTLY WE'RE PROJECTING CLOSE
TO THREE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
THE NEXT YEAR -- AND AS I SAID
NOTED EARLIER -- IN IN ISSUE ONE
THAT THE GROWTH THAT WERE SEEN
IS IS PRETTY SIGNIFICANT IN
ADDITION I GUESS I'D LIKE TO
ALSO NOT JUST TALK ABOUT THE
GROWTH THE CONSUMER POPULATION
BUT ALSO JUST THE CHANGES OF OF
THE SERVICES.
AND I'LL I'LL EXPLAIN TO YOU WHY
THAT'S NOTABLE AS FAR AS THE
SUPPORTS THAT WE PROVIDE AS A
DEPARTMENT -- TO THE COMMUNITY
AS A WHOLE -- BUT IF YOU'LL BEAR
WITH ME FOR JUST A SECOND I'D
LIKE TO JUST GIVE YOU SOME
EXAMPLES OF SOME OF THE CHANGES
OF OUR SYSTEM.
SO AS I NOTED EARLIER IN -- TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT WE HAD
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
TWO THOUSAND CONSUMERS THAT WE
WERE PROVIDING SERVICES FOR IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
THAT WENT TO TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND AND AS I NOTED
THAT GOING INTO THE NEXT YEAR
WE'RE LOOKING AT THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND AS WE HAVE HEARD
YOU KNOW FROM MANY FAMILIES
TODAY AND AS WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH FAMILIES ONE
OF THE MOST.
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES THAT WERE
SEEN IN OUR SYSTEM IS A GROWTH
AND CHILDREN -- WITH AUTISM AND
THOSE CHILDREN ARE ALSO AGING
AND GETTING OLDER AND THE NEEDS
OF OUR SYSTEM IS CERTAINLY
CHANGING AS A RESULT.
OF NOTE TO OUR TOTAL POPULATION
CURRENTLY FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
AUTISM IS A HUNDRED TWELVE
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS.
OF THIS POPULAR AN 80% OF THEM
ARE UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY TWO
JUST TO DRIVE INTO A LITTLE BIT
DEEPER IS THAT WHEN WE TAKE A
LOOK AT OUR POPULATION.
BETWEEN THE AGE OF BETWEEN THREE
AND 2160% OF THEM HAVE A
DIAGNOSIS OF AUTISM -- MOST
NOTABLY IT'S RIGHT AROUND THE
AGE OF SIX TO NINE YEARS OLD AND
SO AGAIN.
WHY IS THIS IMPORTANT WHEN WE
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT AS WE TAKE A
LOOK AT THE CHANGES OF OUR
DEMOGRAPHICS AS FAR AS ETHNICITY
OF OUR POPULATION?
SO WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR HISPANIC
POPULATION IN -- TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT IT REPRESENTED 34% OF OUR
POPULATION -- CONSUMER
POPULATION WHERE AS WHITES WAS
39%.
AND CURRENTLY ARE HISPANIC
POPULATION NOW REPRESENTS 39%
WHERE WHITES IS 31%.
SO WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK AT ALSO
OUR AGING POPULATION THAT IS
ALSO CHANGING.
WHY IS THIS IMPORTANT AS WE TAKE
A LOOK AT OUR HEADQUARTERS?
WE ARE A SYSTEM THAT HAS CHANGED
WHAT I'M LOOKING AT HOW WE
PROVIDE THE SERVICES IT WITH A
TARGETED -- FOCUS AND PRIORITY
OF NOT ONLY ON DELIVERING THE
SERVICES THROUGH THE REGIONAL
CENTERS.
MAKING SURE THAT THE REGIONAL
CENTERS AND OUR SERVICE DELIVERY
SYSTEM IS DELIVERING WITHIN THE
LETTERMAN ACT WE WANT TO FOCUS
ON THE ACCOUNTABILITY OF OUR
SERVICE DELIVERY WE WANT TO
FOCUS ON ENHANCING THE
TRANSPARENCY STORE FAMILIES CAN.
SEE KIND OF WHAT THE SERVICES
ARE AND ALSO START MOVING THE
NEEDLE TO TAKE A LOOK AT HOW CAN
WE MOVE THINGS TO A STANDARDIZED
STATEWIDE APPROACH.
SO WE CAN REALLY MAKE SURE THAT
AS FAMILIES ARE HAVING
EXPERIENCES WITHIN ONE REGIONAL
CENTER CATCHMENT AREA.
THAT THOSE EXPERIENCES COULD BE
FOUND IN ANOTHER AREA HOW DO WE
DO THAT ONE OF THE THINGS WE
NEED TO DO IS A A DEPARTMENT IS
ALSO BE RESPONSIVE TO THOSE
NEEDS -- RIGHT NOW WE HAVE FOUR
LAYERS ON THAT WORK WITH THE
TWENTY ONE REGIONAL CENTERS --
THE PROPOSAL WOULD INCREASE THAT
OUR RELATIONSHIP TO WHERE WE
WOULD HAVE SEVEN TEAMS THAT
WOULD WORK WITH A DIFFERENT
REGIONAL CENTERS SO WE WOULD NOW
HAVE -- ONE LAY IS ON WITH
SUPPORT THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO
WORK WITH THREE REGIONAL CENTERS.
ONE THING THAT IS VERY NOTABLE I
THINK IN THE PROPOSAL THAT WE
HAVE FOR A REORGANIZATION IS
REALLY HAVING A PRESENCE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ALSO AND IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
SO WHAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO DO
OVER TIME IS TO BE HAD ABLE TO
HAVE BETWEEN FORTY FIVE AND
FIFTY OF OUR STAFF IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO
ATTEND.
ANY OF THE DIFFERENT COMMUNITY
MEETINGS WELL IN THE LAST YEAR
WE WERE ABLE TO HAVE ABOUT
THIRTY DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WAS REALLY BENEFICIAL WAS THAT
WE DID HAVE STAFF THAT ATTENDED.
AT LEAST ONE OF THE OF THE
PUBLIC MEETINGS AT EACH REGIONAL
CENTER HAD TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
DISPARITY ISSUES.
YOU KNOW THEY WERE ABLE TO
ATTEND.
ONE IF WE HAD A PRESENCE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IN
INCREASED ARE STOCKING WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO ATTEND MORE THE
COMMUNITY MEETINGS.
NOT TO GET IN THE WAY OF WHAT
THE WORK IS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
BECAUSE THAT IS CERTAINLY NOT
OUR INTENT.
BUT WE CAN REALLY START TAKING A
LOOK AT WHAT ARE THE ISUES THAT
WE'RE HEARING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
TIE THAT BACK UP TO THE POLICY
AND INITIATIVES THAT WERE DOING
AT THE STATE LEVEL.
AS AN EXAMPLE WHEN WE WERE --
DISBURSING ELEVEN MILLION FOR
DISPARITY FUNDS OR WITH THE
FIFTEEN MILLION THAT WE HAVE.
FOR THE H. CBS -- COMPLIANCE
FUNDING WHEN WE HAVE COMMUNITY
PLACEMENT FUNDS AS WELL AS
COMMUNITY RESOURCE DEVELOPMENT
FUNDS ALL OF THAT THE DECISIONS
THAT WERE MAKING FOR ALL OF THEM
VESTMENT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IS DOING.
REALLY CAN'T BE TIED TO
UNDERSTANDING WHAT IS HAPPENING
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
SO THOSE ARE THE THINGS I THINK
IS IS REALLY CRITICAL IN BEING
ABLE TO BE RESPONSIVE ONE OF
THINGS THAT WE HAVE A WANTED TO
DO WAS IMPROVE OUR RESPONSES TO
INFORMAL COMPLAINTS TO FAMILIES --
AND BEING ABLE TO HAVE A
PRESENCE BROADER THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA -- OUR RESPONSE TO
BEING ABLE TO GET OUT WE HAD A A
CONCERN THAT WAS SHARED IN A
PARTICULAR GEOGRAPHIC AREA.
IT WAS A IMPORTANT CONCERN IT
WAS SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY
WANTED TO HEAR FROM THE FAMILIES
IT WAS A PARTICULAR CONCERN TO
AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
YOU KNOW BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
THERE IS USED THE FAMILIES WERE
SAYING THAT THEY WERE NOT
GETTING SERVICES WE NEEDED TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THOSE ISSUES
WERE.
IT TOOK US SEVERAL MONTHS TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE SOMEBODY WITH AN
HEADQUARTERS TO GO OUT AND BE
THERE TO LISTEN TO WHAT THOSE
CONCERNS WERE SO WE CAN PROVIDE
SOME ASSISTANCE TO THE REGIONAL
CENTER. TO SEE HOW WE CAN --
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN MITIGATE
THAT RISK.
AND THE OTHER THING THAT I THINK
IS REALLY A POURTANT AND WHEN WE
TAKE A LOOK AT THE RISK
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM WITH IN
CALIFORNIA.
YOU KNOW AGAIN OUR SYSTEM IS
GROWING SO WHEN WE ARE ARE
BUILDING THE SERVICES FOR
SUPPORTING INDIVIDUALS WITH VERY
COMPLEX NEEDS AS WERE SUPPORTING
SERVICES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
WELL WE DO HAVE A QUALITY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM WE DO HAVE
STAFF THAT WORK IN THAT ENHANCE
THE MESS AND BRINGING IN
SOMEBODY THAT CAN HAVE THAT
EXPERTISE THAT UNDERSTANDS RISK
MANAGEMENT AND A VERY --
PASSIONATE LEVEL BUT ALSO WITH
THE EXPERTISE TO BE ABLE TO HELP
US ASSESS HOW ARE WE DOING AS A
STATE.
IN UNDERSTANDING OUR RISK
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES AND HOW WECAN MOVE FORWARD AND BE ABLE TO
HAVE A VERY CLEAR PLAN SO WE CAN
HELP.
GOING TO MITIGATE RISK -- BY
UNDERSTANDING OR TRANS THE
QUESTION THAT WAS ALSO IN THE
AGENDA FOR US TODAY WAS HOW CAN
RESEARCH.
ON BE ABLE TO KIND OF ADDRESS
SOME OF THE THE DATA CONCERNS
ARE TO TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT ARE
THOSE UNMET NEEDS.
AS I HAD TALKED JUST A SECOND
AGO ABOUT THE COMMUNITY RESOURCE
DEVELOPMENT -- PLANS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT'S IMPORTANT IS THAT
THE REGIONAL CENTERS UNDERSTAND
WHAT THEIR LOCAL NEEDS ARE WHAT
WERE THE GAPS OF SERVICES ARE
THEY CAN REQUEST.
FUNDING RELATED TO THAT WELL
THAT IS NOT THE VISIBILITY THAT
WE HAVE -- AT THE DEPARTMENT
LEVEL AS FAR AS UNDERSTANDING
KIND OF THOSE THAT LEVEL OF
DETAIL ENHANCING OUR RESEARCH
SECTION REALLY CAN HELP US.
START IDENTIFYING WHAT ARE SOME
OF THE DATA ELEMENTS ARE WHAT
ARE SOME OF THE DATE THAT THE
ABILITY TO DO DATA MEASURES THAT
WILL HELP US BROAD AND AN
UNDERSTANDING OF WHERE ARE GAPS
THE SERVICES ARE OR
UNDERSTANDING WHAT'S DRIVING OUR
TRENDS AND AND CHANGES.
AND THAT SECTION THAT RESEARCH
SECTION WITH THE ADDITIONAL
STAFFING WILL BE ABLE TO ALSO
TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF THE DATA
INTEGRITY ISSUES THAT WE HAVE.
AND THEN WORKING WITH THE-REGIONAL CENTERS -- AS FAR AS
THE EFFORTS THAT THEY HAVE SO
CAN A COLLECTIVE WHEN NO IT'S A
LOT OF INFORMATION BUT I WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT I CAN GIVE YOU.
SOME OF THOSE CHALLENGES THAT
WERE SEEN AS A SYSTEM AND AND
THE APPROACH THAT WE WOULD BE
USING WITHIN RE ORGANIZATION TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE ISSUES.
ONE OF THE THE THINGS YOU WAS
ALSO NOTED -- AS FAR AS WHAT IS
GOING TO BE THE THE PRIMARY
FOCUS OF SUPPORTING INDIVIDUALS
AND THE OUTCOMES AND HOW CAN
THIS BENEFIT CONSUMERS AND
FAMILIES.
AS I SAID YOU KNOW CERTAINLY
SUPPORTING THE REGIONAL CENTERS
AND MAKING SURE THEY'RE
ADDRESSING THE CONCERNS IT'S
IMPORTANT BUT ALSO FOR US IS A
DEPARTMENT TO UNDERSTAND SO WE
CAN ALSO MAKE SOME -- IMPORTANT
DECISIONS THE OUTCOMES ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE MAKING
THE BEST DECISIONS TO THE
INVESTMENT OF THE DOLLARS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
MINISTRATION HAS COMMITTED. TO
TO AFFECT THOSE CHANGES
ADDITIONALLY WHEN WE'RE TAKING A
LOOK AT ENHANCING OUR MONITORING
OVER SOME OF THE SERVICES FOR
THE FAMILY HOME AGENCIES TAKING
A LOOK AT HOW WE CAN ENHANCE
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH OUR MONITORING
FOR WORK SERVICES.
THAT ALSO WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE A
DIRECT BENEFIT TO INDIVIDUALS --
THAT ARE DEPENDENT ON OUR
SERVICES.
SO I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS -- THAT -- MAYBE.
WITH YOU TODAY.
OKAY WELL -- OF FIRST THAT COMES
FROM ALEJO.
SONYA PADDICK LA -- AND I'LL TRY
TO KEEP THESE COMMENTS BRIEF AS
SOME OF OUR CONCERNS WERE
ADDRESSED IN THE PARTICULAR
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAD FOR THE
DEPARTMENT IN THE AGENDA.
WE WOULD FIRST NOTE THAT THIS IS
A THIS PROPOSAL REPRESENTS A
RELATIVELY IT'S I MEAN IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY BUT
IT'S A RELATIVELY SMALL AMOUNT
OF MONEY -- AND IT REPRESENTS WE
THINK A THOUGHTFUL AND TIMELY
PROPOSAL -- WHAT'S BEEN PROPOSED
IN.
IN THIS REQUEST -- MORE
ACCURATELY REFLECTS THE
DEPARTMENT'S CURRENT -- AN
IMMINENT RESPONSIBILITIES WHEN
IT COMES TO CONSUMERS AND WE
THINK SOME OF THE OVERSIGHT
PIECES AND RISK MANAGEMENT AND
QUALITY ASSURANCE ACTIVITIES ARE
GOOD -- I'LL JUST MAKE THREE
POINTS -- FIRST OUR OFFICE THE
WOULD HAVE LIKED TO HAVE SEEN
SOME MORE SPECIFIC SHORT TERM
AND LONG TERM.
GOALS THAT THE DEPARTMENT HOPES
TO TO ACHIEVE FROM A CONSUMER
PERSPECTIVE HOW HOW ARE THEY
REALLY INTENDING TO IMPROVE
OUTCOMES FOR CONSUMERS NOT JUST
RESPOND TO RISK OR ATTEMPT TO
PREVENT A NEGATIVE OUTCOMES BUT
HOW ARE THEY ACTUALLY GOING TO
SINK.
IN YOU KNOW AND FOR IN AN
INNOVATIVE WAY ABOUT THE FUTURE --
OUR SECOND KEY POINTS -- DOES
CONCERN DATA AND WE WERE
HEARTENED TO HEAR WITH DIRECTOR
BURGEONING JUST SAID ABOUT THE
THE RESEARCH UNIT BUT WE WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
DOES LACK -- OF OF A SYSTEM FOR
COLLECTING.
DATA IN A SYSTEMATIC WAY TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT SOME OF THE GAPS
IN SERVICES NEEDS ARE.
AND JUST TAKE TO PROVIDE AN
EXAMPLE WE HEARD A LOT OF GREAT
ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE OR ANECDOTAL
STORIES TODAY ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF SOCIAL RECREATION
IN CAMP AND WE DO HAVE SOME
SURVEY DATA.
PROVIDED BY THE ARTIST IN
SOCIETY BUT THAT THERE'S AN
EXAMPLE OF WE DON'T REALLY KNOW
FROM A STATEWIDE PERSPECTIVE
JUST HOW MANY CONSUMERS.
ARE LACKING THESE SERVICES FEEL
THEY NEED THESE SERVICES WOULD
LIKE THESE SERVICES SO IT'S IT'S
HARD TO MAKE THOSE KINDS OF
STRATEGIC DECISIONS WITHOUT THAT
THAT KIND OF INFORMATION AT A
STATEWIDE.
SYSTEMATIC LEVEL AND THEN
FINALLY JUST A SMALL POINT
REGARDING THE PROPOSAL TO TO
OPEN A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
OFFICE -- WE JUST NOTE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT PROPOSES TO TO HOUSE
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA OFFICE
ON THE FAIRVIEW DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER PROPERTY UNTIL IT CLOSES.
SO THIS IS JUST TO SAY THAT WE
WOULD EXPECT THEN THAT THE
DEPARTMENT WILL LIKELY BE COMING
BACK IN THE FUTURE FOR A REQUEST
OF FUNDS TO HOUSE -- THOSE
ACTIVITIES SOMEWHERE.
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A FINANCE ANY COMMENTS.
ALL RIGHT.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE --
SOME STAKEHOLDER BOTH COMMENTS
AND ALSO SOME PROPOSALS OF SORTS
SO ALL RIGHT.
AND SO WE HAVE AMY WESTLING --
FROM -- DISSOCIATION OF REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCIES AND FOLLOWED
THEN BY JUDY MARK.
THIS BILL VOICES UNITED AND THEN.
AND NINETY HAN.
AT KATIE HORNBERGER RIGHT.
CHANGE IN.
DISABILITY RIGHTS OKAY CIVIL --
ASK YOU CAN TRY TO KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS TO THREE MINUTES --
THANK YOU WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AMY
WESTLING ON THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES.
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
HEARING THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE AS
WELL AS YOUR STAFF FOR THE
COMPREHENSIVE RIGHT UP WHICH
MAKES THE REVIEW OF THIS SO MUCH
EASIER.
IT'S AN EXCITING TIME IN
CALIFORNIA'S DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES SYSTEM WE'RE AT THE
POINT WHERE.
MANY OF US HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
THE SYSTEM FOR A VERY LONG TIME
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE DAY WHEN
IT BECAME A UNIFIED SYSTEM WHERE
IT REALLY WAS A COMMUNITY BASED
SYSTEM AND SO WE APPRECIATE.
THAT THE THAT WERE THERE THAT WE
ARE IN A SPACE WHERE THE
DEPARTMENT CAN PIVOT TO FOCUS ON
THE COMMUNITY.
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES
REQUIRES THE INTERPLAY BETWEEN
VARIOUS AGENCIES IT REQUIRES
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO BE THE
BOOTS ON THE GROUND PROVIDING
SOMETIMES DAILY SOMETIMES
CONTINUOUS SUPPORT.
REGIONAL CENTERS FOR LOCAL
PLANNING ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATION ONGOING SERVICE
COORDINATION RESOURCE
DEVELOPMENT QUALITY ASSURANCE
CLINICAL SERVICES FEDERAL
BILLING IT CETERA.
AND THE DEPARTMENT TO PROVIDE
STATEWIDE PLANNING CONTRACTING
MONITORING AND BUDGETING.
AS DIRECTOR BRIDGMAN OUTLINED AS
THE SYSTEM BECOMES LARGER MORE
COMPLEX.
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT ALL THREE
SEGMENTS OF THE SYSTEM SERVICE
PROVIDERS REGIONAL CENTERS AND
THE DEPARTMENT HAVE ADEQUATE
RESOURCES TO DO THEIR JOB.
AND IN RECENT YEARS THE
DEPARTMENT HASN'T HAD THOSE
RESOURCES WHICH HAS LIMITED
THEIR ABILITY TO BE RESPONSIVE.
TO PEOPLE SERVED IN THE
COMMUNITY.
BUT ALSO TO REGIONAL CENTERS
WHICH HAS MADE IT HARDER TO
IMPLEMENT THINGS LIKE DISPARITY
GRANTS H. CBS PROPOSALS
COMMUNITY PLACEMENT PLANS THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS.
AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO THIS
PROPOSAL MOVING FORWARD IN
PROVIDING THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE DEPARTMENT TO BE MORE NIMBLE
AND RESPONSIVE.
AND CAPABLE AND RESPONDING TO
ALL OF THE VARIOUS NEEDS BECAUSE
WE HAVE SO MANY EXCITING THINGS
GOING ON RIGHT NOW.
WE'RE ON THE CUSP OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF NEW STANDARDS
THAT WOULD REQUIRE GREATER
COMMUNITY INTEGRATION AND WE
NEED ALL OF THOSE PARTNERS TO BE
UP TO SPEED AND CAPABLE TO DO
THEIR PART IN THOSE THINGS.
ADDITIONALLY I KNOW THAT WE'LL
BE HEARING FROM DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN JUST A
MOMENT AND I DID WANT TO TAKE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO THANK KATY AS
WELL AS CATHERINE PLAGUE MORE
THAT DIRECTOR OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA FOR ALL OF
THEIR WORK.
IN LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN SERVE
PEOPLE BETTER ADVOCACY GROUPS
AND STAKEHOLDERS ALWAYS
CHALLENGES TO IMPROVE THE SYSTEM
ON BEHALF OF THOSE WE SUPPORT.
AND I JUST WANT TO EXTEND OUR
THANKS TO THE DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA FOR THE COLLABORATIVE
PROCESS THAT WE'VE BEEN GOING
THROUGH OVER THE LAST FEW MONTHS.
TO TAKE SOME OF THEIR PROPOSALS
AND REFINE THEM AND THINK ABOUT
HOW CAN WE ACHIEVE THE OUTCOMES
THAT WE'RE ALL SEEKING TO
IMPROVE THE LIVES OF PEOPLE.
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
AND HOW CAN WE WORK TOGETHER TO
ACHIEVE THAT END.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SORRY WORK -- PRESIDENT
DISABILITIES VOICES UNITED.
THE BY AND FOR PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
FAMILY MEMBERS I'M ALSO IN FACT
AT FACULTY MEMBER A DISABILITY
STUDIES AT UCLA.
WE COMMEND DDS FOR THINKING
SERIOUSLY ABOUT WAYS TO IMPROVE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
BUT WE ARE STILL UNCLEAR ABOUT
HOW THIS ADDITIONAL A POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN.
FIFTY FOUR POSITIONS WILL
IMPROVE OUTCOMES THAT MATTER TO
OUR COMMUNITY.
WILL THIS RESTRUCTURING CHANGE
THE FACT THAT SIMILAR
INDIVIDUALS READ WILL STILL
RECEIVE VASTLY DIFFERENT LEVELS
OF SERVICE DEPENDING ON WHICH
REGIONAL CENTER THEY ARE PART OF
WILL THESE FUNDS ENSURE THAT THE
INCREDIBLY DELAYED SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM FINALLY
BEGINS IT IS SUCCESSFUL.
WILL THESE EXTRA POSITIONS MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES GET JOBS AND CAN
REMAIN AT HOME EVEN IF THEY'RE
STRUGGLING THROUGH CRISIS.
HOW WILL THE OR -- HOW THE
REORGANIZATION ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE LATINO ARE
GETTING THE SAME LEVEL OF
SERVICES PEOPLE WHO ARE WHITE --
HOW WILL THIS HELP PEOPLE
FAMILIES WHO FEEL INTIMIDATED TO
ASK FOR SERVICES FROM THEIR
REGIONAL CENTRES?
YOU MAY ASK WHAT ONE ADDING
FIFTY FOUR NEW POSITIONS BRING
ABOUT PROGRESS IN ALL OF THESE
FRONTS I MEAN AFTER ALL.
DDS IS PROPOSING TO HIRE TWENTY
FIVE MORE PEOPLE TO FUNCTION AS
REGIONAL CENTER LIAISONS WITH
THE DEPLOYMENT OF THESE NEW
STAFF.
IMPROVE OUTCOMES IN ALL THE WAYS
WE CARE ABOUT WELL UNFORTUNATELY
THE ANSWER IS NOT NECESSARILY.
IF THE NEW STAFF OR NOT EMPOWER
TO SOLVE SYSTEMIC ISSUES AND
INDIVIDUAL PROBLEMS THEY WILL
MOSTLY JUST FEED INFORMATION UP
THE FOOD CHAIN AND NOTHING WILL
CHANGE.
IF THE ADDITIONAL STAFF OR NOT
WELL EQUIPPED TO IDENTIFY
PROGRAMMATIC OR STRUCTURAL
CHANGES TO THE REGIONAL CENTER
SYSTEM. TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES
EQUITY TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY NOTHING WILL
CHANGE.
SO HOW WILL WE KNOW FOR
RESTRUCTURING PLAN IS ACTUALLY
WORKING WELL FIRST WE NEED TO
DEFINE MORE CLEARLY.
THE CHANGES WE WANT TO SEE AND
HOLD THE SYSTEM ACCOUNTABLE FOR
ACHIEVING THAT.
INSTEAD OF JUST FOCUSING ON
PUTTING IN MORE POSITIONS AND
MORE FUNDING WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
HOW THIS APPROPRIATION WILL
AFFECT THE OUTCOMES THAT MATTER
TO US.
WE NEED TO ASK HOW MUCH
IMPROVEMENT CAN WE EXPECT TO SEE
AND BY WHAT DATE.
AND WE SHOULD SPECIFY THESE
OUTCOMES AND TIME LINES IN
ADVANCE.
SECOND WE SHOULD ASK THE
DEPARTMENT TO REPORT BACK
ANNUALLY ON A SET OF OUTCOME
MEASURES.
WE PROVIDED SOME OF THESE IDEAS
TO YOUR COMMITTEE AND FINALLY
ANY SIGNIFICANT REORGANIZATION
SHOULD INCLUDE ADDITIONAL
REFORMS THAT PROVIDE FOR MORE
TRANSPARENCY OF DDS AND REGIONAL
CENTERS.
AND WE'VE ALSO PROVIDED SOME
IDEAS TO YOUR COMMITTEE.
SO AS YOU CAN TELL WE SOLVE MANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER THIS
WILL THIS AB REORGANIZATIONS
REALLY CAN IMPROVE THE LIFE OF
MY SON AND OTHERS LIKE HIM --
BUT WE HOPE THAT THESE QUESTIONS
WILL GET ANSWER TO THIS PROCESS
AND WE THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING
HOW IT WILL AFFECT OUR FAMILIES.
THANK YOU.
HI I'M KATY HARBOR AND THE
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
CLIENTS RATES ADVOCACY IT
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
AND WE SUPPORT THE EFFORTS BY
THE DEPARTMENT TO INCREASE THE
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY IN THE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY SYSTEM.
OUT WE ALSO AS AMY INDICATED
APPRECIATE ON THE EFFORTS OF
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
COMMUNITY TO WORK THROUGH ISSUES
TO TRY IMPROVE AND IMPROVE OUR
SYSTEM.
ON THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
RESPONSIVE ON BOTH TO OUR
SUGGESTIONS AS HAS ARCA AND THE
REGIONAL CENTERS -- I THINK THE
RESTRUCTURE REALLY DOES REFLECT
THE CHANGE IN HOW THE DEPARTMENT
AND REGIONAL CENTERS PROVIDE
SERVICES BYUNITING WAS FORMALLY
THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER STREAM
ALONG WITH THE COMMUNITY
SERVICES STREAM.
AS WE PROMOTE A FOCUS ON
COMMUNITY SERVICES LIVING.
UP. ONE OF THE WITH THE
QUESTIONS AS AS MISS MARK
INDICATED IS HOW WILL E KNOW IF
THIS RESTRUCTURE IS SUCCESSFUL
AND I THINK WHAT WE HAVE TO DO
IS COME UP WITH CLICK CLEAR
INDICATORS.
WE NEED TO OUTLINED THOSE
INDICATORS AND OUTLINE A PROCESS
FOR PROVIDING THE LEGISLATURE
WITH DATA ON THOSE INDICATORS ON
A REGULAR POSSIBLY QUARTERLY
BASIS SO THAT WE CAN MONITOR
WHETHER OR NOT THIS RESTRUCTURE
HAS BEEN EFFECTIVE.
AND REALLY RESULTED IN GOOD
OUTCOMES FOR PEOPLE LIKE JUDY
SIGN AND THE OTHER THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND CONSUMERS.
ALONG THOSE LINES -- WE ALSO --
HAVE PROPOSALS ON INTO AREAS TO
PROMOTE TRANSPARENCY IN THE
REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM THE FIRST
ONE IS -- AROUND THE POSTING OF
GUIDELINES PROTOCOLS AND
ASSESSMENT TOOLS LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRED.
REGIONAL CENTERS TO POST ANY
GUIDELINES PROTOCOLS ARE
ASSESSMENT TOOLS RELATED TO
RESPITE AT THE CAP WAS REMOVED
IT HAVINGTHOSE TOOLS AVAILABLE
TO THAT THE PUBLIC WAS VERY
HELPFUL. TO PEOPLE TO BEST
UNDERSTAND HOW TO MAKE THEIR
REQUESTS AND WHAT TYPES OF FACTS
REGIONAL CENTERS WOULD NEED IF
WE WERE ABLE TO POST THOSE FOR
ALL SERVICES THAT WOULD GIVE.
THE PUBLIC ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION SO THAT THEY COULD
BETTER PREPARE FOR A P. P.
MEETINGS AND WORKING WITH THE
REGIONAL CENTER WORKERS.
THE OTHER IS -- TO HAVE REGIONAL
CENTERS PROVIDE A LIST OF AGREED
UPON SERVICES AND SUPPORTS AT
THE END OF AN I. P. P. MEETING.
IN ORDER FOR AYE PP SERVICES TO
BEGAN THE REGIONAL CENTER HAS TO
HAVE A CONSENT FOR SERVICES
SIGNED BY THE CONSUMER OR FAMILY
IF THEY'RE MINORS -- WHAT
HAPPENS NOW IS THAT IN MANY
REGIONAL CENTERS THE SERVICE
COORDINATOR MEETS WITH THE
FAMILY GOES BACK TO HER HIS OR
HER OFFICE DRAFTS AN I. P. P.?
THE I. P. P. IS SUPPOSED TO BE
SENT OUT IN FORTY FIVE DAYS THAT
CAN BE DIFFICULT TO ACHIEVE
GIVEN HIGH CASELOADS AND GIVEN
SERVICE COORDINATOR SHORTAGES --
AND SHORTAGES OF SUPPORT STAFF.
SO IT'S SOME CENTERS THE WAY TO
REMEDY THE S. AND TO NOT HAVE A
LONG GAP IN A SECURING A CONSENT
FOR SERVICES SO SERVICES CAN
BEGIN.
IS HAVING PEOPLE SIGN A BLANK
DOCUMENT ON THE IT'S A CONSENT
FOR SERVICE AS A LAWYER I AM
PARTICULARLY OPPOSED TO PEOPLE
SIGNING BLANK DOCUMENTS.
OF AND ON INSTEAD WHAT AT LEAST
ONE REGIONAL CENTER DOES IS THEY
ACTUALLY FILL OUT OF JUST A
BLANK SHEET OF PAPER AT THE END
OF THE MEETING THAT INCLUDES
SERVICE DURATION FREQUENCY
PROVIDER IF KNOWN.
EACH THE FAMILY GETS A COPY
REGIONAL CENTER KEEPS A COPY
THEY CAN SIGN FOR CONSENT FOR
KNOWN SERVICES.
A QUICK EASY KIND OF CHEAP WAY
TO MAKE SURE EVERYONE HAS THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RIGHT A QUESTION FOR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
OKAY SO WELL I GUESS -- CORRECT
DO YOU WANT TO WE HAVE WRAPS
RESPOND A LITTLE BIT TO WHAT YOU
HEARD AND I THINK PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT MEASURES AND HOUSES.
STRUCTURING GOING TO ACTUALLY
LEAD TO CHANGE FOR THE ACTUAL
CLIENTS SO I KNOW YOU TRUST
SOMEONE YOUR PRESENTATION BUT
MAYBE CAN GET A MORE SPECIFIC
ABOUT SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
WERE RAISED.
NO THANK YOU SENATOR -- WE WHEN
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE REMAIN ENGAGED IN
THE CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR
COMMUNITY YOU SEE WHAT
DELIVERABLES AND HOW THINGSARE
MOVING FORWARD.
AND WHAT SOME OF THE THE
ELEMENTS WITHIN THE RESTRUCTURE
THAT MAY NOT HAVE LIKE A DIRECT
LINK TO OUTCOMES AND MEASURES
AND OTHERS PROBABLY WOULD -- I
LET ME GIVE YOU A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES WITH THE EARLY START
ADDITIONAL STAFF THAT WE HAVE
WITH THAT REALLY START PROGRAM.
WE WOULD BE INCREASE SEEN OUR
OVERSIGHT OF OUR EARLY START
GRANT.
AND MONITORING AS FAR AS WITH
THE REGIONAL CENTERS.
AND TO THE SERVICES IS TO
HOWEVER WE DELIVERING THOSE
SERVICES NOT ONLY WITHIN THE
GRANT.
BUT IT IS ALSO THAN MAKING THE
DIFFERENCE IN TO THOSE FAMILIES
LIVES BECAUSE IF THERE ARE --
ELEMENTS WHERE THERE'S IN NON
COMPLIANCE THAT SIGNIFICANT WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY THOSE
ISSUES EARLIER SO. FOR EXAMPLE
RIGHT NOW WE REVIEW EVERY THREE
YEARS WE WOULD BE ABLE TO DO THE
REVIEW ON AN ANNUAL BASIS -- AS
AN EXAMPLE WE DID HAVE ONE
REGIONAL CENTER WHERE WE WERE
NOTING ON OUR REVIEWS THAT THEY
WERE SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER THAN
THE REST OF THE STATE.
AS FAR AS COMPLIANCE AND BEING
ABLE TO ACHIEVE THE MARKERS THAT
ARE CRITICAL TO NOT ONLY
SERVICES TO BUT TO THE GRANT.
VERY QUICKLY WE'RE ABLE WITHIN
YOU KNOW WHILE WE WERE ABLE TO
MONITOR IT FOR THREE YEARS WHEN
WE DID FIND OUT WE WERE ABLE TO
WORK WITH THE REGIONAL CENTER
THEY QUICKLY -- MADE THE
CORRECTIONS AND CORRECTED IT AND
IT TOOK HIM A LITTLE BIT OF TIME
THIS WOULD BE A REALLY GOOD
EXAMPLE OF IF WE'RE DOING THE
MONITORING ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO SEE
THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO WAIT THREE
YEARS. TO SEE THAT THERE'S A A
PROBLEM OR SOMETHING THAT WERE
NOT SEEN IN A COMPLIANCE SETS AN
EXAMPLE HEALTH AND SAFETY --
REVIEWS WE DO GET A LOT OF
HEALTH AND SAFETY REQUEST THE
TIME FOR US TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
TO BE ABLE TO REVIEW THOSE AND
BE RESPONSIVE AND GET THOSE
RESPONSES BACK TO THE REGIONAL
CENTERS INTO THE COMMUNITY IS
REALLY IMPORTANT.
THAT THOSE ARE VERY TANGIBLE
THINGS THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
DO SO JUST GIVING YOU A COPLE
OF EXAMPLES THAT WE MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO SEE THE BENEFIT DIRECTLY
FOR INDIVIDUALS.
I'M WITHIN THE EARLY START BUT
WE WOULD SEE COMPLIANCE ON A
BROADER SCALE -- SO THERE'S
DEFINITELY SOME THINGS THAT WE
WOULD BE PUTTING FORWARD THAT
WILL BE ABLE -- TO SEE CHANGES
THAT ARE GOING TO BE A BENEFIT
AS A SYSTEM AS A WHOLE THAT
ULTIMATELY IS SPECIFIC TO
CONSUMERS SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND COUPLE MORE
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL -- SO I KNOW THAT --
YOU YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
ACTUALLY THERE'S A CONSERVE ON
US MEANT IN -- SO THE REAL RISK
MANAGEMENT QUALITY ASSURANCE
RIGHT YOURSELF WISHING OFFICE --
WE HAVE POSITIONS IS -- THAT ARE
BEING ADDED -- AND SO FORTH --
IS THAT.
THE IS THAT OFF I MEAN SO
THERE'S THE RISK MANAGEMENT PART
AND I THINK PEOPLE WANT NOT JUST
ABOUT RISK MANAGEMENT BUT YOU
KNOW BECAUSE QUALITY ASSURANCE
RISK MEASURE IN TERMS OF MOVING
FORWARD -- IS IS THAT OFFICE
JUST DEALING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OURS IT ALSO DEALING WITH
POLICIES AND SO FORTH FOR
DIVERSE CONTRACT IS LIKE THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT THE
QUESTION CENTER TODAY -- PART OF
WITH THE THE CHANGE OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS CLOSING
FROM WE HAVE BEEN OPERATING AS
WE HAVEN'T NUMBER TO REGIONAL
CENTERS BY THE WAY YEAH I'M
SORRY.
A AND REGIONAL CENTERS A. SHE'S
RIGHT SO WE HAVE -- WITHIN
HEADQUARTERS WE HAVE THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER DIVISION
AND THEN WE HAVE -- COMMUNITY
SERVICES DIVISION -- SO NOW WITH --
MAKING A CHANGE WITH THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER DIVISION
GOING TO A STATE OPERATED -- WE
REALLY NEED TO TO TAKE A LOOK AT
DO WE REALLY NEED TO HAVE THE
FUNCTIONS VERY SEPARATE.
EVERYTHING SEPARATE FOR RISK
MANAGEMENT QUALITY MANAGEMENT ON
THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER SIDE
AND THEN THE SAME FOR THE
REGIONAL CENTER SIDE WE HAVE YOU
KNOW OUR HR PRACTICES THAT WERE
ON THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER SIDE
WE HAD AT HEADQUARTERS HR.
SO WITH THE RESTRUCTURE WE WOULD
BE CENTRALIZING MANY OF THESE
FUNCTIONSONE OF THOSE CORE
FUNCTIONS IS THE RISK MANAGEMENT
AND QUALITY MANAGEMENT SO WITHIN
THAT OFFICE THAT OFFICE WOULD
HAVE COMPLETE OVERSIGHT.
OF ALL OF THE THE STATE SERVICES
AS WELL AS REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICES KIND OF MONITORING --
THE THE DATA THAT GOES WITH THAT
BUT WITH THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS IT WOULD BE MONITORING
AS FAR AS THE COMPLIANCE WITH
OUR LICENSING REQUIREMENTS AND
AGAIN AS WE'RE MOVING TO THE
STATE OPERATE IN THE COMMUNITY
WE'RE GONNA NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE.
AN OFFICE WITHIN HEADQUARTERS
THAT IS ALSO PAYING ATTENTION --
TO THE QUALITY MEASURES THAT ARE
OCCURRING THERE ONE LAST COMMENT
IS THAN ON THE QUALITY
MANAGEMENT SIDE IS THAT WE DO
HAVE A CONTRACT FOR A NATIONAL
CORE INDICATORS.
BY HAVING A VERY FOCUSED WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO ENHANCE KIND
OF THE ANALYSIS AND
GOING TO BE ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM.
THE OUTCOMES THAT WERE SEEN
WITHIN THE NATIONAL CORE
INDICATORS WHICH IS A DIRECT.
REPORTING TO US ON THE
SATISFACTION OF CONTENT FROM
CONSUMERS AND FAMILIES SO MAKING
THAT LINK AND AGAIN THIS IS NOT
GOING TO BE A SEPARATE SYSTEM.
IT'S EVERYBODY COMING TOGETHER
ONE LAST NOTE IS THAT WE'RE
HAVING IT REPORT TO THE CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR UNDER OUR
RATIONS.
SO IT WOULD NOT BE REPORTING TO
PROGRAM SO WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE A SEPARATE OVERSIGHT FOR
REGIONAL CENTER KIND OF SYSTEM.
SERVICES WHICH IS THE COMMUNITY
SERVICES AS WELL AS THE STATE
OPERATED SERVICES SO WE CAN MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE AN OBJECTIVE
VANTAGE POINT WHEN WE'RE TAKING
A LOOK AT THESE IMPORTANT ISSUES.
AND A NO YOU HAVE A RESEARCH
UNIT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IN
PREVIOUS HEARINGS AS WELL AND
THAT AND ON ONE LEVEL OF COURSE
IS A RESEARCHER MYSELF ALWAYS
EXCITING TO SEE RICHARD UNIT.
BUT I THINK THERE WERE SOME
QUESTIONS WERE RAISED IN THE
PAST -- AND I NOTE THAT WE ARE
ALSO GOING TO BE ADDING MORE
PEOPLE TO THE RESEARCH UNIT AND
THAT -- AND DIZZY AND NINE TIMES
FAVOR RESEARCH UNIT -- I THINK
BUT SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
COME UP IN THE PAST AND PRICE
STILL ELEMENT THERE IN TERMS OF
WHAT ARE WHAT ARE THEY
RESEARCHING AND ARE TO HOW THIS
TOPICS THAT THEIR FOR
RESEARCHING FOCUSING ON GONNA
THEN.
BENEFIT THE THE THE CLIENTS SO --
THAT HOWARD THE HOUSE A RESEARCH
AGENDA BEING SET FOR FOR THIS --
RESEARCH UNIT.
THANK YOU AND AS I SAID --
BRIEFLY MENTIONED THAT WHEN WE
TAKE A LOOK AT OUR RESEARCH
SECTION AND HOW THEY ARE ABLE --
TO PRODUCE AND RICK TAKE A LOOK
AT OUR DATA.
MUCH OF IT WE ALSO WANT TO TAKE
A LOOK AT WHERE WHAT IS OUR KIND
OF MISSING GAPS IN OUR ABILITY
TO COLLECT THE DATA.
SO THE FIRST THING THAT WE WOULD
REALLY WANT THEM TO DO IS TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE THE TIME TO TAKE A
STEP BACK AND CUT IT ANALYZE
WHAT ARE THE SYSTEMS THAT WE'RE
USING TO COLLECT IT.
WHAT IS SOME OF THE DATA THAT'S
GOING TO BE INFORMATIVE TO US
WORK WITH THE DIFFERENT BRANCHES
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT AND THEN
ALSO TAKING A LOOK AT?
KIND OF BROADER WHAT'S GOING TO
BE HELPFUL WE SPEND QUITE A BIT
OF TIME TAKING -- LOOKING AT
SOME OF THE WORK WITH THE
DISPARITY GRANTS BUT I THINK WE
ALSO NEED TO FOCUS SOME
ADDITIONAL EFFORTS RIGHT NOW ON
OUR SAFETY NET.
SO WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK AT AS
WERE BUILDING THE SERVICES WHAT
IS INFORMING US AND LETTING US
KNOW.
THAT THOSE ARE THE SERVICES THAT
ARE NEEDED SO TRACKING AND
UNDERSTANDING WITH THE A. M.
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEW MODEL
SO SERVICE WHETHER IT'S ENHANCE
BE ABLE SUPPORTS HOMES
COMMUNICATE RICE'S HOMES.
STATE OPERATED STAR SERVICES ARE.
MOBILE CRISIS SERVICES HAVE BEEN
IN THE ABILITY TO HAVE A
STRUCTURE RIGHT NOW TO SAY HOW
ARE WE GOING TO SURE THE SUCCESS
OF THOSE -- AND THEN BE ABLE TO
EVALUATE HOW WE WOULD REPLICATED
IF THAT WOULD BE WARRANTED SO
AGAIN IT'S TAKING THAT LINK TO
ASSESSING KIND OF OUR STRUCTURE
OF DATA.
TAKING A LOOK AT HOW WE'RE DOING
THE ANALYSIS OF THAT TAKING A
LOOK AT HOW WE CAN START DOING
THAT MEASURES EARLY ON IS WERE
IMPLEMENTING THESE NEW.
MODELS OF SERVICE AND NEW
INITIATIVES AND THEN ON BEING
ABLE -- TO REPORT BACK AND AND
BE ABLE TO INFORM FUTURE POLICY
DECISIONS OF NEEDED.
OKAY AND THEN -- I ALSO NOTE
THAT IN THE DIAGRAM SO BASICALLY
YOU'RE THE DEPARTMENT'S GOING TO
HAVE CENTURY A PROGRAM SERVICES
PEAS SENATE OPERATIONS AND UNDER
SEPARATE DEBBIE DOCTORS I
PRESUME.
AND I THINK YOU DID SPEAK TO
SOME EXTENT SAMPLE BEFORE TALK
MY QUALITY IMPROVEMENT ARE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A CALL INSURANCE
AND AND THAT KIND OF MONITORING
YOU WANT SOME SEPARATION BUT
SAME TIME I WON YEAH.
BUT BE SURE WE DON'T HAVE A CELL
IS ATION BETWEEN THE PROGRAM
FOLKS IN THE OPERATION FOLKS
THERE'S ACTUALLY IN MANY WAYS --
WHILE SOME THERE MAY BE SOME
OVERSIGHT FUNCTIONS BUT IS
ACTUALLY SUPPOSED TO SUPPORT THE
PROGRAM FOLKS THAT WE DON'T HAVE
THE OPERATIONS FOLKS RUNNING OFF
AND DOING THEIR OWN THING -- AND
THEN DISTRICT CREATING MORE
BURDENS ON THE CLICK ON THE
PROGRAM FOLKS BECAUSE IN A WHILE
SINCE I'M LEGAL I CAN TREAT MORE
LEGAL THINGS TO DO.
AT CETERA SO -- DO YOU SPEAK TO
COORDINATION DALE HOW THE HOUSE
WE'RE GOING -- TO HI.
HOW YOU SEE THE TWO DIVISIONS
AND NOT BECOMING SO AS IT
RELATES TO YOUR FOR TO COME
TOGETHER BUT?
EXACTLY THE TIES THAT YOU SEE TO
BE SURE THAT THE ACTIVITIES OF
THE OPERATIONS FOLKS ARE ARE
RELEVANT TO THE PROGRAM THANKS
AND ANYWAYS -- YEAH.
ABSOLUTELY AND YOU KNOW IT THIS
ACTUALLY IS AN AREA THAT IS.
VERY IMPORTANT TO ME YOU KNOW
WHEN I STARTED THAT THE
DEPARTMENT AS A DEPUTY DIRECTOR
AND THEN CERTAINLY COMING AS A
DIRECTOR.
I HAD A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE
WHEN I CAME TO THE DEPARTMENT I
I HAD NOT WORKED -- AT THE
DEPARTMENT AND SO WHEN I I CAME
IN IT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE WERE NOT
WORKING IN SILOS.
AND SO WE WERE SHARING OF
INFORMATION BECAUSE THAT WAS ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I HAD NOTED
AND PART OF THAT HAD TO DO WITH
THE FUNCTION THAT WE'RE
OPERATING THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER DIVISIONS.
THAT WAS VERY SPECIFIC YOU KNOW
I EIGHT I AM SO PROUD OF THE
WORK THAT OUR STAFF DO AT THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CNTERS YOU KNOW
OUT IN THE COMMUNITY THAT THE
THICK THE WORK THAT THEY'RE
DOING. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
I TEASE THEM A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
IS THAT OFTENTIMES WILL SAY TO
ME OR THEY'LL SAY TO US IS THAT
WELL YOU KNOW ALL OF YOU IT DDS.
AND I KEEP SAYING YOU GUYS ARE
DDS AND IT'S HELPING UNDERSTAND
THAT WE ARE ARE REALLY A TEAM
AND WORKING TOGETHER.
AND SO WORKING THROUGH THE
CULTURE AND MAKING SURE THAT
FOLKS ARE WORKING TOGETHER HAS
REALLY BEEN KIND OF THE THE
MISSION THAT I'VE WORKED ON OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
AND MAKING SURE THAT CROSS WALK
IS HAPPENING SO AN EFFORT THAT
THE WAY THAT WE'RE DOING THAT IS
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE DON'T HAVE A SIDE ROAD SYSTEM.
THAT THEY'RE NOT TALKING THAT
THERE'S COLLABORATIVE WAYS TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
GOING TO BE THAT DIALOGUE.
THAT AS WERE HAVING THE REGIONAL
CENTER STAFF THIS IS VERY TRUE
ALSO WITH OUR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA OFFICE WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WERE VERY GOOD.
AND PROVIDING THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WERE HAVING
THE COLLABORATIVE DISCUSSIONS WE
ARE GOING TO ALSO BE DOING SOME
TECHNOLOGY AS FAR AS MAKING SURE
WE HAVE THE VIDEO CONFERENCING.
GRANTED THAT'S JUST ONE PIECE
BUT WE ALSO HAVE THE SCHEDULE OF
MEETINGS AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE HAVING THE COLLABORATIVE
DISCUSSIONS OF SHARING
INFORMATION. ONE OF THE THINGS
WE ARE DOING IS TAKING A LOOK AT
BRINGING TOGETHER THE
INFORMATION THIS IS WHERE
RESEARCH WILL BE ABLE TO HELP US.
IS SAYING FOR EVERY REGIONAL
CENTER WHAT IS THE INFORMATION
THAT INFORMS US ABOUT WHAT IS
OCCURRING WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO DO THAT ALSO WITHIN OUR STATE
OPERATED SERVICES SO WE WE HAVE
VERY MUCH THOUGHT ABOUT -- WHAT
ARE THE WAYS THAT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE -- PUTTING UP
SYSTEMS THAT ARE GOING TO BE A
BARRIER TO DOING WHAT WE WANT TO
ACCOMPLISH.
OKAY -- ALL RIGHT WELL THE
APPRECIATE THAT -- AND I THINK
YOU KNOW IT -- WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE A I THINK THE THE INCREASE
STAFF FOR MORE OVERSIGHT I THINK
ACTUALLY AND AND TRYING TO GET
MORE CONSISTENCY I KNOW THE MAN
REGIONAL CENTERS TO BE ON
EXCELLENT JOB AND AND AND NAY OF
HAVE VERY INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS
WE'LL SEE HOW WE DISSEMINATE
THAT.
HOW CAN THE STATE PLAY A GREATER
ROLE -- AND ALSO -- WORK MORE
CLOSELY WITH THE REGIONAL
CENTERS I KNOW DEVELOP THE
SURGEON CLOSING DOWN YOU STILL
WILL HAVE A UNIT -- REPORTER
PHIL -- AND THEN THE VARIOUS
OTHER ACTUALLY THE REPLACEMENTS
FOR THEM RIGHT NOW WE HAVE TO BE
SURE THAT'S ALL COORDINATED SO.
AND WE NEED SURE STAFF FOR THAT
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WELL THANKS VERY MUCH
AND I THINK WE'RE NOW MOVING ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER FIVE SEVEN
THANKS VERY MUCH -- PALACES WELL
FOR THE ISSUES THAT YOU'VE
RAISED AS WELL.
OKAY SO ISSUE NUMBER FIVE IS A
FEDERAL HAS A B. C. P. THE SAME
PROPOSAL FEDERAL CLAIMS
REIMBURSEMENT SYSTEM PROJECT
[inaudible]
OKAY ALL.
ACTUALLY FIVE WE HAVE SOME NEW
TV PEOPLE THE TABLE THE COULD
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES -- ZERO
OKAY I THINK.
RON ROBINETTE WITH DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE THANK YOU
APPRECIATE IT OKAY.
RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- THE
THE OF FEDERAL CLAIMS
REIMBURSEMENT PROJECT IS THE
AGENDA.
CORRECTLY POINTS OUT IS A
REPLACEMENT SYSTEM FOR A THIRTY
SIX YEAR OLD LEGACY SYSTEM -- V.
THAT PROCESSES -- FEDERAL CLAIMS
REIMBURSEMENTS.
IN.
THE CURRENT YEAR.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN OUR
FEDERAL CLAIMS ARE PROJECTED TWO
POINT EIGHT BILLION.
GIVEN THE AGE OF THE SYSTEM THE
DEPARTMENT HAS DIFFICULTY
MAINTAINING AND PROGRAMMING THE
SYSTEM -- IT'S WRITTEN IN
NATURAL LANGUAGE PROGRAMMING.
WHICH IS BECOMING INCREASINGLY
DIFFICULT TO FIND INDIVIDUALS
WHO.
ARE FAMILIAR WITH AND TRAINED IN
THAT LANGUAGE -- AS A RESULT
WE'RE EXPECTING TO SPEND
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE CURRENT
YEAR -- TO ASSIST WITH SYSTEM
MAINTENANCE -- IN ADDITION THE
CURRENT SYSTEM LIMITATIONS
PREVENT AUTOMATED IN TIMELY
RECONCILIATION ACTIVITIES.
IN THIS REQUIRES MANUAL
WORKAROUNDS.
THESE MANUAL PROCESS IS PREVENT
TIMELY -- BILLINGS AND AS A
RESULT -- WE HAVE LEFT
APPROXIMATELY. THIRTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS ON THE TABLE ANNUALLY.
IN ON RECOVERED REIMBURSEMENTS.
THE THE DEPARTMENT'S GOAL FOR
THE THE GOALS FOR THE NEW
PROJECT ARE WE HAVE THREE GOALS
AND WE WANT TO MAXIMIZE.
A FEDERAL FUNDING PARTICIPATION.
WE WANT TO REDUCE THE FISCAL
IMPACT TO THE STATE OF
MAINTAINING THE EXISTING SYSTEM.
AND WE WANT TO ESTABLISH A
FRAMEWORK THAT WILL SUPPORT.
ALL OUR FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT
PROGRAMS THAT ARE ADMINISTERED
BY THE APARTMENT.
AS YOU CHEN ALSO POINTS OUT.
THE DEPARTMENT RECEIVED -- THE
STAGE TO APPROVAL. FOUR AT WHICH
IS THE ALTERNATIVES ANALYSIS OF
THE ODJICK LIFECYCLE.
AND THAT THAT APPROVAL WAS
RECEIVED FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY IN
AUGUST.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN OF SO WE'VE BEEN
AUTHORIZED TO PROCEED WITH
STAGES THREE AND FOUR TO PLAN
FOR SOLICITATION AND AND PROVIDE
INPUT YOUR CONTRACTOR.
WE EXPECT TO RELEASE A REQUEST
FOR PROPOSAL IN SEPTEMBER OF
TWENTY NINETEEN IN AWARD THE
CONTRACT IN THE FALL OF TWENTY
TWENTY WE EXPECT THAT THE SYSTEM
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
WILL TAKE APPROXIMATELY. TWO
YEARS FROM THE AWARD OF THE
CONTRACT -- THE AGENDA ALSO S..
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS ABOUT
[inaudible]
ON ANY AFFECTS ON PROJECT COSTS
DURING -- STAGES THREE AND FOUR
OF THE PROJECT APPROVAL
LIFECYCLE -- WE WE DON'T
ANTICIPATE THAT ANY OF THE STEPS
THAT ARE REQUIRED DURING EITHER
STAGE THREE OR FOUR WILL AFFECT
PROJECT COSTS -- THE ACTIVITIES
THAT OUR CURRENT STAGE THREE AND
FOUR FOCUSED ON PREPARING THE
SOLICITATION PACKAGE.
AND SELECTING A PROJECT VENDOR.
PROJECT COST ESTIMATES IN
INFORMATION WERE GATHERED.
DURING THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
STAGE -- TO ALTERNATIVES
ANALYSIS PROJECT [inaudible]
SO -- IS STAGE THREE CONSISTS OF
SOLUTION DEVELOPMENT WHICH IS
FINALIZING -- PROJECT DETAILS
SUCH AS THE CONTRACT STATEMENT
OF WORK AND THE SOLICITATION
PACKAGE -- AN THEN THIS WORK
WILL HELP PREPARE US FOR OUR
STAGE.
FOR IN STAGE FOR THE PROJECT
RATING IS AN APPROVALS -- PHASE
OF THE PROJECT -- IS IT'S
BASICALLY THE PROCUREMENT FACE.
THE WILL RELEASE A REQUEST FOR
PROPOSAL WILL INTERACT WITH
INTERESTED BIDDERS AND EVALUATE
PROPOSALS AND EVENTUALLY --
AWARD A CONTRACT.
ONCE WE'VE RECEIVED APPROVAL
FROM THE DEPARTMENT A TECHNOLOGY.
THE AGENDA ALSO LAST OF WHETHER
WE ANTICIPATED ANY OF THE
INFORMATION GATHERED.
DURING A STAGE FOR OF THE POWER
PROCESS WILL RESULT IN
ADDITIONAL COSTS AND AGAIN WE
DON'T SEE THAT HAPPENING BECAUSE
STAGE FOUR IS THE PROCUREMENT.
OF PORTION OF IT THE BASELINE
SCOPE OF THE PROJECT THAT THE
TIMELINE THE COSTS WILL BE SET
BY THAT POINT.
SO WE DON'T EXPECT WOULD WE
EXPECT TO USE THAT INFORMATION
TO GO OUT TO BID AND WE DON'T
EXPECT PROJECT COST TO CHANGE AT
THAT TIME.
HEY COME IT'S FAMILIAL MEDIC
ALEJO -- WE AGREE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT IN THE IMPORTANCE OF
MODERNIZING THIS I. T. SYSTEM SO
WITHOUT REGARD TO THE MERITS OF
THE PARTICULAR PROPOSAL -- YOU
MAY BE AWARE THAT OUR OFFICE HAS
EXPRESSED SOME CONCERNS ABOUT A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT I. T.
PROJECTS ACROSS DEPARTMENTS IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
THERE ARE SEVEN OF THEM.
THAT ARE REQUESTING ESSENTIALLY
THE FULL DOLLAR AMOUNT THE FULL
MULTI DOLLAR -- MULTI YEAR
DOLLAR AMOUNTS -- TO FINISH THE
I. T. PROJECTS THE THE FULL
DESIGN AND IMPLEMENTATION.
WHAT WE WOULD POINT OUT IS IT'S
VERY HARD FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
HAVE AN IMPORTANT OVERSIGHT
FUNCTION IF THEY'RE BEING ASKED
TO PROVIDE AN AUTHORIZED ALL OF
THE FUNDING BEFORE THEY HAVE THE
BENEFIT OF SEEING?
THE STAGES THREE AND FOUR
RESULTS AND IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE -- THE CONTRACT WOULD NOT
BE AWARDED UNTIL THE FALL OF
TWENTY TWENTY WHICH IS NOT THIS
UPCOMING FISCAL YEAR IT'S THE
FISCAL YEAR AFTER THAT.
SO WE THINK.
YOU KNOW WITHOUT STALLING THE
DEPARTMENT -- THE LEGISLATURE
COULD APPROVE A SINGLE YEAR OF
FUNDING FOR THE PLANNING --
COSTS IN NINETEEN TWENTY N. THE
DEPARTMENT COULD COME BACK NEXT
YEAR WITH THE PROPOSAL FOR THE
FIRST YEAR OF IMPLEMENTATION
FUNDING THEY MAY STILL NOT HAVE --
HAVE -- NECESSARILY A MORE
PRECISE ESTIMATE OF COSTS AND
STILL JUST BE PUTTING OUT THE
SOLICITATION FOR BID AT THAT
TIME.
BUT WE EXPECT THEY WILL KNOW
MORE ABOUT -- THE PROJECT IN
GENERAL FROM CONDUCTING THE
STAGE.
THREE OF THE PROJECT APPROVAL
LIFECYCLE PROCESS AND THE LAST
POINT I WOULD.
WANT TO MAKE IS THAT BEFORE
GIVING THEIR FINAL APPROVAL
BEFORE THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE GIVE THEIR FINAL
APPROVAL TO ANY.
IT PROJECT THEY BENEFIT FROM
SEEING ALL FOUR STAGES OF THE
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE WHERE
IS IN THIS PROPOSAL THE
LEGISLATURE'S BEING ASKED TO
GIVE THAT.
FINAL APPROVAL.
WITHOUT THAT BENEFIT.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
COMMENTS ALL RIGHT -- ACTUALLY
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE KNOWLEDGE
AT THE MOMENT THANK YOU CENTER
PAN A YES JUST REALLY BRIEFLY
THE OPEN AND COMPETITIVE BID
PROCESS THAT WILL BE DONE DURING
STAGE FOR WHEN THE SOLICITATION
IS GOING TO BE RELEASED -- IT
MAY IMPACT THE FINAL COST -- THE
PROJECTS THAT HAVE COMPLETED ALL
FOUR STAGES OF THE PROJECT
APPROVAL BY CYCLE EIGHTEEN OF
THEM -- THE COSTER ACTUALLY
TRENDING DOWNWARD TEY'RE
ACTUALLY COMING IN AT 8% LESS.
THAN THE ESTIMATES THAT ARE
PROVIDED IN STAGE TIM.
AND A REMINDER THAT WHEN WE
ADOPTED THE PROJECT TO POOL IFE
CYCLE IN -- TWENTY SIXTEEN IT IT.
MODIFIED THE WAY THAT WE APPROVE
PROJECTS AND SO MOST OF THE TIME
INVESTMENT DECISIONS ARE
ACTUALLY MADE.
AFTER THE MARKET RESEARCH IS
DONE AND SUBSTANTIATED LIKE THE
DEPARTMENT HAS DONE IN STAGE --
TWO ALTHOUGH THE CONTRACT WON'T
BE EXECUTED WHERE THERE'S BOOTS
ON THE GROUND FOR THE
CONTRACTORS TO COME HELP BUILD
THE NEW SYSTEM.
WE ARE LOOKING AT A NOTICE OF
INTENT TO AWARD IN MARCH OF NEXT
YEAR.
AND SO ANY DELAY TO THE PROJECT
FUNDING I WOULDN'T WANT.
ANY OF THAT TO IMPACT THE
SOLICITATION PROCESS AND
POSSIBLY DISCOURAGE VENDORS FROM
BETTING.
ON ON THIS PROPOSAL -- REMINDER
OF SOME OF THE CHECK POINTS THAT
WE HAVE.
IF THE PROJECT COSTS COME IN
DURING STAGE FOR FOR THE FINAL
FINAL PROJECT COST.
AT OVER FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WAS ESTIMATED IN STATES --
TO BEEN THERE'S A A CAUSE FOR
PAWS AND REFLECTION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AS TO HOW WE WOULD
MOVE FORWARD.
CANCERS PLANNING DOLLARS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS PROPOSAL
THE DEPARTMENT IS REQUIRED ON A
QUARTERLY BASIS TO SUBMIT A
PROJECT EXPENDITURE REPORT TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE -- SO WE
CAN SEE HOW THEY'RE EXPENDING
THESE THESE PLANNING DOLLARS.
AND ONCE THE PROJECT COMPLETES
ALL FOUR STAGES OF THE PROJECT
APPROVAL BY CYCLE.
THE DEPARTMENT WILL BE REQUIRED
TO SUBMIT ON A MONTHLY BASIS A
PROJECT STATUS REPORT ON HOW
THEY THINK THINGS ARE GOING WITH
THE PROJECT.
AND ALSO THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY.
A WILL BE FURNISHING AN
INDEPENDENT PROJECT OVERSIGHT
REPORT.
IF THE PROJECT COST ARE 10% OVER
WHAT WAS BASS LINED -- AND THEN
THE LEGISLATURE WOULD BE WOULD
BE NOTIFIED AT AT THAT POINT
OTHERWISE -- COST MANAGEMENT IS
DONE AT THE DEPARTMENT AND WITH
THE PERMANENT -- TECHNOLOGIES
OVERSIGHT.
OKAY SO SO JUST.
THIS IS THE CLARIFY IS THE FIRST
OF ALL -- THE NATURE OF THIS
PROJECT CLEARLY OF A VERY OLD
SYSTEM WE HAVE TO REPLACE IT --
IT IS [inaudible]
IS SO.
SOMEONE TOLD THE NEW SYSTEM --
IS DO YOU VIEWS THE NATURE OF
THE SYSTEM THAT BASICALLY SAYS.
WE'RE JUST GONNA GO AND BUILD
ONE NEW SYSTEM IS IT GOING TO BE
MORE MODULAR I DON'T THAT DAY I
MEAN I I THEY WERE.
BASICALLY STATES YOU SO YOU
DON'T HAVE THE SCOPE SO I'M JUST
LIKE WHAT KIND OF SYSTEM ARE WE
LOOKING AT PRODUCING.
THEREFORE DOES IT THE CELL.
YEAH THAT THAT THE ACTUAL
BUILDER THE SYSTEM IN THE
RECOMMENDED ALTERNATIVE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS -- PUT FORTH IS
POSTED ON OUR ON OUR WEBSITE AND
YOU CAN SEE THE DETAILS OF THAT
OUR STAFF CAN SEE THE DETAILS OF
THAT -- THIS APPROACH IS
ACTUALLY A MODULAR APPROACH LIKE
YOU'RE SUGGESTING -- THEY HAVE
SUBSTANTIATED THE THE MARKET
RESEARCH BY REACHING OUT TO
OTHER STATES TO SEE HOW THEY'RE
DOING THIS IN THE SYSTEM.
AND THEN ALSO LOOKED AT OTHER
PLATFORMS THAT OTHERS STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENTS HAVE USED
TO SUBSTANTIATE THE COST.
IN THE APPROACH ON THE PROJECT
SO THEN ASSISTED ITS MODULAR DO
YOU EXPECT TO JUST GO OUT FOR A
ONE VENDOR TO DO ALL THE MODULES
ARE WE LOOKING AT THE DIFFERENT
YOU KNOW.
THE DATES FOR DIFFERENT MODULES.
THE THE PROCUREMENT APPROACH
THAT THEY'VE SELECTED IN AND
WANTS DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY
AGREES WITH IS A REQUEST FOR
PROPOSAL.
THAT COULD BE THAT WAY AND
VENDOR COMES BACK WITH HERE'S MY
PRODUCT AND AND THIS IS HOW
WE'RE GOING TO CONFIGURE THE THE
THE PRODUCT -- MULTIPLE VENDORS
CAN CAN.
BIND TOGETHER AND SUBMIT A
PROPOSAL THAT TAKES PIECES OF OF
ONE PARTICULAR FUNCTIONALITY AND
ATTACH IT TO ANOTHER PART.
ANOTHER PARTICULAR TECHNOLOGY SO --
IT'S IT'S OPEN AND COMPETITIVE
IN HOW THE APPROACH FOR THE
PROJECT AND AND ULTIMATELY THE
SOLUTION.
I WILL BE IDENTIFIED.
AND IN TERMS OF THE MAINTENANCE
OF THE SYSTEM AFTER TO PRODUCE
THAT COULD BE A SEPARATE
CONTRACTORS THAT PART OF THIS
PACKAGE.
THE THE MAINTENANCE COSTS ARE
ARE IN THIS PACKAGE OKAY.
SOI GUESS THE OTHER.
SO -- SO WHAT THE LA --
PRESENTED US SO WILL HAPPEN IS
THAT YOU'RE STILL DOING STAGE
THREE WHICH IS THE PRESIDENT
SOMEWAY SEVENTY CERTIFY THE
PASSAGE TO BUT EXACTLY FIGURE
OUT WHAT YOU NEED AND THE MORE
DETAILS CORRECT AND THEN STAGE
FORCED PROCUREMENT.
CORRECT THE STATE'S THREE IT'S
IS PRIMARILY BUILDING THE
SOLICITATION IN THIS CASE THE
REQUEST FOR PROPOSAL PACKAGE
OKAY AND HOW AND HOW THAT
PACKAGE WILL BE EVALUATED ONCE
BIDS ARE SUBMITTED.
OKAY AFTER STATES THREE APPROVAL --
AT THE VERY BEGINNING STAGE
FORCE WHEN THE SOLICITATION
ACTUALLY HITS THE STREET OKAY
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IN SEPTEMBER OF NINETEEN
RIGHT THE R. P..
IT'S GOING TO GO OUT.
PEOPLE RESPOND CELLS THERE'S A
QUESTION SO I SO I GUESS THERE'S
A QUESTION THE DAILY -- RAISED
ABOUT WELL.
YOU'RE NOT GOING -- AWARD.
UNTIL FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY
WHATEVER BUDGET WE PASS NEXT
YEAR WILL GO ON THE PLACE IN
JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY SO
CERTAINLY MONTHS BEFORE -- I
MEAN WE CAN GUESS CENTURY DAVE
WE'VE BEEN OUT HOW MUCH THE
PEOPLE PAID -- FOR WHY DO WE
NEED TO DECIDE WHERE IT'S AT I
THINK THERE'S A WILLINGNESS
ALLOCATE THE PLANNING MONEY AND
SO FORTH -- THIS YEAR'S THE
REASON WHY WE NEED.
TO BUDGET THE MONEY FOR NEXT
BUDGET YEAR FOR THIS NOW.
VERSES NEXT YEAR WHEN YOU HAVE A
BETTER IDEA IF YOU DON'T HAVE
THE BIDS IN HAND SO YOU MIGHT IT
YOU'LL KNOW WHAT THE HIGH DID A
LITTLE BIT AND SO FORTH SO YOU
HAVE A BETTER IDEA OF EXACTLY
HOW MUCH MONEY WE REALLY NEED.
TO BUDGET FOR THIS -- I WOULD
JUST SAY FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGIES PERSPECTIVE IF
THERE'S ANY EFFICIENCIES TO BE
GAINED DURING THE SOLICITATION
PROCESS.
AND THIS CONTRACT IS READY TO
AWARD WITHIN THE NEXT BUDGET
YEAR -- IN THIS CASE ACCORDING
TO OUR OUR CURRENT PROJECT
SCHEDULE -- IN IN MARCH OF NEXT
YEAR.
THEN THE CONTRACT WOULD BE HELD
FOR THREE MONTHS UNTIL THE NEXT
BUDGET YOUR TOES SO SO YOU'RE
SAYING THAT DO YOU ANTICIPATE
YOU MIGHT EVEN BE ABLE YOU MIGHT
EVEN SIDE TOWARD THIS. FOR FOUR
AND MARCH.
I THERE ARE THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT DURING THE
PROCUREMENT PROCESS WE MIGHT
FIND SOME EFFICIENCIES AND BE BE
ABLE TO AWARD THE CONTRACT AND
GET CONTRACTORS ONBOARD.
BEFORE THE END OF THE BUDGET
YEAR.
OKAY AND THE OKAY YES FINANCE NO
I WOULD JUST.
KIND OF ADD ONS THAT I THINK I
THINK WHAT YOU'RE HEARING IS IS
THAT.
WITH THE FULL PROJECT COSTS
BUILT IN A IN THIS PROPOSAL IT
PROVIDES US THE FLEXIBILITY TO
THE EXTENT THAT THERE ARE SOME
EFFICIENCIES THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS. TO ALLOW US -- TO
PROCEED WITH THE PROJECT --
SOLICITATION EARLIER THAN
ANTICIPATED OKAY -- FAN LA --
MEAN THAT IT'S THAT THAT HAPPENS
TO BE HAVE MECHANISMS IN PLACE
IF WE GAVE THE MONEY NOW THE
STILL STE CHECK OUT WHAT THEY'RE
DOING AND THEY ACTUALLY DECIDE
THE WARD OF BEFORE.
I GUESS AND OF JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY I MEAN.
YEAH I MEAN ONE POSSIBILITY.
WOULD BE TO ADD PROVISIONAL --
BUT YOUR BILL LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD REQUIRE A NOTIFICATION OF
THE LEGISLATURE IN APPROVAL BY
THE LEGISLATURE AND BEFORE THE
FUNDS ARE -- SPENT -- BEFORE THE
FUNDS ARE PROVIDED TO THE
DEPARTMENT TO SPEND ON IT
PROJECT.
OKAY THAT WOULD MEAN THAT ALL OF
THIS IS ABOUT TRYING TO ENSURE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS A ROLE
IN OVERSIGHT AND HAS MORE
PRECISE INFORMATION ABOUT COST
AND SCOPE INTO AND TIMELINE --
SO THE TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE
IS A MECHANISM TO INVOLVED.
THIS IS A THING ON THE TECHNICAL
SIDE I MEAN WE WE TRUSTS.
THE DEPARTMENT SO FORTH WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE NIT PICKY ABOUT THE
TECHNICAL SIDE BUT YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES WE HEAR FROM
STAKEHOLDERS RIGHT WHEN THE FILE
AND SOLICITATION COMES OUT
SIGNALS A WAIT A MINUTE THIS
THING IS GOING TO BE.
YOU KNOW INCLUDING SOMETHING
THAT WE THINK RIGHT IT COULD BE
AN AGENCY TO S. OF WORK WITH
THAT IT COULD BE WHATEVER I KNOW
YOU WENT THROUGH THIS PROCESS
BUT STAGE.
TWO YOU MIGHT HEAR FROM SOMEONE
AND FRANKLY WE WANT TO BE ABLE.
TO FIND PEOPLE CONTACT US VIA
THE FEEL THE IT'S LIKE TALK TO
YOU AND FIGURED OUT AND SO FORTH
SO BUT BEFORE WE COMMIT
OURSELVES TO A SYSTEM.
BY ACTUALLY WARNING THE MONEY
THAT MAY ACTUALLY -- BE MRS
THEY'LL HAVE HAVE A COMPONENT
ARE MISSING SOMETHING OR HAVE
SOMETHING THAT THERE'S MAJOR
CONCERNS ABOUT SO I THINK THAT
SERVE OUR OVERSIGHT ROLE.
SO I JUST WANNA BE SURE WE HAVE
SOME MECHANISM IN PLACE AGAIN.
FRANKLY THIS IS NOT THE BIGGEST
IT SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE TO DEAL
WITH ALTHOUGH CERTAINLY VERY
IMPORTANT ONE FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE HERE IN THIS AUDIENCE AND
WEEKS FIVE BE SURE THAT WE HAVE
A BEFORE WE ACTUALLY COMMIT THE
MONIES THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS.
NOW WITH GRANT THE MONEY BEFORE
YOU COMMIT.
THAT WE HAVE A MECHANISM BY
WHICH WE CAN HAVE THAT DIALOGUE
WITH -- THE DEPARTMENT AND
TECHNOLOGY YOU BEFORE WE
ACTUALLY AWARD -- THE END IS
THAT IT'S NOT JUST FOR THE
PROGRAM ITSELF I MEAN PROGRAMS
INVOLVE THEIR INTERFACES IT
INVOLVES MAINTENANCE INVOLVED.
AT THEIR ON GOING COMMITMENTS
BEFORE YOU SIGN I THINK WE WANT
TO BE SURE.
THERE ARE CONCERNS ARE REYES
THAT THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY HAVE
THAT DIALOGUE.
BEFORE THE FINAL MONIES SIGNED
OFF ON AND I WOULD JUST ADD THAT --
AS NOTED THAT THERE'S QUARTERLY
EXPENDITURE UPDATES THAT ARE
PROVIDED THE FINANCE -- THROUGH
THE PROJECT I'M -- PLANNING
PROCUREMENT AND AND ALSO --
THERE'S DEFINITELY GIVEN THE
TIME WHEN THERE'S OPPORTUNITY
NEXT SPRING TO HAVING THESE
DISCUSSIONS WITHOUT COMMITTEE
LOW YEAH AND AND IT'S SO I MEAN
I THINK THAT'S HAVING.
WE WILL BE SURE THERE'S BEFORE
IT'S ACTUALLY AWARDED NOW IF YOU
DECIDE TO WARD EARLY YOU'RE
SAYING YOU PLAN ACTUALLY IS FALL
BUT IF THERE'S NOT THE ONLY ONE
BE HELPFUL IF THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BOARD EARLY AND
GET A BETTER DEAL.
I MEAN LIKE TO SEE THAT HAPPEN --
BUT ALSO A BE SURE THAT.
WHO IS FOR THE WAR IT'S ACTUALLY
AWARDED THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
A CHANCE -- TO IF THERE IS A
REASON TO WAY AND TO BE ABLE TO
WAY AND HAVE THAT.
DIALOGUE AND ALSO WAS THERE'S
ADJUSTMENTS AND WE MADE BEFORE
HIM IT'S HARD TO ADJUST THE
CONTRACT A FEW SIDE RIGHT NOW
YOU CAN BUT IT'S USUALLY A LOT
MORE EXPENSIVE CHANGE ORDERS OR
IS EXPENSIVE BETTER DO IT UP TO
THE FRONT END.
AND HOPEFULLY DIRT THAT WILL
COME UP AND THAT'S NOT AN ISSUE
AT ALL.
RIGHT OKAY.
I MEAN I KNOW THE BIG GIANT WHEN
WITH THE OTA SALAS TWENTY TWENTY
THREE RIGHT NOW ALL THE PIECES
WE WILL BRING THAT UP AGAIN --
BUT BUT BUT YOU KNOW THIS ONE
THE I MEAN IT'S AN OLD SYSTEM
AND WE'RE REPLACING IT AND IT
NEEDS TO BE REPLACED BUT IT
OBVIOUSLY AFFECTS ALL OF ALL
HAVE AN EFFECT ON A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN THIS AREA.
YEAH AND JUST ONE MORE THING --
IS IS THAT YOU KNOW TO THE
EXTENT AND AS NOTED -- BY MISTER
DOYLE THAT THERE WILL BE SOME
EFFICIENCIES AND ADDITIONAL
CLAIMING THAT WOULD BE --
ENABLED BY REPLACING THE SYSTEM
AND TO THE EXTENT WE CAN GET
THIS ONLINE SOONER THIS THE
SOONER THAT THE DEPARTMENT CAN
START RECOVERING THOSE COSTS OF
F. B..
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO WE'LL FIGURE THAT
OUT FOR THE FINAL BUDGET TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN ALL BE ON
THE SAME PAGE ON THAT.
ALL RIGHT ANYTHING ELSE THAN ON
THE SAN.
OKAY THANKS AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH ALWAYS APPRECIATE HAVING TO
PARTY KNOWLEDGE HERE WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT IT CELL.
THANK YOU.
OKAY -- ISSUE NUMBER SIX IT'S
THE OVERVIEW THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER CLOSURES AYE.
YES THANK YOU A SENATOR PAN -- I
I PROVIDED SOME -- CONTACTS A
LITTLE BIT EARLIER BUT AGAIN
JUST -- TO CHER AGAIN THAT -- WE
ARE VERY CLOSE TO MOVING THE
LAST INDIVIDUALS -- THAT HAVE
BEEN PART OF THE CLOSURE THAT
WAS ANNOUNCED IN -- TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN OF NOTE AGAIN THAT WE
STARTED AT EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY
SIX AT THAT TIME CURRENTLY WE
HAVE A CLUE -- ASIAN FOR
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE PART OF OUR
CULTURE -- FOR FAIRVIEW IMPORTER
BILL TOGETHER IT'S A TOTAL OF
NINETY TWO INDIVIDUALS -- I JUST
KIND OF WANT TO SHARE ALSO THE
EFFORT AND THE COMMITMENTS THAT
EVERYBODY IS MADE IN DEVELOPING
THE RESOURCES IN THE COMMUNITY
TO SUPPORT THE INDIVIDUALS.
AS FOCUSED ON RESIDENTIAL
SERVICES FOCUSED ON SUNDAY
SERVICES THERE'S BEEN A NUMBER
OF THINGS ALSO SOME VERY UNIQUE
THINGS HAS TO DO WITH MEDICAL
WITH -- FQHCS AND AND LOOKING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S AN
EXPANSION OF SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES -- WE DID HAVE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF RESIDENTIAL HOMES
FOR BOTH SO NO MATTER --
PORTERVILLE AND FAIRVIEW -- WE
DEVELOPED A HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN
HOMES AS PART OF THE CLOSURE.
AND THAT PROVIDED A CAPACITY OF
ABOUT -- SEVEN HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS SO COMING TO THE END
OF THIS PROCESS -- WE'LL BE BACK
NEXT YEAR AND THAT THAT TIME
WILL PROBABLY BE REPORTING TO
YOU THAT WE HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
TRANSITIONED EVERYBODY TO THE
COMMUNITY SO I DID JUST KIND OF
WANT TO PROVIDE TO THAT UPDATE.
THERE'S TWO QUESTIONS ON THE
AGENDA -- TO DISCUSS THE STATUS
OF THE LAND AND PROPERTY AND
MISTER DOYLE WILL BE PROVIDING
RESPONSES FOR THOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ARM SO WE
JUST WANTED TO PROVIDE A BRIEF
UPDATE ON THE THREE CENTERS THAT
ARE CLOSING -- CINEMA
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER -- IS.
BUDGETED IN THE CURRENT YEAR.
OUT TO HAVE JURISDICTION TURNED
OVER TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES ON JUNE
THIRTIETH OF THIS YEAR -- THE
PROPERTY IS CURRENTLY IN ONE
SHUT DOWN.
MEANING THE DEPARTMENT CONTINUES
TO MAINTAIN THE CAMPUS -- WE
CONTINUE TO OPERATE THE CENTRAL
PLANT PROVIDE SECURITY AND FIRE
SUPPRESSION SERVICES.
HOWEVER THE ADMINISTRATION IN
LEGISLATIVE MEMBERS REPRESENTING
CINEMA COUNTY.
RECENTLY REACHED AN AGREEMENT TO
CONTINUE OPERATION OF CINNAMON
IN A SIMILAR WARM SHUT DOWN FACE --
FOR A THREE YEAR PERIOD THAT
WOULD END IN -- TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO TGS WILL AS
PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET TAKEOVER JURISDICTION THE
PROPERTY JULY FIRST OF THIS YEAR.
BUT THE WILL ENTER INTO AN
INTERAGENCY AGREEMENT WITH DDS
WE'LL BE PROVIDING THE STAFF
SUPPORT TO CONTINUE THE
OPERATION OF THE THE CAMPUS --
DTS IS ALSO DURING THIS THREE
YEAR PERIOD GOING TO BEGIN THE
ADDITIONAL THE COMMISSION OF THE
THE CAMPUS.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE -- REMOVING
FUEL STORAGE TANKS WE HAVE -- A
FUEL STATIONS THAT ARE GONNA BE
THAT NEED TO BE REMOVED.
AND THEY'RE ALSO GOING TO BEGIN --
DEMOLISHING THE SWIMMING POOLS
BECAUSE VAPE PRESENT BOTH A
PUBLIC HEALTH VANDA A SAFETY
RISK -- INTO SPRING FINANCE
LETTER TO THE LEGISLATURE D. G.
S. ESTIMATED THAT THE TOTAL
COSTS FOR THE THREE YEAR PERIOD
WOULD BE FORTY THREE POINT SEVEN
MILLION GENERAL FUND.
AND WOULD REQUIRE THIRTY SIX
POSITIONS IN SUPPORT.
ON THE FORTY THREE POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLAR COST ALSO
INCLUDES THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION.
A GENERAL FUND FOR CINEMA COUNTY
TO CONDUCT UP ONE TIME LAND USE
PLANNING PROCESS -- THEN AT
FAIRVIEW DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER WE
EXPECT THE LAST RESIDENT TO
TRANSITION INTO COMMUNITY LIVING
BY DECEMBER OF THIS YEAR.
OF THE FAIRVIEW CAMPUS WILL GO
INTO A SIMILAR WARM SHUT DOWN
MODE EFFECTIVE.
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
AND WE PLAN TO TURN OVER
JURISDICTION THE PROPERTY.
OR AT LEAST PORTIONS OF IT TO D.
G. S. EFFECTIVE JULY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY WE DO EXPECT TO
RETAIN -- V..
PORTIONS OF THE CAMPUS THAT
INCLUDE HARBOR VILLAGE WHICH IS
A MIXED USE HOUSING COMMUNITY --
THE NEW A STABILIZATION TRAINING --
ASSISTANCE AND REINTEGRATION
HOMES THE STAR HOMES.
THAT ARE BEING DEVELOPED ON MARK
LANE.
AND THEN THE TWENTY ACRE
PROPERTY SIDE THAT.
IS -- COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS
SHANNON'S MOUNTAIN.
SO WE WE INTEND TO RETAIN
JURISDICTION OVER THOSE PORTIONS
OF THE CAMPUS -- V. ARM.
AS FAR AS PORTABLE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER.
V. SECURE TREATMENT PROGRAM WILL
CONTINUE ONE THAT'S THE THE
PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES.
SERVICES TO INDIVIDUALS IN A
HIGHLY STRUCTURED AND SECURE
SETTING.
AND IT WILL REMAIN IN OPERATION
AFTER THE GENERAL TREATMENT AREA
CLOSES -- WHICH WE EXPECT TO
HAPPEN DURING THE SAME CALENDAR
YEAR -- IN THE ADMINISTRATION IS
CURRENTLY EXAMINING ALTERNATE
USES FOR THE CAMPUS [inaudible]
THE THE AGENDA ALSO ASKED FOR AN
UPDATE ON SHANNON'S MOUNTAIN --
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
ON BY DEVELOPING A PER WE'VE WE
START WE ISSUED AN RFP FOR
DEVELOPER.
IN DECEMBER THERE WAS ONE
DEVELOPER THAT SUBMITTED A
PROPOSAL THE DEVELOPERS PROPOSAL
WAS RESPONSIVE -- A END.
IT WHEN IT WAS SCORED IT WAS IT
WAS FOUND TO BE COMPLIANT WITH
THE NEEDS OF THE THE PROJECT
PROPOSAL -- BUT ON JANUARY
FIFTEENTH OF THIS CURRENT YEAR.
THE GOVERNOR ISSUED HIS
EXECUTIVE ORDER -- ZERO SIX
NINETEEN THAT'S THE ORDER THAT
REQUIRES AMONG OTHER THINGS FOR
D. G. S. TO CONDUCT.
A COMPREHENSIVE SURVEY OF STATE
PROPERTY TO DETERMINE.
BOB POSSIBLE USES FOR ON
ALTERNATE HOUSING AND LOW INCOME
HOUSING [inaudible]
AND SO AS A RESULT THE CHANCE
MOUNTAIN PROJECT IT HAS BEEN PUT
ON HOLD.
BUT THERE ARE DISCUSSIONS GOING
ON WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION.
TO OF LOOK AT THE POSSIBILITY OF
MOVING IT FORWARD.
THANK YOU -- I JUST CLARIFY
SHANNON'S MOUNTAIN IS A MIXED
USE DEVELOPMENT THAT INCLUDE
IT'S A YEAH IT'S INCLUDING SOME
FOR DDS EXACTLY THAT'S RIGHT
YEAH IT WOULD IT THE REQUIREMENT
IS THAT AT LEAST. 20% OF THE
UNITS WOULD BE FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
SO ACTUALLY MAY ACTUALLY BE IN
LINE WITH THE GOVERNOR'S GOALS
FOR PRODUCING MORE HOUSING OKAY.
COMMENTS FROM OHIO.
WE DON'T HAVE MUCH TO ADD EXCEPT
TO TO NOTE THAT WE JUST -- HAVE
STARTED A REVIEW OF THE RECENT
PROPOSAL AND THAT ACTUALLY FALLS
UNDER DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES FOR THE CINEMA
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER PROPERTY
AND WE'RE STILL -- CONDUCTING
COULD COLLECTING INFORMATION AND
CONDUCTING ANALYSIS ON THAT BUT
THREE OF THE ISSUES THAT WERE
SORT OF TAKING A LOOK AT IS.
ARE -- WHAT IS THE?
OVERSIGHT ROLE OF THE
LEGISLATURE WHAT SORT OF
PRECEDENTS -- MIGHT THIS
APPROACH -- CREATE FOR THE
FUTURE SUCH AS PAYING FOR LOCAL
PLANNING COSTS -- AND THE THIRD
ONE AND BEING JUST -- WE'RE
TRYING TO GET SOME MORE BACK UP
INFORMATION ABOUT THE THE
SPECIFIC COSTS OVER THE THREE
YEAR PERIOD.
SO AND WHAT WE KNOW ONCE WE'VE
CONDUCTED MORE ANALYSIS WILL BE
SURE TO TO LET YOU KNOW.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
OKAY.
AND INSTEAD WE HAVE A PANEL HERE
WITH SOME STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS
WE HAVE -- CARL LONDON WITH THE
ALLIANCE FOR SUPPORTING PEOPLE
WITH. NINETY DE AND OKAY.
OKAY THERE YOU GO ALL RIGHT YOUR
THE STAKEHOLDER FALLS.
OKAY.
WELCOME FULL PANEL.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN -- I WAS
OUT SPECIFICALLY TODAY BY A
CENTER GROVE TO MAKE A COMMENT
ON HER PROPOSAL WHICH SOMEWHAT
RELATES TO THIS -- WHAT I'D LIKE
TO DO IS -- SORT OF MAKE THE
COMMENTS RELATED TO HER PROPOSAL
AND THEN JUST MAKE A COUPLE
COMMENTS ON MY OWN IF YOU DON'T
MIND -- I'M A LOBBYIST AS YOU
MENTIONED FOR THE LINE
SUPPORTING PEOPLE OF IDEA TO
ORGANIZATION OF COMMUNITY BASED.
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA SERVICE POPULATION --
I'VE BEEN INVOLVED WITH THAT
POPULATION FOR APPROXIMATELY
FIFTEEN YEARS -- ALSO SERVED AS
A BOARD MEMBER AND PAST
PRESIDENT OF A LOCAL AGENCY FOR
TEN YEARS.
HERE IN THE SACRAMENTO REGION
AND I'M ALSO THE FATHER OF A
TWENTY TWO YEAR OLD WHO.
IS GETTING READY TOLEAVE THE
SYSTEM IN JUNE THAT THE SCHOOL
SYSTEM THAT IS AND GO INTO THE
ADULT SYSTEM HERE SO I HAVE A
LOT OF RELATIVE EXPERIENCES --
RELATED TO THIS.
CENTER GROWS PROPOSAL
SPECIFICALLY -- CALLED -- FOR
SORT OF AN APPLICATION OF WHAT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
PUT OUT IN THEIR STUDY WHERE
THEY WERE ASKED TO LOOK AT THE
AMOUNT OF SAVINGS THAT MIGHT BE
DERIVED.
WHEN THE -- DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS ARE CLOSED.
AND THE LA IS REPORT BASICALLY
CAME OUT AND SAID THERE WAS
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS.
THAT WOULD BE SAVED TO THE STATE
ANNUALLY BY THE CLOSURE THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS.
I THINK CENTER GROWS POSITION ON
THAT IS -- IN LIGHT OF ALL OF
THE RATE PROBLEMS WE HAVE IN THE
STATE BE ISSUES THAT YOU TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER SUCH AS THEY HAVE
TO A BILLING THE HOLIDAY
SCHEDULE SOCIAL WRECK CAMPS.
WOULD BE GREAT IF WE COULD
CAPTURE SOME OF THE SAVINGS AND
MOVE IT OVER. TO THESE COMMUNITY
PROGRAMS TO BOLSTER THEPROGRAMS.
I THINK FURTHER -- CENTER GROVE
IN HER CAUCUS HAS DEVELOPED A
LETTER THAT I THINK YOU'VE SEEN.
THAT PARALLELS THE LETTER THE
YOU'VE ALSO PROBABLY RECEIVE
FROM SENATOR STERN -- THERE ARE
NOW SEVENTEEN MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE THERE SUPPORTING THE
PROPOSAL FOR AN 80% ACROSS THE
BOARD RATE INCREASE FOR
COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAMS AND
THAT WAS PART OF CENTER GROCER
QUESTIONS WELL.
AND THEN -- THE LAST THING WAS --
OF COURSE RELATED TO THE THE
VARIOUS PROGRAMS THAT WE
DISCUSSED EARLIER MOVING THAT
SAVINGS.
I THINK -- ONE OF THE CONCERNS
THAT THE COMMUNITY HAS AROUND
THE US AND I THINK THIS IS
SHARED BY SENATOR GROVE IS THE
WE HAVE A LENGTHY HISTORY IN
CALIFORNIA.
OF SHUTTING DOWN THESE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS WHICH WERE
LONG TIME NOW SAYS USED TO SERVE
CALIFORNIANS WITHINTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
AND WHEN THEY'RE CLOSE THE
LARGELY GO AWAY AND SO TO THE
ASSETS AND THE OPERATING DOLLARS.
JUST LOOKING BACKWARDS I'VE
PULLED SOME FIGURES ON THIS.
YOU KNOW DATING BACK.
TO TWO THOUSAND SEVEN EIGHT THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS BUDGET IN
CALIFORNIA SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS WE'RE
SERVING -- JUST UNDER THREE
THOUSAND PEOPLE BUT AS A BED PER
BED COST ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER PERSON.
AND NOW WE'RE DOWN TO WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY WITH A VERY
LOW OPERATING BUDGET.
AND ASSETS THAT ARE JUST
DISAPPEARING WRITER FROM UNDER
US.
I THINK THE COMMUNITY MANY OF US
IN THE COMMUNITY -- AND I THINK
THIS IS SURE BY SENATOR BREAUX
AND OTHERS.
WOULD TAKE THE VIEW THAT WE HAVE
ONE LAST TIME. TO DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT IN THE SYSTEM.
WHILE WE ALL COMPLAIN ABOUT THE
AVAILABLE RESOURCES FOR
COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAMS IS NOT
LOST ON A LOT OF US.
WHO WE ARE AGAIN -- GOING TO A
POSITION WHERE WE'RE GOING TO
CLOSE. TO TREMENDOUS ASSETS IN
THIS COMMUNITY ONE IN CINEMA.
THAT'S BEEN IN THIS COMMUNITY
SINCE THE EIGHTEEN NINETIES
SERVING THIS POPULATION.
AND THERE'S REALLY NOTHING.
IN ANY OF THIS CLOSURE THAT
BENEFITS THE COMMUNITY INSTEAD
WERE FIGHTING FOR SOME OF THE
ISSUES HERE EARLIER -- FIGHTING
FOR RATE INCREASES AND HOPEFULLY
GETTING SOME ASPECTS OF THE RATE
STUDY -- IMPLEMENTED SO WHAT I'D
LIKE TO DO IS AT LEAST OF
NOTHING ELSE PUT IN A MARKER --
FOR THIS LEGISLATURE IN YOU TO
CONSIDER AN ALTERNATIVE PATHWAY
ON THIS.
THE LAST THING I WOULD SAY IS
IT'S NOT IN YOUR INTEREST IS NOT
IN CENTER TITLES A TRUE INTEREST.
IS NOT IN CENTER STONE'S
INTEREST FOR THE CINEMA
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER PROPERTY TO
BE SIMPLY HANDED OVER TO CINEMA
COUNTY AND THE LOCALS.
THERE'S NO INTEREST FOR THIRTY
SIX OTHER LEGISLATORS IN YOUR
HOUSE.
ON THAT PROPOSAL AND WE WOULD
ASK YOU TO LOOK VERY CERTAINLY
IN STRONGLY.
AT POSSIBLY A DIFFERENT SOLUTION
CAN BENEFIT THE SYSTEM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
SO I'D.
RED DESIRE FROM PRE SHEET THAT
PERSPECTIVE WE'VE HEARD THAT
HERE IN THIS COMMITTEE -- WAY
BEFORE WELL -- OVER CERTAINLY
TIME I SERVED ON THIS COMMITTEE --
SO.
I APPRECIATE CENTER GROOVES
INTEREST I THINK WE'VE BEEN YOU
KNOW WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT THIS
FOR EVEN LONGER.
THAN THAT -- AND CERTAINLY I
THINK ILL WITH THAT'S THAT'S WHY
WE'RE NOT HANDING OVER.
CINEMA TO D. G. S. AND SAY
ITSELF SURPLUS PROPERTY RIGHT
THAT'S IN FACT I WOULD BE NOTE
THAT THE COST OF KEEPING THIS IN
THE SERVICE WARM SHUT DOWN IS
ABOUT.
ROUGHLY THE IT'S FOR FORTY SOME
BILLION.
DOLLARS RIGHT.
CORRECT OVER THREE YOUR PEERS
OVER A THREE YEAR PERIOD SO AND
THAT THAT'S ABOUT THE SIZE OF
OUR CAMP PROPOSAL WE THINK.
AS WELL SO I MEAN THAT'S WHAT
WAS THAT FOR SOME OF THAT MONEY
IS GOING -- ALSO I JUST MAKE
NOTE THAT IN THE OVERVIEW -- SO
WOULD YES WE HAVE REDUCTION IN
STATE OPERATED RESIDENTIAL
COMMITTEE FACILITIES.
THE SO THERE'S A REDUCTION --
HERE OF EIGHTY FOUR WELL. EIGHTY
FOUR MILLION -- HERE BUT I ALSO
MAKE NOTE THAT THE INCREASE AND
WHAT'S BUDGET FOR COMMITTEE
SERVICES UP FIVE FIVE HUNDRED
SIX MILLION SO MANY FOLD.
LARGER THAN THE REDUCTION SO WE
ARE PUTTING MORE MONEY IN -- IT
SO EVEN THOUGH THE SO THERE'S A
DROP THAT THE DROP IS A FRACTION
OF THE INCREASE.
SO I'M NOT SAYING THAT WE SHOULD
PUT MORE AND I THINK IT WILL
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
RATE STUDY AND AND I HEAR WHAT
PEOPLE ARE SAYING.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO JUST.
DEL BIG KNOWLEDGE THAT IT'S NOT
THAT THE MONEY'S GOING DOWN HERE
AND WE'RE NOT PUTTING WE'RE NOT
PROPOSING THE GOVERNOR HAS A
PROPOSED AND I THINK THAT'S
LEGISLATORS IN PROPOSING PUTTING --
NOT JUST THE SAME BUT EVEN MORE
MONEY AND THEN WERE REDUCING --
WITH THE WITH SOME OF THE
SHUTDOWN BUT I HEAR WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING I WILL CERTAINLY WE WANT.
TO KEEP IN MIND THOSE ASSETS AYE
AYE I THINK WHAT WE WANT TO TRY
TO DO.
IS -- AND AND I AGREE WE PRIDE
HAVE NOT DONE AS GOOD A JOB IN
DOING THIS IS FIGURE OUT WHAT'S
THE RIGHT AMOUNT RIGHT I MEAN
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS
WHAT'S THE RIGHT AMOUNT WHAT'S
YOU KNOW AND WERE BEHIND ON THAT.
AND THAT'S WHY WE FOR THOSE
PROPOSALS.
AND I THINK THAT'S PROBABLY THEM
THE MORE POURTANT THING THAT I
THINK WE WANT TO TRY.
TO ACHIEVE -- AND CERTAINLY SOME
ONE WAY TO TRY TO GET THERE IS
THAT WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT THE
ASSETS THAT WE ALL HAVE AN THAT
WE'RE TRANSITIONING BECAUSE OF A
DIFFERENT DIRECTION WE'RE GOING.
SO I APPRECIATE THAT AND WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT THAT BUT
CERTAIN I HOPE WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT LIMITING.
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS SIMPLY BEING
WHILE WE SHUT DOWN THIS AND
THAT'S THE ONLY AMOUNT OF MONEY
WE SHIFT OVER AND DAY APPRECIATE
THAT AND THIS AT LEAST THIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL?
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S PUT FORWARD
THAT IS ACTUALLY A LOT MORE
MONEY GOING IN THE AND IS THEN
JUST THE MONEY THAT WE'RE SAVING --
AND AND AND BASICALLY AS WERE
SHUTTING DOWN WHAT WE MOVED
EVERYONE OUT OF CINEMA AND ALSO
WERE TRANSITIONING PEOPLE OUT OF
FOR PHIL AND WHAT'S.
THE OTHER ONE YEAH SO YEAH I I I
THINK THE ONLY ALL OF BY BECAUSE
THAT SENATORS THAT -- AS WE'RE
LOOKING AT WE'RE GOING TO DRAW
THE FUNDS TO SOLVE SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT WE'VE DISCUSSED
TODAY AND IT WILL BE ON YOUR
AGENDA NEXT WEEK.
WE THINK THIS SHOULD BE PART OF
THE SOLUTION.
AND I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT A LOT
OF THE MONEY THAT -- YOU'RE%
TALKING ABOUT THAT IMPROVES THE
FIGURE FOR COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAMS.
AS DEDICATED CASELOAD GROWTH
THERE'S AN AWFUL A CASELOAD
GROWTH BUT THE RATES HAVEN'T
RISEN SO THAT MEANS THE QUALITY
LEVEL SERVICES AVAILABILITY
STILL REMAINS WHERE IT IS.
THAT'S WHY YOU'RE HAVING THE
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS YOU'RE
HEARING FROM THE COMMUNITY EVERY
SINGLE DAY YEAH THANK YOU VERY
SO SO NO I APPRECIATE THAT BUT I
I HOPE THAT WE CAN FRAME THE
DISCUSSION IS NOT SIMPLY UP WELL
THAT'S BECAUSE OTHERWISE
ACTUALLY BE EVEN.
WORSE OFF RIGHT IF WE ONLY SAID
THE ONLY AMOUNT OF MONEY WE'RE
CAN BE TALKING ABOUT IS THE
ASSETS FROM THIS BEING
TRANSFERRED OVER AND WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT WHAT'S THE RIGHT
AMOUNT AND THE FACT IS PROUD TO
BE MORE MUCH MORE THAN WE'RE
JUST GOING TO GET BEAUSE OF
CASE.
LOAD GROWTH AND OTHER TYPES OF
ISSUES RIGHT AND CERTAINLY YOU
KNOW SAID VERY SUPPORTIVE OF ME
THE PROPOSALS THAT WE'RE HEARING
HERE TODAY SO -- SO ANYWAY OKAY
NO THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
APPRECIATE YOUR ADVOCACY YEAH
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS ON THAT RIGHT
SO LET'S -- OKAY SO LET'S MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER.
SEVEN JUST SAFETY NET CITIES IN
CRISIS SERVICES AND ACTUALLY
JUST TO MAKE NOTES I KNOW THAT
IN THE AGENDA IS ACTUALLY --
IT'S IS MARK THIS INFORMATION
THAT THIS IS ACTUALLY NOT JUST
INFORMATIONAL THIS IS ACTUALLY
PROPOSAL CITING WHY KNOWLEDGE
THAT -- IF YOU FOR PEOPLE
LOOKING AT THE AGENDA THAT WAS
MISLABELLED SIMPLY INFORMATIONAL
THIS IS ACTUALLY -- A A PROPOSAL
SO.
LET'S.
BEGIN WITH -- THE SO WE'RE GONNA
GET HAVE THE AGENCY PRESENT AND
THEN WE DO HAVE A PANEL.
AS WELL IS GONE PROVIDE COMMENTS
ON THE DEPARTMENT SAFETY NET
PLANNING CRISIS SERVICES SO.
ALL RIGHT AND O'DONNELL
SHUFFLING HERE AT THE TABLE HERE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY WE'RE GETTING SETTLED INTO
AREA.
WANT TO MAKE ROOM.
ABSOLUTELY ALL RIGHT SOME
INTEREST HERE SO THANK THAT
WELCOME AT THANK YOU -- I'VE
BEEN ASKED TO PROVIDE AN UPDATE
ON OUR SAFETY NET -- PLAN AND
THEN ANSWERS SOME SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS THAT ARE OUTLINED ON
THE AGENDA -- SO THE GENDER --
CORRECTLY ON PAGE THIRTY ONE
PROVIDES A SUMMARY OF THE
PROPOSAL THAT -- WE'VE PUT
FORWARD FOR EXPANSION OF THE
SAFETY NET SUPPORTS AND CRISIS
SERVICES TOTAL FUND IS ELEVEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION WITH GENERAL
FUND OF SEVEN POINT THREE MEN --
MILLION.
THE THE REQUESTED -- HERE --
POINTS -- TO TO DDS OPERATED
CRISIS HOMES WHICH WOULD BE --
FOCUSED IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
THAN ALSO ADDING A THIRD MOBILE
CRISIS TEAM WHICH WOULD BE -- IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY -- CALLED
CAST AND THIS IS THE THIRD OUT
OF THE THE OTHER TWO THAT WE
HAVE DEVELOPED ONE IN THE NORTH
AND ONE IN THE SOUTH.
AND THEN IT ADDS -- THREE POINT
TWO MILLION IS A REQUEST FOR
TOTAL FUND TWO POINT SIX FOR
GENERAL FUND FOR ON GOING FOR
THE TWENTY SEVEN NEW POSITIONS --
THAT WOULD BE STAFF BEING THE
THIRD -- STAR HOME THAT IS
SCHEDULED TO OPEN IN THE FALL OF
TWENTY NINETEEN SO THIS IS A
PRIOR APPROVAL OF DEVELOPMENT OF
THE THIRD HOME THAT I TALKED
ABOUT IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
THAT WOULD BE IN THE COMMUNITY
FOR THE STATE OPERATED ACUTE
CRISIS SERVICES.
AND THEN THERE'S THE ADDITIONAL
REQUEST -- FOR THE NINE
POSITIONS FOR THE OVERSIGHT OF
THE SAFETY THE STAR HOMES AND
THE CAST HOMES SO IT'S JUST
TAKING A LOOK AT NOW THAT WE'RE
MOVING TO THE COMMUNITY.
THAT WE NO LONGER HAVE THE
PRESENCE OF THE STAFFING THAT
WAS AT THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER
AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE -- TO
HAVE THE RESOURCES THAT IS
STRUCTURED DIFFERENTLY IN THE
COMMUNITY TO PROVIDE THOSE
SUPPORTS.
SO I'D I'D LIKE TO JUST GIVE YOU
A LITTLE BIT OF AN UPDATE -- ON
WHERE WE ARE IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE HOMES THAT WE HAVE -- HAD
APPROVAL IN THE PAST IT'S BEEN
PART OF THE SAFETY NET BEFORE
THAT THOUGH I'D LIKE TO JUST
KIND OF SHARE THAT WHEN WE TAKE
A LOOK AT OUR SAFETY NET.
AND WE REALLY START SAFETY NET
PLAN IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
AND THAT WAS INFORMED BY QUITE A
BIT OF STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
DISCUSSIONS AND IT REALLY WAS IN
RESPONSE OF SAYING THAT WE ARE
CLOSING THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS AND SUPPORTING
INDIVIDUALS IN A DIFFERENT WAY
IN THE COMMUNITY.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO EXPAND
THAT SERVICE THAT TO SUPPORT
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE SOME VERY
UNIQUE AND COMPLEX NEEDS IN THE
COMMUNITY -- SO WE'VE WE'VE BEEN
VERY BUSY.
THE REGIONAL CENTERS HAVE BEEN
BUSY AND THE DOCTOR BACKSTROM
AND HIS STAFF HAVE BEEN VERY
BUSY AND DEVELOPING SOME OF THE
RESOURCES SO I'M JUST GOING TO
GIVE YOU A SUMMARY OF THAT.
SO WITH THE TWO THE HOME
STARTING -- AS I SAID IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
OPENING AND THAT THE NEXT COUPLE
OF WEEKS AND MOVING THE
INDIVIDUALS WE DO HAVE TO
ADDITIONAL HOMES THAT WE ARE
GOING TO BE DEVELOPING A
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR THE
STATE OPERATED STAR -- WE HAVE
ONE HOME THAT'S BEEN IDENTIFIED
IN MORE IN THE PROCESS OF DOING
THE RENOVATION SO THIS YEAR WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO GO AHEAD AND
SEE THE OPERATION OF THAT.
THAT HOME WERE IN SEARCH OF THE
THIRD HOME SO WE ARE PROBABLY A
BIT IT WAY FROM BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES FOR THE
THIRD.
I Q. CRISIS ON THAT STATE
OPERATE IN THE NORTH AND THE
SOUTH WE ALSO HAVE THE SEVEN
CALIPHATE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE AT FAIRVIEW THE THE TWO
HOMES ARE GOING TO BE AN
OPERATION ONE IS GOING.
TO SUPPORT THE FIVE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE AT FAIRVIEW PRESENTLY
THAT WILL BE GOING INTO THEIR
QUEUE CRISIS.
AND THEN THE OTHER ONE WILL BE
ADDED CAPACITY THAT WILL BE --
ABLE TO OFFER -- SO WE'RE GOING
TO BE DEVELOPING AT ON MARK LANE
WE'RE JUST TALKED A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE PROPERTY AT FAIRVIEW
SO MARK LANE IS GOING TO HAVE A
GROUND UP CONSTRUCTION OF THESE
TWO HOMES.
WE ALSO IN THE SAFETY NET PLAN
HAD DEVELOPED -- HOME TO BE OPEN
FOR HOMES TO BE A STEP DOWN HOME
FOR THE INDIVIDUALS IN THE
SECURE TREATMENT PROGRAM AT
PORTER BILL -- WE HAVE EXT SO
THREE HOMES THERE'S THREE HOMES
THERE I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT.
ALL THREE ARE ACTUALLY IN ESCROW --
IN DEVELOPMENT -- HEATHER FLORES
IS HERE -- FROM CENTRAL VALLEY
AND WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL TO THEIR
EFFORTS AND HELPING US IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THOSE HOMES --
THE SECURE TREATMENT INTENSIVE
WRAPAROUND SERVICE -- WE WERE
ABLE TO ACTUALLY START THE
SECURE TREATMENT WRAPAROUND
SERVICES SO THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT IS A CONTRACT THROUGH THE
STATE.
SO WE HAVE CONTRACTED WITH
LIBERTY I'M HAPPY TO SAY THAT WE
STARTED THE SERVICE AND THIS IS
INTENDED TO SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS
MOVING FROM THE SECURE TREATMENT.
TO THE COMMUNITY -- THEY'RE
WORKING WITH NINE INDIVIDUALS WE
WILL HAVE THE FIRST PERSON THAT
IS AN BE TRANSITIONING TO THE
COMMUNITY WITH THE SUPPORT OF
THIS NEW NEWLY DEFINED PROGRAM.
WE ALSO HAVE A FOCUS AND WE HAVE --
FOR QUITE A FEW YEARS TAKING A
LOOK AT HOW DO WE START
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE AN
INSTITUTION FOR MENTAL DISEASES
I AM DAYS WITH WELL OVER THE
YEARS WE HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
DECREASE.
AS FAR AS INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
IN I AM DIS HOWEVER WE HAVE
QUITE A FEW INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAVE BEEN AND RESIDING AT I. M.
D. -- FOR SOME FOR FOUR YEARS
FIVE YEARS SO IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES A SAFETY
NET PLAN WAS -- PRESENTED THE
DEVELOPMENT OF STEPPED DOWN
HOMES -- THERE FOR HOMES THERE'S
ONE TWO IN THE SOUTH -- ONE IN
THE IN THE NORTH THAT AL TO
REGIONAL CENTER AND THE ONE
FURTHER NORTH OF FAR NORTHERN
REGIONAL CENTER ALL HAVE BEEN
ACQUIRED IN THE FIRST ONE IS
GOING TO BE OPEN AND ABLE TO
PROVIDE SERVICES AND SUPPORTING
INDIVIDUALS.
ARE MOVING IN JUNE THIS IS GOING
TO PROVIDE A CAPACITY FOR
SIXTEEN INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
PRESENTLY AND I AM DES CURRENTLY
WE HAVE A OF JUST SHY OF SIXTY
INDIVIDUALS.
THAT ARE CURRENTLY AND I AM DAYS
AT THIS TIME.
ANOTHER IMPORTANT ELEMENT OF
SUPPORTING INDIVIDUALS MOVING
FROM THE MORE RESTRICTIVE
SETTINGS -- IS A WRAPAROUND
SERVICE AND THE SERVICE ALSO HAS
STARTED A MORE HAPPY TO SAY THAT
THIS INTENSIVE SUPPORT SERVICE
THAT IS OPERATED INVENTED BY --
L. TO REGIONAL CENTER IN ST
GBRIEL POMONA REGIONAL CENTER
THAT THEY ARE CURRENTLY WORKING
WITH NINETEEN INDIVIDUALS -- TO
SUPPORT THEM IN THEIR EFFORTS TO
MOVE FROM AND I AM DE TO THE
COMMUNITY -- IN THE REQUEST THAT
WE HAVE AND PART OF THE SAFETY
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT SAFETY NET
PLAN I FREQUENTLY SAY THAT --
DEVELOPING THE SAFETY NET PLAN
IS NOT AN EVENT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE TO DO ON
GOING WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
EVALUATE THOSE NEEDS.
SO WE HAVE A PROPOSAL TO DEVELOP
TO ADDITIONAL -- STAR HOMES AS I
SAID IN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA AND
THEN THE MOBILE CRISIS TEAM --
IN IN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA AS WELL
JUST WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU HOW
WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING TO TO
IDENTIFY WHY WE HAVE THAT NEED.
AND WHY WE THE QUESTION HAS COME
UP A COUPLE OF TIMES HOW DO WE
PICK CENTRAL CALIFORNIA WHY IS
THAT THE PLACE THAT WE NEED TO
BE.
WELL WHEN WE'VE LOOKED AT ON THE
DATA BUT WE ALSO KNOW OUR STORE
SERVICES YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE
ONE EXACTLY AND EVERY LOCATION
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT IF THERE'S
INDIVIDUALS WHO DO NEED SOME
SERVICES WHETHER IT'S THROUGH
THE STATE OPERATED.
STAR SERVICES OUR STATE OPERATED
MOBILE CRISIS SERVICES THAT
THERE'S THE NORTH AND THE SOUTH
THERE'S A BIG CHUNK OF
CALIFORNIA THAT IS IN CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA -- WE DO KNOW THAT
11% OF THE INDIVIDUALS THAT AND
I AM DES THAT COULD RECEIVE
SERVICES -- AS A PREVENTATIVE
MEASURE -- IN THESE HOMES AND
THE SERVICE 11% OF THEM ARE IN
THE CENTRAL REGION THAT IS BY
FOUR DIFFERENT REGIONAL CENTERS
16% OF THE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
LIVING OUT OF STATE AT THIS
POINT -- ARE ALSO WITHIN THAT
CENTRAL REGION WHILE IT MAY NOT
BE A LARGE NUMBER WE'D STILL
HAVE SOME INDIVIDUALS THAT --
ARE ARE IN NEED OF SERVICES THAT
ARE VERY COMPLEX AND THIS WOULD
BE AN OPPORTUNITY. 15% OF THE
REFERRALS THAT -- WE HAVE TO OUR
STAR HOMES SO WE HAVE A HUNDRED
pHAD SINCE THE INCEPTION OF OUR
STAR HOMES. THIRTY INDIVIDUALS
HAVE BEEN FROM THOSE FOUR
DIFFERENT REGIONAL CENTERS THAT
ARE WITHIN KIND OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
SO AND RIGHT NOW WE DON'T HAVE
AN ACUTE CRISIS MOBILE TEAM THAT
IS A STATE OPERATED IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
SO IN ADDITION WE HAVE A
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES THAT
WE'RE LOOKING TO EXPAND AND
WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT THOSE
LATER BUT I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
NOTE THAT.
THE EFFORT TO EXPAND THE
CHILDREN COMMUNITY CRISIS HOMES
AND AND THE THE REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICE COORDINATOR RATIO TO
SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS WITH COMPLEX
NEEDS WITH THE ONE TO TWENTY
FIVE ALL OF THAT REALLY DOES GET.
TO OUR EFFORTS IN MAKING SURE
THAT WE ARE BEING VERY MINDFUL
OF CONTINUING OUR EFFORTS TO
SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS -- WITH THAT
HAVE KIND OF GROWING COMPLEX
NEEDS WITH A CO OCCURRING --
THAT CERTAINLY IS A CHALLENGE
FOR SYSTEM.
THANK YOU ARE COMING FROM ALEJO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- WE'D
FOR SAY THAT WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE WHAT DIRECTOR
BRIDGEMAN SAID ABOUT THE SAFETY
NET BEING MORE OF A PROCESS THAN
A SINGULAR EVENT -- THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT -- IS GOING TO BE
AN ONGOING.
ISSUE FOR THE SYSTEM AN ON GOING
CONCERN -- IT WAS ALSO NICE TO
HEAR SOME OF THE STATISTICS
ABOUT THE DEMAND IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY THAT'S THE FIRST TIME
WE'VE HEARD THOSE STATISTICS AND
THAT FOR ME OUR MAIN POINT IS
THAT THERE'S SORT OF A LACK OF
COMPREHENSIVE DATA TO UNDERSTAND
THE DEMAND FOR CRISIS SERVICES
IN THE STATE.
GENERALLY.
WE DON'T OUR OFFICE DOES NOT --
DISAGREE WITH THE FACT THAT
THERE IS.
A LIKELY A NEED IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY THAT'S THE YOU KNOW WHEN
THE ORIGINAL AND SAFETY NET PLAN
CAME OUT THAT SEEM TO BE THE
AREA THAT WAS.
MISSING - SOME STATE OR IN
SERVICES -- HOWEVER ARE OUR
ULTIMATE RECOMMENDATION IS -- TO
WE RECOMMEND TO THE LEGISLATURE
TO HAVE THE DEPARTMENT DEVELOP --
AN UPDATE TO THEIR OVERALL
SAFETY NET PLAN -- PERHAPS
SUBMITTED WITH THEIR BUDGET --
NEXT YEAR AND THE PURPOSE OF
THIS WOULD TO BE TO GET A BETTER
SENSE OF OF HOW THE DEPARTMENT
IS LOOKING AT THE DEMAND FOR
SERVICES -- WHAT SERVICES DO
REGIONAL CENTERS PROVIDE AID AND
HOW CAN THOSE SERVICES BE
UTILIZED TO PREVENT CRISES FROM
EVEN ARISING -- AND THEN -- THE
OBVIOUSLY THE THE STATE HAS
INVESTED A LOT OF DOLLARS INTO
DEVELOPING THESE NEW.
MODELS OF HOMES IN THE COMMUNITY
AND IT WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL TO
HAVE A SENSE OF HOW ARE THEY
WORKING WATER -- THE LESSONS
LEARNED HOW DO WE PLAN TO
EVALUATE -- THOSE SERVICES ON AN
ONGOING BASIS AND THEN JUST A
FINAL COMMENT -- WE DID HAVE
RAISED SOME QUESTIONS IN OUR
BUDGET ANALYSIS ABOUT PLACING
THE CENTRAL VALLEY HOMES IN NEAR
THE PART OF BILL DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER.
THAT MIGHT MAKE A LOT OF SENSE
IN THE VERY NEAR TERM BECAUSE
THERE ARE SOME STAFF FROM THE
PORTABLE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER
THAT.
WOULD BE WELL QUALIFIED TO RUN
THESE HOMES BUT WE DO.
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
SORT OF REMOTE LOCATION OF
PORTER VILLE IN TERMS OF SERVING
THE BROADER -- COMMUNITY GOING
FORWARD AND IN TERMS OF
RECRUITING STAFF TO WORK IN
THOSE HOMES IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU COMES FROM FINANCE.
OKAY THANK YOU AND WE HAVE A
PANEL HERE IS GONNA.
ADDRESS THIS AND ALSO I BELIEVE --
I'LL SEE I THINK YOU HAVE A
PROPOSALS WHILE I BELIEVE --
FROM THIS BILLY RIGHT SO WITH
HEATHER FLOOR IS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FROM CENTRAL VALLEY
REGIONAL CENTER AND GROOM BALL
AND KATHERINE BLAKE MORE SO
LET'S GO AHEAD LET'S GO BEGIN
WITH A SORE AS A ASK IF YOU CAN
TRY TO KEEP YOUR MARKS WITHIN
THREE MINUTES.
THANK YOU I'LL DO MY BEST THANK
YOU SENATOR POUND.
AND DISTINGUISH STUFF IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE UP HERE -- SO IT
IS DIFFICULT TO DISCUSS AN ISSUE
OF THIS MAGNITUDE IN THREE
MINUTES -- BUT LET ME PAINT A
PICTURE FOR YOU AS CENTRAL
VALLEY REGIONAL CENTER WE SERVE
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES WITH A CURRENT
GROWTH RATE OF 7%.
WE REPRESENT ABOUT 6% OF THE
INDIVIDUAL SERVICE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
WE HISTORICALLY RECEIVE AN
AVERAGE OF THREE CRISIS CALLS
PER NIGHT -- LAST NIGHT WE
RECEIVED THREE CRISIS CALLS IN
ONE NIGHT I'M SO WE'RE STARTING
TO SEE AN INCREASE IN THESE
CRISIS CALLS AT NIGHT TIME --
WHICH GIVES US ON AVERAGE RIGHT
NOW ABOUT ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SIX CRISIS CALLS -- PER YEAR --
BUT INCREASING OVER TIME WE ALSO
HAVE A LIST OF INDIVIDUALS WERE
CHALLENGING TO SERVE -- WHO HAVE --
HISTORICAL ISSUES WITH HIGH
ACUITY BEHAVIORS ARE CHALLENGES
ARE MEDICAL NEEDS -- AND THEN
PERIODS WHERE THEY'RE DOING OKAY
AND WE CAN ENGAGE IN SPECIALIZED
THERAPEUTIC RESOURCES -- SO IF
YOU EXTRAPOLATE THOSE NUMBERS
OUT TO THE STATE WIDE.
IS OUT TO ABOUT THIRTY NINE
HUNDRED PEOPLE -- STATEWIDE --
THAT THAT ARE PROBABLY IN CRISIS
OVER TIME YOU KNOW SOME WITH
HIGH ACUITY AND SOME JUST WITH
MORE CHRONIC SITUATIONS.
SO OUR RECOMMENDATION AT THIS
TIME AS A REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM
IS AS SIGNIFICANT START UP
FUNDING FROM THE COMMUNITY
RESOURCE DEVELOPMENT PLAN.
IS DESPERATELY NEEDED TO CREATE
CRISIS AND LONG TERM RESIDENTIAL
OPTIONS WITH APPROPRIATE CARE
AND TREATMENT FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH THE MOST CHALLENGING NEEDS.
WE KNOW THAT THE HOUSING MODELS
OF THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER
CLOSURE HAVE BEEN EFFECTIVE SUCH
AS THE ENHANCE BEHAVIORAL
SUPPORT HOMES AND THE OUR
FISSIONS THE ADULT RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES FOR PERSONS WITH
SPECIAL HEALTH CARE NEEDS --
HOWEVER IS THE PERCENTAGE OF OUR
NEED INCREASES ARE WORRIED
RESOURCES ARE NOT CURRENTLY
KEEPING UP -- WE WOULDN'T
RECOMMEND FRONT LOADING CAPACITY
NOW OUT OF THE C. R. D. US --
AND THEN RELEASING THAT DOWN THE
ROAD ONCE WE HAVE ACHIEVED
CAPACITY FOR THESE HIGH ACUITY
SITUATIONS -- THIS ALSO
INCREASES THERAPEUTIC OPTIONS --
FOR INDIVIDUALS SERVED AND
FAMILIES -- AS WELL I'M A BETTER
SUPPORT FOR THEM AND INDIVIDUAL
CHOICE.
BUILDING A BETTER OUTCOMES FOR
FOLKS.
SO I JUST WANNA SURE AT LEAST
ONE POSITIVE STORY WITH YOU
BECAUSE IT ON THE T. MARK.
WE HAVE ONE INDIVIDUAL SO IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WE HAVE TWO OF
THE SPECIALIZED HOMES WERE THE
FIRST IN THE STATE WE WERE THE
FIRST IN THE STATE TO DEVELOP
THEM SOMEONE WAS THAT A LADY
CROSS SECURE PERIMETER HOME.
WE HAVE A FELLOW IN THERE WITH
DRAMATIC BRAIN INJURY WHICH WE
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER TODAY.
AND HE SUICIDAL IDEATION
ESPECIALLY AROUND THE TIME OF
HIS CAR ACCIDENT ALL THESE SORTS
OF THINGS -- YOU KNOW AND ALL
THE REGIONAL CENTERS HAVE
STORIES LIKE THIS.
BUT THIS YOUNG MAN IS NOW
MENTORING HIS PEERS -- USING HIS
COPING SKILLS TO TEACH OTHERS
COPING SKILLS AROUND HIS
SITUATION AND ACTUALLY HAVE AN
IMPACT ON OTHER PEOPLE AND THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE DON'T KNOW
THAT HE WOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE BEFORE SO IT
REALLY WONDERFUL OUTCOMES -- WE
DO AS REGIONAL CENTERS IN A
SOMETIMES PEOPLE GET A LITTLE
CONFUSING THEY THINK I CAN'T I
JUST AS A FAMILY MEMBER CALL THE
STATE DIRECTLY -- THE
RELATIONSHIP IS WITH THE
REGIONAL CENTER WE DO SERVE
THROUGHOUT THE LIFESPAN AND
THERE'S SOME CONFUSION SOMETIMES
BUT THE IPPV.
WHICH IS AN EVENT -- ANYWAY I'LL
STOP TALKING ABOUT THAT PART.
SO -- ANYWAY FAMILIES NEED A
BROADER UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
REGIONAL CENTERS CAN DO WHEN
THEY'RE CRISIS AND THERE'S A
MISPERCEPTION BUT STAFF ARE --
ONLY SEE FAMILIES ANNUALLY --
BUT WITH THIS ISSUE OF CAPACITY
WE WOULD RECOMMEND THAT THE C.
R. T. F. MEME MONEY BE FRONT
LOADED WE WOULD LIKE TO COMMEND --
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA FOR
THE FIVE MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST --
AND ALSO THE DEPARTMENT FOR THE
ONE TO TWENTY FIVE CASELOADS AND
AB TWO ZERO EIGHT THIRTY THREE
FOR THE COURT NAY TO CARE FOR
FOSTER YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ABOUT GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ANNA GROUP LAW AND I AM THE
MOTHER OF KYLE BAKER A CLIENT OF
NORTH BAY REGIONAL CENTER.
KYLE WAS DIAGNOSED WITH AUTISM
JUST PRIOR TO HIS THIRD BIRTHDAY
AND IS NON VERBAL HE TURNS
SIXTEEN THIS LAST.
DECEMBER INSTEAD OF SPENDING HIS
BIRTHDAY AT HOME WITH HIS FAMILY.
HE SPENT IT AT THE Q. CRISIS
UNIT AT FAIRVIEW DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER IN ORANGE COUNTY.
HE IS THE ONLY MINOR LIVING IN A
TO CALIFORNIA DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER SO COMPLETELY SEPARATE
UNIT WAS CREATED FOR HIM AWAY
FROM THE ADULTS WHO LIVE THERE.
EXCEPT FOR THE MANY STAFF WHO
CARE FOR HIM HE SPENDS MUCH OF
HIS DAYS ALONE IN HIS ROOM.
WHICH HE LIKES TO KEEP DARK HE
USUALLY ONLY LEAVES HIS ROOM TO
USE THE BATHROOM BASIN AND EAT
HIS MEALS.
I AM ABLE TO VISIT HIM ONCE A
MONTH SINCE I LIVE AND WORK IN
CINEMA COUNTY.
HE DOES NOT RECEIVE BEHAVIORAL
TREATMENT SPEECH THERAPY OR
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES TO SPEAK OF
AND I FEAR HIS COGNITIVE AND
COMMUNICATION SKILLS HAVE
REGRESSED.
HIS GIVEN FIVE SEPARATE
PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATIONS
INCLUDING FOR PSYCHOSIS AND
SEIZURES NEITHER OF WHICH HE HAS.
AND MOST OF HIS MEDICATIONS --
AT OR HIGHER THAN THE
RECOMMENDED DOSAGES FERN JOLT
[inaudible]
EXCUSE ME.
SOMETIMES HE TRIES TO HURT THE
STAFF AND IS GIVEN ADDITIONAL
MEDICATIONS ARE PUT INTO
RESTRAINTS YOU MAY BE WONDERING
HOW KYLE ENDED UP IN THIS
SITUATION.
AFTER KYLE ENTERED PUBERTY HE
ENGAGED IN MORE INTENSE.
AGGRESSIVE BEHAVIORS TOWARDS
HIMSELF OTHERS AND PROPERTY.
IN EARLY TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
MY HUSBAND KYLE'S FATHER NEIL
[inaudible]
SORRY.
AND I COULD NO LONGER TAKE CARE
OF KYLE SAFELY IN OUR HOME.
NEIL WAS KYLE'S I'D JUST US CARE
PROVIDER AND HAD STAYED AT HOME
WITH HIM. FOR MUCH OF HIS LIFE
IN JANUARY TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
KYLE'S AGGRESSION ESCALATED HE
ATTACKED.
AND OUR RESPITE CARE PROVIDER
AND WE CALLED.
NINE ONE ONE BECAUSE THERE WAS
NOWHERE ELSE FOR HIM TO GO NO
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITAL WOULD TAKE
HIM BECAUSE OF HIS DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY.
AND THERE WERE NO APPROPRIATE
COMMUNITY PLACEMENTS KYLE AGE
FIFTEEN WAS ADMITTED TO A
REGULAR MEDICAL HOSPITAL ON AN
ADULT FLOOR.
WHERE HE REMAINED FOR MUCH OF
THE NEXT TEN MONTHS [inaudible]
SORRY -- RATHER THAN RECEIVING
THERAPEUTIC TREATMENT HE SPENT
THE MAJORITY OF THAT TIME IN BED
HEAVILY MEDICATED AND AND FOUR
POINT RESTRAINTS TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A DAY.
CAUSING HIM MUSCLE ATROPHY
IMPACTING HIS ABILITY TO WALK OR
EVEN STAND UNDER ITS OWN WEIGHT.
HE WAS PRESCRIBED HIGH DOSES OF
PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATIONS TO
SEDATE HIM AS HE INJURED
NUMEROUS MEDICAL STUFF SECURITY
GUARDS AND HIMSELF.
HE SUFFERED FROM SIGNIFICANT
MEDICAL PROBLEMS AS SIDE EFFECTS
OF THOSE MEDICATIONS AT ONE
POINT HE DEVELOPED SEPSIS AND
SPENT TEN DAYS IN THE INTENSIVE
CARE UNIT.
UNDER COMPLETE SEDATION.
THE HOSPITAL FOUND A RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT PROGRAM FOR HIM IN MAY
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BUT HE WAS
KICKED OUT AFTER SIXTEEN HOURS
AND VERY SOON.
RETURN TO THE HOSPITAL.
OUR FAMILY WAS REPEATEDLY
THREATENED WITH AND REPORTED TO
CHILD PROTECTIVE SERVICES BY
HOSPITAL STAFF BECAUSE WE WERE
UNABLE TO MEET KYLE'S NEEDS AT
HOME.
ON JULY TENTH.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WHEN KYLE
REMAINED IN THE HOSPITAL.
NEIL DIED SUDDENLY FROM A HEART
ATTACK.
I SINCERELY BELIEVE THAT HIS
GRIEF AND STRESS ABOUT PILE
SITUATION.
PLAYED A ROLE IN HIS EARLY DEATH
AT AGE.
FIFTY FIVE I STILL HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO BRING MYSELF TO TELL
KYLE.
NOT WHEN HIS ALONE SO FAR AWAY
FROM ME.
AFTER UNSUCCESSFUL STATEWIDE
SEARCHES BY THE REGIONAL CENTER
DDS APPROVED A RESIDENTIAL
SCHOOL PLACEMENT IN KANSAS WHICH
FELL THROUGH MAYOR DAYS.
BEFORE HIS PLANNED ADMISSION IN
OCTOBER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
APOLOGIZE I'M GONNA HAVE TO ASK
YOU TO WRAP OKAY I'M ALMOST I'M
ALMOST DONE SO -- OF A SO
REGIONAL CENTER IDENTIFIED OF A
SO CALLED CRISIS HOME IN
NOVEMBER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
BUT THE PROGRAM WAS CLEARLY NOT
PREPARED TO MEET HIS NEEDS.
WITHIN A FEW DAYS OF PLACEMENT
THERE KYLE SLAMMED HIS HEAD INTO
A SLIDING GLASS DOOR RE OPENING
A HEAD WOUND THAT HE HAD
SUFFERED IN THE HOSPITAL AND
BREAKING THE DOOR.
THE HOME CALLED NINE ONE ONE AND
REFUSED TO ALLOW HIM TO RETURN
HE SPENT TWO WEEKS STRAPPED TO A
GURNEY AND AN ER.
HOURS AWAY FROM ME BEFORE HE WAS
FINALLY TRANSFERRED TO THE ACUTE
CRISIS UNIT AT FAIRVIEW WHERE HE
CURRENTLY LIVES.
I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HERE TODAY AND TO SHARE
KYLE STORY WITH YOU I HOPE THAT
KYLE'S EXPERIENCES AND ALL THAT
HE IS AN TOWARD.
WILL BE TO SOME MEANINGFUL
CHANGE THAT CAN HELP KYLE AND
MANY ADOLESCENTS IN SIMILAR
SITUATIONS.
I'D LIKE TO THANK SENATOR MIKE
MCGUIRE AND DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA FOR THEIR SUPPORT OF
KYLE AND OUR FAMILY DURING THIS.
SITUATION THE THING THIS IS
KYLE'S PICTURE OKAY.
THANK YOU KNOW TOOK THE LAST
VISIT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SHARING THIS STORY.
THANK YOU.
I THINK THAT POINTS OUT WHY
WE'RE HERE.
AND I'M NOT REALLY SURE HOW.
TO SORT OF BRING THAT TOGETHER
TAUGHT TO TALK ABOUT THE KINDS
OF THINGS THAT DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA THINKS -- ME TO
HAPPEN BUT I'M GONNA TRYING TO
THAT BRIEFLY FIRST WE AGREE WITH
THE LA -- ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF TAKING A STEP BACK TO SAY
WHAT ELSE DO WE NEED IN
CALIFORNIA WHAT ARE THE UNMET
NEEDS -- WHAT ADDITIONAL KINDS
OF PLACEMENTS OR SERVICES MIGHT
INSURE THAT WE CAN BETTER MEET
THE NEEDS OF ALL INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE SERVED BY THE REGIONAL
CENTER?
I THINK THAT MEANS LOOKING AT
HEALTH AND SAFETY WAIVERS AND
SORT OF RATES AND ALL OF THAT
THAT GOES INTO THAT SO WE CAN --
BEST SERVE BEST SERVE PEOPLE SO
I WANT.
TO ENCOURAGE THAT THAT
RECOMMENDATION -- I WANT TO
SPEAK BRIEFLY BEFORE YOU DO THAT
I I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE -- THE
REALLY TREMENDOUS WORK THAT HAS
DONE BEEN DONE BY THE DEPARTMENT
AND THE REGIONAL CENTERS.
BOTH TO CLOSE THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS ARE VERY CLOSE TO
CLOSING THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS HAVE BEEN WORKING IN THE
SYSTEM FOR A LONG TIME AND IT'S
ACTUALLY QUITE REMARKABLE THAT
WE ARE WE ARE AND AND TO THINK
ALL THE HARD WORK THAT HAS
HAPPENED.
TO TO BEGIN THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
COMMUNITY.
OF CRISIS -- US SERVICE SYSTEM --
SO THE FIRST THING I WANT TO SAY
IS WE CURRENTLY HAVE STATE
OPERATED CRISIS TEAMS WHICH ARE
TERRIFIC WE NEED TO EXPAND THE
CAPACITY OF THOSE CRISIS TEAMS
TO SERVE PEOPLE STATEWIDE.
IT SHOULDN'T FOR FOR PEOPLE THAT
ARE AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
SECURITY IN CRISIS WE NEED TO
HAVE THAT COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT
FOR ALL OF THEM AND WE'RE NOT
THERE YET.
ON THE SECOND IS WE ARE
PROPOSING CRISIS CAPACITY FOR
CHILDREN ADOLESCENTS THAT WILL
SERVE PRECISELY TWELVE
INDIVIDUALS I THINK. THREE HOMES.
IS IN SUFFICIENT WEEK.
WE HAVE ONE IN THE FAR NORTH ONE
IN THE CENTRAL WHICH I THINK IS
GREAT AND ONE IN THE SOUTH BUT
IT WILL MEAN.
THAT CHILDREN WHO ARE IN CRISIS
ARE MOVED LONG DISTANCES FROM
THEIR FAMILIES TO RECEIVE THOSE
SERVICES FOR UP TO EIGHTEEN
MONTHS IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
EXPANDING THE MONEY AVAILABLE
AND BUILDING THOSE OUT MORE
QUICKLY.
IS ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
THINGS WE CAN DO TO AVOID THE
KIND OF A SITUATION THAT AND HER
FAMILY FOUND THEMSELVES IN -- WE
ALSO WANT TO ENCOURAGE THE LIMIT
ON THE USE OF SECLUSION
RESTRAINT IN CHILDREN'S CRISIS
HOMES AS A WAY OF NOT THERE ARE
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THAT
MAY NEED TO BE DONE BUT THERE
ARE PROTOCOLS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS DEVELOPED FOR A
TOLD HOMES THAT SHOULD BE
REPLICATED -- IN THE CHILDREN'S
CRISIS HOMES -- THE DEPARTMENT
APPROPRIATELY HAS IDENTIFIED OF
THE NEED FOR REDUCE CASELOADS WE
SUPPORT THAT WE WILL NOTE THAT
THERE IS A TIME LIMIT ABOUT HOW
LONG THOSE CAN BE AVAILABLE.
AND WE THINK THE STANDARD FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE TRANSITIONING
FROM OF A LIVING ARRANGEMENT
BACK TO LOOK AT A LOWER LEVEL OF
COMMUNITY SERVICE.
SHOULD BE THE SAME AS FOR PEOPLE
MOVING OUT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS WHICH IS FOR A YEAR OR
SO BOTH KNEW THAT IN THE
FACILITY.
WHAT WERE YOU LOOKING FOR
PLACEMENT BUT EQUALLY IMPORTANT
WHEN YOU'RE LEAVING AND YOU
MIGHT BE MOST AT RISK OF A RE
OCCURRENCE?
I'M GONNA QUICKLY TALK ABOUT --
THREE THINGS THAT THE R. C. IS
INTERESTED IN.
BUT FIRST IS -- AS OF A DIRECTOR --
HEATHER NOTED ON THAT -- FLOORS
NOTED IS THAT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO ALLOW REGIONAL CENTER
PILOTS THAT WILL LOOK AT NEW
WAYS OF PROVIDING SERVICES --
FOR INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE BOTH
DEVELOPMENTAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
DISABILITIES SOMETIMES IT MAKES
SENSE TO LOOK AT WHAT LOCAL
FOLKS KNOW THE NEEDS ARE HOW
THEY CAN COORDINATE WITH MENTAL
HEALTH AGENCIES HOW THEY CAN
DEVELOP.
UP CAPACITY THE SECOND IS TO RE
ALIGN HOW WE COMMIT PEOPLE TO I
AM DIS.
ARM TO HAVE THAT STANDARD BE THE
SAME AS PEOPLE GOING INTO THE
SHORT TERM ACUTE CRISIS AND YOU
CAN READ -- THE DETAILS OF THAT
AND THE THIRD IS TO ENSURE THAT
THE CLIENTS RIGHTS ADVOCATES WHO
CAN DIRECTLY INTERVENE IN THE
MIDST OF A CRISIS GET NOTICE
WHEN INDIVIDUALS ARE IN -- SITE
FACILITIES OR WHEN THEIR
COMMITTED IN THE SIXTY FIVE
HUNDRED PROCEEDING.
THANK YOU -- I JUST MAKE NOTE WE
HAVE.
A VERY LONG AGENDA THIS IS ONLY
PART A WE STILL HAVE PART B. TO
GO IT'S READY FOR PM THERE'S
ITSELF I'D FULLY MY STAFF DOES
EDUCATE PEOPLE ABOUT TIME LIMITS
NOT BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO
HEAR YOUR STORIES BUT BECAUSE WE
HAVE TO BE FAIR TO THE PEOPLE.
WHO WILL BE HEARD PROBABLY SEVEN
OR EIGHT PM TONIGHT AND DEL DAY?
SO I SO YOU KNOW AND WE DO ASK
PEOPLE OF SOME THAT THINGS IN
WRITING IF THEY WANT TO GIVE
SOMETHING MORE EXTENDED SO
APPRECIATE -- SO I GUESS --
DIRECTOR AREA.
THIS IS IT IS A PEDIATRICIAN YOU
KNOW I'VE.
ACTUALLY WORKED WITH FAMILIES
WHO'VE HAD CHILDREN TOO YOU KNOW --
PHRASEOLOGY HIT ADOLESCENCE --
THE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
DEVELOPMENTAL ISSUES I
SPECIALIZE IN CHILDREN WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL ISSUES. TWELVE SO
I KNOW YOU'RE TRYING VERY HARD
TWELVE SPOTS IS IN A POPULATION
WHAT'S THE THREE POINT NINE WERE
ALMOST FORTY MILLION WE HAVEN'T
QUITE HIT IT DO F. JUST CAME OUT
THEIR NUMBERS I THINK WAS
YESTERDAY OR DAY BEFORE -- SO
WHAT WHAT SO HOW WE FIGURE OUT
OUR RIGHT SIZING LIE HOW MANY
IT AND SO FORTH SO THAT THIS.
HAPPENED.
SO I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT SPURS LIKE OKAY
NINE THREE SHE YOU KNOW YOUR
TITLES OUT WE ARE.
CLOSING THE ABOUT THE CENTERS
BUT HOPEFUL -- WHAT WHAT ARE YOU
DOING TO FIGURE OUT HOW MANY?
BEDS WE NERI BEDS OR BEYONCE'S --
OR SPACES WE NEED.
AND TWELVE CELLS LIKE A VERY
SMALL NUMBER -- AND I REALIZE
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SOME
PEOPLE PEOPLE NEED SOME OF THE
MOST INTENSE OF SERVICES AND I
THINK WHAT I WAS ONE OF THE
CONCERNS WE SAID NGUYEN CLOSE
DOWN THE VOLATILES CENTERS RIGHT
SO WE'RE GOING TO DO.
WE NEED TO ACTUALLY INVEST IN
THESE.
THINGS SO I KNOW THAT YOU FIFTY
L. THE SAFETY NET FACILITIES SO
FORTH SO WHAT WHAT'S THE WHAT'S
THE PLAN TO LIKE HOW MANY
RECLAIM THE WHAT'S THE PLAN IF
YOU'RE HOW WE WE NEED AND HOW WE
GET THERE TERMS OF THE HAVING
THIS FACILITIES AVAILABLE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CAN M..
AS YOU CAN TELL THIS IS SUCH A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE RIGHT NOW WE
ARE SEEING AN INCREASED NUMBER
OF KIDS PARTICULARLY THAT HAVE
CO OCCURRING NEEDS VERY COMPLEX --
AND DO REALLY TAKING A LOOK AT
IT SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE NOTE
pWHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT OUR SAFETY
NET PLAN -- WE'RE GOING TO BE
PRESENTING A AYE AND OUTLINING
KIND OF ACROSS THE STATE HAD A
WHAT ARE THOSE SERVICES SO.
YOU KNOW BEFORE YOU TODAY IS THE
THREE COMMUNITY CRISIS HOMES FOR
CHILDREN IT'S A NEW MODEL IT IS
GOING TO BE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE -- WE HAVE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
ESTABLISHMENT AS A NEW LICENSE
CATEGORY.
SO IT'S ONLY FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE A DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY --
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT THERE'S NOT
OTHER SERVICES THAT'S BEING
DEVELOPED WITHIN THE REGIONAL
CENTERS SO YOU HAVE OTHER HOMES
THAT ARE BEING DEVELOPED THAT
ARE CRISIS HOMES.
THE DESIGN OF THE COMMUNITY
CRISIS HOME FOR CHILDREN IS
REALLY KIND OF A VERY HIGH
INTENSITY.
AND AND REALLY WITH THE
EXPERIENCES THAT KYLE'S FACING
AND SO MANY OTHERS THAT ARE THE
CHALLENGES THAT.
AND IT WAS BECAUSE THROUGH THOSE
CHALLENGES THAT WE SAID WE NEED
TO DEVELOP A NOTHER MODEL OF
SERVICE YOU KNOW TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THOSE SUPPORTS.
AND SO THAT IS REALLY THE INTENT
OF THOSE THREE IS FOR THOSE
REALLY KINDA UNIQUE CHALLENGES
THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS.
THE OTHER PIECE OF IT IS THAT
WE'RE TAKING A LOOK AT MAKING
SURE THAT COMMUNITY PLACEMENT
PLAN THE PRIORITY. FOR NINETEEN
TWENTY IS THAT ALL OF WHILE WE
WILL STILL DO SOME THE COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT.
THE PRIORITY IN THE GUIDELINES
AS ABOUT THE SAFETY NET.
SO MAKING SURE THAT THE REGIONAL
CENTERS ARE DEVELOPING FIRST
WORLD IN APPROVED FIRST ALL OF
THE SERVICES THAT NEED TO BE
WITHIN THE REGIONAL CENTERS IT'S
NOT GOING TO MEET ALL THE NEEDS.
BUT THEY ALL NEED TO TAKE AN
INVENTORY OF WHAT THE NEEDS ARE
WITHIN THEIR AREA AND WE'RE
GOING TO PRIORITIZE THAT
DEVELOPMENT.
SO I JUST WANT TO YOU KNOW IT'S
A LONG DISCUSSION THAT WE CAN
CERTAINLY HAVE IS TO THOSE
STRATEGIES -- BUT THE OTHER
PIECES THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
PILOTING MORE WORKING WITH TO
REGIONAL CENTERS THAT ARE GOING
TO BE PILOTING KIND OF A NEW
MODEL THAT IS MORE OF A INFORMED.
CREDIT -- TRAUMA FOCUSED --
SUPPORT SYSTEM SO BECAUSE OF
THAT THAT STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS
THAT WE HAD WITH WITH FAMILY
MEMBERS THAT ARE EXPERIENCING
THIS MOST COMPLEX SITUATIONS
THAT ARE VERY DEVASTATING TO
THEM.
IN TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT ARE
SOME OF THOSE STEPS SO OUR FIRST
STEP IS PILOTING A COUPLE OF
THINGS THAT ARE DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT WE'VE DONE IN THE PAST.
THAT IS WITHIN OUR CURRENT
PRIORITIZE SEEN OUR COMMUNITY
PLACEMENT PLAN FUNDS FOR THESE
PURPOSES DEVELOPING TO STATE
OPERATED -- COMMUNITY KIRK TO
STATE OPERATED CRISIS SERVICES
OUR STAR HOMES BETTER FOCUS JUST
FOR CHILDREN AND THEN STARTING
WITH THOSE THREE HOMES BY WAY OF
HAVING A NEW LICENSE CATEGORY WE
CAN EXPAND BEYOND THOSE THREE
HOMES AS JUST TO START.
SO IT'S YES -- AND IT I THINK.
YOU MADE SOME COMMENT ABOUT THIS --
TO IS IS THAT -- I THINK IT'S
HELPFUL TO SAY OKAY WHAT IS THIS
NEW MODEL GOING TO BE RIGHT
BECAUSE WE HAVE LOTS OF
DIFFERENT PIECES YOU HAVE YOUR
STAR HOMES RIGHT WHICH IS BEING
OPERATED BY THE STATE.
THERE ARE ABLE TO SELL RIGHT AND
THEN YOU HAVE YOUR REGIONAL
CENTERS.
TO WHILE ALSO TAKING OUT THAT
AND THAT AND THIS AND THE SOURCE
SPECTRUM THAT THEY'LL TAKE IN
EXACTLY WHAT YOU KNOW UP TO WHAT
POINT AND MAYBE VARIES A LITTLE
BIT BY REGIONAL CENTER.
EXACTLY HOW WHAT POINT SEVERITY
CAN THEY HANDLE RIGHT IN TERMS
OF AND WHAT CUT FACILITIES WILL
THEY BE OPERATING BECAUSE YOU'RE
RIGHT IT'S NOT JUST THE STAR
HOME SO WITH SO WHERE'S THAT
INTERFACES IS GOING TO BE IN
TERMS OF BETWEEN.
AND I DON'T KNOW IS IS IS THIS
IS THE FUTURE.
FOR YOU PLAIN.
TO FILLED OUT MORE OR STAR HOMES
IN THE LONG TERM OR IS IT GOING
TO BE MORE WELL ACTUALLY HESE
ARE MODELS THAT WE'RE NOT GONNA
TRANSITION TO REGIONAL CENTERS
REGIONAL CENTERS ON THE BE
OPERATING HOW MANY CRISIS SOME
SO.
I MEAN.
AND YOU MAY BE STILL FIGURING
SOME OF THAT OUT US IN EXACTLY
AND HOW MANY HOW MANY OF THEM WE
GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THE
CURRENT ACUITY AND WHERE WE
THINK THAT'S GOING.
HOW MANY?
FACILITIES DO WE NEED AN OPERATE
BY WHOM SO AND THAT IS SO LEAD
TO HELPFUL TO HAVE A BETTER
SENSE OF THAT -- YEAH OF THE THE
IT DID IT WOULD BE ON THE NEXT
YEAR OR SO WHEN WE START TALKING
ABOUT OUR SOMETIME IN THE COMING
YEAR LIKE WHAT WHAT IS THE SORT
OF THE OVERALL PLAN I. V. ON
THIS IS THE THIS IS THE INITIAL
SAFETY NET SELLING CRISIS
SERVICES.
BUT WHERE WE ARE WHERE WE WERE
WE GOING TO THE YOU KNOW WE WERE.
HOPEFULLY WE'RE GONNA BE FUNNY
YOU SOME MORE STAFF TO LOOK AT
SOME OF THE STUFF BUT I MEAN
JUST.
WHAT WHAT?
WHERE WHAT IS THE WHAT IS THE
PLAN THAT WE'RE MOVING FORWARD
HOW ME AND AT LEAST A BASELINE
OF DATA ABOUT HOW MANY?
HOW MANY BEDS WHAT'S THERE HOW
MANY?
THINGS OF HOW WHAT SEVERITY DO
WE NEED RIGHT S. NOW THAT WE'VE
CLOSED OUT INCLUDING DOT
DEVELOPMENTAL -- CENTERS OF WHAT
WHAT WHAT WE HAVE OUT THERE AND
WHAT WE NEED TO BUILD OUT TO AND
HE'S GOING TO DO IT RIGHT HOW'S
IT GOING TO BE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER IS GOING TO GO UP THAT
CERTAIN POINT.
STATES CAN DO CERTAIN POINT
CETERA I THINK SOME CLARITY
THERE WOULD BE HELPFUL.
YEAH AND AND REALLY MUCH OF THE
THE INVENTORY THAT WE'RE GONNA
BE DOING THROUGH THE CPP PLANS --
IN THIS CYCLE IS GOING TO GIVE
US SIGNIFICANT CLARITY AS TO
WHERE WE ARE AND WE DO HAVE IN
INVENTORY CURRENTLY.
BUT REALLY KIND OF EXPANDING
THAT WITH EACH OF THE REGIONAL
CENTERS AND UNDERSTANDING THAT
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
WE REALLY DO HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK
AT MULTIPLE APPROACHES.
I MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE FROM
PREVENTATIVE SUPPORT SERVICES TO
MAKING SURE THAT YOU KNOW WE WE
HAVE THE EFFORT TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THAT SUPPORT. TO REALLY
REDUCE THE RISK OF HAVING SOME A
CHILD HAVING TO GO OUT OF HOME
INTO A CRISIS SERVICE BUT
BECAUSE OF WHAT WE WERE SEEN.
IN THE INCREASE OF OF REQUEST --
FOR MORE STATE OPERATED SUPPORT
SERVICES IS REALLY WHAT GAVE US
THE INDICATION THAT WE
IMMEDIATELY NEEDED TO TAKE A
LOOK AT WITHIN OUR PROPOSAL IN
ABILITY AND THAT'S WHERE YOU'RE
SEEING THE THREE HOMES ASKING
FOR THE COMMUNICATIONS HOME
LICENSE.
SO WE CAN HELP THE REGIONAL
CENTERS TO BE ABLE TO DEVELOP
WITHIN THEIR COMMUNITY THESE
OPTIONS AND HAVE THOSE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE -- BUT A GREAT IN
TAKING A LOOK AT KIND OF A
MAPPING OF THE STATE AND HAD A
WHERE WE ARE AND WHAT THE FUTURE
NEEDS ARE ALSO SERVE THEM.
SO WHAT'S THE DEMAND ALRIGHT SO
THERE'S AND THEN THERE'S
INVENTORIES LIKE WHAT ARE
CAPACITY IS WHAT'S THE DEMAND
AND THEN THE SERVER ROADMAP OF
US WERE BIG REALLY GOING INTO
THIS NEW WORLD RIGHT WITH THE
CLOSING DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
BUILDING.
THEY'LL THIS PROPOSAL THE
SICKNESSES ELISE -- WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WHAT THE REGIONAL
CENTERS IN A ROLE HOW THE
INTERFACE RATE -- ARE NOT
DEPENDING ON THE LOCATIONS AND
SO FORTH -- ANY OF THE MOBILE
CRISIS TEMA HOW'S THAT FIT INTO
THIS PICTURE SO.
IN THE END AND I THINK PEOPLE
ALSO NEED SOME CLARITY SO THAT
THEY KNOW WHAT THEY'RE BECAUSE
OTHERWISE WE'RE GONNA HAVE GAPS
RIGHT I MEAN -- SO OF SOMEONE'S
GOT LIKE WHAT'S NOT MINE IS NOT
MINE AND THEN FOR FAMILY STOCK
RIGHT AND SO [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER COMMENTS
THEN.
OKAY WELL THANKS VERY MUCH FO
YOUR PRESENTATIONS APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
ELSE ON THAT.
ONE BECAUSE THIS YOU NUMBER
EIGHT THE OVERVIEW AND THAT
CHANGED RULES OF FOR EIGHT CBS
COMPLIANCE AND FINAL RULE SITE
ASSESSMENTS [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
CAN.
IT'S HELPFUL TO HAVE.
IT'S HARD TO HEAR THE THE OF A
PARTICULAR RELIGIOUS COMMENTING
OR IS IT A PARTICULAR PROPOSAL.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
BECAUSE THE PREVIOUS.
SHIFTED AROUND YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY.
ARE IN SO WILL SO THREE EFFORT.
THE PANEL FOR COMMENTING
AFTERWARDS SO WHAT'S GOING HAD
BEGIN WITH THE PROPOSAL OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
YEAH.
I DOCTOR PENA JIM NIGHT WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SUGGEST --
THE AGENDA DOES A GOOD JOB AGAIN
SOME BACKGROUND ABOUT WHAT THESE --
HOME A COMMUNITY SERVICES RULES
ARE ABOUT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
AND WHAT THE PROPOSAL IS IS FOR
US TO BUILD ON AND HELP US
DETERMINE WHERE WE ARE AS FAR AS
MEETING THOSE REQUIREMENTS.
AND SO THE THE REQUEST IS -- FOR
THREE MILLION DOLLARS ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION IN GENERAL FUND
FOR US TO DO -- AN ON SITE
ASSESSMENT WHICH IS REQUIRED AS
PART OF THE SELF -- STATEWIDE
TRANSITION PLAN.
AND THE THESE ON SITE
ASSESSMENTS -- BECAUSE WE NEED
TO DO ABOUT ALL ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED OF THEM WE REALLY NEED
SOME SUPPORT IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO DO THAT AND EFFICIENT TIME
FRAME.
THESE ASSESSMENTS ARE GOING TO
SERVE AS A VALIDATION OF WHAT IS
BEEN REFERRED TO AS A SELF
ASSESSMENT WHICH ALL PROVIDERS
WILL -- YOU NEED TO COMPLETE --
AS PART OF THIS PROCESS AS WELL
TO US TO IDENTIFY AGAIN WE ARE
WE ARE IN MEETING THE
REQUIREMENTS AND WHAT NEEDS TO
WHAT ACTIONS NEED TO BE TAKEN IN
ORDER TO GET THERE.
SO THIS PROPOSAL REALLY BUILDS
UPON SOME OF THE PRIOR EFFORTS
AND SOME OF WHICH HAVE BEEN
TOUCHED ON IN THE AGENDA AS WELL.
IT'S REALLY IF YOU THINK ABOUT A
KIND OF A STEPPING STONE OF US
GETTING GETTING TO WHERE WE NEED
TO BE.
AND SO SOME OF THE EFFORTS --
THAT ARE MENTIONED WERE IN THE
BUDGET -- IN PREVIOUS BUDGET HAS
BEEN FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
EACH OF THE PRIOR THREE YEARS --
FOR PROPOSED A SERVICE PROVIDERS
OR TO REQUEST SOME FUNDS IN
ORDER TO MAKE SOME MODIFICATIONS
ARE TO MEET THE THE REQUIREMENTS.
AS THE AGENDA NOTES THAT -- SOME
OF THE ACTIVITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
FUNDED INCLUDED PERSON CENTERED
PLANNING TRAINING AND TRAIN THE
TRAINER -- ASSISTANCE -- WITH
STAFF TO HAVE FOLKS BE ABLE TO
SEE CAN AND OBTAIN COMPETITIVE
EMPLOYMENT.
AND SOME OTHER AREAS AS WELL.
SO PART OF THAT PROCESS AGAIN
TALKING ABOUT BUILDING ON WHERE
WE'VE BEEN GOING IT WAS REALLY
DESIGNED THAT PROCESS WITH SOME
STAKEHOLDER INPUT WHICH WAS VERY
VALUABLE. TO HELP.
NOT ONLY -- OBVIOUSLY.
HOW THE MONEY WOULD BE GIVEN OUT
THE TO HELP PROVIDE SOME
EDUCATION AND FOR US TO ASSESS
WHERE WE ARE AS WELL?
SO THE UPSET THE THAT --
APPROVAL PROCESS OR THE CONCEPT
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS FOR THE
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS REQUIRES
IT PROVIDERS IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE PEOPLE THY SERVE.
REALLY TAKE A LOOK AT WHERE THEY
ARE IN MEETING THESE
REQUIREMENTS INTO THAT PROVIDES
A VALUABLE OPPORTUNITY FOR
KNOWLEDGE PROVIDERS BUT FOLKS
RECEIVING SERVICES TO HELP LEARN.
HOW THESE -- NEW FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS APPLY TO THEIR
SITUATIONS -- ANOTHER THING
THAT'S BEEN.
BUILDING UPON AS SAYS ALSO
REFERENCE TO SEE -- REGIONAL
CENTER STAFF POSITIONS ARE
EVALUATORS AT EACH REGIONAL
CENTER -- SOME OF THE THE
ACTIVITIES A BEEN INVOLVED IN
HIS BAND OVERSIGHT OF THE
OBVIOUSLY THE FUNDING PROCESS
ALSO HOLDING FROM LOCAL FORMS IN
THEIR AREA. TO HELP INFORM NOT
ONLY PROVIDERS BUT ALSO PEOPLE
RECEIVE SERVICES AND DOING SOME
BRAINSTORMING WITHIN THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITY ABOUT WHAT ARE SOME
OTHER THINGS THAT CAN BE DONE.
OR WHEN BUT THESE RULES REALLY
MEAN.
ADDITIONALLY THE APARTMENTS
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH A
CONTRACTOR TO ASSIST IN OUTREACH
AND TRAINING ACTIVITIES THE TO
REFOCUS ON WHAT THESE RULES
MAIMED AND TO PREPARE FOR THE
ASSESSMENT PROCESS.
IN THAT TRAINING AND IN THE OUT
REACH IS NOT ONLY GOING TO BE
FOR PROVIDERS BUT IT'S BEEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY IT'S GOING -- TO
FOCUSED ON FOLKS WHO RECEIVE
SERVICES THEIR FAMILIES AND
OTHERS.
IT IS PART OF THAT OF THAT A
SELF ASSESSMENT PROCESS IN AND
ON SITE ASSESSMENT PROCESS OF
THE SELF ASSESSMENT PROCESS WERE
LOOKING TO START LATER THIS
SUMMER.
AND THEN THE ON SITE ASSESSMENT
PENDING APPROVAL OF THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD START EARLY NEXT
YEAR.
THAT'S GOING TO INFORM US WHERE
WE ARE TO ADDRESS THE QUESTION
DAY YOU HAD IN THE AGENDA OF HOW
MANY -- FACILITIES ARE IN
COMPLIANCE.
AND SO ALSO AGAIN TALKING ABOUT
BUILDING ON TO WHAT WE'RE DOING --
IN YOU KNOW RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF IMPORTANCE OF
PERSON CENTERED PLANNING AND
PERSON CENTER PRACTICES IN.
AS IT RELATES CITIES RULES THE
PARCHMENT SOON GOING TO BE
ENTERING INTO A CONTRACT WITH A
ANOTHER -- ENTITY IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE GUIDANCE TRAINING AND
INFORMATION IN THAT AREA AS WELL
BECAUSE THAT'S JUST SUCH A
CRITICAL ROLE -- PERSON CENTERED --
THINKING AND PRACTICES ARE SUCH
A CRITICAL -- PIECE OF MEETING
THESE REQUIREMENTS SO WE
REALIZED THAT THAT WAS SOMETHING
THAT WE HAD TO DO AS WELL.
SO IT IN ADDITION TO EVERYTHING
THAT WE JUST TALKED ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL ON ALL THOSE STEPS ARE
STILL MORE TO DO -- ONE OF THE
THE OTHER QUESTIONS YOU HAD IN
YOUR AGENDA AS ABOUT THE
HEIGHTENED REVIEW PROCESS OR IS --
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CALLS IT
HEIGHTENED SCRUTINY -- WHICH
JUST THE WORDING OF THAT
OBVIOUSLY CREATES -- A LOT OF
CONCERN RIGHT BECAUSE BEFORE
THAT WHAT REALLY GOES UNDER
QUOTE HEIGHTENED SCRUTINY.
IS SOMETHING THAT'S GOOD -- WHAT --
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT RELATED --
LABEL AS A PLACE IT IS PRESUMED
INSTITUTIONAL.
SO WHAT IT BUT IT REALLY THAN
MEANS FOR FOLKS WHEN YOU READ
THAT IS THAT.
YOU'RE PRESUMED GUILTY AND LESS
AFTER WE REALLY REALLY LOOK
CLOSE YOU CAN PROVE THAT YOU'RE
NOT -- SO THAT OBVIOUSLY CREATES
A LOT OF CONCERN FOR US AND SO
IT'S IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
REALLY BEEN TRYING TO TAKE A
MAJOR LOOK AT IN DEVELOPING WHAT
THAT PROCESS IS.
BECAUSE TO WE HAD TO WHAT WHAT
FALLS UNDER THAT -- PROCESS ARE
PLACES THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS SAID -- TEND TO
ISOLATE.
AND SO INITIAL GUIDANCE FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WAS --
ACTUALLY.
HAD A LITTLE BIT EVEN CREATED
MORE CONFUSION AND WHEN READ
LITERALLY ONE COULD EVEN THINK
THAT -- PLACES THAT WERE WORLD
THAT WE'RE NOT LOCATED NEAR --
PUBLIC AND OR WERE NOT LOCATED
NEAR PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION.
FIT INTO THIS -- THIS THIS
REVIEW PROCESS WHICH OF COURSE
CREATED EVEN MORE CONFUSION
KNOWING THAT -- THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAD FOR A LONG TIME --
INDICATED THAT FURTHER GUIDANCE
WOULD BE COMING OUT WE REALLY
WERE WANTING TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE WE HAD THE MOST RECENT
INFORMATION BEFORE GOING FORWARD.
SO THAT GUIDANCE DID JUST COME
OUT IN MARCH OF THIS YEAR WE
SENT IT OUT TO OUR STAKEHOLDERS.
AND WE WANT -- TO OBVIOUSLY BE
INFORMED BY OR ADVISORY GROUP
AND OTHERS AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN
DEVELOPING THAT PROCESS.
AND SO THAT'S INITIALLY WERE
GOING TO BE HAVING A MEETING
WITH OUR EIGHT CBS ADVISOR GROUP
LATER THIS MONTH AND THAT'S
GOING TO BE PART OF THE TOPICS.
THANK YOU A THOMAS MILIEU.
THANK YOU -- REGARDING THE
PROPOSAL -- FOR FOR CONDUCTING
THE ON SITE ASSESSMENTS -- WE
AGREE WITH THE DEPARTMENT THAT
THIS -- IS SOMETHING THAT IT IS
GOING TO NEED TO HAPPEN SOON --
IT'S PART OF THE STATE WIDE
TRANSITION PLAN THAT'S BEEN --
INITIALLY APPROVED BY THE
CENTERS FOR MEDICARE AND
MEDICAID SERVICES -- AND THEY
DID BASE THEIR COSTS ON AND WHAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ESTIMATES COSTS WILL BE
TO CONDUCT THOSE ASSESSMENTS SO.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THAT PROPOSAL -- REGARDING AS
THE EACH CBS RULES MORE
GENERALLY -- IF I MAY I'D LIKE
TO SORT OF T. HAVE BEEN ISSUE
THAT WILL PROBABLY BE DISCUSSED
NEXT WEEK IN OUR RATE STUDY
DISCUSSION AND THAT IS.
THAT IN GENERAL THERE MAY NEED
TO BE MORE TRANSPARENCY FROM THE
DEPARTMENT ABOUT WHICH SERVICE
CATEGORIES IT DOES NOT CONSIDER
COMPLIANCE WITH THE EACH CBS
RULES.
A GOOD EXAMPLE OF THE WORK
ACTIVITY PROGRAMS THERE'S I
THINK -- SOME.
ANXIETY IT -- IN THE COMMUNITY
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THIS
SERVICE -- HAS TO GO OR WHETHER
THERE'S A WAY TO WORK IT OUT
BIRD DOESN'T HAVE TO GO -- IT'S
SORT OF UNCLEAR AND SO I THINK
IT'LL BE REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
THE DEPARTMENT TO PROVIDE SOME
GUIDANCE ON HOW THOSE TAPES BUT
IF THOSE SERVICES ARE NOT GOING
TO BE SUPPORTED IN THE FUTURE.
HOW THEY'RE GOING TO BE PHASED
OUT AND WHAT ALTERNATIVE?
SERVICES GOOD QUALITY
ALTERNATIVE SERVICES WILL BE
PROVIDED TO CONSUMERS DURING THE
PHASE OUT AND AFTERWARD
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FINANCE ONCE.
ALL RIGHT AND WE HAVE -- TO
SINGLE PAYER WHAT THE COMMENT ON
ON THIS -- SO WE HAVE MARTY
AMADO ACOSTA AND IS A DIRECTOR
OF CALIFORNIA DISABILITY SENIOR
ME ACTION NETWORK AND JAMIE
DAVIS EXACT DOCTOR MARIN VENTURE
SO THEY WILL START WITH.
AND THAT ORDERED AND OKAY AND
WILL BE BRIEFED WE KNOW THE TIME
IS THEM WE APPRECIATE -- YOU
KNOW YOU THE THE HEARING AND ALL
THE ISSUES THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE
OF HEARD.
OF FIRST -- DDS HAS TAKEN SOME
GOOD STEPS ON OF MOVING TOWARDS
A COMPLIANCE OF EIGHT CBS AND
I'VE BEEN ON THE EIGHT CBS
ADVISORY COMMITTEE FOR THE PAST
OR GROUP FOR THE PAST FIVE YEARS.
BUT WE DO THINK THAT THERE NEED
TO BE MUCH MORE GUIDANCE COMING
FROM THE DEPARTMENT AND FROM THE
STATE -- IN PERHAPS THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDING MORE
GUIDANCE ON WHAT COMPLIANCE
MEANS.
AND ONE THING WE WOULD ST
SUGGEST SAYS AFTER BI BI MONTHLY
MONTH -- BY MONTHLY CONFERENCE
CALLS -- WEBINARS WITH THE EIGHT
CBS TRANSITION FUNDING GRANTEES --
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE
TALKED TO SOME OF THE GRANTEES
IS THAT THERE'S CONFUSION ABOUT
YOU KNOW WHETHER WHAT THEY'RE
DOING IN THEIR PROJECT IS -- IN
COMPLIANCE OR THEY'RE RUNNING
INTO DIFFERENCE OF OPINION
WHAT'S THE THE REGIONAL CENTER --
PERSON AND THAT'S NOT TO SAY
THAT THE REGIONAL CENTER PERSONS
A BAD PERSON IS JUST MEANS OUT.
THE CONFERENCE CALLED WOULD
PROMOTE MORE OF A PARTNERSHIP
BECAUSE THIS IS REALLY AN
EXCITING THING IF WE WORK AT
RIGHT. TO TRANSFORMING OUR
SYSTEM ALSO THAT THE D. G. DDS.
ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON THE CBS
NEED TO MEET MORE FREQUENTLY
PERHAPS ON A QUARTERLY BASIS WE
DON'T MEET.
AT ALL SOMETIMES -- YOU KNOW FOR
LONG PERIODS OF TIME SO WHAT IT
THE LACK OF INFORMATION PROMOTE
SO.
A LOT OF FEAR AND ANXIETY -- AND
ALSO -- I'VE HEARD FROM SOME OF
THE GRANTEES.
SOMETIMES -- SOME OF THE GRANTS
ARE TREATED MORE AS A PROGRAM
AND NOT AS A GRANT AND THEREFORE
IT IT MAKES IT MUCH MORE HARDER.
TO IMPLEMENT THE GRANT -- SECOND
DATE CBS FINAL RULE INCLUDES
PROVISIONS REQUIRING PERSON
CENTERED PLANNING IN THAT
PROCESS WHICH JIM SPOKE OF IN AT
THIS DONE THE RIGHT WAY CAN HAVE
BE A SIGNIFICANT TOOL IN PROCESS
TO ALIGNING.
WHAT A PERSON WANTS AND NEEDS?
TO WHAT SERVICES SUPPORTS CAN BE
PROVIDED MEASURED BY OUTCOMES
AND MOST PEOPLE DON'T WHAT IT IS
AND SO WE WOULD SUGGEST.
THAT THE DEPARTMENT IN KERR --
ACTUALLY REQUIRES THAT WERE UP
ALLOW -- PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENT
DISABILITIES -- TO RECEIVE THE
ORIENTATION AND TRAINING AND
PERSON CENTERED PLANNING --
THIRD.
SOME SETTINGS AS A THE HE'LL
ELLIE -- JUST MENTION MAY OR MAY
NOT BE IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE H.
E. B. AS FINAL RULE.
IT IS NOT FAIR TO THE WORKERS OF
THE PEOPLE IN THOSE TYPES OF
SETTINGS. TO BE CONTINUED TO
CONTINUE YEAR AFTER YEAR NOT
KNOWING WHETHER OR NOT YOU'RE
SETTING WOULD EVER BE IN
COMPLIANCE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE STATE
ADMINISTRATION NEEDS.
TO KIND OF MOVE FORWARD ON SOME
POLICY ISSUES AND TERM AND TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THE CERTAIN
SETTING IS ACTUALLY NO LONGER.
WHAT WE NEED TO BE AND THAT WE
SHOULD TRANSITION THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AND THOSE WORKERS
INTO A?
A A DIFFERENT TYPE OF SETTING
THAT IS THAT IS COMPLIANT AND
USE THE SAME TYPE OF PROCESS AND
SENSITIVITY THAT WE USE WHEN WE
CLOSE THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
MEANING WE TREATED THE STAFF AS
WELL AS THE PEOPLE RECEIVING
SERVICES WITH RESPECT.
AND TO TRY TO MAINTAIN THEIR
LEVEL OF EXPERTISE AND MOVING
THEM INTO A COMMUNITY LASTLY.
FUNDING IS A MAJOR BARRIER FOR
PROVIDERS AND THE PEOPLE THEY
SERVE IN TRANSITIONING TO
COMPLIANCE AT THAT WE SUGGEST
THAT YOU WOULD TARGET.
OR THE STATE TARGET SO FUNDING
INCREASES TO THOSE PEOPLE TO
THOSE PROVIDERS WHO ARE
COMPLIANT OR IN PROCESS OF
TRANSITION TOWARD COMPLIANCE
THANKS.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR THANK AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
MY NAME IS JAMIE DAVIS AND I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR MARIN
VENTURES A SITE BASED COMMUNITY
INTEGRATION TRAINING PROGRAM IN
CENTER FILE.
AND I'VE SUBMITTED A MORE
COMPLETE VERSION OF MY REMARKS --
TO THE COMMITTEE.
I'D LIKE TO OFFER A WAY TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT AN INSTITUTION IS AND
WHAT CAN BE ISOLATING FOR THE
PEOPLE WE SERVE.
THE MORE THE ACTIVITIES FOCUS ON
THE NEEDS OF THE STAFF THE MORE
LIKELY IT IS IT'S AN INSTITUTION.
WHEN WE BECOME CENTERED ON THE
PERSON WERE SERVING?
WE MOVE TOWARD LESS
INSTITUTIONAL OPERATIONS.
I ALSO BELIEVE WE NEED TO BE
VERY CAREFUL ABOUT PHILOSOPHIES
AND POLICIES WE PROMOTE.
MOST OF THE PEOPLE WE SUPPORT
HAVE THE SMALLEST ARE NO
POLITICAL VOICE.
AND ARE AMONG THE MOST
MARGINALIZED AND IMPOVERISHED.
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER THE POWER
THAT WE HAVE AS WE ADVOCATE FOR
THEM.
MY REMARKS TODAY FOCUS ON
WHETHER PROVIDERS FEEL PREPARED
FOR MARCH.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WHEN WILL BE
EXPECTED BE FULLY COMPLIANT WITH
H. CBS SETTINGS REGULATIONS.
ESPECIALLY WITH REGARD TO A
SETTINGS WHICH MAY BE ISOLATING --
ACCORDING TO AGE CBS.
I THINK THEY'RE BIG UNANSWERED
QUESTIONS THAT I HEAR FROM
PROVIDERS WHEN WE HAVE THE SELF
ASSESSMENTS OF OUR PROGRAM SO WE
CAN FIND OUT IF WE APPEAR TO BE
COMPLIANT TO THE REGULATIONS.
ACCORDING TO OURSELVES.
WHEN WE KNOW IF WE'VE
INTERPRETED THE SELF ASSESSMENT
CORRECTLY ACCORDING TO THE STATE?
WHEN WE KNOW WHAT PROGRAMS A
STATE WILL SELECT FOR FURTHER
REVIEW?
WHEN ALL STATE TELL US IF THEY
ARE DEFINING CHARACTERISTICS OF
ISOLATING BEYOND THE FEDERAL
GUIDELINES AND WHAT ARE THOSE?
WHEN WE KNOW FOR PROGRAM IS
CONSIDERED TO BE ISOLATING AND
THEREFORE NOT COMPLIANT?
WHAT IS THE DEPARTMENT OF FELT
MIDDLE SERVICES DURING TO
PARTNER WITH KEY AGENCIES LIKE
COMMITTEE CARE LICENSING SO THE
COMPLIANCE WITH H. CBS DOES NOT
PUT US OUT OF COMPLIANCE WITH
COMMUNICATOR LICENSING?
HOW WILL THE STATE HELP
PROVIDERS WORK WITH AN
EMPLOYMENT LAW TO BECOME MORE
PERSON CENTERED?
WHEN SOME EMPLOYMENT LAWS LIKE
BREAK AND REST PERIODS ARE IN
CONFLICT WITH BEING LESS
INSTITUTIONAL?
HOW CAN WE INNOVATE AND DEVELOP
BETTER PRACTICES TO HELP US
BECOME H. CBS COMPLIANT?
WE TEETER ON THE EDGE OF
FINANCIAL INSTABILITY.
I'M HAPPY TO BE A RESOURCE FOR
THE COMMITTEE AND INVITE YOU TO
VISIT MARIN VENTURES OR ANY
PROGRAM WHICH MAY BE.
PERCEIVED BE ISOLATING UNDER AGE
TO BE US.
FINALLY AS I DO IT EVERY
OPPORTUNITY I WOULD LIKE TO ADD
THAT UNTIL WE CAN PAY OUR DIRECT
SUPPORT EMPLOYEES A BETTER THAN.
POVERTY LEVEL WAGES OUR ABILITY
TO ACTUALLY MEET THE H. CBS
GUIDELINES IS TERRIBLY TERRIBLY
COMPROMISED.
AND BILLIONS OF FEDERAL DOLLARS
ARE AT STAKE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SO.
WHAT I'M HEARING IS THAT --
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY NEED
TO DO [inaudible]
SO HOW.
AND THEY HAD AND YOU HAVE UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY TWO MARCH -- YOU
CAN'T TELL PEOPLE THE LAST
MINUTE AND HAVE THEM SUDDENLY
CHANGES WHAT THEY'RE DOING THEY
DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE DOING
THE RIGHT THINGTHEY'RE NOT WHAT
THEY'RE EXPECTED TO DO WHAT
THEY'RE IN.
FACT SO -- TELL ME HERE SO.
WHAT WHAT WE CAN DO TO DREAD
SUITED TO ADDRESS THAT A CELL?
THANK YOU YOU KNOW AND THESE ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT COMMENTS AND
AND ONE OF THE BENEFITS OF OUR
EIGHT CBS WORKGROUP IS TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE -- THE DIALOGUE TO
TO SAY OKAY WHERE THE THE THE
THINGS THAT ARE CONCERNING TO
THE COMMUNITY TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
TOWARDS THE COMPLIANCE WE STILL
HAVE THE FIFTEEN MILLION EVERY
YEAR -- THAT THIS IS OUR THIRD
YEAR OF PUTTING FORWARD AS
MISTER KNIGHT HEAD HAD SHARED.
SO THOSE ARE THAT'S ONE OF THE
EFFORTS THAT WERE WERE DOING.
I DO AGREE THAT THE
COMMUNICATION NEEDS TO IMPROVE
AS FAR AS BEING ABLE TO HAVE
THAT COMMUNICATION TO THE
COMMUNITY AND REALLY THE EFFORT
BY HAVING THE ARE IF HE AND THE
CONTRACTORS THAT WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO USE.
IS GOING TO GIVE US THE
INFORMATION AS TO THOSE STEPS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE TAKING
FOR THE SELF EVALUATIONS AND
THEN TE SITE ASSESSMENTS.
SO HAVING THAT.
ASSISTANCE WITH THE CONSULTANTS
IS GOING TO GIVE CLARITY TO WHAT
WE CAN COMMUNICATE.
SO VERY YOU KNOW HAVING THESE
ELEMENTS IS GOING TO BE THE
INFORMATION TO DO THAT -- THE
COMMITMENT OF WORKING WITH THE
AGE TO BE S. WORK GROUP IS --
GOING TO BE STEPPED UP AND
THAT'S EVIDENCED BY HAVING TO
THE MEETING THAT SCHEDULED NOW
AND WE'RE GOING TO BE SEEN OF
THAT MUCH MORE FREQUENT TIME --
MORE WE'RE GONNA BE SPENDING
TOGETHER WITH OUR COMMUNITY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE GETTING THE
INFORMATION AND TAKING THOSE
STEPS THE OTHER THING IS IS THAT --
FIRST OF ALL YOU'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT SOUNDS LIKE YOU TRY
TO FIGURE OUT SOME OF THE
ANSWERS RIGHT TO AND AND
ACTUALLY I I WOULD POINT OUT SO
THE EIGHT CBS.
RULES ARE SET BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO WRITE SO I
APPRECIATE REFERENCING THE
LEGISLATURE BUT ACTUALLY
COMPLIANCE IS THAT SOMETHING WE
HAVE MUCH OF A SAY AND IT'S THE
FED'S WORKING WITH THE AGENCY
AND THEN SAY THAT THIS IS SO.
AND BELIEVE ME I DEAL WITH THIS
ON THE MEDI CAL SIDE OTHER
PLACES TO WRITE SO -- TO BE SURE
EVERYONE'S ON THE SAME PAGE --
ELSA HOPE THAT IN TERMS OF
COMMUNICATION THAT.
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY EVERYONE HAS
REIMPORTANT ROLES TO PLAY BUT
THAT WE'RE NOT IT'S NOT THAT
THINGS ARE LIKE TELEPHONE WHAT
HAPPENS SO I TELL YOU AND THEN
THAT PERSON SPACE TELL THEM THAT
PERSONS POSTS TO TELL THEM
BECAUSE IT'S POSSIBLE THERE'S
THINGS GET LOST IN TRANSLATION.
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
SOMETHING LIKE THIS THERE'S
PEOPLE EVERY LAYER SHOULD HAVE
BE ABLE TO HEAR THAT HAVE DIRECT
CONTACT WITH.
THE DEPARTMENT BECAUSE YOU'RE
THE FINAL ARBITER BE OUT YOUR
THE INTERPRETER TO FINAL
ARBITRATION FROM THE SAID SO I
MEAN.
AND SO EL AT THE THE CONTRACTOR
WITH TWO DEALS WITH THAT
REGIONAL CENTER.
NOW DOESN'T NEED NEED TO BE ABLE
TO SAY WELL ACTUALLY THAT
EVERYONE EASIER SAME THING SO
THEY KNOW WHAT THE RULES ARE
IT'S NOT THAT -- WELL.
I HEARD THE DEPARTMENT SAY ACTS
SO I'M TRYING TO ENFORCE ACTS
BUT TURNS OUT IT'S A LITTLE
DIFFERENT THAN WHATEVER SO.
I I HOPE THAT I MEAN I THINK
THERE'S GONNA BE A LOT OF
COMMUNICATION NEEDS TO HAPPEN
AND PEOPLE THAT HAVE TO HEAR
DIRECTLY FROM.
DEPARTMENT DEPARTMENT THEY'RE
GONNA COME UP QUESTIONS THE
DEPARTMENT'S GOING TO HAVE TO
ANSWER THAT AND ACTUALLY THAT
BECOMES YOU KNOW A RULING THAT
EVERYONE ELSE KNOWS RIGHT BUT
INSTEAD EVERYONE.
TRYING OF THIS LATER THINKS IT'S
THIS NOW THEIR THINGS IT'S THAT.
IS IT'S THAT I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT MAYBE YOUR THAT IS THAT
IT'S GOING TO BE IS THAT ISSUE
THAT YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT.
OKAY YEAH SO WITH SO I THINK THE
AND AND THAT CAN'T START
HAPPENING AND TWENTY TWENTY TWO
SEC IN MANY WAYS IT BECAUSE THEY
ALL HAVE TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS
RIGHT THEN PEOPLE OF THAT SIDE
WHAT THEY'RE GONNA DO WHAT
THEY'RE NOT THE ON SATURDAY I
CAN IF I CAN.
I'M IN THE LEAD TIMES ARE MUCH
LONGER.
FOR YOU KNOW NONPROFIT SET UP
BOARDS THAT HAVE TO RUN YOU KNOW
THE CHANGES YOU KNOW AND GET
YOUR GET IT GET THAT APPROVED
WOULD GO BY THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS BUT ALSO THEY HAVE TO
TALK WITH THEIR FAMILIES AT
THEIR SERVING.
WITH THE PEOPLE THERE SERVING IN
HIS ANXIETY LEVEL THERE AGAIN I
YOU KNOW I PLUGGED THE
DEPARTMENT FOR TRYING TO WORK
WITH US BUT THERE'S SO MUCH
UNCERTAINTY.
OF AND ANDERS PROVIDERS WHO ARE
TRYING TO MOVE ON THEIR OWN TO
BE COMPLIANT.
BUT THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
AND AND SO TO YOUR POINT.
AND ALSO LEGISLATURE CAN DO
SOMETHING THEY CAN ACTUALLY
INCORPORATE ALL THE GOOD
ELEMENTS OF THE CBS ROLL INTO
STATE LAW [inaudible]
THAT'S BUT I GUESS THERE'S NOT A
BIG PLOT FOR THAT BUT IT BUT BUT
YOU KNOW THAT IS A WAY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO GET INVOLVED.
CARE FOR YOU ASK.
FOR IN THE SECOND I SAID THAT I
WHICH IS KIND OF THINKING OF A
DOWN SO -- BECAUSE WELL I THINK
WHAT WE WANT IS IS THAT WE WANT
TO TRY TO GET AS MUCH LATITUDE
AS POSSIBLE FROM THE FED SO THAT
THE STATE CAN THEN HAVE LATITUDE
TO WORK WITH BECAUSE RECOGNIZING
IN THE END.
THE YOU KNOW.
EVERY PROVIDERS GOING TO HAVE A
CIRCUMSTANCE THAT THERE THAT'S
GOING TO MAKE A LOT OF SENSE AND
IS A SHOULD BE THE RIGHT THING
TO DO BUT THAT AND THEY'RE
TRYING TO MAKE IT SAID INSIDE A
BOX RIGHT BECAUSE OF THE HIGHER
UP YOU GO THE MORE LAYS YOU.
GO UP THE MORE YOU KNOW IT THE
RADICAL IT GETS LET'S PUT IT
THIS WAY AND SO -- SO AND
DEPENDING ON WHA FEDERAL AGENCY
WE'RE DEALING WITH THAT THE
FEDERAL AGENCY HOW STRICT THEY
WANT TO BE AND THEN THAT HOW
THAT GETS OPPOSED TO DOWN AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL SO.
I APPRECIATE EVERYONE NEEDS TO
KNOW WHAT.
FIRST OF ALL YOU I KNOW WHAT YOU
HAVE TO DO BUT THEN WHEN YOU
SUDDENLY REALIZE WHAT YOU HAVE
TO DO YOU MIGHT PUSH BACK AND
SAY WELL THAT'S NOT THE BEST
THING FOR MY CLIENT.
RIGHT.
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU SHOULD DO IS
AN ADVOCATE THEN THE QUESTIONS
HOUSE I GET TRANSLATED BACK UP.
AND HOW HE LEADS US TO GO UP SO
ANYWAY -- THAT EIGHTY HERE WHAT
THE WE NEED TO DO AND CERTAINLY
WE'RE GONNA BE VERY INTERESTED
SUMMIT OVER SEVEN BILLION IT'S
NOT THAT I DON'T DO ANY LAWS IS
MORE ABOUT THE OVERSIGHT
FUNCTION AND BEING SURE THAT --
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE MOVING ON THIS
CERTAINLY I THINK THERE'S A LOT
OF PROMISE BUT I THINK IF PEOPLE
NEED TO KNOW THE AFTER ACTION
AND I WAS LOOKING FOR IT TELL.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO I THINK AS A
ANNOUNCED EARLIER WE WILL NOW
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS ON ISSUES
THIS IS ISSUES FOUR THROUGH.
EIGHT AGAIN I ASK THAT -- FOR
SELF PEOPLE OF COMMON ON ISSUES
FOUR THROUGH EIGHT AND I ASK
THAT YOU TRY TO KEEP YOUR
REMARKS TO A MINUTE OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S MORE YOU WANT TO EXPLAIN
YOU CAN FEEL FREE.
TO SUBMIT WRITTEN COMMENTS --
LATER OR IF YOU HAVE THEM WITH
YOU EVEN NOW -- SO WELCOME THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AARON
CARUTHERS EXACTED DIRECTOR THE
STATE COUNCIL DEVELOPMENT
DISABILITIES SPEAKING ON ISSUE
NUMBER SIX I THINK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT.
FOR POINTING OUT IN THE ANALYSIS
ABOUT THE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THAT THE LA -- ESTIMATES
THAT COULD BE AVAILABLE IN THE
SAVINGS FROM OPERATIONAL
OPERATING THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS.
PRESHEAF MISTER TEARS COMMENTS
THAT IN NET THE SYSTEM IS
RECEIVING MORE.
WEATHER GETS THESE THIS HAD A
MILLION DOLLARS ARE NOT THE ONE
INVITE THE CHAIR TO CONSIDER THE
UNIQUE CHALLENGE THAT HOUSING
PLAYS IN REALLY FULFILLING THE
PROMISE THE LANTERN ACT.
AND WE KNOW HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AGO THE BEST THING WE
COULD DO IS PUT PEOPLE INTO
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS AND
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE YEARS LATER
WE KNOW THE BEST THING TO DO IS
KEEP PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITIES.
THE REALITY IS IT 63% OF
REGIONAL CENTER ADULTS.
ADULT CLIENTS ARE LIVING IN A
FAMILY HOME.
WHICH MEANS THAT THE PROMISED
LAND TO ENACT IS BEING DELIVERED
ON THE BACKS OF FAMILIES THIS IT
AND AND IT'S A POPULATION THAT
IS AGING QUICKLY IT'S WHEN IT
CAN'T BE SUSTAINED SO I THINK
IT'S WHETHER SUCH FOCUS FROM THE
ADVOCACY COMMUNITY.
ON THIS HUNTER MILLION DOLLARS
AS A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO
CREATE A DEDICATED REVENUE
STREAM THE STATE COUNCIL CREATED
A STATEWIDE STRATEGIC PLAN.
ON HOUSING FOR PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENT
DISABILITIES AND WE WOULD LIKE
TO ENGAGE IN CONVERSATION THE
COMMITTEE ABOUT.
SOLUTIONS THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND I APPRECIATE THE THE
POINTING OUT THE AT HOUSING
COSTS THANK YOU.
NOW THAT IS THE LOCAL V. -- SCA
YOU DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
COUNCIL.
IN WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT
THE PLANS FOR THE USE OF THE
PROPERTY OF THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS AS THEY CLOSE -- WE'RE
GLAD TO HEAR THAT THE STATE IS
NOT TALKING ABOUT CLEARING THEM
SURPLUS.
BECAUSE THE PURPOSE FOR WHICH
THEY CREATED IS CERTAINLY NOT
SURPLUS WE CERTAINLY NEED TO DO
A LOT MORE TO HELP PROVIDE A
HEALTHY AND SAFE ENVIRONMENT FOR
PEOPLE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES TO LIVE IN -- AND
TO THAT PURPOSE I THINK THE
REVENUE GENERATED FROM THOSE
PROPERTIES SHOULD ON AN ONGOING
BASIS BE DEDICATED BACK TO THAT
PURPOSE AND NOT SIMPLY.
DISAPPEAR.
OKAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
SENATOR PANDA RICK ROLLINS REPS
IN ARKANSAS SHE XIN REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCY ADD RESPECT YOUR
TIME YOUR YOUR VALUABLE TIME --
JUST WANT TO MAKE A COMMENT
QUICKLY ON ITEM NUMBER FIVE
SEVEN AND EIGHT ON ITEM FIVE THE
FEDERAL CLAIMS REIMBURSEMENT
PROJECT.
THE STRONG SUPPORT GIVEN THE
DEPARTMENT EVERY EFFORT TO GET
OUR FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENTS INTO
THE SYSTEM AND I THINK IT'S IN
EVERYONE'S BEST A BEST INTEREST
THAT HAPPENS IN A TIMELY MATTER --
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SAFETY NET
FACILITIES AND CRISIS -- WE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH A D. R. C.
AND THE DEPARTMENT -- AND OTHERS
ON ON THOSE PROPOSALS TO ME
CAPACITY AND OTHER ISSUES
SURROUNDING THAT.
AN ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SAID
OVERVIEW B. C. P. -- WE JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THE STATE
REMAINS IN CONTROL OF THAT
PROCESS AND THAT THE CONTRACTOR
DOESN'T TAKE OVER CONTROL THANK
YOU OKAY THANK YOU I WOULD MAKE
NOTED STOP MY TIME I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT IT'S THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
TO PRESENTS LATER ON IN THIS
HEARING AS WELL AS RESPECT.
THEIR TIME.
THANK YOU WELCOME WILL SAVE IT
FEATURES EXPLORED -- ON ISSUE
NUMBER FOR A SPORT THAT YES IS A
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL STAFF IN A
DDS I REALLY SUPPORT THE LA OWES
COMMENT RELATED.
TO INNOVATION. EIGHTY BEST IS A
WHOLE NEW SYSTEM SELF
DETERMINATION IS A WHOLE NEW
SYSTEM WE NEED INNOVATION NOT
MONITORING WE NEED IMPROVEMENT
NOT MONITORING SO I THINK WE
NEED TO REALLY MAKE SURE THAT
FOCUSES RIGHT.
AND THEN TO THE COMPLIANCE.
WE DO NEED DRECTION SO WE KNOW
WHAT WE'RE DOING AND AGAIN WE
DON'T WANT TO LOSE ANY CAPACITY
WE HAVE TODAY WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH.
WE NEED TO HELP THAT CAPACITY
CHANGE WHAT WE WANTED TO DO
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME MISTER CHAIRMAN AGAIN A
CARL LUNDEN YOU'RE ABOUT FOR OF
THE ALLIANCE SUPPORTING PEOPLE'S
ID DE.
I JUST WANT TO ECHO WHAT TO MR
SANFORD SAID ALLOWED ONE BRIEF
COMMENT.
AND THAT IS THERE'S REALLY
NOTHING UNDER EACH CBS
COMPLIANCE AND THAT WHOLE REGIME
THIS COMING.
THAT'S CHEAPER THAN ANYTHING WE
DO TODAY.
SO TO THE EXTENT WERE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT STICKER
SHOCK AND PRICE TAG ISSUES
AROUND THE RATES STEADY OR WHAT
WE FIND TODAY OR WHAT WE'RE NOT
FUNDING.
GET READY BECAUSE THE H. CBS
REGIME LOOKS LIKE IT'S GOING TO
COST MORE TO MATTER WHAT WE DO
AND I THINK THAT'S GOING.
TO CREATE A VERY SERIOUS POLICY
CONSIDERATION FOR YOU IF YOU OF
PROGRAMS IN AN AREA.
THAT WE SUDDENLY DEEM NOT
COMPLIANT UNDER EACH C. B. S. IN
THE PROGRAM GOES AWAY AND THREE
HUNDRED PEOPLE LOSE THEIR
PROGRAM.
THAT'S A SERIOUS PROBLEM THAT
SOME CENTER ALL OF A SUDDEN AS
WHEN THE WHEN THE PHONE DOESN'T
STOP RINGING.
AND THAT'S GONNA BE PARTICULAR
PROBLEM WE BELIEVE IN RURAL
AREAS -- PERFECTLY WITH REGARDS
TO WORK BASED PROGRAMS WHERE THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES IN RURAL
AREAS ARE MUCH HIGHER THAN THEY
ARE EVERYWHERE ELSE SO.
GOING UP THE COMMUNITY IN
FINDING AN INTEGRATED JOB WHEN
THERE AREN'T JOBS.
THAT'S COULD RAISE A WHOLE
DIFFERENT KIND OF PROBLEM FOR US
TO THINK THROUGH JUST WANNA MAKE
YOU WEAR THAT THING OUT THANK
YOU AND I UNDERSTAND WILL BE
TALKING ABOUT THE RATE STUDY.
THE NEXT WEEK SO THAT IN A TO
CVS SO WE HAVEN'T FORGOTTEN THAT
THANK YOU WELCOME.
HI -- I'M EGGMAN THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR GOLDEN GATE REGIONAL
CENTER WE SERVE TEN THOUSAND
FOLKS IN SAN MATTEO.
SAN FRANCISCO IN MARIN COUNTY
SOME TIMING MYSELF SO BECAUSE
I'M NOT KNOWN FOR BREVITY -- I
JUST WANTED THERE'S A THEME I
GUESS MY COMMENTS GO TO ISSUES
FOR SEVEN EIGHT BUT I'M SURE
WILL APPLY TO NINE IN SOME WAYS.
TO THIS IDEA YOU'VE HEARD TODAY
OF THE THREE LAYERS OF THE
SYSTEM DEPARTMENT -- REGIONAL
CENTERS AND PROVIDER AGENCIES.
BEEN MUCH TALK ABOUT THE
CAPACITY IN RESPONSIVENESS AND
SO WE APPLAUD THE IDEA OF HAVING
A SINGLE.
DDS -- YOU KNOW ORGANIZATION
AROUND A COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES -- AND APPLY THE IDEA
OF A STANDARDIZED STATEWIDE DATA
SYSTEM BECAUSE WE SHOULD ALL BE
MEASURING THE SAME THINGS TO
IDENTIFY GAPS -- BUT WITHOUT
INVESTMENTS IN THE CAPACITY IN
AND RESPONSIVENESS OF REGIONAL
CENTERS AND PROVIDER AGENCIES --
ALL THE INVESTMENTS IN
MONITORING AND THE LAYERING OF
STATUTORY EXPECTATIONS IS NOT
CAN IMPROVE THE OUTCOMES FOR THE
PEOPLE WE SERVE.
AND OWNS SO IN MY THIRTY YEARS
AT THAT SEE IT'S BEEN NOT THE
WHERE WITH ALL IN SOME CASES NOT
EVEN THE MODELS OF SERVICE BUT
JUST OUR ABILITY TO HAVE THE
RIGHT STAFF TO DO TEM.
IF YOU LOOK AT OVER THE LAST
TWELVE YEARS FOR GOLDEN GATE
REGIONAL CENTER THE PERCENTAGE
OF OUR TIRE BUDGET THAT GOES --
TO OPERATIONS HAS GONE FROM 15%
IN 2000528% NOW AND THAT'S THE
CAPACITY WE LACK TO BE ABLE TO
THE THINGS WE WANT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
JUDY MARK DISABILITY VOICES NINE
PARENT -- ON SAFETY NET -- WE
WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT WE NEED
TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO KEEP
PEOPLE OUT AT HOME.
AND THAT MEANS THAT WE HAVE TO
ALLOW THEM TO HAVE HEALTH AND
SAFETY WAIVERS TO BE ABLE TO
ACCOMMODATE STAFF FOR PEOPLE
WITH HIGHER NEEDS AND WE DIDN'T
HEAR A LOT ABOUT THAT TODAY BUT
WE HAVE CONCERNS THAT IT.
TAKES TOO LONG TO GET THOSE
APPROVED AS WELL AS WE SUPPORT
THE DRC PROPOSAL THAT ALLOWS FOR
MORE OF THESE MOBILE CRISIS
UNITS TO KEEP PEOPLE HOME.
ON THE H. CBS ISSUE -- YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT HOW WITH THEIR
NEEDS TO BE MORE INFORMATION TO
PROVIDERS.
I CAN TELL YOU FAMILIES NO
NOTHING WE NOTE I KNOW BECAUSE I
SIT AND GO TO THE MEETINGS BUT
WE KNOW NOTHING NO INFORMATION
HAS BEEN GIVEN TO THEM.
AND THEY'RE THE ONES THAT ARE
GONNA BE AFFECTED THE MOST.
ON AND I ALSO I JUST WANT TO
TAKE A DECENT DIFFERENT ISSUES I
DON'T THINK THAT EACH CBS
COMPLIANT.
SETTINGS ARE NECESSARILY MORE
EXPENSIVE I AM A VERY BIG FAN OF
THIS RULE I BELIEVE THAT IT IS
WHAT ARE.
MY SON WANTS IS TO BE INTEGRATED
IN THE COMMUNITY AND IT MEANS
THAT INSTEAD OF GOING TO
SEPARATE PROGRAMS WHERE YOU'RE
WITH PEOPLE DISABILITIES ALL DAY
YOU'RE GOING TO THE BOYS GOT
YOU'RE GOING TO WIND CA.
YOU'RE GOING TO OUR CLASS AND
YOU ARE PAYING FOR SOMEONE TO
SUPPORT YOU TO BE INTEGRATED IN
THE COMMUNITY.
I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT IS MORE
EXPENSIVE IT IS A DIFFERENT WAY
OF LOOKING AT SUPPORTING PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME THANK YOU A VERY JEDINI
CSA JUST WANT TO COMMENT ON TWO
ISSUES FIRST ON THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER CLOSER JUST
WANT TO ECHO OUR SUPPORT FOR MR
LONDON'S POSITION -- TO MAKE
SURE THAT WERE REINVESTING IN IN
BOTH THE COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF HOUSING
FOR PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
AND THEN ON THE TBS PIECE -- ONE
ECHO MISS DAVIS'S POINTS ABOUT
OUR CONCERNS ABOUT THE TIMING
THE RECENT FEDERAL.
FEDERAL GUIDANCE THEY CAME OUT
IN IN SUPPORT OF THIS STATE
STIPULATES THAT THE STATE SHOULD
HAVE THEIR THEIR DUCKS IN A ROW
BY JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY IN
TERMS OF WHAT'S GOING TO BE
SUBMITTED FOR HEIGHTENED
SCRUTINY.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO
GO TO GET THEIR WITHIN ONE
YOURSELF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI CAROLYN TAMALE AGAIN I'M
WEARING A HAT A IFFERENT HAT
RIGHT NOW AS A SOCIAL WORKER
LEASES CLINICAL SOCIAL GREEN A
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL.
OUR TELL YOU ABOUT THE SAFETY
NET AND THE ISSUES THAT I HEAR I
ALSO RUN A SUPPORT GROUPS OF
FAMILIES CALL ME.
WE HAVE KIDS WITH A DEVELOPMENTS
AWAY -- WILLIE DEVELOPMENTAL
DELAY DIE BE AT STILL MOMENTS
AWAY WHO ARE SITTING IN OUR
HOSPITAL CLOSE TO A YEAR MANY
MANY MANY TIMES.
THE THE WINNERS THAT GET TO
LEAVE GO TO ANOTHER STATE FOR
MONTHS AND MONTHS AT A TIME THE
WHOLE FAMILY SEPARATE IT.
SO THIS IS A HUGE ISSUE WE
NEEDED IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
PORTABLES NOT THE PLACE TO HAVE
IT.
IF YOU'VE EVER BEEN THERE
THERE'S A TWO LANE ROAD THAT
GETS THERE.
AND I'M FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AND IS SAYING LIKE -- YOUR KID
YOU LIVE IN SAN DIEGO WE'RE
GONNA SEND YOU THE MAGIC
MOUNTAIN BUT IT'S A TWO LANE
ROAD.
GO HAVE IT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
BACK AGAIN MARTY MOTO -- FAMILY
MEMBER JUST -- WANT TO MENTION
THAT -- ON THE ISSUE OF
RESTRUCTURING OF DDS AGREE WITH
THE SOME OF THE CONCERNS RAISED
BY ADVOCATES AND AFTER NEED TO
BE MUCH MORE DETAIL BUT I
ACTUALLY THINK THAT IT COULD BE
POTENTIALLY A VERY GOOD.
STEP IN MONITORING AND OVERSIGHT
AND ALSO ON THE SAFETY NET ISSUE
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE DRC
PROPOSAL AND THE COMMENTS MADE
BY -- HEATHER FLORES AND AND THE
OTHER ADVOCATES THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
WELCOME.
A DOG PASSED COVER FROM MANAGING
SUPPORTED LIVING SERVICES IN THE
PERSON CENTERED ADVOCACY
PARTNERSHIP.
FIRST I WANT TO GREET AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING.
MARTY SAID IN SAYS BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT I DRIVE UP HERE FOR
MONTEREY COUNTY TO DO -- BUT I
ALSO WANTED TO STRESS --
SOMETHING THAT JUDY MENTIONED
EARLIER WHICH IS.
THE IMPORTANCE IN THE
RESTRUCTURING OF LOOKING AT
OUTCOMES IMAGINE IS THE BEST
AGENCY WE NOW TO BE.
BUT IT'S HARD TO KNOW HOW TO GET
BETTER IF WE DON'T HAVE BASS
LINES FOR COMPARISON.
OF OUTCOMES AND THAT'S A MISSING
PART OF THE SYSTEM THANK ME
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
YOU MISTER CHAIRED JORDAN
LINDSEY MY FIRST COMMENT ON
ISSUE SIX WILL BE ON BEHALF OF
THE LETTERMAN COALITION AND
SIMPLY WANT TO ALIGN WITH THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MISTER
CROWTHER'S FROM THE STATE
COUNCIL.
I'M IT'S BEEN A BIG PROPOSAL OF
OURS AND BIG PRIORITY TO
INCREASE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPTIONS FOR PEOPLE DIED EIGHTY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND A GREAT RESOURCE FOR THAT IS
OBVIOUSLY THE BOTH THE CITY
MEANS AND THE REVENUE FROM THE
ASSETS THEMSELVES.
AND WANT TO PUSH THAT I'M ON
ISSUE NUMBER -- SEVEN ON BEHALF
OF YOUR CALIFORNIA -- WE USED A
OUR TOP CALL IN OUR OFFICE USE
BEYOND CONSERVATORSHIP
UNFORTUNATE LAST YEAR TO IN
DOUBTS ABOUT PEOPLE IN CRISIS
CALL IN OUR OFFICE.
AND WHAT THE DOWN WE WE'D LIKE
TO ALSO MENTION THAT IT'S A
DOWNSTREAM CONSEQUENCES.
OF AN UPSTREAM STREAM PHENOMENON
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT MISS
MARK ALSO MENTIONED WHICH IS
THAT WE WANT TO KEP PEOPLE IN
THEIR HOME.
WE NEED TO ALLOW FOR SAFETY
HEALTH AND SAFETY WAIVERS AND
ALSO PAINS ME FOURTEEN DOLLARS
AN HOUR WHEN SOMEBODY HAS IS IN
CRISIS.
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IN
THE DOWNSTREAM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
MICHELLE HI I'D BE CVA ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM FOR
BEHAVIOR ANALYSIS ON ISSUE SEVEN
WE JUST WANT TO THANK THE
DEPARTMENT -- FOR INCLUDING US
IN CONVERSATIONS RELATED TO THE
SAFETY NET AND CRISIS SERVICES
AND WITH THE WHICH IN FUNDING
FROM.
REGIONAL CENTER TRADITIONAL
FUNDING A BEHAVIORAL SERVICES TO
SB NINE FORTY SIX WE'VE SEEN A
LOT OF GREAT THINGS FROM THAT
BUT WE ALSO FEEL LIKE THE REAL
SERVICES.
CAN BE USED AS A WAY TO PREVENT
A LOT OF CRISES AND WE URGE.
THAT INCLUSION IN THAT
CONVERSATION SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME RAINY X. CALIFORNIA'S
DISABILITY RIGHTS TWO ONE I
WANTED TO TALK ABOUT WAS THE
CLOSURE OF THE CENTERS.
WHAT HAPPENS WITH THE CLOSURE OF
THE CENTERS IS THERE'S GOING TO
BE A LOT A LANDERS GOING TO BE A
LOT OF BUILDING SINNERS CAM
ALLOWED ON ACCESSIBILITY?
SO I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT IF
YOU'RE GOING TO GO IN THERE
LET'S MAKE EVERYTHING ACCESSIBLE
AGAIN MAY WE CAN HAVE THAT
COMMUNITY PLAN THAT WE HAD A
LONG TIME AGO THAT MISS ERIN --
TALKED ABOUT HOW SHE SAID WE'RE
GONNA SEPARATE TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM AND WILL IT BE A MIXED
USE DEVELOPMENT.
IT WOULD NOT BE JUST PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITY OF ELLIS ABILITIES
ANOTHER DISABILITIES BUT TO BE
ALSO BE ABLE BODIED PEOPLE AND
YOU MAKE IT LIKE A LITTLE TOWN
WHERE EVERYBODY CAN LIVE IN HELP
EACH OTHER OUT.
AND IS WHERE SHE'S RIGHT PART OF
IT WAS A VERY DIFFICULT PLACE TO
GO TO BECAUSE I KNOW I HAD TO
TAKE A LONG BUS RIDE TO GET
THERE.
SO KNOWING THAT I THINK WE FALLS
TO FIND OUT MAYBE AT LOOK AT THE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM TO ALL THE
CENTERS. TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY CAN GET TO THEM
OTHERWISE NOBODY'S GOT GOING TO
GET ANYWHERE.
I THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE THE THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR SINK COMMENTS
AND APPRECIATE THE INPUT SO
WOULD LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER -- SEVEN WHICH IS
DISPARITIES FUNDING.
SORRY NINE SORRY NINE ISSUE
NUMBER NINE DISPARITIES FUNDING
SORRY THANK YOU FOR THE
CORRECTION YES.
ALL RIGHT.
AND THE OTHER PANEL FOR THIS
[inaudible]
TOO OKAY [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO IF THREE PEOPLE FOR
PANEL OF BECOMING A LEADER
[inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
RIGHT.
OKAY SO LET'S GO AHEAD AND BEGIN
WITH -- THE AGENCY THANK YOU
APARTMENT THANK YOU -- I'VE BEEN
ASKED -- TO ADDRESS THREE THREE
QUESTIONS AND INTO CONSIDERATION
OF TIME ILL GO AHEAD AND REALLY
FOCUS ON THOSE -- BUT I I DO
WANT -- TO JUST BRIEFLY SPEAK
ABOUT -- THE WORK THAT'S BEEN
DONE OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS --
THERE'S BEEN A COMMITMENT -- TO
LOOK AT HOW TO ADDRESS THIS --
REALLY SIGNIFICANT IMPORTANT
ISSUE AS FAR AS IN EQUITY A
SPENDING AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE REALLY UNDERSTANDING THE
SERVICES -- AND BARRIERS TO
ACCESSING SERVICES -- FOR THE
COMMUNITIES -- AND TAKING A LOOK
AT WHERE THERE'S DISPARITIES --
MANY WE THERE'S SOME HISTORY
THAT I'VE AND I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
AND AND NOT SPEAK TO JUST
BECAUSE I THINK WE'VE HAD
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE PAST.
BUT ONE OF THE QUESTIONS IS THAT
WHAT IS IT THAT WE'RE DOING NOW
TO CONTINUE TO FOCUS AND ADDRESS
THE ISSUES.
SO THE ONE OF THE AREAS IS
REALLY LOOKING AT THE USE OF THE
ELEVEN MILLION MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE TYING THE WORK THAT'S
BEING DONE IN UNDERSTANDING THE
PURCHASE OF SERVICE --
INFORMATION THAT TELLS US WHERE
WE HAVE INEQUITIES IN THE
DIFFERENT REGIONAL CENTERS AND
THEN ACROSS THE STATE.
AND THEN THROUGH THAT WORK WE'RE
TAKING A LOOK AT HOW DO WE USE
THE LEVIN MILLION TO PRIORITIZE
HOW TO MOVE THAT FORWARD.
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS -- WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO SUPPORT TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY FOUR PROJECTS ON THE LAST
TWO YEARS WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO USE
IT AS A GRANT PROGRAM AND
SUPPORTING COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS -- WHERE THERE'S --
REAL FOCUS ON KIND OF A GRASS
ROOTS OR IT LOOKING AT HOW ON
THE COMMUNITIES THEMSELVES CAN
PROVIDE -- THE SUPPORT TO
NAVIGATING THROUGH THE SYSTEM
WE'VE SEEN SOME REALLY GREAT
THINGS AS FAR AS DIFFERENT
PROPOSALS THAT'S FOCUSED ON
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
SO WE WE DO HAVE A SUMMARY OF
THOSE PROPOSALS AND SO AGAIN IN
THE CONSIDERATION OF TIME WE'LL
GO AHEAD AND YOU CAN TAKE A LOOK
AT IT WILL HAVE A MONTH ON OUR
WEBSITE WILL MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE AVAILABLE FOR FOLKS IS A
SUMMARY.
BUT WHAT WE DO IS THAT AS A
DEPARTMENT IN ADDITION TO THE
STAKEHOLDER WORK THAT THE
REGIONAL CENTERS DO WE ALSO I
ANNUALLY REACH OUT TO
STAKEHOLDERS THIS YEAR WAS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT.
INSTEAD OF DOING A BROAD REVIEW
WHAT WE DID IS WE DID A FOCUSED --
KIND OF PRESENCE IN THE
COMMUNITY AND WE TALKED -- TO
COMMUNITY MEMBERS THAT -- WERE
IN A PARTICULAR GEOGRAPHIC AREA
THAT WE HAD HEARD CONCERNED SO
WE WENT TO THE COUNTRY COACHELLA
VALLEY AND WE HAD STAFF THAT MET
WITH THE COMMUNITY THERE.
THE OTHER IS TO TAKE A LOOK A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY SO WHAT
WE DID WAS WE ALSO MET WITH A
FOCUS GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS.
WITHIN THE DEAF COMMUNITY --
THAT -- USE A SL AS A LANGUAGE
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY BARRIERS
IN ACCESSING SERVICES.
ADDITIONALLY EACH OTHER REGIONAL
CENTERS HAVE A CULTURAL
SPECIALIST WE AS A DEPARTMENT
PROVIDE A MONTHLY CALLS TO
UNDERSTAND KIND OF THE EFFORTS
THAT THEY'RE DOING WITHIN THEIR
PLANS TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES
TALKING ABOUT BEST PRACTICES HOW
WE CAN GO AHEAD AND REPLICATE
SOME OF THOSE BEST PRACTICES --
WE'VE ALSO STARTED WORKING ON
TAKING A LOOK AT THE DATA --
WHEN WE FIRST MOVED FORWARD WITH
THE -- PROPOSALS -- WITH ELEVEN
MILLION WE WE ESTABLISHED --
MEASURES THAT WE'RE GOING TO
WHICH IS OUTLINED IN THE AGENDA
THAT WE'RE GOING TO USE TO
MEASURE -- THE BASIS FOR THAT
WAS -- FIFTEEN SIXTEEN FUNDING
THAT WE HAD -- WITHIN THE
MEASURES WHICH AGAIN IS POSTED
ON OUR WEBSITE.
IS THAT THE REPORTING OUT OF THE
PROGRESS -- ON ON MEASURING HOW
WE'RE WERE IMPROVING IN THE AREA
OF LOW -- REDUCING THAT GAP AS
FAR AS THE INEQUITY OF SPENDING
IS THAT WOULD BE THROUGH
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FUNDING.
SO SINCE IT'S THROUGH EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN OUR REPORT AND BEING
ABLE TO TAKE A LOOK AT THOSE
MEASURES IS GOING TO BE AT THE
END OF THIS YEAR.
YOU KNOW SO WE TAKE A LOOK AT
THE EXPENDITURES WILL BE ABLE TO
TAKE A LOOK AT AND LIKELY HAVE A
UP A REPORT THAT'S RESPONSIVE TO
THE MEASURES THAT WE HAVE
COMMITTED -- TO REPORTING ON ON
THE FIRST PART OF THE CALENDAR
YEAR NEXT YEAR.
I'VE BEEN ASKED -- IF WE PROVIDE
ANY SUPPORT OR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO THE RECIPIENTS OF
THE GRANTS PARTICULARLY THOSE
THAT ARE WITHIN THE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
AND WE DO -- WHEN WHEN WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO AWARD THE GRANTS
WHAT WE DID THIS YEAR IS THAT WE
ALSO HAD KIND OF A MANDATED TO
SPEAK YOU KNOW -- CALL WITH THEM
TO SAY OKAY LET'S TALK ABOUT
WHAT THE THE GRANT IS AND HOW
YOU AS IN A AR DE ARE
RESPONSIBLE TO THAT GRANTS TO
THE MEASURES AND HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO REPORT THAT BACK AND
AND AND AT LET THEM HAVE SOME --
OPPORTUNITIES TO ASK QUESTIONS
SO WE CAN PROVIDE THAT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AS WELL.
I'M SO WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE COMMUNITY IT IS AN AREA
THAT I'VE I'VE PARTICULARLY BEEN
VERY PLEASED TO BE ABLE TO BE A
PART OF THAT LISTENING TO THE
COMMUNITY MYSELF -- AND I AM
VERY PLEASED TO SEE MNY OTHER
PROJECTS THAT ARE GOING FORWARD --
I DO HAVE TO GIVE A LOT OF
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT TO A PARTICULAR
GROUP THAT.
HAS KIND OF BEEN MY VOICE YOU
KNOW THAT HAS SHARED THEIR
CONCERNS AS A GROUP AND I'D
THERE'S THESE WONDERFUL MOMS
THAT ARE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
THAT STARTED.
MEETING WITH ME A FEW YEARS AGO
DAVID THROUGH THEIR WORK THEY
REALLY START TAKING FOR THROUGH
THE GRANTS AND THEY WERE ABLE.
TO KIND OF BE THAT THAT VOICE TO
CHANGE OUR APPROACH AND SO I I
DO WANT TO THANK THEM AND I KNOW
THEY KNOW WHO THEY KNOW WHO THEY
ARE.
SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT COMES
MILLENNIAL FINANCE ALL RIGHT --
AND WE HAVE A PANEL HERE -- IN
THE WEST WING -- FROM THAT
YOU'RE BACK FROM THE ASSOCIATION
OF VISUAL CENTER AGENCIES AND
FERNANDO GOMEZ -- BOARD MEMBER
DISPLAY VOICES UNITED AND THEN
MARIO MOTO -- BACK AGAIN AS WELL
SO WHAT WE JUST GO IN THAT ORDER
AND AGAIN ASK THAT YOU TRY TO
KEEP YOUR REMARKS TO WITHIN
THREE MINUTES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR PAN.
FIRST AND FOREMOST I JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT REGIONAL CENTERS ARE
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO ENSURING
EQUAL ACCESS TO SERVICES. TO
THOSE SERVICES THAT PEOPLE VALUE
AND THAT THEY NEED IN ORDER TO
HELP THEM LEAD THE LIVES THEY
ENVISION.
THE DISPARITY FUNDS HAVE BEEN
AVAILABLE FOR THREE YEARS NOW
AND HAVE PROVIDED AN IMPORTANT
OPPORTUNITY TO ESSENTIALLY HI
WITH INTERVENTIONS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND SEE WHAT WORKS. TO
GIVE US A CHANCE TO SEE WHAT
WORKS TO IMPROVE THIS ACCESS TO
CRITICAL SERVICES.
FROM SOME PRELIMINARY
INFORMATION WE KNOW THAT A
COUPLE OF THINGS REALLY DO SEEM
TO BE EFFECTIVE THE PROMO TORA
MODEL.
PROVIDES NOT ONLY [inaudible]
SERVICES. TWO PEOPLE BUT SOME OF
THE OUTCOMES THAT WE SEE FROM IT.
IS THAT PEOPLE REPORT GREATER
CONFIDENCE IN ACCESSING SERVICES.
FAMILIES REPORT THAT THEY FEEL
MORE SUPPORTED.
THEY REPORT THAT THEY ARE
ACCESSING NOT ONLY MORE BUT A
WIDER ARRAY OF SERVICES
AVAILABLE THROUGH THE REGIONAL
CENTER.
THEY UNDERSTAND THE SERVICES
BETTER.
AND THAT THEY'RE ACCESSING MORE
COMMUNITY RESOURCES AS WELL
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT REGIONAL
CENTERS AREN'T THE ONLY PLACE
WHERE PEOPLE WERE DROPPED
SERVICES FROM.
SO THEY'RE ACCESSING SPECIAL
EDUCATION MEDI CAL
TRANSPORTATION FOOD BANKS ALL
KINDS OF THINGS THAT ENABLE THEM
TO THEN FOCUS ON THEIR CHILD'S
DISABILITY.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT CASELOAD
SMALLER CASELOAD RATIOS WORK AND
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT INCREASES
IN PURCHASE OF SERVICE WHEN.
PEOPLE ARE ON A SMALLER CASELOAD
THAT'S TARGETED TO THEM.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT THESE
INTERVENTIONS ARE LIMITED TO
VERY SMALL POPULATIONS.
AND SO THE NEXT STEP IS ONCE WE
CAN AGREE THAT INTERVENTIONS
WORK.
THROUGH ROBUST INFORMATION THAT
THEY ARE MAKING PROGRESS WE NEED
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S THE NEXT
STEP HOW DO WE TAKE THOSE
TARGETED SMALL PILOTS.
AND MAKE THEM MORE BROADLY
AVAILABLE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH COMMUNITY PARTNERS
ADVOCACY GROUPS AND OTHERS TO
THAT END.
AND APPRECIATE THE WILLINGNESS
OF DISABILITY VOICES UNITED TO
SIT DOWN AND MEET WITH US TO
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THOSE NEXT
STEPS WERE WE CAN FIND.
PLACES WHERE WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER.
WE AGREE THAT SERVICES AGAIN
NEED TO BE RESPONSIVE TO
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS TO FAMILY AND
CULTURAL PREFERENCES AND THAT
THEY NEED TO BE FLEXIBLE AND
AGAIN BACK TO THE ISSUE OF
SOCIAL RECKON CAMP AS JUST AN
EXAMPLE OF SOME OF THE SERVICES
THAT PEOPLE VALUE.
THAT MAY NOT COST A LOT BUT MADE
A BIG IMPACT IN THEIR LIVES
THANK YOU.
YES.
THANK YOU CENTER AND THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF DISABILITY VOICES
UNITED THEN.
MORE IMPORTANTLY I AM THE FATHER
TO WONDERFUL VOICE BY TWELVE
YEAR OLD SON -- SCOTT I'M TONY
OF OUR HAS DOWN SYNDROME IS ALSO
A REGIONAL CENTER CLIENT.
DISABILITY VOICES UNITED HAS
REVIEWED POS DATA FROM THE LAST
TWO YEARS TO DETERMINE WHETHER
THE GRANTS TO REGIONAL CENTERS
AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE REDUCE
DISPARITIES.
WE HAVE A SHOULD REPORT TO A
REALITY CHECK HERE.
THAT ACTUALLY.
SHOWS THAT.
DISPARITIES HAVE NOT DECREASED
BUT ACTUALLY INCREASED -- AND BY
FAR WITHIN THAT THE THE INCREASE
LATINOS CONTINUE TO FACE THE
GREATEST LEVEL OF DISPARITIES AS
THE LARGEST ETHNIC GROUP SERVED
BY THE SYSTEM.
AND THREE YEARS INTO DISPARITY
EFFORTS MY COMMUNITY.
CONTINUES TO RECEIVE THE LOS
AMOUNTS OF SERVICES.
THE DATA SHOWS THAT IN EVERY
SINGLE REGIONAL CENTER LATINOS
GET ABOUT HALF TE AMOUNT OF
SERVICES COMPARED TO WHITES.
AT FIVE REGIONAL CENTERS LATINOS
RECEIVE ONLY A THIRD OR ACTUALLY
LESS.
OF WHAT WHITES RECEIVE AND
THINGS SEEM TO BE WORSE.
REGIONAL CENTERS WITH THE
LARGEST POPULATION OF LATINOS
FOR EXAMPLE ONCE AGAIN
CALIFORNIA REGIONAL CENTER.
WHO HAS A ABOUT A 68% LATINO
POPULATION OR OF CONSUMERS
RECEIVES ABOUT 18% OF WHAT
WHITES RECEIVING SERVICES?
SO WE RICH APPRECIATE AND TO
RESPECT THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
LEGISLATOR. FOR ALL THE EFFORTS
OF THE MADE.
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT REGIONAL
CENTERS TO A LOT OF THINGS VERY
WELL -- TODAY AND OUR FOCUS HAS
BEEN IN THIS ONE AREA WITHIN
DISPARITIES [inaudible]
WE ASK WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT ARE
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT CAN BE
DONE THE FIRST WE BELIEVE THAT
MANY REGIONAL CENTERS HAVE NOT
MEANINGFULLY INCLUDED.
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE AFFECTED BY
DISPARITIES IN THEIR PLANNING.
SO PEOPLE WHO FACE DISPARITIES
ARE ACTUALLY THE BEST EXPERTS AT
WHAT THEY ARE AND HOW THAT CAN
BE HELPED.
SECOND THE FUNDS THAT WERE
ALLOCATED.
BASED ON THE LEVEL OF DISPARITY
IN A PARTICULAR AREA OR HOW THEY
WILL ACTUALLY REDUCE DISPARITIES
IS GOING TO BE A KEY ISSUE.
AND THIRD THERE REALLY IS NO
INDEPENDENT EVALUATIONS OF THE
FUNDED PROGRAMS TO SEE THEIR
IMPACT.
FINALLY IT IS TIME THAT WE ARE
HONEST ABOUT THE FACT THAT MANY
IN MY COMMUNITY REPORT FEELING
INTIMIDATED BY THE SYSTEM.
THAT ARE SOMETIMES AFRAID TO
SPEAK UP IN FEAR RETALIATION
AGAINST THEM IN THEIR CHILD.
SO WE NEED TO REALLY STOP
DENYING THE FACT THAT.
THE REAL BY A SUCCESS AND WE
NEED TO STOP CONTRIBUTING
DISPARITIES TO ACTUALLY ETHNIC
CULTURES OF FAMILIES.
WE NEED TO REALLY STOP MAKING
EXCUSES THAT'S WHY DISABILITY
VOICES UNITED THIS REQUEST IN
THAT A SMALL PORTION.
OF NEXT YEAR'S ELEVEN MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET GO TO AN
INDEPENDENT EVALUATIONS OF THE
PROCESS THAT'S USED TO DETERMINE
GRANTS AND WHETHER THE FUNDED
PROJECTS.
ACTUALLY REDUCE DISPARITIES.
THE RESULTS OF THE INDEPENDENT
EVALUATIONS CAN BE SHARED.
SO THAT WE CAN WORK TOGETHER TO
CREATE A TRANSPARENT AND
COLLABORATIVE PATH TOWARD AND
EQUITABLE SYSTEM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
PARDEE MODEM OF FAMILY MEMBERS
CALIFORNIA DISPLACING YOUR
COMMITTEE ACTION NETWORK ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE DDS DIRECTORS
DISPARITIES ADVISORY.
COMMITTEE.
YEAH AND I AGREE -- THAT -- THE
DDS HAS TAKEN SOME GOOD STEPS --
TOWARDS REDUCING DISPARITIES BUT
THERE'S A SENSE OF URGENCY -- AS
A FAMILY MEMBER AND AS AN
ADVOCATE.
YOU KNOW IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
IMPACT OF DISPARITIES IS NOT
JUST SOMEONE LOSING A SERVICE
ARE NOT GETTING A SERVICES
SOMEONE BEING HARMED.
ESPECIALLY INFANTS IN NEED OF
EARLY START EARLY INTERVENTION --
AND I THINK WHEN SOMEONE IS
FACING DISCRIMINATION OR
BARRIERS DUE TO DISCRIMINATION
DUE TO OF DISPARITIES.
IT'S HARD TO BE PATIENT AND HARD
NOT TO FEEL THAT THE SITUATION
IS ANYTHING BUT URGENT AND THAT
AND AND NOT ENOUGH IS BEING DONE
SUGGESTIONS.
YOU KNOW TO THE STATE INTO THE
LEGISLATURE IS THAT.
DDS SHOULD REPLICATE BEST
PRACTICES BY THE GRANTEES -- IN
LINK THOSE AS A BASIS FOR
TARGETED FUNDING INCREASES TIED
TO MEASURING OUTCOMES -- HAVE
THOSE DISPARITY FUNDING GRANTEES
TRAIN OTHER PROVIDERS.
AND COMMUNITY STAKE HOLDERS SO
THAT THEY CAN REPLICATE WHAT
THEY HAVE DONE.
I'VE TALKED TO SOME THE GRANTEES
AND DDS TO CONDUCT MONTHLY OR BI
MONTHLY CALLS SO THAT THE
GRANTEES AND THE STATE CAN
EXCHANGE INFORMATION ON HOW
THEIR GRANTS ARE GOING IN ANY
PROBLEMS -- ENCOUNTERING TO
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY.
LASTLY -- THE ISSUE OF
DISPARITIES CROSSES SYSTEM LINES
AND IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
RECOGNIZE THAT COULD WE DON'T
RECOGNIZE THAT WE'RE NOT GONNA
BE ABLE TO SOLVE THE PROBLEMS IS
PROBLEMS IT JUST BURIES A MEDI
CAL I JUST SAYS SPECIAL ED.
HOUSING MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
IDENTITY HEARING WHERE IT WAS
THE STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT OF
TWO MILLION CHILDREN.
ON MEDI CAL WHO WERE NOT
RECEIVING A PREVENTIVE HEALTH
CARE SERVICES AND THE ISSUE IN
PART WAS DUE TO DISPARITIES.
AND I THINK ONE THING IS THAT
CAN HELP ADDRESS THAT PROBLEM IS
THAT.
DID ISSUED DISPARITIES IS NOT.
JUST IN THE REGIONAL CENTER
SYSTEM IT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED.
LEASE WITHIN HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES ONE SUGGESTION IS THAT
THE AGENCY BRING TOGETHER ALL
THE DEPARTMENTS AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO LOOK AT HOW
TOGETHER WE CAN. TO RESOLVE
DISPARITIES OR REDUCE
DISPARITIES DISPARITIES OR
PERSON FROM THE COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR LIKE FOR NOT DOING ME.
WE DON'T LIVE IN A SILO IS WHOLE
PERSON THE WHOLE ISSUE NOW IS
ABOUT HOPE PERSON CARE AND SO
THE APPROACH TOWARDS REDUCING
DISPARITIES SB TAKEN IN THAT
SAME MANNER.
THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU SO. THREE YEARS
[inaudible]
OF MONEY.
AND THINGS ARE WORSE
[inaudible]
SO.
WATCH WHAT WHAT WE CAN DO ABOUT
THAT THAT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE --
SENATOR PAN AYE I'M NOT.
I I CAN'T SPEAK TO KIND OF WHAT
THE INFORMATION THAT INFORMED
THEIR REVIEW.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO DO IS TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF THE
INFORMATION.
RIGHT -- SO DO WE BUT THE HAVE
ALTERNATIVE DATA THEN SO WELL
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AS FAR AS THE
MEASURES THAT I WAS -- SPEAKING
TO I DO WANT TO MAKE NOTE AS TO
THE TIMING OF THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE GRANT SO THE FINDINGS
WERE AVAILABLE IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN RIGHT --
IMPLEMENTING THE SERVICES AND
HAVING THE FIRST PROJECTS START.
REALLY HAS ONLY BEEN IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS AND SOWHENYOU
START -- OKAY SO THEY'VE BEEN
DOING PROGRAMS FOR TWO YEARS
DAVE NOT RIGHT SO WE JUST HAD
OUR OUR FIRST -- PROJECTS FROM
THAT WERE APPROVED I'M JUST
SUBMITTED THEIR FINAL REPORTS TO
US IN DECEMBER.
SO WE REALLY ARE IN THE VERY
EARLY STAGES.
OF LOOKING AT THE DATA AND
LOOKING AT THE INFORMATION.
ARE YOU LOOKING AT THE OVER I
MEAN THERE'S PROJECT ON FRIDAY
AND WHILE OVERALL CORRECT
CORRECT BUT THE OPPORTUNITY SO
ALL I'M I JUST WANT TO KIND OF
POINT OUT IS THAT.
A POINT OF INFORMATION IS THAT
WE HAVE THE PROJECTS THAT JUST
RECENTLY STARTED SO THE IMPACTS
TO A BROADER SYSTEM.
YOU KNOW WE STILL HAVE WE STILL
HAVE TO DO SOME KIND OF DIGGING
INTO THE DATA TO SEE WHAT THOSE
IMPACTS ARE.
THE OTHER POINT THAT I'D LIKE TO
JUST MAKE AND I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S INFLUENCE ENOUGH BUT IT'S
TAKING TIME TO REALLY.
KIND OF GET INTO THE INFORMATION
AND DOING OUR ANALYSIS IS
THERE'S BEEN QUITE A BIT A
DIFFERENT POLICY.
THAT HAS ALSO CHANGED SOME OF
THE THE EFFORTS AT OR THE
EXPENDITURES WITHIN OUR PURCHASE
A SERVICE DATA I DON'T KNOW WHAT
INFLUENCE THAT HAS ON IT.
SO IT IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
REALLY TAKE A LOOK AT OUR
EXPENDITURES TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THE INFORMATION THAT IS NOT ONLY
REGIONAL.
WITHIN EACH REGIONAL CENTER BUT
STATEWIDE.
SO NOT SAYING THAT THESE ARE NOT
IMPORTANT ISSUES BECAUSE I
CERTAINLY AM.
BUT I AM SAYING THAT WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH INFORMATION TO
RESPOND TO SAY WHETHER.
WE ARE LOOKING AT IT AND THE
TOTALITY THAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO REPORT -- WHETHER THERE IS
PROGRESS OR NO PROGRESS
[inaudible]
OKAY SO.
SIDE DEBT.
SO THE THING IS I FOOD BECAUSE
THIS WAY -- I THINK YOU KNOW
THIS IS URGENT. EIGHT BECAUSE
DISPARITIES ARE QUITE SEVERE AND
THE LEAST.
THE HEARING MAY BE WORSE RIGHT I
AM NOT HEARING A LOT OF LIKE --
GOT A LOT BETTER I MEAN MAYBE
MAYBE DETAILS WE'LL SEE HOW MUCH
MARGINAL CHANGE OR IS -- BUT
THANK YOU KNOW AND EVERY AND
EVERY.
YEAR THAT GOES BY THAT'S ANOTHER
GROUP.
RIGHT I MEAN AND SO I CAN GO
WINE BACK TIME AND SIX IT FOR
THEM.
SO I THINK THERE'S A TREMENDOUS
URGENCY I THINK THAT WAS
EXPRESSED BY THE LEGISLATURE WE
FIRST ALLOCATED THE MONEY.
THAT THIS IS PROBLEMATIC --
PEOPLE ASK ME SO HOW'S THINGS
GOING AND I'M GOING WELL I GUESS
WE'LL FIND OUT SO AND RIGHT NOW
I'M NOT GONNA BILL SURE ANY GOOD
NEWS WITH THEM YET -- AND DAIRY
EXPECT TO HAVE THEY WANT TO SEE
MAJOR CHANGES AND AND THAT.
AND EIGHT YOU KNOW APPRECIATE
PEOPLE OF THESE LITTLE PROJECTS
HERE BUT I'M WE'RE TALKING MAJOR
CULTURAL CHANGE.
THE OTHER THING THAT I'M HEARING.
AS VERY DISTURBED -- FROM MISTER
GOMEZ IS IS THAT PEOPLE FEEL
INTIMIDATED -- EITHER WAY I'M
ALSO SIT ON THE COMMITTEE HUMAN
SERVICES WE JUST HAD A BILL
SOMEONE ACTUALLY SUBMITTED
BECAUSE THEY SAID DOES
INTIMIDATION GOING ON AT THE
CENTERS AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON THERE WHY WHY WHY IS
EVERYONE TALKING ABOUT TO
MEDIATION.
I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE AS FAR AS
THE ON THE INTIMIDATION NOW WE
HAVE YOU KNOW AND AND MISTER
GOMEZ AND OTHERS HAVE SHARED
THOSE CONCERNS.
AND IS.
LOOKING AT THE WORK THAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING WHAT THE REGIONAL
CENTERS AND ANY TIME.
CERTAINLY THAT WE'VE HEARD THE
CONCERNS WE REACT TO IT BUT
THAT'S NOT THE ANSWER WE GOT A
CHANGE THE CULTURE AS FAR AS THE
RELATIONSHIP AND MAKING SURE
THAT THERE IS A SAFE PLACE. FOR
FOR FAMILIES TO GO AND MAKE SURE
THAT THEY HAVE THOSE RESOURCES
SO WHEN.
WHEN WE LOOKED AT THE PROPOSAL'S
IT'S LIKE WHAT ARE THE PROPOSALS
ARE THE ACTIONS THAT ARE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO BE TAKEN? TO HELP.
YOU KNOW ADDRESS THAT
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE BECAUSE
INTIMIDATION IS NOT OKAY NO IT'S
NOT -- TAKING A LOOK AT SO FOR
EXAMPLE -- YOU KNOW USING THE
PERMIT TORAH MODEL HAS BEEN A
VERY VERY GOOD PROJECT THAT HAS
BEEN REPLICATED OVER DIFFERENT.
ON REGIONAL CENTERS CATCHMENT
AREAS AND THEY BEEN MODELS THAT
HAVE BEEN DONE BASED ON
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
SO HERE ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
TRUST WITHIN THE COMMUNITY THAT
IS SO CRITICAL. TO REALLY START
CHANGING KIND OF THAT CULTURE
AND HELPING MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S THAT VOICE NOW WHEN WE
DO SO WE HAVE TO DO IT TOO I SEE
TWO PATHS THAT WE HAVE TO TAKE
WITH IT WHAT IS THAT
PREVENTATIVE PATH TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE CHANGING THAT CULTURE.
AND THEN ALSO MAKING SURE THAT
IF WE DO AS AN APARTMENT HERE
THAT THERE IS LEVELS OF
INTIMIDATION THAT WE STARTED
DRESSING THOSE ISSUES AND MAKE
AND HOLDING REGIONAL CENTERS
ACCOUNTABLE. TO TO FIX KIND OF
THEIR CULTURE YOU THERE'S A
REASON WHY IF THERE IS SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING ON WE NEED TO HAVE
A A PLAN. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS A SAFE PLACE TO HAVE
SERVICES WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE'S CHANGES THAT HAVE
HAPPENED AS FAR AS IMMIGRATION
AND EVERYTHING BUT THE
HEIGHTENED.
KIND OF THE THE FEAR OF PURE
KIND OF FIGHT A BUREAUCRACY OR
AN ORGANIZATION.
IN GOVERNMENT AND SO REGIONAL
CENTERS BY WAY OF WHO KIND OF
THEY ARE THEY'RE KIND OF A QUIET
SIGH YOU KNOW GOVERNMENT AND
THERE'S THIS.
YOU KNOW FEAR THAT CAN BE
INHERENTLY THERE BUT THEN WHEN
YOU ADD KIND OF OTHER
RELATIONSHIP THING SECOND KIND
OF MAGNIFY THAT.
SO WE DO HAVE SOME REALLY GREAT
PROPOSALS I AM VERY VERY PLEASED
WITH SOME OF THE PROPOSALS I'M
NOT SAYING THAT WE'RE NOT
CONCERNED AND IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT IS SO CRITICAL TO PAY
ATTENTION.
TO AN UNDERSTANDING KIND OF THE
SYSTEM WIDE KINDA MEASURING THAT
PROGRESS BUT WHEN WE LOOK AT
SOME OF THE MEASURES WITH
PARTICULAR PROJECTS WE ARE
SEEING THAT THERE'S IN INCREASE
AND PURCHASE A SERVICE WE ARE
SEEING THAT THERE'S A REDUCTION
IN SOME OTHER AREAS.
SO WE DO HAVE SOME PROJECT BASED
THAT WE ARE SEEING SOME EVIDENCE
OF REALLY GOOD PRACTICES THAT
ARE MAKING A DIFFERENCE.
SO IT'S TAKING THAT NEXT STEP IS
SAYING OKAY HOW DO WE TAKE A
LOOK AT THIS MORE ON AT A LARGER
SKILLS SO NGUYEN.
SO WHENEVER YOU MOVE THE NEEDLE
ON ON THIS ISSUE SO GIVE ME A
TIME.
WHEN DO I GET A REPORT DISHES WE
MADE A MAJOR MOVE IN THE
DISPARITY NUMBERS?
I I CANNOT ANSWER THAT FOR YOU I
MEAN IS IT IS LIKE THE MAJOR MAY
WELL AS IT TWO YEARS THREE YEARS
FIVE YEARS TEN YEARS I MEAN
THAT'S SO WHAT WE HAVE SO I DOVE
SO WE HAVE PILOTS WHO CAN AND
REPORTS REPORTS ARE GONNA COME
OUT.
THEN YOU'RE DOWN THEN THE
DEPARTMENT NEEDS TO TELL ALL YOU
KNOW THE CENTERS LIKE YOURS THE
BEST PRACTICES AND YOU NEED TO
DO THIS OR ELSE RIGHT AND AND
MIDDLE MOVES STRAIGHT
[inaudible]
SO.
I THAT WE HAVE OUR MEASURES
WHICH WHEN IS THE FINAL YEAR OF
THAT.
THE THE REPORT.
ON SO EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND THEN
IT'S ANNUALLY AFTER THAT RIGHT
SO ARE SO WE HAVE YEAH SO
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IS AS ALWAYS
SEEN ON OUR MEASURES THAT WAS
THE POINT IN TIME THAT WE'RE
USING TO MEASURE. TO FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN TO SEE A FOR MOVING THAT
NEEDLE OKAY IN THAT REPORT YOU
SAID THE END OF THE YEAR THAT
RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO BE USING
PURCHASED A SERVICE DATA THAT
ENDS DECEMBER. TWENTY NINETEEN
SO -- THAT WILL HAVE THAT
INFORMATION SO WE'LL SEE -- THE
ABILITY TO PRODUCE A REPORT
EARLY PART OF NEXT YEAR.
AND THAT IS THAT COMPREHENSIVE
MEASURE REPORTERS THAT'S THE
OVERALL ACROSS THE SYSTEM
CORRECT ON THE MEASURES THAT ARE
ACTUALLY LISTED IN YOUR AGENDA.
AND THEN YOU ALSO ARE LOOKING AT
THE INDIVIDUAL PRIDE I MEAN
YOU'VE BEEN FUNDING THEM FOR
SEVERAL YEARS NOW.
LOOKING AT THE INDIVIDUAL
PROJECTS AND THEN THOUGH AS I
WAS SAYING THE FIRST YEAR
PROJECTS WE JUST RECEIVED THEIR
FINAL REPORT.
AT THE END OF DECEMBER AND SO
WE'RE JUST IN THAT THERE WERE
FINALIZING KIND OF THOSE.
THAT -- OKAY SO OUTCOMES AT THIS
TIME OKAY SO WHAT AT WHAT POINT.
THEN DE USE THAT [inaudible]
THIS. TWELVE CAN NOW THAT YOU
HAVE THE INFORMATION FROM THESE
PILOTS.
WHAT POINT DO YOU SAY OKAY WELL
WE CAN TAKE THE BEST OF THAT AND
EVERYONE HAS TO DO IT
[inaudible]
WELL.
WE ARE WERE REVIEWING THOSE WERE
NOT WAITING FOR JUST OKAY.
TO A MOM AS FAR AS EVERYBODY HAS
TO DO IT I THINK THAT THOSE
THAT'S PART OF THE DISCUSSIONS
THAT WERE LOOKING OUT AS FAR AS
THOSE BEST PRACTICES.
BUT WE'RE ALSO STILL USING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY YOU KNOW IF
THERE ARE SOME BEST PRACTICES OR
REPLICATING WE DON'T WANT TO
WAIT.
SO WE ARE SEEING THAT WE ARE
DOING SOME REPLICATION OF
PROJECTS THAT ARE SHOWING
EVIDENCE OF PROGRESS AND SO FOR
EXAMPLE I MEAN WE HAVE.
ALL RIGHT I'D I'D HAVE TO GET
YOU THE NUMBER BUT THE NUMBER OF
FROM A TORAH MODELS OR
NAVIGATORS OR TAKING A LOOK AT
EXPANDING KIND OF THE THAT THE
THAT OUT REACH THAT FAMILIES
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO FROM THAT
ORGANIC KIND OF GRASS ROOTS.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO REPLICATE
THAT SO WE DON'T WANT TO WAIT.
SO WE DO WANT TO DO SOMETHING
THAT IS MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
DOING PROGRESS ON ANNUAL BASIS
AS OPPOSED TO WAIT ON IT AND AND
AND AND NOT SAYING WAIT BUT A
WHAT POINT DOES IT ACTUALLY
REACH SCALE.
UNDERSTOOD RIGHT NOW I MEAN.
WHAT POINT IS A READ SCALE
BECAUSE AGAIN IT COMES DOWN?
TO WHEN DO WE SEE A MAJOR CHANGE
IN THOSE NUMBERS RIGHT SO
BECAUSE IF EVERYONE EVERYTHING
STAYS PILOTS.
WE'RE NOT MOVING THE BIG NUMBER
SO I MAY MOVE A LITTLE NUMBER
FOR THE PILOT PHOSPHORYLATION
BUT THEN WE GOT AND THEN MOVES
TO CHANGING THE NUMBER.
SO THAT MEANS TAKING THE MOST
EFFECTIVE THINGS AND BRING IT TO
SCALE RIGHT THAT MEANS WELL
ALMOST EVERYBODY DOES IT MAYBE
THERE'S SOME PLACES WHERE IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE BUT
ESSENTIALLY USE STAR ROLE AND
MORE THAT CELL.
AND AND I THINK WHAT.
WE HEAR AN EIGHT AND WHAT I HEAR
FROM MY COLLEAGUES IS THAT NOW
THEY'RE GETTING A LITTLE
IMPATIENT.
ABOUT THIS SO -- SO WITH IT.
SO IT'S BEEN THREE YEARS AND
UNITE I GOT WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT
THAT SET HER UP BUT HOW MANY
YEARS DO WE HAVE TO WAIT.
RIGHT AND SO WHEN WHEN YOU KNOW
HOW.
THIS WORKS [inaudible]
THE THANK YOU TO REGIONAL CENTER
SHOULD BE IN OVERDRIVE TRYING TO
FIX THIS PROBLEM.
RIGHT I MEAN IT'S IT'S NOT NOT
LIKE WHAT HAVE I GOT SOME LABEL
DEAL TILE ON THE SIDE IF THEY
SHOULD BE LOOKING INTERNALLY AND
RIGHT NW CHANGING THE WAY THEY
DO THINGS LOOKING AT HEY WHAT'S
GOING ON AND WE HAVE TO TAKE
THREE TYPES OF PEOPLE AT THE
TABLE. TO BE SURE WE CAN ADDRESS
THE DISPARITIES AT CENTER OF SO
BEYOND JUST THE FUNDED PILOTS.
YOU KNOW.
WHO HE IS WE SHOULD BE SEEING --
YOU KNOW MAJOR CHANGES AND AND
THE DISPARITY NUMBERS THAT'S
THAT'S THE EXPECTATION.
AND RIGHT AS FAR AS THOSE
MEASURES YOU KNOW THE FIGHT.
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE THOSE
MEASURES AND BE ABLE TO RESPOND
TO THOSE MEASURES THE CERTAINLY
IMPORTANT WE DO ABSOLUTELY AND
AND THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF HAVING --
THE ESTABLISHED MEASURE MEASURES
THAT WE PUT FORWARD -- I ALSO
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT AS A
DEPARTMENT WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT
ANY OF THE MAJOR INITIATIVES THE
FIRST THINGS THAT WE DO IS TO
SAY HOW ARE WE ADDRESSING THIS
FROM.
KIND OF A CULTURAL PERSPECTIVE
AS WELL.
SO WHAT WERE SO WE CAN REALLY
TAKE A LOOK AT MAKING SURE THAT
AS WERE IMPLEMENTING -- NEW
EFFORTS THAT WERE NOT CONTINUING
TO HAVE KIND OF THIS INEQUITY SO
FOR EXAMPLE WITH SELF
DETERMINATION.
YOU KNOW WHEN WE WERE DOING OUR
SELECTION AS FAR AS THE TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED PARTICIPANTS.
THE FIRST POINT OF OF THE POLL
AS FAR AS THE RANDOM SELECTION
OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS HAD TO BE
BASED ON ETHNICITY AS
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE KIND OF
THE COMMUNITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE WERE NOT PERPETUATING KIND OF
THIS PROBLEM FROM NEW
INITIATIVES.
SO I JUST I JUST WANTED YOU NOTE.
LIKE NOT MINIMIZE KIND OF THE
THE CONCERNS THAT ARE SHARED BUT
TO SAY THAT THIS EFFORT THAT HAS
TO GO FORWARD IS SOMETHING THAT
WE ARE.
ARE DOING MORE COMMITTED TO TO
WORKING ON KIND OF THAT
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE.
WITHIN THE PROPOSAL'S BUT TAKING
A LOOK AT THE CULTURE AND AGAIN
HAVING THAT COMMITMENT AS WERE
PUTTING FORWARD ANY OF THE
NATION DOES THAT WERE DOING IT
IN A MINDFUL WAY.
SO WE'RE ADDRESSING IT --
THROUGH THE LENS OF MAKING SURE
THAT AS OUR SYSTEM IS MAKING
CHANGES THAT WERE ALSO DOING IT
WITH RECOGNITION OF ADDRESSING
THAT THE CULTURAL.
AND AS WELL AS THE ETHNIC
DIFFERENCES THAT OUR COMMUNITY
IS [inaudible]
SO.
WELL I THINK THE EXPERT YEAH.
SO I DON'T KNOW -- THIS
WHISTLING CAN YOU SPEAK TO WHAT
THEY'RE ABOUT HOW THE REGIONAL
CENTERS ARE GOING TO MOVE THE
NEEDLE ALL A I MEAN THAT'S
THAT'S ALL I MEAN WHEN.
THEY AGENCIES ARE OVERSEEING IT
BUT I MEAN I THINK THAT'S YES
PEOPLE WANT PEOPLE PEOPLE AND
PEOPLE I DON'T SWIM PILOTS THEY
WANT TO SEE THE NUMBERS CHANGE.
ABSOLUTELY AND SO I MEAN I
REALIZE PILOTS HELP INFORM
ACTIONS BUT AT SOME POINT YOU
KNOW WE'VE GOT TO MOVE THE SCALE
AND AND AND AND CHANGE THINGS
AND SO AND IT'S NOT GONNA BE ANY
SINGLE PILOT THERE'S NO SILVER
BULLET TO THIS SO.
I MEAN HAVE REGIONAL CENTERS
HAVE BEEN I MEAN WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS FOR SEVERAL
YEARS HAVE BEEN HAVING YOU KNOW
DEEP DISCUSSIONS STRATEGIC PLANS
TO ADDRESS THIS BEYOND JUST
DOING PILOTS BASED ON NOW.
PUT OUT BY THE THE PARK THE BY
THE DEPARTMENT ITSELF.
ABSOLUTELY SO.
REGIONAL CENTERS VIEW THE
OPPORTUNITY TO USE DISPARITY
GRANTS AS THAT OPPORTUNITY TO
TRY BEYOND THE GRANTS A GOOD
HEAD STRAIGHT SO UNDERSTAND
CHANGING THE CULTURE INTERNALLY.
AND THEY ARE DOING A LOT OF
OTHER INITIATIVES THAT ARE TIED
TO THE DISPARITY GRANTS THEY ARE
PULLING TOGETHER FAMILIES TO
TALK ABOUT WHAT SERVICES DO YOU
NEED HOW DOES THIS WORK WHAT
DOESN'T WORK WHAT DOES.
ENERGY REACHING OUT TO NOT JUST
CLIENTS OF COLOR BUT MAYBE OTHER
FAMILIES OF DIFFERENT ETHNIC
GROUPS TO HAVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS
BECAUSE THE PROD THE CHALLENGES
THERE WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT S
WAS PRESENTED WAS IS THAT.
THEY'RE NOT GETTING ANY THEY'RE
NOT THE EITHER THEY'RE NOT
GETTING THE SERVICE IS NOT
SEEKING THE SERVICES BECAUSE
THEY FEEL IT'S NOT.
DON'T DATE BALL THEY THEY'RE NOT
FEELING IT REALLY CONNECTS WITH
THEM SO YOU CAN'T JUST TALK TO
THE PEOPLE YOU'RE SERVING YOU
ACTION TO TALK TO PEOPLE YOU'RE
NOT SERVING WHO.
SHOULD BE SERVING.
THAT TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S GOING
ON ABSOLUTELY AND ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES IN A SYSTEM
FINDING THOSE PEOPLE YOU'RE NOT
SERVING AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THE REGIONAL CENTERS ARE DOING --
IN PART THROUGH THE CULTURAL
SPECIALIST BUT IN PART THROUGH
JUST MORE TARGETED OUTREACH IN
THOSE AREAS IS WORKING WITH
COMMUNITY LEADERS. TO IDENTIFY.
WHAT IS IT ABOUT OUR SERVICE
SYSTEM THAT ISN'T SPEAKING TO
PEOPLE?
ARE WE GETTING PEOPLE TO COME IN
THE FRONT DOOR AND I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF WORK DONE
ON THAT QUESTION.
AND ONCE WE GET PEOPLE TO COME
IN THE FRONT DOOR.
IT'S NOT ABOUT CONVINCING PEOPLE
THAT.
WHAT?
THE SERVICE DELIVERY THAT HAS
ALWAYS BEEN OFFERED IS
APPROPRIATE FOR THEM AND THEY
SHOULD TAKE IT IT'S ABOUT
TAILORING SERVICES TO MEET THOSE
NEEDS.
AND A LOT OF WORK IN THAT
RESPECT IS HAPPENING AS WELL --
IN TERMS OF IDENTIFYING SERVICE
PROVIDERS FROM -- DIFFERENT
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES AS WELL --
FINDING PEOPLE WHO HAVE
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE CAPABILITIES
WHO CAN -- INTERFACE WITH
DIFFERENT POPULATIONS -- AS
DIRECTOR BRIDGEMAN SAID A LOT OF
WORK IS GOING ON WITH -- A
PROMONTORY MODELS BUT ALSO
SIMILAR MODELS WHERE YOU ARE
WORKING WITH.
CURRENT MENTORS WHO -- PARENTS
WHO HAVE CHILDREN IN THE SYSTEM
TO OUTREACH TO OTHER PARENTS
THEY KNOW AND OTHER PARENTS THAT
THEY COME TO KNOW WHO ALSO HAVE
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES.
IT IS A COMPLEX SYSTEM AND
FINDING WAYS TO BREAK IT DOWN
AND HELP PEOPLE TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND IS A HUGE PIECE OF IT --
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT REGIONAL
CENTERS HAVE DONE A LOT OF OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS.
IS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
BEST EXPLAINER SERVICE DELIVERY
SYSTEM IN A WAY.
THAT -- IS ACCESSIBLE TO PEOPLE
AND THEN ASK PEOPLE THROUGH
INCREASINGLY ROBUST PERSON
CENTERED PLANNING.
HELP US TO IDENTIFY WHAT ARE THE
GOALS FOR YOU AND YOUR LOVED.
ONE AND HOW CAN WE AS A TEAM
WORK TO GET THERE EVEN IF IT'S
NOT WITH THEIR CURRENT SERVICES
OKAY SO AND I KNOW RESERVE
TRYING TO MOVE INSTRUCTIONAL THE
PC AND SO FORTH BUT I THINK.
THAT.
BUT I THINK THAT THE PROBLEM IS
LIKE IS ARE WE TRYING TO MAKE
THEIR FAMILIES CONFORM TO OUR
SYSTEM.
OR SHOULD BE SYSTEM BE SERVING
OUR FAMILIES AND WHAT WE'RE
HEARING IS THAT WE HAVE --
DISPARITY ISSUE PARTIALLY
BECAUSE YOU HAVE FAMILIES -- WHO --
PARTICULARLY FAMILIES WHO -- AND
DIFFERENT ETHNIC GROUPS OR
CATEGORIES OF COLOR WHO DO NOT --
UNDERSTAND OR DO NOT -- IT FEEL
COMFORTABLE WITH -- THE CURRENT
SYSTEM AND SO WE'VE GOT TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO RESPOND TO
THAT AND I A AGAIN I WOULD.
UNDERSCORE THE URGENCY OF THAT
NIGHT THREE YEARS AGO THE
LEGISLATURE SAID THIS IS A BIG
PROBLEM.
HERE'S SOME MORE MONEY TO DEAL
WITH THAT IT CETERA -- AND YOU
KNOW AND I GET ASKED ABOUT IT
AND AND THAT'S LIKE WHEN WHEN
CAN I TELL THEM THAT WE'VE
CHANGED THE NEEDLE HAS MOVED TO
WRITE SO -- AND YEAH I WANNA BE
JAIL THREE YEARS LATER SAYING OH
WELL WE'RE STILL DOING PILOTS
AND STUFF IT'S IT'S ULTIMATELY I
MEAN YES IT MATTERS WHAT YOU DO
BUT ULTIMATELY THE AND THE
QUESTION IS IS THAT.
ARE PEOPLE GETTING SORRY ON THE
PEOPLE WHO SHOULD BE A SERVICE
THEY NEEDED A WE DOING THIS I I
COULD REALLY.
ACROSS DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES AND
OF THE ANSWER STILL NO.
THAT'S A BIG PROBLEM THAT ARE
YOU KNOW TO YOUR TO YOUR POINT
IF YOU WANT ONE THING AND
FERNANDO ADDRESS THIS IN.
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT TO
DEPARTMENT CAN DO STATEWIDE IS
TO REALLY.
IMPLEMENT -- AND WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS -- AWAY SO THAT
PEOPLE DO NOT FEEL INTIMIDATED
OR FEEL LIKE THEY'RE GONNA BE
RETALIATED THAT SURREAL FEELING
EVEN IF IT DOESN'T ACTUALLY
HAPPEN.
AND IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT IS NOT
GOOD PEOPLE WORKING AT THE
REGIONAL CENTERS AND BECAUSE
THERE ARE.
AND I THINK WE HAVE TO DO IS
CREATE A SITUATION WHERE IT IS
SAFE FOR PEOPLE TO RAISE
CONCERNS THAT YOU'RE NOT GETTING
THE SERVICES OR THERE'S A
PROBLEM BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T
CREATE A SAFE ENVIRONMENT.
THAN ALL THE REPORTING THE WORLD
IS NOT GOING TO MATTER RIGHT AND
YOU KNOW JUST FROM YOUR OWN
PRACTICE.
AND WE GOT TO CREATE A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT FOR PEOPLE TO AT
LEAST RAISE CONCERNS.
AND THAT AGAIN IS NOT A
REFLECTION ON THE GOOD PEOPLE
WHO ARE TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT
THING AND REGIONAL CENTERS BUT
IT'S ALSO NOT A REFLECTION.
OF THE PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITIES
WHO SIMPLY WANT TO GET HELP FOR
THEIR FAMILIES AND I THINK IF WE
WORK IN THAT WAY WE'RE REALLY
TRYING TO BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER --
AND THEN LATER ON THE OTHER
STEPS AS YOU MENTIONED SENATOR --
YOU KNOW MIGHT START WORKING BUT
THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN STATEWIDE I
I THINK YOU'RE YOU'RE RIGHT OR
SOME STEP TO HAVE TO HAPPEN
STATEWIDE.
CAN HAPPEN AS A PILOT BECAUSE
OTHERWISE WE'RE NEVER GONNA
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM IN READ THE
FEAR RETALIATION IS DEFINITELY
REAL EVEN IF IT DOESN'T HAPPEN
AND I AND I WOULD.
EVEN THOUGH THIS IS NOT THE
RIGHT ANALOGY BUT TO ME TOO
MOVEMENT REALLY CREATED FIRST
THE ENVIRONMENT WHERE IT WAS
SAFE FOR PEOPLE WOMEN.
ESPECIALLY TO FEEL THEY CAN
RAISE A COMPLAINT OR CONCERNED
ABOUT BEING HARASSED THAT WAS A
MAJOR STEP.
AND FOR THE FOR THEM TO FEEL
THAT SAFE PLACE AND WE GOT TO
CREATE SOMETHING LIKE THAT LEASE
FOR THOSE FAMILIES WHO FEEL
THREATENED EVEN AFTER YOU KNOW
THAT DOESN'T ACTUALLY HAPPEN.
AGAIN IT'S NOT A REFLECTION ON
THE GOOD PEOPLE WERE TRYING TO
DO THE RIGHT THING.
BUT THE OTHER THING THAT IS IS
THAT THE IF YOU'RE A CONCERN
THAT THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS TO YOU
YOU TURN THERE'S BEEN OTHER PASS
SO MAYBE IT'S STRICTLY TO THE
APARTMENTS WHERE PEOPLE FEEL
LIKE THEY CAN EXPRESS BECAUSE
OTHERWISE.
YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE IS THAT THE
PERSON THE PERSON YOU HAVE TO
TALK TO ABOUT THIS IS THE RIGHT
PERSON YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT.
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
TOO THE OTHER THING I WOULD MAKE
NOTE -- SINCE THIS IS A BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AND WE DON'T JUST DO
THIS THE APARTMENT -- YOU KNOW
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING -- MY
MIND APPROPRIATELY THAT WE DO
DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENING ON EVERY
CHILD IN MEDI CAL [inaudible]
GREAT [inaudible]
GOOD THING.
WELL WHAT HAPPENS WE START
PICKING UP ALL THOSE KIDS DO YOU
THINK YOU KNOW YOU THINK ABOUT
THE PERCENTAGE SO IT WAS ON A
REFERENCE TO THE THE AUDIT
REPORT THAT SHOWED UP MOST TO
THE OUT BY KIDS ARE GETTING.
THERE PREVENTIVE CARE AND THAT
INCLUDES THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SCREENING.
OKAY NOW WE SHOULD BE ADDRESSING
THAT AND HOPEFULLY WILL FIX THAT
RIGHT AND THEN ALL HAPPEN IS
WE'RE GONNA TRY TO SCREEN ALL
THOSE WE HAVE A NEW SURGEON
GENERAL FOR A TUESDAY INTEREST
IS AND ADVERSE TO OUT EVENTS --
THINK ABOUT WHICH AGENCIES ARE
NOW GOING TO BE GETTING ALL OF
THOSE REFERRALS.
SENATOR IF -- YOU KNOW I THINK
THIS IS ONE OF THEM THAT'S GOING
TO GET A LOT OF REFERRALS AND
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE AND FROM
THE LAW AND ACTUALLY THE THE THE
THEY'LL POINT OUT THAT WE HAVETO SAY YES WE HAVE DISPARITIES
IN OTHER PLACES AND THAT
INCLUDES -- SO WHEN WE TRY TO
FIX THAT PROBLEM IN THE MEDIC
OUTSIDE AND SO FORTH.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A WAVE OF
PEOPLE COMING OVER THIS WAY AND
THEY FEEL LIKE THAT AND THEN IF
THEY DON'T GET SERVICE HERE AND
SO WE CAN GET YEAH THAT'S GOING
TO BE A PROBLEM SO YEAH.
SENATE IF I CAN REALLY BRIEFLY
MENTIONED ARM I PERSONALLY AM
VERY ENCOURAGED WITH THE INTRO
TO DEPARTMENT HAS MADE AND A LOT
OF THAT PLANTS THAT THEY'VE
LOOKING TO PUT IN PLACE AND AS
YOU MENTIONED EARLIER THERE IS
NO ONE SILVER BULLET THAT'S
GONNA.
REALLY RESOLVE A LOT OF THESE
CHALLENGES BUT I THINK ONE OF
THE KEY ITEMS THAT I BELIEVE WE
CAN WORK COLLABORATIVE TOGETHER.
IS WILL WE CAN HAVE A A A A
SPACE OR PLACER A SAFE HAVEN
WHERE PEOPLE CAN FEEL LIKE THEY
CAN REALLY OPEN UP AND HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
IT BE EDUCATIONAL ALL THE WAY
AROUND SO IF WE CAN FOCUS ON
SOMETHING LIKE THAT WERE
CONVERSATIONS MINIMAL
CONVERSATIONS WITHOUT THAT FEAR
RETALIATION WILL HAPPEN I
BELIEVE A LOT OF GROUND COULD BE
COVERED QUICKLY.
OKAY WELL CAN WE CREATE THAT
SPACE DIRECTOR.
YOU KNOW I'VE I'VE REALLY AS I
MENTIONED WHEN WE FIRST STARTED
THE CONVERSATION ONE OF THE THE
THINGS THAT I'M VERY GRATEFUL
FOR IS -- THIS GROUP OF MOMS
THAT HAVE BEEN MEETING WITH ME.
AND I WOULD HAVE TO SAY THAT
THAT WAS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR A
SAFE CONVERSATION -- AND SO I A
I LOOK FORWARD TO LOOKING T
WHAT ARE THOSE OPPORTUNITIES AND
HOW DO WE KIND OF BROAD NOSE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE SAFE
CONVERSATION SO.
FOLKS FEEL COMFORTABLE SHARING
THE CONCERNED SO I JUST WANT TO
MAKE NOTE THAT THERE'S THERE'S
ALWAYS THOSE THOSE PEARLS THAT
CAN BE BROADENED TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
THOSE THOSE SAFE CONVERSATIONS
THAT I AM I AM.
I AM ALWAYS COMMITTED TO MAKING.
A COMMITMENT TO LOOK AT HOW WE
CAN DO THAT.
OKAY SO -- SO WE HAVE AN URGENT
PROBLEM.
WE'D LIKE TO SEE THAT.
THE NEED TO MOVE ON THIS RIGHT
WE HAVE SO WE NEED TO TRY TO WE
NEED -- TO THE NEED ON THE
DISPARITIES -- PART OF DOING
THAT IS NOT ONLY THE VARIOUS
PILOTS AND SO FORTH BUT TREATING
THAT SPACES FOR PEOPLE TO HAVE
HONEST CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THEIR
CONCERNS -- STARRING SO THAT
SOUND THAT'S AN ISSUE AND AND BY
THE WAY YOU -- THERE'S A
POTENTIAL WAVE OF MORE KIDS
THAT'S GOING TO SHOW UP.
IF WE ACTUALLY EXECUTE ON SOME
OTHER POLICIES THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S EXPRESSES.
HIS GOAL IN THE AND IS AND I
SHARE THOSE -- BUT I ALSO WAS
VERY CONSCIOUS IS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IT THAT.
THIS AGENCIES AND ALL AND THE
THE VARIOUS THE BILL.
THERE IS GOING TO BE THE THE ONE
OF THE RECIPIENTS OF THE THAT
ACTIVITY.
WELL IT'S NOT ENOUGH JUST TO
DETECT IT SOMEONE NEEDS TO THEN
PROVIDE SUPPORT SERVICES AND SO
THIS IS ONE OF THE AGENCIES AND
THE CENTER REGIONAL CENTER THAT
THAT OUR CONTRACT WITH IT CETERA.
IT IS GOING TO HAVE YOU WITH AND
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE PEOPLE
FROM LOTS OF DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES OF WE DO THIS RIGHT.
AND THEN -- SO IF WE DO IT RIGHT
WILL BE SURE TO SCREEN SO THAT'S
A DISPARITIES ISSUE IF THE DRESS
THERE -- WE FIX THAT PROBLEM BUT
THEN IT MEANS THAT WHEN THEY
SHOW UP AT THIS AGE AND SELL AT
THE BILL BUT THE PROGRAMS
OVERSEEN BY THIS AGENCY THEY
NEED TO BE SURE TO GET SERVED.
AS WELL AND THERE'S A CELL ASIDE
FROM THE FINANCIAL ISSUES WE
ALSO NEED TO SHARE WITH
ELIMINATE CULTURAL BARRIERS AND
THAT'S ALSO PART OF THE URGENCY
NOT ONLY FOR THE EXISTING
CLIENTS AND EXPECTED FUTURE.
BUT THOSE ARE THE CLIENTS AS
WELL SO.
CAN HELP YOU UNDERSTAND EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS WHY I AM SO ANXIOUS
THAT WE MOVE THE NEEDLE ON THIS
BILL.
THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE HERE -- WELL
WE ARE WE'RE DOING SOME STUFF
BUT I MEAN THAT'S GREAT PEOPLE
DOING STUFF THEY ALSO WAS THE
RESULTS [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY.
SO I KNOW WE SPENT A BIT OF TIME
ON THIS BY.
I'VE BEEN HEARING FROM PEOPLE
HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS.
ALL RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE PANELISTS.
OKAY ISSUE NUMBER TEN SPRING
LETTER B. C. P. FOSTER USED
COMMON FORMS SYSTEMS OF CARE
.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU -- ON ISSUE --
TEN THE AGENDA DOES PROVIDE
REALLY GOOD DESCRIPTION AS FAR
AS AB TWENTY EIGHTY THREE AND
THEN PORTENT FOCUS.
ON THE CORE NEED AN TIMELY
TRAUMA INFORMED SYSTEM OF CARE
APPROACH.
AND THE EFFORT THAT -- WILL BE
MOVING FORWARD SO WITH THE
SECRETARY OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AND THE SUPERINTENDENT
PUBLIC INSTRUCTIONS REQUIRED TO
BRING TOGETHER A JOINT EIGHT
INTER AGENCY RESOLUTION TEAM.
AND OUR PROPOSAL IS REALLY
CENTERED AROUND KIND OF THE
RESPONSE TO LOOKING AT HOW WE
CAN -- BE ABLE TO ACTIVELY
PARTICIPATE WE ARE CURRENTLY
ACTIVELY A PARTICIPANT IN THE
EFFORTS -- THAT ARE IN DESIGNING
THE THAT THE INTER AGENCY
RESOLUTION TEAM -- WILL CONTINUE
TO DO THAT AND LOOKING AT WAYS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
FROM A STATE PERSPECTIVE BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT AND INFORM THE AMMO
USE THAT WOULD BE OCCURRING AT
THE KIND OF COUNTY LEVELS -- AND
REALLY IT'S ABOUT MAKING SURE
EXT ESPECIALLY THOSE FOSTER CARE
CHILDREN THAT HAVE KIND OF
SHARING OF SYSTEMS.
AND MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S A
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH AND
SUPPORTING THE INDIVIDUALS -- WE
CURRENTLY HAVE WITHIN
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES OVER FIVE
THOUSAND KIDS THAT HAVE
DEVELOPED A DISABILITY THAT ARE --
ALSO -- HAVE A COURT DEPENDENCY --
WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK AT HOW THE
MO USE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WOULD
THEN MOVE FORWARD SO WHILE THE --
AB.
TWENTY EIGHTY THREE OUTLINES
KINDA GOING THE COUNTY BASED
REGIONAL CENTERS ARE NOT
ESTABLISHED AS A COUNTY THERE'S
TWENTY ONE REGIONAL CENTERS.
SO WHEN WE'RE TAKING A LOOK AT
HOW THEY'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
BE AN ACTIVE PARTICIPANT AND
MAKING SURE THAT THEY ARE.
MOVING FORWARD THE INTENT OF
MAKING SURE THERE'S A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT WHEN WE
LOOKED AT HOW WE CAN BEST
SUPPORT THAT THAT'S WHAT THIS
PROPOSALS ABOUT.
IS HAVING THE STAFF THAT WOULD
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THOSE EFFORTS
SO WHEN WE LOOK AT DOING THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT LA COUNTY
HAVING FIVE STAFF THAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO WORK WITHIN.
THE LA COUNTY REGIONAL CENTERS
WE HAVE SEVEN REGIONAL CENTERS
IN THAT AREA AND THEN WE WILL
LOOK AT THE REST OF THE STATE WE
DID A AND APPOINT FIBER A PART
TIME.
POSITION THAT WOULD BE IN THE
SMALLER AREAS THAT DON'T HAVE AS
MANY CHILDREN THAT ARE ACTUALLY --
COURT DEPENDENCE OR THAT WOULD
HAVE KIND OF THOSE MULTIPLE
SYSTEMS ON THAT THEY WOULD HAVE
TO WORK WITH SO THAT'S OUR
PROPOSALS TO MAKE SURE THATWE
HAVE THE RESOURCES --
PARTICULARLY AT THE REGIONAL
CENTER LEVEL TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN BE SUCCESSFUL IN MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE DOING THAT
COORDINATED -- SUPPORT AND
DISCUSSION ON ON THE CHILDREN
THAT HAVE TO SHARE SYSTEMS.
OKAY THANK YOU COMES FROM OHIO.
FINANCE [inaudible]
OKAY.
SO THAT EVERY SHIFT -- A SO
ACTUALLY AB I'M NOT SURE MAYBE
I'M THIRTY MYSTIC ANSWERED BY SO
IN TERMS OF MULTIPLE REGIONAL
CENTERS -- BUT BASICALLY HAVE AB
DID YOU MENTION RIGHTS YOU HAVE
SOME PLACES YOU HAVE MULTIPLE
REGIONAL CENTERS WITH -- MULL IT
IN ONE COUNTY OTHER PLACES YOU
HAVE ONE RESULTS ARE COVERING
MULTIPLE COUNTIES HOUSE.
IN TERMS OF COORDINATING BETWEEN
IS THAT THE THE HOUSE APARTMENTS
GOING TO BE TRYING TO BE SURE WE
DON'T HAVE REGIONAL CENTERS
RUNNING INTO EACH OTHER AND THE
AND THE USE.
CORRECT YEAH AND AND JUST WHEN
WE TAKE A LOOK AT LA COUNTY
RIGHT WITH THE SEVEN REGIONAL
CENTERS THEY'VE BEEN WORKING
TOGETHER IN FOR MANY MANY MANY
YEARS YOU KNOW BECAUSE THEY PLAN.
WORKING IN THE SAME COUNTY SO
THEY'VE HAD -- TO AS A AS A
REGIONAL CENTERS OF SEVEN
REGIONAL CENTERS THEY'VE HAD TO
LEARN TO KIND OF HOW DO THEY
COORDINATE.
AMONGST THEMSELVES SO THEN
THEY'RE WORKING TOGETHER WITH
THE COUNTY SO THEY THEY HAVE
THOSE KIND OF OKAY SO LA LAYS
THE WORKS ALREADY BUILT ISRAELIS
USED TO WORKING EACH OTHER
THERE'S ARE YOU DO YOU HAVE
OTHER AREAS WHERE YOU SEE THE
SCREEN OF THE TENT.
MORE FOR POTENTIAL PROBLEMS.
YOU KNOW THE REGIONAL CENTERS
THAT HAVE KIND OF SHARED
COUNTIES IT'S VERY LIMITED OTHER
THAN YOU KNOW REALLY LA COUNTY'S
LARGEST -- ONE SO I'D I DON'T
SEE ANY PROBLEMS WITH THAT IN
THE END -- SO AMONGST THOSE
AREAS I THINK HAVING THE STAFF
OUT THERE THAT'S GOING TO BE
ABLE TO FOCUS THAT COORDINATED
EFFORT IS GOING TO HELP.
OKAY THAT'S ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
RIGHT ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN CRISIS
HOMES FOR CHILDREN.
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
YES SO FOR THE COMMUNITY AT THE
COMMUNITY CRISIS HOMES FOR
CHILDREN -- I HAS I SPOKE ABOUT
THOSE A LITTLE BIT EARLIER WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE SAFETY
NET YEP SO THE PROPOSAL WAS.
TO HAVE THE THREE COMMUNITY
CRISIS HOMES FOR CHILDREN BUT
REALLY IT'S ABOUT HAVING THAT --
THE ABILITY TO HAVE THIS LICENSE
CATEGORY IT'S A BRAND NEW
LICENSE CATEGORY FOR CHILDREN
THIS IS REPLICATED AFTER A
COMMUNITY CHORUSES HOMES FOR
ADULTS.
I'M SO RECOGNIZING THAT THE
REGIONAL CENTERS HAS STARTED TO
DEVELOP THOSE RESOURCES WE HAVE
A NUMBER OF THEM THAT HAVE NOW
BEEN.
LICENSED AND THEY'RE IN
OPERATION WE HAVE QUITE A FEW
MORE RIGHT NOW THAT ARE IN
DEVELOPMENT BUT ALSO
UNDERSTANDING THE URGENCY OF OF
SUPPORTING CHILDREN.
IN NEEDING KIND OF THAT
STABILIZATION SO WE TOOK A LOOK
AT KIND OF THE NUMBER OF KIDS AS
I TALKED ABOUT EARLIER.
THAT WE WE WANTED TO GET A JUMP
START ON IT WE DIDN'T WANT TO
GET THE AUTHORITY TO GO AHEAD
AND DEVELOP THE HOMES AND THEN
HAVE THE REGIONAL CENTERS.
START DEVELOPING KIND OF THE THE
PLANS WE WANT TO GO AHEAD AND
SAY LET'S START WITH AT LEAST
THREE LET'S GO AHEAD AND GET THE
AUTHORITY TO DO THE LICENSING.
ARM AND THEN WE CAN FOLLOW IT UP
WITH FUTURE YEARS WHEN WE START
DOING THAT BIGGER PLAN OF
UNDERSTANDING WHAT'S NEEDED.
THANK YOU LA -- COMMENTS FINANCE
ALRIGHT SO.
ALRIGHT SO WE GIVE YOU THE STORY
RIGHT -- ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE OF
SPECIALIZED CASELOAD RATIOS FOR
REGIONAL CENTERS.
YES THANK YOU AND AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER WITH THE SAFETY NET WHEN
WE'RE TAKING A LOOK AT ELEMENTS
THAT HAVE TO KIND OF MOVE
FORWARD YOU KNOW WHEN WE DO TAKE
A LOOK AT KIND OF THIS THE THE
RANGE OF WHERE THE SUPPORTS NEED
TO OCCUR.
YOU KNOW I I REALLY WANT US TO
START LOOKING AT KIND OF THAT
PREVENTATIVE SUPPORTIVE AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE FRONT END OF A CRISIS OR
STABILIZING AS SOMEBODY HAS BEEN
IN CRISIS HOW DO WE HELP THE
FAMILY AND THE INDIVIDUAL.
KIND OF STABILIZE THE REGIONAL
CENTERS CASELOAD.
AS FAR AS BEING ABLE TO SUPPORT
INDIVIDUALS WITH COMPLEX NEEDS
WE'VE NOT ADDRESS THAT IN THE
PAST THIS PROPOSAL REALLY GETS
TO ADDRESSING THAT PARTICULAR
ISSUE.
GIVING THE REGIONAL CENTERS
ABILITY TO HAVE A CASELOAD A
SPECIALIZED CASE ON A ONE TO
TWENTY FIVE THAT IS REALLY
FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE THAT WE
CAN HELP STABILIZE.
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE AND
KIND OF THE MOST -- COULD A
CRISIS IF YOU WILL -- AND WE DO
BELIEVE THAT BY HAVING A SERVICE
COORDINATOR THAT'S ABLE TO YOU
KNOW WORK WITH THE FAMILY WORK
WITH THE INDIVIDUAL WORK WITH
THE OTHER AGENCIES THAT CAN
PROVIDE THOSE SUPPORT SERVICES
WORK WITH THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ARE PROVIDING IT THROUGH -- THE
VENDOR SERVICES THAT WE WILL SEE
YOU CAN IT INCREASE
STABILIZATION ON MORE OF A
PREVENTATIVE AS OPPOSED TO KIND
OF APPROACHING REACTIVE BIKE
KIND OF THE CLOSE COMMUNITY
CRISIS HOMES ETCETERA SO IT'S
APPROACH.
TO KIND OF DO THE FRONT END AND
THE SUPPORTIVE SIDE -- IN IN
RELATIONSHIP TO THE SERVICE SIDE
AS WELL.
BELIAU COMMENTS THIRTY PEDICLE
ALE A REAL BRIEFLY WE DON'T HAVE
ANY PARTICULAR CONCERNS ABOUT
THIS PROPOSAL WE THINK IT'S
LIKELY A GOOD IDEA BUT IT DID.
BRING UP AN ISSUE FOR US THAT
WE'VE BEEN THINKING ABOUT FOR
SEVERAL YEARS WHICH IS THE FACT
THAT MOST REGIONAL CENTERS ARE
OUT OF COMPLIANCE WITH THE THE
REQUIRED STAFFING RATIOS ACROSS
VARIOUS CATEGORIES SO.
I MEAN THIS MAY HELP.
EASE SOME OF THOSE -- SOME OF
THOSE RATIOS OF A BIT BUT IT YOU
KNOW AGAIN IT'S ONLY ABOUT FIFTY
ADDITIONAL SERVICE COORDINATORS
AND WE ONLY MENTION THIS TO TO
POINT OUT THAT.
EVEN FOR THOSE CONSUMERS WHO ARE
NOT IN CRISIS THEY ALSO NEED AN
ADEQUATE AMOUNT OF TIME WITH
THEIR SERVICE COORDINATOR TO GET
WHAT THEY NEED AND WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THINGS LIKE RACIAL
AND ETHNIC DISPARITIES IN
PURCHASE OF SERVICE EXPENDITURES.
YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT -- STAFFING
RATIOS THAT ARE OUT OF
COMPLIANCE PROBABLY DON'T HELP.
RIGHT.
IN FACT IT PROBABLY DOES RATIOS
ARE PROBABLY DESIGNED.
FOR CLIENTS WHO DON'T HAVE
LANGUAGE CHALLENGES OR CULTURAL
CHALLENGES AS WELL.
ALL RIGHT FINANCE [inaudible]
OKAY SO [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
SO JUST HOW OUT OF COMPLIANCE OR
THE OTHER ISSUES.
SO -- THIS IS SOMETHING WE'VE
REQUESTED A DATE ON THE PAST
COUPLE OF YEARS AND HAVE NOT
ACTUALLY RECEIVED IT -- I
UNDERSTAND IN THE NEXT ISSUE IN
THE NEXT -- ISSUE IN THE AGENDA
THAT -- THEY ASSOCIATION
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES WILL BE
TALKING ABOUT.
THAT VERY ISSUE AND I THINK THEY
HAVE ACCESS TO BETTER DATA THAN
WE DO OKAY SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN
[inaudible]
NOW YES.
WE DO HAVE -- UPDATED.
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS WE HAVE --
CASELOAD RATIOS THAT IS REPORTED
TO US WERE HAPPY TO PROVIDE THAT
AND IT IT IS.
THE LAST TIME IT WAS UPDATED WAS.
MARCH FIRST SO WE'LL WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND PROVIDE THE CASELOAD
RATIO REPORT THAT WE DO RECEIVE.
OKAY THAT WOULD BE FANTASTIC
BECAUSE THAT'S THE EXACT REPORT
THAT OUR OFFICE HAS REQUESTED
PASSED O YOU KNOW I SO ALL
RIGHT I APPRECIATED DIRECTOR NAY
YOU'LL SUPPLY THAT TO THE LA L.
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY RIGHT THE CELL ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTEEN IS ACTUALLY A PROPOSALS
FOR INVESTMENTS OF USEFULNESS.
STAY THERE AND WILL.
HAVE.
THE ASSOCIATION FOR REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCIES COME UP AND
THANK YOU HAVE [inaudible] THREE
THREE ITEMS.
A THREE REQUESTS.
AND THE I THINK WE DO HAVE A
DESCRIPTION OF THOSE SO BREVITY
WOULD BE APPRECIATED.
ABSOLUTELY AND I APPRECIATE THE
KICKING OFF OF THE DISCUSSION OF
SERVICE COORDINATION.
JUST BRIEFLY SERVICE
COORDINATION IS THE CORE
FUNCTION OF REGIONAL CENTERS AND
THE MOST VISIBLE FUNCTION THEY
PROVIDE.
IT GOES FAR BEYOND BEING AN
ELIGIBILITY WORKER FOR RESPITE
OR OTHER SERVICES AND IS
FUNDAMENTALLY ABOUT MAKING THE
LIVES OF PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES
BETTER AND EASIER.
IT'S ABOUT BEING A SUPPORT FOR
THEM IN THE GOOD TIMES AND BAD.
IN SERVICE COORDINATORS I'VE
WORKED WITH.
THEY'VE HAD. TO BE THAT PERSON
THAT A FAMILY.
DOES TO WHEN THEY DISCOVER THAT
THEIR CHILD HAS A DISABILITY AND
NEED SOMEONE TO PROCESS THAT
WITH.
WE CELEBRATE THE SUCCESSES OF A
CHILD COMMUNICATING FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN A WAY THAT THE
FAMILY UNDERSTANDS EVEN IF THAT
COMMUNICATION ISN'T VERBAL.
THEY SUPPORT FAMILIES WHEN
SOMETHING UNEXPECTEDLY PUNCHES
HIM IN THE GUT.
LIKE WHEN YOUR CHILD TURNS
SIXTEEN AND THEY'RE NOT DRIVING
YOU DIDN'T EXPECT HIM TO BUT
THAT SIXTEENTH BIRTHDAY STILL
HURTS.
AND THEY ATTEND FUNERAL SERVICES
ALONGSIDE FAMILY MEMBERS
SOMETIMES EVEN THOUGH CEREMONIES
USUALLY RESERVED ONLY FOR FAMILY
MEMBERS.
AND TO BE SUCCESSFUL SERVICE
COORDINATORS NEED A WHOLE
INFRASTRUCTURE BEHIND THEM TO
MAKE THEM EFFECTIVE.
WE NEED CLINICAL SERVICES
SUPPORT SERVICES.
THEY NEED RESOURCE DEVELOPMENT
QUALITY ASSURANCE RISK
MITIGATION ACCOUNTING SOMEONE
HAS TO PAY SERVICE PROVIDERS FOR
THE SERVICES THAT ARE
COORDINATED.
EFFECTIVE SERVICE COORDINATION
AND OTHER CRITICAL SUPPORT
SERVICES.
AT REASONABLE CASELOAD RATIOS IS
WHAT WE ARE PROMISED TO PROVIDE
WE PROMISE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN OUR INSURANCES.
AND THIS IS A PROMISE THE
REGIONAL CENTERS ARE STRUGGLING
TO KEEP.
WE HAVE A COMPLEX ARRAY OF
CASELOAD RATIOS.
BUT IN NO CASE.
HAVE WE PROMISED ANYTHING
GREATER THAN A ONE TO SIXTY SIX
CASELOAD RATIO.
TODAY MORE THAN THREE QUARTERS
OF THE PEOPLE SUPPORTED BY
REGIONAL CENTERS ARE IN CASE
LOADS OF GREATER THAN SEVENTY
PEOPLE SO OVER THREE QUARTERS OF
THE PEOPLE.
ARE BEING SHORT CHANGED THEIR
SERVICE COORDINATION TIME.
AS CASELOADS GET LARGER.
AND DOCUMENTATION EXPECTED GREAT
EXPECTATIONS GET MORE ONEROUS.
WHAT WE FIND IS THAT SERVICE
COORDINATORS?
CHECK BOXES.
BECAUSE THOSE ARE THE THINGS
THAT CAN BE AUDITED AND COUNTED.
AND WHAT WE LOSE IN THAT PROCESS
WHEN A CASELOAD RATIO IS TOO
HIGH.
IS THE QUALITY OF THE
INTERACTION INTERACTIONS BECOME
MORE TRANSACTIONAL.
AND THE TIME FOR CULTIVATING
STRONG TRUSTING RELATIONSHIPS IS
WHAT GETS SACRIFICED.
TODAY THE STATE IS SIX HUNDRED
NINETY ONE SERVICE COORDINATOR
SHORT.
FROM WHAT WE WERE PROMISED THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND WHAT WE
KNOW MAKES REGIONAL CENTER
SPECIAL AND SETS THEM APART FROM
[inaudible]
ELIGIBILITY WORKERS.
REGIONAL CENTERS PRIORITIZE
SERVICE COORDINATION.
BUT THIS REQUIRES THAT THEY
SACRIFICE OTHER THINGS BECAUSE
BUDGETED SERVICE COORDINATION
WAGES AND BENEFITS ARE ABOUT 57%
OF THE ACTUAL COST OF AN F. DESK
YOU TO WRAP UP JEFF AND I ASSUME
YOU WANT ACTUALLY GET TO YOUR
REQUEST.
OUR REQUESTS ARE PRETTY STRAIGHT
FORWARD AND THEY'RE ALL TIED TO
THIS.
SINCE THE LAST TIME.
REGIONAL CENTERS RECEIVED AN
INFLUX OF MONEY FOR OPERATIONS.
THE CPI HAS INCREASED BY 8% THE
CALIFORNIA WAGE INDEX BY TWELVE
SO THERE'S A REQUEST FOR AN 8%.
DOWN PAYMENT FOR RETENTION AND
COMPETITIVE WAGES.
IT WOULD COST AN ADDITIONAL
THIRTY EIGHT POINT TWO MILLION
GENERAL FUND. TO BACK FILL THE
SIX HUNDRED NINETY ONE MISSING
POSITIONS AND APPROPRIATE
SUPERVISION.
AND IF WE WERE TO TRY TO BRING.
REGIONAL CENTERS BUDGETED.
SALARIES FOR SERVICE
COORDINATION UP TO CURRENT
STANDARDS IT WOULD BE ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY
WHICH IS A BIG INVESTMENT.
BUT IT'S BECAUSE THE SYSTEM HAS
BEEN STAR FOR SO LONG SO.
THAT'S IT OKAY.
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
FOR PART OF THE HEALTH SERVICES.
NO OKAY -- COMMENTS AT THE LA --
FINANCE [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
SO -- I APPRECIATE THE HE SAID
ABOUT THE SHORTFALL HERE SO WE
HAVE THREE WE HAVE AN
OPERATIONAL OF PAYMENT SERVICE
CORPS NATION SHORTFALL
REALIGNMENT SOME.
OF PLANNING COSTS -- SO CLEARLY
AND YOU SAID WERE SIX HUNDRED
NINETY ONE SHORT.
CORRECT [inaudible]
YES OKAY -- DID TO EAT ITSELF SO
CERTAINLY WE HAVE AN OVERALL AND
NUMBER SHORTAGE STATE YOUR AND
DESERVE AGREEMENT WITH THAT
NUMBER [inaudible]
MYERS.
WE'VE NOT LOOKED AT THAT I LIKE
IS THAT WE DO HAVE A CASELOAD
RATIO REPORTS AND SO THERE -- AS
MISS WAS LEAN HAD NOTED THAT
THERE'S DIFFERENT RATIOS THAT A
RETURN FOR RIGHT PURPOSES AND SO
TO TAKE A LOOK AT KIND OF THAT
OVERALL ANALYSIS YOU KNOW
THERE'S THERE'S A LITTLE BIT.
OF OF VIEW THAT WE NEED TO DO AS
A RESULT -- BUT LIKE I SAID
THERE'S RATIOS FOR INDIVIDUALS
WHO MOVE FROM DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS THERE'S RATIOS.
FOR COMPLIANCE WITH OUR
APPLICATION FOR THE WAIVER SO
THERE'S THERE'S AN A NAME NUMBER
OF PIECES BUT WE ARE SEEING THAT
THERE'S A WITHIN OUR CASELOAD
RATIOS.
THE KIND OF AN AVERAGE OF ABOUT.
ONE TO SEVENTY SEVENTY YEAH SO
IT'S IT'S A REPORTED RIGHT NOW
BETWEEN ONE TO SEVENTY SEVEN OR
ONE SEVENTY FIVE ALL RIGHT.
AND AS FAR AS THE THE THE RACIAL
ETHNIC DISTRICT -- DEMOGRAPHICS
OF THE BILL'S EXISTING AND
FEATURES COORDINATORS THAT
REFLECTIVE OF THE POPULATION
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT DATA YOU KNOW
I KNOW ANYONE COLLECTING THAT
DATA.
WE DON'T CUTTING THAT.
WE DON'T LIKE IT THE DEPARTMENT
WE DON'T COLLECT I DON'T AND
WHAT ABOUT THE EMPLOYERS I MEAN
YOU HAVE TO THE SPY EOC REPORTS
AND SO FORTH FOR EMPLOYEES AND
CETERA SO.
AND IN TERMS OF STATEWIDE
NUMBERS I DON'T HAVE IT I HAVE
HEARD FROM A COUPLE OF REGIONAL
CENTERS THAT HAVE COLLECTED THAT
DATE AND THEY DO FIND THAT THEIR
SERVICE COORDINATORS ARE LARGELY
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE DEMOCRAT
A. B. TO ADAPT THAT DATA.
RIGHT AS WE WERE TALKING
PREVIOUSLY.
RIGHT CELL AND ALSO.
AND THE LANGUAGE CAPACITY.
THE SERVICE COORDINATORS.
SO THE GOOD TO HAVE THAT
INFORMATION TO WE DON'T HAVE IT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
RIGHT BUT I THINK IT WOULD ALSO
BE GOOD.
TO CHECK UP ON I MEAN CLEARLY
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH IF YOU'RE
TELLING ME YOU'RE RATIOS
[inaudible]
ONE TO SEVENTY FIVE RIGHT
OKAY.
OKAY ANYTHING ELSE THE ON OKAY.
ALL RIGHT OKAY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SO -- WE WILL.
GO AHEAD TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
THEN ON ISSUES NINE THROUGH
THIRTEEN AGAIN ASK IF YOU CAN
PLEASE KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO A
MINUTE OR LESS.
RIGHT THANK YOU WELCOME.
THANK YOU -- MY NAME IS HOST OF
IN ANY OF IS A AND I'M FROM THE
INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE -- NE OF THE
THINGS THAT I WANTED TO MENTION
IS DAY MIS COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
THE FAMILY IT'S AN AND THEIR
REGIONAL CENTER.
NOW -- WORKING WITH FAMILIES IREALIZE THAT IT'S A BIG ISSUE
BECAUSE SOMETIMES IT'S NOT
TRANSLATED -- GOOD ENOUGH OR OR
WERE THEY JUST.
DON KNOW HOW TO COMMUNICATE SO I
THINK YOU FROM.
WE FIND A WAIT FOR THE REGIONAL
CENTER TO TELL THE FAMILIES.
IN ALL.
ON ONE WAY.
IT WILL BE WAY FOR MUCH BETTER
FOR THE FAMILIES TO UNDERSTAND
IT OR EITHER -- SO EVERYBODY
COULD KNOW WHAT IT IS BECAUSE
NOW I FIND OUT THAT A LOT OF A
LOT OF OUR CASES ARE A LOT OF
MISCOMMUNICATION.
AND THEN THE FAMILY DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE SERVICES -- THEY
DON'T KNOW WHAT THERE IS.
OR OR THEY REGIONAL CENTER THE
SERVICE COORDINATORS TELLS THEM
THE NAME OF THE SERVICE BUT THEY
DON'T KNOW WHAT IT COVERS.
SO I THINK A MUSE COMMUNICATION
IS A BIG ISSUE WITH THE REGIONAL
CENTER AND THE FAMILIES THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME -- HI EVERYBODY I WILL
TRY IS PICKING THESE ARE I'M PER
SE ONE IS A THANK YOU JUDY MYERS
OF THE V. YOU'LL FOR HIM BY AS
THE BUT DISOBEY AND IS MEETING.
AIRING -- MY COMMENT IS THE
STICKING -- I KNOW EVERYBODY WE
ARE HERE DISCUSS THING ABOUT --
THESE ARE A BIT ISHAQ.
M. FOR ME AS AS VERY SAD HERE
SUNDAY ALLY THAT ODD Là YOU.
MAY BE -- YOU THESE ARE NOT
FIXED AS SOON AS POSSIBLE MAYBE
WE CAN CHANGE SOMETHING FOR
MEDICA. FOR ME IS VERY SAD
BECAUSE I WOULD CONSUMERS NEED
THAT REGULAR CENTER NEEDED
SERVICES.
IN ORDER SO IF EVERYBODY
REMEMBER -- FOR WHAT A FOR WHAT
THE REGULAR CENTERS.
WHAT MADE WHAT WAS THE MAIN
PURPOSE? FOR THE REGULAR CENTERS.
YEAH ALLEVIATE IT -- IS A
WONDERFUL WONDERFUL SERVICE SAYS
IT WONDERFUL I CAN SEE BUT THE
PROBLEM IS HOW IS IT WORKING
THIS SEIZE THEM SYSTEMATIC ARE
NOW IS THAT BE IT FOR ALL
BILLING.
SYSTEM AT THE BRAWLING NOW BANG.
WE NEED TO MAKE CHANGE AND WORK
TOGETHER THANK YOU SO MUCH
EVERYBODY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
NUMBER SEVEN AND TO THIS.
FIRST OF ALL I RECOGNIZE THE
HARD WORK.
THAT HAS BEEN DONE.
A SO FAR.
BY ALL DAY USES BUT UP THIS
PETITIONS ARE MUCH HIGHER THAN
THE ACTUAL RESULTS. TO THE POINT
THAT I HE GIVES THE IMPRESSION
THAT THERE IS NO SENSE OF
URGENCY IN SOME AREAS.
UP THE SAID THE THIS A CULTURAL
ISSUE.
OF THE TWO HISPANICS OR
DIFFERENT CULTURES INVOLVED.
WHICH I DEFINITELY DISAGREED BUT
IS MORE THAN -- REGIONAL CENTERS
CULTURE IN THE WAY OF THESE
FAMILIES ARE ARE BEING.
TAKEN CARE OF FOR WHEN THEY
REQUEST -- HELP.
AND IT EXPOSES THE LACK OF US
SINCE THE SENSITIVITY AND SENSE
OF URGENCY ALSO.
AS WELL AS NO PLANS. TO HOLD
THESE PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
POOR RESULTS SO FAR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
DAVID MALL THE REPEAT SITTING
SEIU DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
COUNCIL AND I'M RETIRED NOW BUT
I WAS A SERVICE COORDINATOR FOR
THIRTY THREE YEARS -- AND I'VE
HAD CASELOADS IN THE SIXTIES AND
I'VE HAD CASELOADS IN THE
HUNDREDS.
OVER A HUNDRED AND I KNOW WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE IN TERMS OF THE
DIFFERENCE IN THE QUALITY OF
SERVICES ARE I CAN PROVIDE.
WHEN YOU GET A CASE LOAD ITS WAY
OUT OF COMPLIANCE ALL YOU CAN DO
IS MANAGE EMERGENCIES AND THE
THINGS THAT THE AUDITOR'S LOOK --
FOR YOUR BILL YOU REALLY GET TO
KNOW FAMILIES AND AND SUPPORT
FAMILIES IS JUST INCREDIBLY
DIMINISHED AND THAT'S ONLY
AMPLIFIED FOR SERVICE
COORDINATORS.
WHO ARE SUPPORTING PEOPLE WHO
SPEAK A LANGUAGE OTHER THAN
ENGLISH -- THERE YOU KNOW
THERE'S A LOT MORE.
CULTURAL UNDERSTANDING AN
EXPLANATION IT'S REQUIRED THIS
TRANSLATION THAT'S REQUIRED --
AND IF ANYTHING THEY SHOULD HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER CASE LOADS
AND THE REST OF US OFF IN THE
END UP HIGHER BECAUSE WE HAVE
DIFFICULTY ATTRACTING PEOPLE
WITH THOSE KIND OF LANGUAGE AND
CULTURAL SKILLS A SERVICE
COORDINATOR.
WITH THE WAGES WE PAY AND AND
THE PROBLEM ISN'T REGIONAL
CENTERS ARE TRYING TO HIRE
SERVICE COORDINATORS -- AND AND
IF YOU LOOK AT THE BUDGET WERE
BUDGETED FOR ENOUGH.
BUT THE AMOUNT THAT WE BUDGET
FOR EACH SERVICE COORDINATOR IS
BASED ON NUMBERS.
THAT WERE SET IN.
TWO THOUSAND ONE AND WE CAN'T
PAY PEOPLE TWO THOUSAND ONE
WAGES YOU LOOK AT THE BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSALS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT.
NONE OF THEM ARE BASED ON WAGES
THAT IT WOULD HIGH COST THEM TO
HIRE NEW EMPLOYEES IN -- TWO
THOUSAND ONE SO ANYWAY HI
COURAGE IS STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THANK YOU.
WELCOME HI JUDY MARK DISABILITY
VOICES UNITED I WANNA THANK YOU
DOCTOR PAN FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE
LEADERSHIP ON THE ISSUE OF
DISPARITIES -- YEAR QUESTIONS
WERE ARE REALLY AB BUT WHERE IT
EFFECTED ME GREATLY - I JUST
WANT TO MAKE A COUPLE OF POINTS
THAT -- INTIMIDATION ISRAEL THIS
IS NOT SOMETHING THAT IS BEING.
FABRICATED -- THERE WERE PARENTS
WE WANTED TO COME HERE AND SPEAK
BUT THEY WERE AFRAID AFRAID THAT
SOMETHING WOULD HAPPEN TO THEIR
SERVICE THEIR CHILD SERVICES --
AND THE OTHER POINT I WANT TO
MAKE IS THAT WE DON'T KNOW
WHETHER ANY OF THE GREAT OF THE
PROJECTS HAVE WORKED WE REALLY
DON'T KNOW IT EVERYTHING IS SELF
REPORTING.
AND WE HAVE TO HAVE AN
INDEPENDENT ANALYSIS I WAS THE
LEAD RESEARCHER ON OUR PAPER ON
A REPOT ON THIS DISPARITIES I
CAN TELL YOU THAT I USE THE
NUMBERS THAT ARE PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE THERE ARE NEW NUMBERS
THE DDS CAN MAKE AVAILABLE TO ME.
I WILL RUN THOSE NUMBERS AS WELL
BUT THE DISPARITIES OF ACTUALLY
GOTTEN WORSE IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
AND SO IT WE HAVE TO HAVE SOME
SORT OF INDEPENDENT ANALYSIS AND
EVALUATION OF THE PROJECTS THAT
ARE BEING FUNDED AND THE METHOD
IN WHICH WE ARE SELECTING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
SENATOR PATRICK ROLLINS
REPRESENTING OUR CAREER
ASSOCIATION REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES JUST WANT TO GO ON
RECORD -- ON ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
THE CRISIS HOMES FOR CHILDREN IN
SUPPORT OF THAT ITEM AND ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE THE SPECIALIZED
CASELOAD RATIOS IS WELL THANK
YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
MANY X. CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
RIGHTS I WANT TO PICK UP A
NUMBER NINE DISPARITIES IT
HERE'S WHAT CAP SACRAMENTO
COUNTY STILL NICE IN A COUNTY
COMMISSION NOT REPRESENTING THE
COMMISSION TODAY BUT WHAT WE'VE
DONE IS WE WANT TO KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU GO INTO THE
DOOR.
WHAT KIND WHAT KIND OF SERVICE
DO YOU GET?
AND WE'RE WHAT KIND OF MATERIALS
DO YOU GET AND THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING THAT WE LEARNED
IN OUR COUNTY IS NOT EVERYBODY
KNOWS ENGLISH AS A SECOND
LANGUAGE.
THEY WOULD GO IN THERE BUT NAY
WE GO I CAN'T HELP YOU BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE A TRANSLATOR.
THIS IS THE OTHER ISSUE IS
PRETTY LGBT COMMUNITY.
THERE HAS TO BE CULTURAL
SENSITIVITY TO BECAUSE SOME OF
THOSE STUDENTS AND SOME OF THOSE
KIDS ARE COMING IN THERE WHO ARE
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN YEARS OLD.
THERE WE GOT THIS CHANGE THEY
FEEL IT COMING OUT AND THEY
DON'T BELIEVE THAT IT'S SAFE FOR
THEM.
WE'VE HAD DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THIS
ADD TO YOUR RESULTS ARE AT OUR
LAMBDA CENTER ABOUT KIDS WHO
WANT TO COME OUT IN TO THE
PARENTS BUT THEY CAN'T BUT THEY
WANT MAY SAY WELL MAYBE I CAN
COME OUT TO A REGIONAL
COUNCILLOR.
WHAT WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
RECENT COUNSELOR SENSITIVE
ENOUGH TO KNOW THAT THIS IS
HAPPENING SO THIS IS ANOTHER
ISSUE THAT WE SHOULD LOOK INTO?
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
I'M GONNA TRY TO SPEAK IN
ENGLISH.
OKAY -- GOOD AFTERNOON.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
OKAY A GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY --
LET'S SEE ANOTHER IN ESPANOL
[inaudible]
OKAY -- LOS [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
I AM.
RIGHT OKAY.
THANK YOU WE REALLY SHOULD HAVE
INTERPRETERS.
OKAY DOES THIS THE ONE THAT IS
SO NOT REALLY THAT.
IT IS BETTER USE THAT I A
REALITY.
I'M CARE AGAIN WHICH WAS AS FOR
SOULS BUT A LOT OF THE CARDINAL.
EVEN IF THERE IS A LOT OF OF
WHICH EFFORTS. TO TO WORK WITH
THAT YEAH.
GET OUT REPORT THAT A K. MUCHO
ME OF THE PROCESS -- A PRESENT
CENTER OF LARA NESTOS COMMITTED.
A I WANNA LET YOU KNOW THAT
THERE IS FEAR A IN COMING IN AND
TESTIFYING IN THIS COMMITTEE.
BUT CAN USE.
GET SAY.
BURKE IS A CONCEALER A GAY ONE
ANOTHER THIS YEAR OF COURSE AS
MY LAST.
BECAUSE IF A EIGHT FOUR SUPPOSED
TO NOT SAY ANYTHING BY BEING.
IS THAT MANY OF THEM.
AND IT'S A SCARY.
YOUR MUST ADDRESS ON THE I AM.
TAKEN THERE IS THERE A MESSAGE
WAS MUST SUPPORT BUT WE DO NEED
MORE.
HELP MORE SUPPORT ACTUALLY.
LARA LIST WE HAVE A SIMPLE THE
LET ME HOLD.
A BUSTED BMW I JUST KIND OF LET
YOU KNOW A LITTLE BIT ABOUT MY
SON IT WILL BE LIKE REALLY FAST.
IT [inaudible]
IN.
WHEN HE HAD A?
VERY BAD AGGRESSIVE BEHAVIORS
THEY SEND US TOOL. TWO OF THESE --
OF NO IT'S CLASSES BUT A
PROVIDENCE -- BEHAVIOR CLASSES
FOR PARENTS YEAH HE ENTERED I'M
IT DOESN'T BOTHER BOTHER.
HE GONNA SON ALSO THROW SENSIBLE
NEGATIVE IN MOST AS THEY ARGUE
THAT I MUST THROW SEE HOSPITAL
YOUR LET YOUR LATEST AND WITH
THAT WE WERE SUPPOSED TO HELP
OUR KIDS OUR CHILDREN.
BETTER YOLO THIS YES HELLO SEND
OF CENTRAL RECOGNIZE YOUR
NECESSARY BUT YOU THAT IT ACT UP
ON ME HOLD.
BUT I I WILL TELL THE REGIONALS
AND THE THANK SHE WILL NEED THEY
READ SERVICES FOR TO CHECK.
EIGHTY E. S. THAT BAGEL
SIMPLEMENTE IT BEGINNING NOT
OFTEN IN YOUR MOST OF YOUR
PROCESS SO THEY WILL BUT IT.
THEY BELIEVE NOR MEANS SOUL AND
I DO THE KNOW THE PROCESS SO I
JUST THOUGHT.
E. IMMISCIBLE SO YOU'LL SEE MOST
CORNER.
ARE YOU ON THE MEDICAL COMO
NOSOTROS FOR THE ALMOST AND WE
IN MY HUSBAND AND MYSELF WOULD
JUST HELP OUR KIDS THAT WAY WE
WOULD [inaudible]
IN.
THIS CALL THE MY BOOK AND I'LL
GO BEYOND FOR RESTAURANT THEY
LOOK.
YEAH LOOKING OUT I'M SORRY BUT
IT WAS VERY FRUSTRATING HE WILL
GET THE CHAIR AND THROW IT OUT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THIS CALL FOR ME [inaudible]
OUR BATTLE -- ORDER.
OUR TO YOUR STORY.
GET THE END OF THE NURSES TO BE
SUPER ME WHOLE END OF A DAY ON
YOUR I APOLOGIZE FOR BAD BUT NOW
I'M.
TRYING TO GET OUR SERVICES FOR
MY SON HE'S TWENTY YEARS.
ESTO ENCOUNTER Là M<c.cyan> CHOSE</c>
WATER US.
KNOW.
I'M GETTING THROUGH A LARA
BARRIERS.
YES THE ORDER THE YOUNG AND THE
AND THE PEOPLE GET THE MUSCLE
PROCESS ALL.
IT WAS A VOLUME OF THE ASEAN.
ESPN AND OWN ONE NOVEL VITAL.
NO ONE ANY BILL YOU'LL SO YOU'RE
NOT SEEING THEM AND NOW THAT I
KNOW A LITTLE BIT OF THE PROCESS --
I FOLLOW THE PROCEDURE
[inaudible]
AND AND IN PANAMA NOVEL A AND
THEY HAVE A LAWYER SO -- YEAH SO
YOU'RE NOT I'M A SIMPLE.
I'M JUST A MOM.
I'M NOT A LAWYER I'M NOT AN
ATTORNEY [inaudible]
AND FOR US -- THE COMMUNITY THE
HISPANIC COMMUNITY.
THAT INTO ME THEY SAW US.
OKAY SO WE JUST STOP.
FOLLOWING THE PROCESS OKAY OKAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT
THANK CRISIS THANK YOU FOR
SHARING YOUR STORY WE NEED TO
HELP YOU.
OLA THE NUMBER OF MONEY A SOLANO.
NO MY NAME IS MONEY AT A SOLANO.
IS THE IRAQI BUT A LOT OF A LOT
THEY SPEND IT YEAH THIS BODY OF
THEM AND ALSO HERE TO TALK ABOUT
THESE BATTERIES.
ALL THOSE A HOLES GOING OUT
THESE MORE I HAVE TWO SONS WITH
AUTISM OR KNOW THE RAINY DAY ONE
IS TWENTY YEAR THAT IS YOUR
CHOICE IN HIS.
EIGHTY NO CONSERVE ERA. ONE IS
SEVERE OUT YOUR TOTAL LIVING IN
THE NINE ONE IS -- LESS.
IN A LOS THE SERVICIOS AND BOTH
OF THEM WILL HAVE SERVICES BEEN
RECEIVING SERVICES CONCORD
CORNICE COOLER LE GUSTA POLICY
AT DANIEL WITH HOME SCHOOL I
HOPE I HOPE WITH HOME SCHOOL FOR
SEVEN YEARS.
YOUR GALLAGHER OF A FEDERAL
SERVICIOS ABA YET BUT I'M IS
THAT MAYBE GOD.
ARE YOU LOSE YOUR MODEL CALL ME
BECAUSE I THINK DANIEL.
I REALLY LIKE -- TO SAY THAT
APPRECIATED AB EIGHT FROM
MEDICAL BECAUSE THOU WORK FOR MY
SON FOR WHEN THINGS BEING FOR
TWENTY YEARS.
IN A KILEY THAT MAYBE THAT HE
HAS A QUALITY LINE ESTE MEAL
LAUGH HE SENT HOME FOR LIFE ON
MEDIAN WITH FAMILY. ONE GOOD
THING THEIR COMPORTAMIENTO WHEN
HE HAD BEHAVIORS AND I WOKE ALSO
ENOUGH FOR ME TO DEAL WITH A K.
KOS.
HELLO SERVICIOS THEY VA THANKS
TO THE A. B. A SERMON THAT ALSO
SET RULES ON THE FOLLOWING NEW
VAN LIVING.
BEHAVIOR START MORLEY MORITZ.
YOUR STORY I KEEP OF LUMBER FOR
MUCHO SPOT AS GUEST I'M NOT BUT
I HAVE THEY ME AND I'M HERE TO
TALK ABOUT -- THIS A IN A LOT OF
PARENTS FOLLOW GET THE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THEIR FRANK.
ALLOW THE PRESIDING. TO THE
HELLO THE PERCENT.
AS THE DAY [inaudible]
ONLY GONE.
HE CONCLUDED WITH A WITH THIS
IDEA [inaudible]
RETALIATION.
YOUR LET'S GET OUT OF THE
CELEBRATORY THAT CAME ALONG WITH
YOU AND THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. SEVEN METERS BUT IF
I WAS RECENT THE MAN TO COME AND
EXPRESS OUR FEELINGS.
AS HOTEL A HUMAN BEING THANK YOU
STEPHANIE THEY HAVE DREAMS IN MY
SON YOU KNOW.
WHETHER THINKING THAT IN THE IN
THING THE MICE THAT THE HE CAN
BE INDEPENDENCE IS PALATABLE QUE
BUT HE NEEDS THE HELP.
GORE THEY PUSH HI.
CRISIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MUCH.
HEY HI MY NAME IS -- CHRIS
SOLANO I'M YEARS BECAUSE I'VE
BEEN LOOKING FOR MY SERVICES
EVERYWHERE AND ALL PLACE I'M IN
LIKE.
EVERYWHERE TO FIND MY OWN LIFE
AND ALSO I JUST LIKE WANT TO
GIVE LIKE A BETTER.
JOB AND I'D WANT TO GET THAT
BECAUSE I'M AN ACTIVE VALLEY
REGIONAL CENTER.
ASKING FOR HELP BUT THE VALLEY
REGIONAL CENTER THEY DON'T THEY
DON'T HELP ME AT ALL AND I'M
BEEN LIKE WAITING LIKE A LOT OF
YEARS SINCE WHEN I WAS A KID.
AND ALSO WHEN I WAS IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND AND AFTER THAT HE
THAT THEY DON'T HELP ME ALSO AT
ALL AND THEY DON'T EVEN ALSO.
CARE ABOUT ME WHEN I'M TELLING
THEM THE TRUE THAT WHAT IS I
NEED FOR MY SERVICES.
AND ALSO I JUST MIGHT WANT TO GO
TO THE SICK THE COLLEGE. TO
LEARN SO I CAN BE SMART WHENEVER
I WANT TO BE.
AND I JUST ALSO WANT TO GET MY
LESSON LIKE A DRIVE LIKE A CAR
AND GIVE LIKE A BETTER LIFE.
AND NOT TO JUST LIKE ACTING LIKE
WAITING LINE IF THE REGIONAL
CENTER.
THEY JUST LIE TO ME THE WHOLE
TIME WHAT IS I JUST NEED.
AND I TELL THEM THAT I NEED
SERVICES.
AND THEY SAID A I'M GONNA HELP
YOU DO THIS I'M HELP YOU DO THAT
AND THEY TELL ME LIKE THAT TO ME.
AND I WAS LIKE WAIT AND IT'S
BEEN LIKE LANA A LOT OF YEARS
AND LONGTIME.
LONGTIME HE THEY DON'T HELP ME
AT ALL.
AND I'M BEEN LIKE MAD WITH THEM
BECAUSE THEY LIED TO ME THE ALL
TIME AND THE GUY THE MANAGER I
MEAN THE PERSON MANAGER AND
REGIONAL AS A REGIONAL CENTER.
HE DOESN'T HELP ME.
AND HE'S JUST PLAYING AS MINORS
WERE ME.
AND THAT'S WHY I'M HERE TO FOR
YOUR HELP AND THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
OKAY AS PASSED OVER AGAIN WITH
IMAGINE SUPPORTED LIVING
SERVICES AND THE PERSON SENATE
ADVOCACY NETWORK -- I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF PROPOSALS
ASKING YOU TO MAKE INVESTMENTS.
IN THIS SYSTEM AND I JUST WANTED
TO POINT OUT THAT -- WHEN YOU
MAKE WHEN THEIR COMMUNITIES NOT
BEING SERVED AS WE'VE BEEN
HEARING?
THERE'S NO ONE TO ACCEPT A RATE
INCREASE AND SO TASK THAT SHOOT
TARGETS -- THE INVESTMENTS I
HOPE YOU DO MAKE YOUR MAKING OUR
SYSTEM.
AB MORE EQUITABLE AND BETTER.
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU WELL I THINK
EVERYONE INVADE PUBLIC COMMENTS --
SO -- FIRST OFALL.
YEAH I WAY DOLLARS AFTER THAT IS
NOW THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD AND
HARD WORK BEING DONE -- THAT --
AND IN SITUATIONS OF YOU KNOW
PROBABLY UNDER RSOURCE -- WELL
WE FOR HEARD ABOUT THAT -- BUT
ALSO I THINK THERE CLEARLY.
CHALLENGES WITH OUR COMMUNITY
SYSTEM SO I KNOW THAT THERE'S
BEEN A LOT FOCUS ON ON WINDING
TO DEVELOPMENTS OR DOES A LOT OF
REALLY HARD WORK THAT HAD TO
HAVE HAPPENED -- AND IT'S NOT
COMPLETED YET WE'RE TRYING TO
ALSO FIGURE OUT WHAT KIND OF
SYSTEMS WE PUT IN PLACE FOR
PARTICULARLY THE MOST THE OTHER
TO THE HIGHEST NEEDS -- PEOPLE
INCLUDING CHILDREN I APPRECIATE
THAT WERE TRYING TO IMPLEMENT A
DIFFERENT APPROACH -- WITH A
FEDERAL WAIVER AND SO FORTH --
BUT I SO I THINK WHAT WE'RE
HEARING HERE IS THAT -- AND WE
TALKED ABOUT DISPARITIES BUT
UNDERLYING THE DISPARITIES.
AND AGAIN YOU KNOW -- NEVER
HEARING STORIES ABOUT PEOPLE
FEEL THEIR NEED MORE NEEDS TO BE
DONE AND SO.
I THINK EVEN AS WE LOOK AT SOME
OF THESE RESOURCES WE'VE GOT TO
FIGURE OUT HOW THOSE ARE TIED TO
PERFORMANCE ON THINGS LIKE
DISPARITIES.
RIGHT AND AND TO A CERTAIN
EXTENT PERHAPS ALSO UNDER
RESOURCING IS LED TO EXACERBATES
THESE PROBLEMS TOO BECAUSE
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE THE TIME TO
DEAL WITH THESE ISSUES BUT I
THINK WE NEED TO LOOK AT
AVAILABILITY OF LANGUAGE.
CAPACITY -- IS OUR WORK FORCE
THE KIND THAT I MEAN TO PEOPLE
OR IN THE WORK FORCEI'M SURE OF
WORKING VERY HARD T DEDICATE IS
NOT THE KIND OF JOB YOU GO INTO
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT INTEREST IN
HELPING PEOPLE SITES WHAT BUT
THAT OUT THERE.
THAT WE MIGHT WANNA LOOK AT THE
WEATHER ARE YOU KNOW WAS WERE --
HOPEFULLY HAVING SOME MORE
RESOURCES TO BUILD ON THE WORK
FORCE THAT WE NEED TO BUILD ON
ARE WE BUILDING ONE THAT ALSO
BETTER REFLECTS.
THE NEEDS OF THE THE VERY
COMMUNITIES THAT WE ACTUALLY
SERVE AND I AGAIN I DON'T WHAT
THE NUMBERS ARE SO I BE A NEED
TO LOOK AT THE NUMBERS AND SO
FORTH AND THEN I THINK THERE'S
GOING TO BE MORE -- ANY WE HEARD
ABOUT THE NEED FOR THAT NOT JUST
SELF REPORTED BUT OVERALL
VALUATION APPRECIATE RESEARCH
UNIT WE'RE GONNA BE PUTTING MORE
MONEY INTO CLIMATE BUT I THINK
WE NEED MORE STE THE LOOKING
ACROSS THE STATE -- PERFORMANCE
MEASURES THAT -- AN INVALUABLE
ATION THAT IS INDEPENDENT FROM
JUST THE PERSON ACTUALLY
DELIVERING THE SERVICES AND I
KNOW YOU RECOGNIZING WITHIN YOUR
DEPARTMENT THE NEED FOR FOR THAT.
I WOULD SAY SEPARATION BUT THAT --
THAT TYPE OF ACCOUNTABILITY SO --
SO I KNOW A LOT OF WORK'S BEEN
DONE THIS IS A DEPARTMENTS HAD
TO DEAL A LOT OF DIFFERENT
CHANGES AND AND MAKE MAKE THAT
WORK -- AND BUT IT THINKING WE
SERVE MORE WORK TO DO AND I
APPRECIATED THAT OKAY.
ALL RIGHT ANYTHING ELSE.
OKAY WITH THAT ALL RIGHT SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- WE HAVE
NOW JUST CONCLUDED PART A
THERE'S ACTUALLY A PART B. TO
THIS HEARING.
AND AT FIVE WOULD BEG THE
INDULGENCE OF THE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE TO PRESENT PART B. BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A FIVE MINUTE
BREAK SINCE I'VE BEEN SITTING
HERE -- FOR THE LAST
[inaudible] FIVE HOURS.
PAUSE AND THEN WILL RECONVENE AT
SIX TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU
AHEAD
AND RESUME THE THIS HEARING OF
THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER
THREE ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES WE ARE ON TO PART BE.
AND IT IS SIX TWENTY SEVEN PM.
ALL RIGHT SO.
OKAY SO LET'S GO AHEAD AND SEVEN
OF COURSE.
SO LET'S GO AHEAD AND START WITH
THE FIRST ITEM WE WERE FOR
EIGHTY OF ITEMS RELATED -- TO
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY AND
HEALTHCARE SERVICES AND PUBLIC
HEALTH OF THE LAWN SERVICES
SOCIAL SERVICES EVERYONE WANTS
ACKNOWLEDGING.
OKAY SO LET'S START OFF WITH
ISSUE NUMBER ONE THE CAL YOUR
SYSTEM INTEGRATOR CONTRACT
TRANSITION ACTIVITIES SO WE CAN
BRING UP.
HOW MANY PEOPLE COME IN FOR THIS?
ONE ARE THEY HERE.
OKAY SEVEN BRING EVERYONE UP
WHO'S.
I THINK THIS TOUCHES LOTS OF
AGENCIES.
WE HAVE ON THE OTHERS ALL RIGHT
SO IF I CAN JUST HAVE EVERYONE
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES AT THE
TABLE STARTING WITH THE AGENCY
OR AGENCIES.
GOOD AFTERNOON I AM JAMES TOKENS
I WORK FOR THE OFFICE OF SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION I'M CAL HERE'S
PROJECT DIRECTOR OKAY EXCELLENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN OF US MY
NAME FORCE WAS LATE FOR
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY OKAY
ALL RIGHT LA L..
BRIAN IT'S CARRILLO OKAY.
CHECK A PLAN FINANCING IT'S
THANK YOU THANKS VERY MUCH AND I
CAN WANTS TO THANK THE FARM
TECHNOLOGY FOR HAVING -- BEING
HERE TODAY ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO AHEAD AND
START ON THE CAL HERE SYSTEM
INTEGRATION AND GREATER CONTRACT
INSERTION ACTIVITIES TO US.
OKAY I'M OF THE VERY SUCCINCT
HERE.
BOTH CARRIERS PROJECT IS -- THE
AUTOMATED SYSTEM THAT PROVIDES
HEALTH BILL T. DETERMINATION
ROMAN RETENTION.
SERVICES FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE TO SPONSORS
COVER CALIFORNIA.
AND DEPARTMENT DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
WE HAVE A CONTRACT THAT WE
ENTERED IN WITH A SYSTEMS
INTEGRATOR.
IN.
JUNE OF TWENTY TWELVE WE'VE HAD
ABOUT A FIVE YEAR BASE CONTRACT
THAT WE WENT THROUGH WITH AT
THREE ONE YEAR EXTENSIONS WERE
ON IN JUNE WILL BE UP THIS YEAR
WILL BE ENTERING THE FINAL YEAR
OF THAT.
THE FINAL PART OF THE CONTRACT
[inaudible]
AND SO.
THEREFORE WE WE ARE IN A
PROCUREMENT PROCESS RIGHT NOW.
RICK CAM PROCESS ON STARTED A
YEAR AGO.
WE ARE NOW GETTING TO THE
ANTIWAR THE END OF THAT.
AND SO WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS --
TRYING TO PROVIDE FOR
POSSIBILITY OF HAVING TO VENDORS
ON TWO HUNDRED TRANSITIONS --
THIS YEAR AND WE ARE LOOKING FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDS ARE DISTURBANCE
OF SEVENTEEN POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS TO TO COVER THAT.
SEVENTY POINT SIX MILLION CITIES
OKAY.
ANY COMES FROM LA -- ARE YOU
FINISHED SORRY.
THIS ARCHITECT LA OF ANY
COMMENTS BY MISTER LA -- WE HAVE
NO SPECIFIC CONCERNS WITH THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL BUT WE DID WANT
TO NOTE THAT IT ASSUMES THE
HIGHEST ESTIMATED COSTS OF THE
TRANSITION ACTIVITIES.
AND THAT BASED ON THE BIDS FROM
QUALIFIED VENDORS IT'S OF RANGE
OF FIFTEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
MILLION IN NINETEEN TWENTY SO
COULD BE LOWER OKAY ALL RIGHT
FINANCE.
THE CURRENT TECHNOLOGY HUMANS.
AND I UNDERSTAND JUST TO CLARIFY
THAT -- THIS IS IN THE THAT YOU
HAVEN'T ACTUALLY MADE A DECISION
YET SO -- SO THIS WOULD JUST BE
NEEDED IN THE EVENT THAT YOU
DECIDE TO CHANGE THE INTEGRATOR
VENDOR CORRECT BECAUSE YOU WOULD
BE THAT THE OVERLAP TRANSITION
TIME FROM ONE VENDOR TO ANOTHER
CORRECT.
AND WHEN WHEN WHEN DO YOU EXPECT
A DECISION TO BE MADE.
WE'RE WE ARE PLANNING TO HAVE
THAT DONE WITHIN THE NEXT MONTH
OR TWO OKAY.
ALL RIGHT IT HAS A PROCESS ONCE
WE SELECT A VENDOR IT HAS TO BE
APPROVED BY CMS ALSO THIS IS A
PROCESS.
IT TAKES SOME TIME OKAY.
IN A SHE QUICK QUESTION FINANCE
OF THE SEVENTY TWO OF THE IN THE
PICKING THE SAME VENDOR THEY
DON'T NEED THE MONEY WHAT IS
THIS MONEY GO -- IT WOULD BE
SAVINGS AND EIGHT NINETEEN
TWENTY OKAY WE JUST FUNDS
SAVINGS THERE'S A COUPLE THINGS
ONE IS.
WE HAVE A DIFFERENT CONTRACT SO
THERE WILL BE SOME TRANSITION
REGARDLESS OF OKAY WHOEVER THE
VENDOR IS.
IT WILL BE LESS IF WE HAVE TO
INCOME BUT BUT WE STILL WILL
NEED SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
THAT TRANSITION PERIOD.
AND ALSO THE FUNDS THAT WE HAVE
IS PART THIS IS SCOTT IS A
PASTOR TO DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE
SERVICES SO WE DON'T ACTUALLY
HAVE TO THE MONEY WILL USE IT AS
NEEDED [inaudible]
OKAY.
CORRECT OKAY WELL WELL WITH
SICKLY WE'RE WE'D BE.
APPROPRIATE I MEAN WE'D BE
BASICALLY PROPANE THE MONEY TO
THAT THE NEED TO BE USE RIGHT
NOW IT'S I USED TO GO BACK TO
AND DEBT AND THEN REASON YOU
WOULD STILL NEED TRANSITION
MONEY IF THE IF THE IF.
THE VENDOR SAY THE SAME AS IT
BECAUSE THEN THE CHANGE OF A
CONTRACTOR.
YES OF WE WORK WE WE HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL CHANGES IN THE
CONTRACT SO WE WOULD NEED SOME
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR SOME.
NEW -- SERVICES THAT WOULD.
THEY HAVE TO BRING IN A COMEDY.
FOR AND THE WAY WE WE WE THAT'S
WHAT CHANGE SOME DELIVERABLES
AND A CONTRACT THAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW OKAY.
SO CAL HERE'S A WORK BETTER THE
NEXT ROUND RIGHT [inaudible]
YES.
I WAS GOING TO POSE THE QUESTION
I USUALLY DO ASK OF IT CONTRACTS
ALTHOUGH I KNOW IT'S GETTING
RATHER LATE IS THAT THE
IMPROVEMENT WILL REDUCE IT WILL
ACTUALLY IMPROVE THE RESULT IN
IMPROVED EFFICIENCY.
AND LESS THE FIRST FEATURE STAFF.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SOUNDS GOOD.
OKAY THANK YOU -- AND ACTUALLY
SINCE EACH OF THESE ARE SEPARATE
CHECKS.
THE WAY TO THE END OF OKAY ALL
RIGHT IT'S A MOVE ON THEN WILL
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT THE END OF
ISSUE SIX IN THE SECTION SO WITH
MOVE ON ISSUE TO MEDICAID
ELIGIBILITY DATA SYSTEM
MODERNIZATION [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
AND AS WE HAVE NEW PEOPLE A THE
TABLE ASK YOU TO FIRST INTRODUCE
YOURSELF FOR THE RECORD.
BEFORE YOU BEGIN.
OKAY SEVERAL COULD JUST FIRST IT
JUST INTRODUCE THEMSELVES THE
RECORDS SO STORE THE AGENCY
FOLKS.
HI THIS IS I'M CYNTHIA TUCKER
WITH THE OFFICE OF SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION THANK YOU.
FEATURING A SOCIAL SERVICES
THANK YOU.
I NAY MAILLOT DH CS THANK YOU.
RON ROBINETTE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY OKAY THANK YOU.
ELEVEN METS CARRILLO AND IT'S
WORDS FROM A FINANCE RIGHT
EXCELLENT WHILE WE OF GET ALL
THESE PEOPLE HERE ALRIGHT SO
LET'S GO AHEAD BEGIN THIS SPRING
A AS TO THE S. REFINANCE LETTER
YES.
YES THE SPRING PRICE LETTER THE
ARE RIGHT UP IN THE AGENDA IS
VERY THOROUGH WITH REGARDS -- TO
YOU KNOW WHAT IS BEING REQUESTED --
AND I KNOW THAT STATED TO GIVE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE PROPOSAL.
SO MS MODERNIZATION OF COURSE IS
TO MODERNIZE THE EXISTING MED
SYSTEM -- AND SO WITH THIS
REQUEST WE ARE ASKING FOR TWENTY
ONE POINT TWO MILLION WHICH IS A
TWO POINT ONE MILLION IN GENERAL
FUND IS FOR CONTRACTS STAFFING
HARDWARE SOFTWARE.
EXETER -- THAT INCLUDES
CONTINUING SOME LIMITED TERM
POSITIONS ARE SIR LIMITED
FUNDING POSITIONS ACROSS CDSS DH
CS IN OUR SIDE.
AS WELL AS REQUESTING -- THREE
NEW POSITIONS -- ACROSS THE
THREE ORGANIZATIONS SO WE'RE
ABOUT TO STE WE WERE CURRENTLY
IN PROCUREMENT TO GET OUR FIRST
DEVELOPER.
AND START DOING THIS WORK AND
THIS WILL CONTINUE ON OUR FIRST
PHASE AND BRING US OUT TO THE
START OF FACE.
TO IT'S A LITTLE BIT UNIQUE
JUSTICE SICK A NUMBER I'LL BRING
IT UP SO WHICH WE TALKED
YESTERDAY -- THE WAY WE'VE
CONSTRUCTED -- THE WORK WITH CDT
IS THIS FIRST PHASE OF MEDS OF
DEVELOPMENT IS ACTUALLY YOU
COULD CONSIDER PROOF OF CONCEPT
WITH IN THE PAL PROCESS.
SO THE GOAL IS TO GET SOME
LEARNING SACRAMENTO STANDING
BEING ABLE TO FINE TUNE.
DO WE HAVE THE RIGHT STAFF TO WE
HAVE YOU KNOW WHAT ARE THE
THINGS THAT WE CAN LEARN THAT
WOULD THEN INFORM FOR THE
APPROVAL FOR THE PROJECT WHICH
SHOULD BE PHASES.
TWO THREE FOUR SO IT'S A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT FROM -- OTHER PAL --
PROJECTS.
THAT'S AT A HIGH LEVEL UNLESS
YOU HAVE QUESTIONS.
OKAY -- COME A FELLOW COMES.
PRIME MINISTER ALEJO -- HI SOME
OF MY COMMENTS OF OR EVEN MADE
SO I'LL TRY TO KEEP IT SHORTER --
SO AS WAS MENTIONED THIS IS
STILL GOING THROUGH THE PROCESS
TO PROVIDE LIFE CYCLE TO
ANTICIPATED TO COMPLETE IN
FEBRUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY AND AS
WAS MENTIONED THIS IS BEING USED
AS A KIND OF PILOT ARE PROOF OF
CONCEPT FOR THE SMALLER
COMPONENT OF MEDS THEY TRY A
SYSTEM -- TO AT LEAST
DEMONSTRATE SOME OF THE
UNDERLYING DEVELOPMENT
ENVIRONMENTS INFRASTRUCTURE --
WE GENERALLY AGREE WITH THIS
APPROACH HAS A SIZEABLE COMPLEX
PROJECT -- BUT WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS BEING
ASKED TO APPROVE FUNDING -- FOR
DEVELOPMENT IMPLEMENTATION
ACTIVITIES OUTSIDE OF THAT PHASE
ONE INTO PHASE TWO THERE'S
THERE'S A A COMPONENT OF IT
THAT'S ACTUALLY STARTING --
WITHIN NINETEEN TWENTY AND SO --
THE LEGISLATURE WHEN THEN HAVE A
COMPLETE PROJECT PLAN -- BE READ
BEFORE IT AND NOW IT TO ITS
EVALUATE -- IN SO WE'RE ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT THE APPROVAL OF
RESOURCES INTO THE OUT YEARS
GIVEN THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
THE COMPLETE PROJECT PLAN BEFORE
US -- BE YOU KNOW IN FEBRUARY
TWENTY TWENTY AND SO TO ADDRESS
THESE CONCERNS THE LEGISLATURE
MIGHT JUST ASK THE MINISTRATION
TO EXPLAIN WHY -- BUT YOU'RE
FUNDING IS NECESSARY FOR FACE TO
ACTIVITIES SPECIFICALLY AND THEN
TO EXPLAIN WHY THE FOR YOUR
LIMITED TERM FUNDING IS
NECESSARY FOR THE PROJECT GIVEN
LEGISLATURE DOESN'T HAVE A
COMPLETE PLAN AT THIS TIME.
OKAY FINANCE COMMENTS --
TECHNOLOGY COMMENTS.
FROM THAT TECHNOLOGIES
PERSPECTIVE THE ESTIMATES FOR
THE PROJECT WERE SUBSTANTIATED
THROUGH THE MARKET RESEARCH THAT
THE DEPARTMENT IS DONE.
IN STATES.
TO AND LIKE I BRIAN WAS SAYING
THE SIZE AND COMPLEXITY OF THE
EFFORT.
REQUIRED US TO TAKE A DIFFERENT
APPROACH WITH HOW WERE APPROVING
THE PROJECT OVERALL WHERE THEY
CAN SUBSTANTIATE THIS THROUGH
THE PROOF OF CONCEPT.
OKAY THANK YOU.
THAT WOULD TO LIKE TO DO YOU
HAVE A COMMON SUN VALLEY IS --
DON'T HAVE PLEASE DON'T MIND.
SO WITH REGARDS TO THE LIMITED
TERM FUNDING FOR THE RESOURCES
THAT WE ARE REQUESTING THAT
BECAUSE IT'S IT CAN BE DIFFICULT
TO KEEP CONSISTENT STAFFING --
WHEN IT'S A WIN WIN YOUR GET
WHEN YOU'RE BY WHEN YOU'RE
FUNDING BECAUSE PEOPLE WILL?
YOU KNOW FOR SOME STABILITY Là
MOVED TO THE POSITION SO WE'RE
REALLY ASKING FOR THIS FOR YEARS
TO CARRY US THROUGH WHAT WE
BELIEVE WILL BE THE ENTIRE
PROJECT.
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE SOME
CONSISTENCY -- ACROSS THE
PROJECT NO KNOWLEDGE BASIC
CETERA.
SO THAT'S THAT WOULD BE THE
REASONING FOR THAT.
THE SECOND PIECE I CAN'T
REMEMBER THE QUESTION WAS NOW --
BOTH ALLOCATING MONEY FOR OR THE
FACE TO ADDRESS THESE TWO
ACTIVITY WHICH MAY NOT WHICH ONE
THE STORY TAKE PLACE UNTIL NEXT
BUDGET YEAR RAIDER LATE.
OUR RELEASE IN THE SPRING THERE
WILL BE ABOUT FOUR MONTHS THAT
SAY BUDGET YEAR BUT AGAIN THE
RIGHT REMAINDER OF THE FACE TO
ACTIVITIES ARE A MORE FIRMLY HOW
WE EXERCISE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT.
SO I THINK THE THE REASON WE'VE
REQUESTED THAT IS WE'LL HAVE A
CONTRACTOR ON BOARD WHO WILL OF
WORK PHASE ONE THE GOAL IS. TO
GET APPROVAL WITH CDG AND BE
ABLE TO MOVE DIRECTLY INTO PHASE --
TWO THE PROJECT YOU KNOW IT IF
WE HAVE A DELAY OF FOUR MONTHS
AWAITING APPROVAL OF FUNDING FOR
THE NEXT PHASE WILL ALSO END UP
HAVING A RESOURCING ISSUE WITH
REGARDS TO OUR DEVELOPMENT UNDER
BECAUSE NO WORK.
YOUR RESOURCES MOVED OTHER
PROJECTS THAT ARE SO WE'RE
REALLY LOOKING AT IT FOR
CONSISTENCY AND NOT HAVING A
DELAY.
IN MOVING THIS PART IN MOVING
THIS FORWARD K. SO.
IN JAPAN IF I CAN ALSO ADD -- TO
CYNTHIA'S COMMENTS THAT -- IN IN
LIEU OF COMING BACK EVERY YEAR
THROUGH THE THROUGH THE BUDGET
CYCLE THERE ARE OTHER
CHECKPOINTS BUILT INTO THE
PROCESS -- THAT WILL KEEP THE
COST M. CAPPED AT A AT A CERTAIN
LEVEL SO.
AGAIN IF IF THROUGH THE PROOF OF
CONCEPT WHENTHE PROJECT HAS TO
FINALIZE THEIR ENTIRE PROJECT
COST.
IF THE TOTAL PROJECT COST --
OVER FIVE MILLION THERE'S CAUSE
FOR PAWS FOR US TO DISCUSS HOW
THAT HOW THE PROJECT WOULD MOVE
FORWARD.
ADDITIONALLY ONCE THIS PROJECT
IS AN IN FLIGHT AND THERE IS --
THEY ARE ACTIVELY WORKING ON
PROJECT ACTIVITIES.
THE DEPARTMENT WILL FURNISH A
PROJECT STATUS REPORT DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY WILL FURNISH AN
INDEPENDENT PROJECT OVERSIGHT
REPORT -- WHICH INCLUDES COST
MANAGEMENT IS ONE OF THE FOCUS
AREAS THAT WILL REPORT ON SO I
GUESS NONE OF YOU ARE HERE FOR
THE PREVIOUS DISCUSSION WE HAD
ABOUT A PROJECT IN THE VOTE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES -- BUT
I'M TRYING TO MAKE SIMILAR
COMMENTS AND DO IT -- MAYBE THIS
IS SOMETHING I THINK THAT --
GIVEN THE NATURE OF THE
PROCUREMENT PROCESS -- WE PRIDE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT.
GIVEN THE NATURE OF TIME LINES
AND SO FORTH -- BECAUSE I HEAR
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING ABOUT
CONTINUITY AND AND AND SO FORTH
AND I APPRECIATE THE ACTIONS
THAT TO BE SURE WE ALSO MAINTAIN
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT AND WHEN I
SAW LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT IT'S
NOT JUST THE MONEY PART SO WHAT
THE RESPONSE IS ALWAYS BEEN WELL
YOU KNOW ABOUT THE MONEY.
IT'S ADDRESS.
AND IT IS TO SOME OF THAT FOR
EXAMPLE SOMEONE MAY COME AND I
THINK -- YOU TOO BYE KNOW THIS
BETTER THAN ANYONE ELSE WHENEVER
WE HAVE OUR HEARINGS RIGHT SOME
OF THE STAKEHOLDER MAY COME AND
SAY LOOK YOU KNOW THE THE PRINT
OUT YOUR AND WAS IN FACE TO YOUR
FIGURE OUT YOU'RE A WHAT THE
SCOPE AND SO FORTH AND THE DAY
HE DIDN'T.
HEAR FROM US ARE DATED -- DARE
NOT LISTENING TO US WE SAID THAT --
YOU KNOW YOU YOU'RE NOT
COOPERATING THIS INTO YOUR
UNDERLYING PROJECT DESIGN OR
WHATEVER ELSE RIGHT AND SO THAT
OVERSIGHT IS NOT JUST THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY IT'S ALSO ABOUT BEING
SURE THAT -- BEFORE WE ACTUALLY
PURCHASE -- RIGHT OR EVEN SEND
OUT THE R. F. P. AND SAY THIS IS
THE PARAMETERS THAT WERE ABLE TO
COME IN AND AND AND AND HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION IF.
A STAKEHOLDER OR SOME OTHER
OTHER PEOPLE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
IT RIGHT AND AND WORK THAT OUT
BEFORE WE ACTUALLY DON'T INSTEAD
OF TRYING TO PLAY CATCH UP LIKE --
WELL NOW THEY ARE FEES OUT WE
DON'T LIKE THIS WE WANT TO PULL
BACK OR LIBERAL THAT'S EVEN MORE
EXPENSIVE.
AND RIGHT RECOGNIZING THAT ALSO
THE PURCHASING OF THIS DOESN'T
ALWAYS FIT NEATLY INTO OUR USUAL
BUDGET CYCLES.
SO -- SO BUT I DO THINK THERE'S
WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT THE
MECHANISM BY WHICH WILL HAVE AS
WE CAN SAVE YOU KNOW WILL.
OUT WILL APPEAL BUDGET THE MONEY
BUT THE MONEY ACTUALLY DOESN'T
GET RELEASED UNTIL WE THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE SOME SORT OF A
THING YOU KNOW THAT THE PROOF
THAT PHASE BEFORE EDL SO.
WHEN YOU PHRASE ON THE FACE TO
WORK WELL WE GET A CHANCE TO
LOOK AT AND SAY YEA OR NAY
BEFORE IT MOVES ONWARD --
BECAUSE OTHERWISE THE
ALTERNATIVE IS LIKE WHICH IS THE
BUDGET THE MONEY AND THEN YOU
HAVE THE PROBLEM YOU TALK ABOUT
SO I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
WE DO THIS AND I THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY NOT THE FIRST TIME
THIS ISSUES COME UP.
AND AND I DO WANT TO SUPPORT I
THINK I'VE BEEN A BIG SUPPORTER
OF THE NEW PROCESSES TO AND I
ALWAYS SAY THAT YOU KNOW
EVERYONE'S ALWAYS NERVOUS ABOUT
IT PROJECTS IN THE STATE'S
ACTUALLY DO A LOT OF THE VERY
WELL -- YOU HEAR ABOUT THE
DISASTERS HE HAD -- BUT THE ONES
ARE GOING WELL BUT WE BUT WE
ALSO NEED TO BE SURE THAT
OVERSIGHT PIECE IN THERE BECAUSE
AND FORTY TWO BY MY TO MAKE
COLLEAGUES OF FORTY HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THE WAS IT DIDN'T WORK ALSO
AND DON'T LIKE THAT EXPERIENCE.
SO -- SO WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE SEX WITH HIM WE TALKED AND
SO YOU MIGHT WANT TO TALK TO YOU --
I SEE A STATUS HERE I THINK SHE
WAS LISTENING TO THAT
CONVERSATION FROM LA -- BUT I
MEAN THINKING ABOUT WHAT IS THAT
PROCESS BY WHICH WE CAN SORT OF
BRIDGE THOSE ISSUES RIGHT WE
DON'T WANT TO SLOW THE PROCESS
DOWN WE WANT TO MAKE IT MORE
EXPENSIVE BY.
PUTTING CAL GUMMING UP THE WORKS
BUT SAME TIME.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE -- TO TO WAY
YEAH AND WHEN WE NEED TO WAY AND
SO -- AND HOW WE DO THAT IN A
WAY THAT'S MORE SEAMLESS IN THE
PROCESS [inaudible]
YES.
I JUST NOTICED MY COLLEAGUES
CINEMATIC MENTIONED DURING THE
DDS DISCUSSION THAT -- THAT THE
USE OF PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE IS
CERTAINLY AN OPTION HERE IF
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT IS OF
INTEREST AT THE SUBCOMMITTEE
SOME NOW SO I THINK SOMETHING
PROBABLY OF THAT NATURE WHERE --
WERE BASICALLY WE WOULD BE ABLE.
TO BEFORE THE MONEY WOULD
ACTUALLY BE ABLE BUDGET BUT
BEFORE CAN ACTUALLY BE RELEASED
YOU KNOW WE HAD SIGNED OFF ON IT.
AND THIS AND THIS SAID IF IT
TURNS OUT NO ONCE EVERYTHING'S
GOING HUNKY DORY IS LIKE -- YEAH
SURE -- IT'S FELL OVER HEARING
FROM STAKEHOLDERS THAT THERE'S A
PROBLEM WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
SAY HAVE THAT CONVERSATION SAY
OKAY WHAT'S GOING ON WHERE WE
HEARING FROM PEOPLE THERE'S A
PROBLEM.
AND THE THING AND HOW WE FIXING
IT BEFORE WE GO AND MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT PHASE.
SO WE CAN WORK SOMETHING OUT AND
TRIM TRAILER BILL BUT ALSO WE
SHOULD DO THINK A LOT MORE
SYSTEMATICALLY HOW IT HOW WE DO
THIS TO SELL THAT WERE NOT --
DOING IT PROJECT BY PROJECT ALL
THE TIME CELL.
ANY COMMENTS FROM.
THERE IS NEEDED FROM.
FEATURED SOCIAL SERVICES WE
APPRECIATE YOUR RECOGNITION OF
THE VARIETY OF UNCERTAINTIES AND
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE PROJECT
IT'S BEEN ON THE PLATE SINCE --
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE WOULD LIKE
TO MOVE FORWARD QUICKLY TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT NOT JUST
ON THE ON THE DOLLAR PIECES A
LOT OF THE PROJECT DOCUMENTATION
DOES BECOME PUBLICLY AVAILABLE --
AS A MATTER OF PRACTICE WE FOUND
THAT ON ON MOST OF OUR LARGE IT
PROJECTS CD S. CARES AYE HSS AND
OTHERS THE SAWS.
THE QUARTERLY OR SEMI ANNUAL
BRIEFINGS FOR ALLEGE STAFF OF
MORE LEGISLATORS THAT MAY CHOOSE
TO CALM IS.
IS A A GOOD POLICY IT BRINGS
EVERYBODY ALONG EVERYBODY
UNDERSTANDS WHAT WE'RE DOING
TOTALLY UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR
THAT AND THE RECOGNITION WE ALSO
DON'T WANT FOUR MONTH PAUSES AT
THE MIDDLE OF SOMETHING RIGHT
EXACTLY.
THEN JUST TO ADD TO THAT -- WE
ALSO WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
KEY STAKEHOLDERS THAT WILL HAVE
AN IMPACT IN TERMS OF THE
MODERNIZATION OF THE SYSTEMS
THAT ALSO AT THE TABLE SO WE DO
HAVE VARIOUS WORK GROUPS.
AND ENGAGEMENTS WITH THE PARTIES
THAT ARE GOING TO HAVE AN IMPACT
WITH THE MODERNIZATION OF THE
SYSTEM SO THAT INCLUDES OUR
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES THAT ALSO
INCLUDES.
THAT CONTRACTORS THAT WORK ON
THAT ELIGIBILITY AND ENROLLMENT
SYSTEMS. FOR BOTH THE COUNTY AS
WELL AS FOR CAL HERE'S THERE
ALSO AT THE TIME NINE A REAL AND
RECOGNIZE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION DOES IS ON YOUR
SIDE BUT THEY ALSO COME TO US.
TO AND SOMETIMES ARE NOT HAPPY
WITH WHAT YOU'RE DOING OR FEEL
LIKE YOU'RE NOT LISTENING SO
THEN THEY COME TO US AND THEN WE
SO ANYWAY THAT'S THE DANCE OF
GOVERNMENT RIGHT THE THREE
BRANCHES.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE PRESENTATION I
THINK FOR US WE WORK OUT.
THE FINAL BUDGET WILL WORK IN
SOME.
SOME LANGUAGE STRATEGY TO
ADDRESS THAT HOPEFULLY IN A WAY
THAT WILL LET YOU PROJECT KEEP
MOVING ALONG IF THAT -- AND WITH
THAT AND THAT SAME TIME INFLOWS
OF LOW RECITE FUNCTION THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- NEXT ITEM IS --
ELECTRONIC VISIT VERIFICATION
FACE TO PLANNING [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
THREE ALL RIGHT.
WE HAVE SOME NEW PEOPLE AT THE
TABLE [inaudible]
OKAY.
CAN INTRODUCE YOURSELVES TO THE
RECORD AGAIN.
SENATOR -- JIM NIGHT WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES IF YOU
GET.
GIVE ME ANASTASIA DODSON WITH
DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE SERVICES
OKAY THANK YOU SEE IMPOSSIBLE TO
FORM FINANCE AND IT'S OKAY AND I
GUESS THE RECIPES ALL RIGHT.
BABY JUST A EXTRA.
THE LUCKY LINE OKAY.
RIGHT PLEASE BEGIN OKAY JUST AS
THE LAST ITEM ON THE AGENDA OF
LAYS EVERYTHING OUT VERY WELL --
TO DO A HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW THE
PROPOSAL -- WE THIS PROPOSAL IS
TO BEGIN THE PLANNING FOR THE
EACH ELECTRONIC IS A
VERIFICATION PHASE TWO THIS IS --
REQUIRED TO THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY CURES ACT I KNOW YOU'VE
HEARD A LOT ABOUT IT AND OTHER
HEARINGS I WON'T GO INTO DETAIL --
THIS BUDGET IS -- IS FOCUSED ON
THE PHASE ONE IS FOCUSED ON IN
HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES PHASE
TWO IS FOR ALL OTHER PROGRAMS IN
THE STATE AND CROSSES OVER FIVE
DEPARTMENTS.
SO -- REQUESTING.
IS UP BY TWENTY FOUR POINT THREE
MILLION UP TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION OF THAT IS GENERAL FUND --
IT WILL ALLOW FOR POSITIONS
ACROSS AS I'M SORRY I USE THE
WRONG NUMBERS THE SPRING FINANCE
LETTERS THREE POINT FIVE MILLION.
I LOOK AT MY NUMBERS FOR PHASE
ONE APOLOGIES.
AS A FELLOW THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION WITH THREE AND A FIFTY
ONE THOUSAND FOR GENERAL FUND
AND THAT ALLOWS FOR POSITIONS
FOR DDS AS WELL AS ASSIGN.
AND CONTRACT RESOURCES -- ACROSS
THE DEPARTMENTS -- FOR ALTERS
ANALYSIS AS WELL AS PROJECT
MANAGEMENT SUPPORT SERVICES.
THAT'S IT HIGH.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT LA -- COMES.
WE HAVE NO CONCERNS AT THIS
PROPOSAL FINANCE [inaudible]
TECHNOLOGY.
THE PERMANENT TECHNOLOGY HAS
REVIEWED THE STATE ONE BUSINESS
ANALYSIS AND BASED ON THE SIZE
SCOPE AND COMPLEXITY THEY
SEPARATE.
THEIR RESOURCES SEEM REASONABLE
OKAY AND ANY COMMENTS FROM TO
AIDS IT ALL RIGHT.
GREAT ALL RIGHT SOUNDS GOOD OKAY
SO OBVIOUSLY WE'VE HEARD.
US HEARD ABOUT ELECTRONIC VISIT
VERIFICATION DISTILLERS TODAY.
THE DELIVER RIGHT LET'S MOVE ON
AND ISSUE NUMBER FOR STATEWIDE
AUTOMATED WELFARE SYSTEM
CONSOLIDATION [inaudible]
SARAH.
JUST A LITTLE PROJECT CALLED
SAWS.
WELCOME ALRIGHT WE'LL DO THE
ROUND ROBIN AGAIN FOR THESE AT
THE TABLE.
I'M CHRIS DUDLEY WITH THE OFFICE
OF SYSTEMS INTEGRATION THANK YOU
HELLO.
LEO FINANCE TERRORISTS FINANCE
RATE THESE BEGIN.
A FEW WEEKS AGO WE HAD THE
CHANCE TO DISCUSS THE COUNCIL'S
PROJECT WITH YOU WERE WILL MOVE
THREE EXISTING CONSORTIA SYSTEMS
INTO -- ONE USING THE IRS
PROJECT THAN TO MODIFY THAT TO
MEET THE NEEDS.
THIS IS A REQUEST. FOR EIGHT
LIMITED TERM STATE POSITIONS
THROUGH TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
TO SUPPORT THE PROGRAM SPONSORED
DEPARTMENT PARTICIPATION IN CAL
SAUCE DEVELOPMENT.
THE PRIMARY GOAL OF THE PROGRAM
SPONSORS IN THE OUR SITE EITHER
SHIP IS TO ENSURE CONSISTENT
POLICY APPLICATION.
AND THEN THE CONSISTENT --
CLIENT EXPERIENCE AS WELL AND SO
AS WE KNOW THAT.
LARGE PROJECTS ARE SUCCESSFUL IF
THEY HAVE ADEQUATE RESOURCES
WITH THE RIGHT SKILL SETS WERE
ASKING THESE ADDITIONAL PROGRAM
SPONSOR.
ROLES TO SUPPORT THIS PROJECT
AND PROVIDE PROGRAMS PERSPECTIVE
SPECIFICALLY WITHIN THE PROJECT.
SO -- SOME OF THE PRIMARY THINGS
WOULD BE -- I GUESS I REALLY
SAID THEM ALREADY -- AND ALSO TO
ADD SUPPORT COORDINATION -- FOR
WITH OTHER STATES SYSTEMS SUCH
AS CAL HERE'S IMAGE MON TO ADD
THAT.
ON THE TECHNICAL SIDE OKAY THANK
YOU ALEJO.
THE CONCERNS OF THE PROPOSAL
FINANCE.
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY THANK YOU I APPRECIATE.
RIGHT ISSUE NUMBER FIVE HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL COMMISSION
SPRING FINANCE LETTER.
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE PROPOSAL.
RIGHT -- FOR JUST INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES FIRST A PRINT MCCARTY
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
I THANK YOU BEN JOHNSON ALEJO
RIGHT FINANCE JACOB LAMB FINANCE
ALL RIGHT.
A PLEASE BEGIN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR SO -- THE PROPOSED TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE IS TO REVISE AND
RECAST THE EXISTING COMMISSION
ON HEALTH CARE TRANSFORMATION --
TO RE IS IT NEW NAME WOULD BE
THE HEALTHY CALIFORNIA ALL FOR
ALL COMMISSION.
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE WOULD
EXPAND THE MEMBERSHIP OF THE
CUTS TO THE OF THE NEW
COMMISSION -- TO THIRTEEN
MEMBERS THE SECRETARY OF HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES WOULD BE THE
CHAIR.
THE GOVERNOR WOULD APPOINT SIX
APPOINTEES SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE WOULD POINT THREE THE
SPEAKER ON A POINT THREE AND
THEN THERE WOULD BE. THREE EX
OFFICIO MEMBERS FROM COVER
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE
SERVICES AND CALPERS -- THE
TRAILER BILL WOULD REVISE AND OR
CAST THE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
THAT WOULD BE THE WOULD BE TO
REPORTS REQUIRED UNDER THE
TRAILER BILL.
THE FIRST DUE IN JULY OF TWENTY
TWENTY WOULD INCLUDE AN ANALYSIS
OF THE CURRENT HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
LOOKING AT VARIOUS ASPECTS OF
THE SYSTEM.
OPTIONS FOR STATES OPTIONS THAT
THE STATE CAN TAKE IN THE NEAR
TERM -- FOR TRANSITION TOWARDS A
SINGLE PAYER FINANCING SYSTEM
THOSE TO BE ISSUES LIKE COST
CONTAINMENT QUALITY IMPROVEMENT --
REORGANIZING OUR STATE HEALTH
CARE PROGRAMS.
THE FIRST REPORT WOULD ALSO
INCLUDE OPTIONS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR TO
CONSIDER OF REGARDING FUTURE THE
COVERAGE EXPANSIONS.
THE SECOND REPORT WOULD BE DUE
IN FEBRUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THAT REPORT WOULD -- INCLUDE
OPTIONS FOR THE X. SORT OF KEY
DESIGN CONSIDERATIONS FOR A
SINGLE PAYER FINANCING SYSTEM
THERE'S A LONG LIST IN THE
TRAILER BILL BUT THAT WOULD BE
ISSUES LIKE ELIGIBILITY
ENROLLMENT.
THE BENEFITS THAT WOULD BE
COVERED HOW TO ENSURE OF
PROVIDER PARTICIPATION IN A
SYSTEM PROVIDER PAYMENTS COST
CONTAINMENT STRATEGIES -- DE
GOVERNANCE AND ADMINISTRATION
THE SYSTEM AS WELL AS LOOKING AT
THE UNDERLYING INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS THAT WOULD BE
NECESSARY FOR SYSTEM.
AND THEN INTEGRATION OF FEDERAL
SPENDING ON HEALTH CARE SERVICES
IN THE STATE.
IN ADDITION TO THOSE TWO MAIN
REPORTS THE TRAILER BILL
REQUIRES THAT THE COMMISSION
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE EVERY
SIX MONTHS STARTING IN JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY ON ITS PROGRESS --
AS IS THE CASE WITH THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE IN LAW REGARDING THE
EXISTING COUNCIL THE TRAILER
BILL GIVES NO AUTHORITY TO THE
COMMISSION TO IMPLEMENT ANY OF
THESE IT'S A DELIBERATE OF BODY
THE NAME WOULD REPORT BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE FOR FUTURE
STATUTORY CHANGES.
ON AND THE LAST ELEMENT IS A
FISCAL ONE THAT THE PROPOSES
REVERTING TO FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
PROBATION BEATEN UP -- CURRENT
YEAR AND THEN MAKING A NEW FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR PREPARATION TO
SUPPORT THE WORK OF THE
COMMISSION.
THAT'S MY POSITION HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OKAY THANK
YOU ALEJO.
THE ONLY THING I WOULD NOTICE --
THAT -- PROPOSE LANGUAGE I THINK
WOULD.
REPRESENT A SHIFT IN REALLY THE
FOCUS OF WHAT THAT THE
COMMISSION WOULD BE -- CARE THE
WORK THAT THEY BE CARRYING OUT
THE PREVIOUS LANGUAGE.
HAD A LITTLE HAD SOMEWHAT
BROADER -- ACTIVITIES IN TERMS
OF UNDERSTANDING HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS AND VARIOUS
ALTERNATIVESWAS THIS WOULD
RECAST EFFORTS AS A REALLY
FOCUSING ON BRINGING CALIFORNIA
TO A SINGLE PAYER SYSTEM.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
ALL RIGHT AND THE IN TERMS OF
THE FIVE MILLION AND SO WHEN
RELEASED THE SICKLY YOU'RE
CHANGING COMMISSION THIS THERE --
IS THERE ANY DETAIL WHAT WE'RE
SPENDING THE FIVE MILLION ON I
MEAN HOW THE STAFF IT WOULD IT
WOULD BE FOR SUPPORT OF THE
COMMISSION SO WE DON'T HAVE A
DETAILED PLAN BUT I THINK THAT
WOULD AND INCUR A STAFF SUPPORT
IT WOULD ALSO PROBABLY IN CALL.
INVOLVED SOME CONTRACTORS TO
PROVIDE EXPERTISE IN SPECIFIC
AREAS OF THE COMMISSION WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THE EXACT AT THE
SPECIFICS OF HOW YOU SPEND THE
FIVE MILLION TO COME BACK TO
LEGISLATURE OR HOW WOULD THAT BE
HANDLED -- I THINK THAT WOULD BE
HANDLED.
REPORTER THE LEGISLATURE THROUGH
THE A SIX MONTH UPDATES TO THE
TO THE LEGISLATURE THAN WE COULD
GIVE UPDATES ON HOW THE MONEY IS
BEING SPENT WHAT THE PLAN IS FOR
THE REST OF THE SPENDING OVER
THE THE LIFE OF THE
APPROPRIATION WHICH X. EXTENDS
UNTIL JULY. THIRTY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ALL RIGHT SO I THINK
BE HELPFUL JUST TO KNOW WHAT THE
PLAN IS FOR HOW YOU ACTUALLY.
PLANNED SPEND THE MONEY LIKE
COUNTY KIND IT WHETHER ITS
CONTRACTORS STAFF WHATEVER ELSE
SO ABSOLUTELY OKAY.
ALL RIGHT AND DAY TO MAKE NOTE
THAT PART OF IT IS --
INTEGRATION FEDERAL FUNDING
SOURCES SELVES THIS BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE WELL THOSE OF US
ABOUT 70% OF OUR HEALTH CARE
DOLLARS FOR A PUBLIC PROGRAMS
COME FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
FOR STATE HEALTH CARE PROGRAMS
SO THAT'S NINETY COUNTY MEDICARE
SO ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND FINALLY WE HAVE FOR FALLS A
PROPOSAL FOR INVESTMENT -- WHICH
THE CAL QUALITY CARE ABOUT.
AND SEE WHO'S PRESENTING THAT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ROTH OKAY WELCOME.
ALL RIGHT EXCELLENT AND BOOKS.
REALLY WELL SINCE WE HAVE.
DIFFERENT PEOPLE AROUND THE
TABLE OF THE MANY OF THE BEEN
SITTING HERE BEFORE ME WAS JUST
COOKED.
GROUND EVERYONE INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES UNDER TITLE SO.
OKAY EXCELLENT AND ACTUALLY DONE
YOU'LL NEED TO TURN IT
MICROPHONE IS ART OKAY AND LA --
ONLY A PEDICURE LEO RIGHT
FINANCE ARE WORDS FINANCE ALL
RIGHT -- FLEETS BEGIN -- GET THE
V..
AS THE YOU KEEP YOUR TESTIMONY
THREE MINUTES OR LESS THANK YOU.
I THINK I SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO
THAT THOSE REALLY NICE RIGHT UP
IN THE AGENDA SO I APPRECIATE
THAT AND I ALSO APPRECIATE.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE CAL QUALITY
CARE -- WEBSITE A PROJECT
INFORM'S IN BENEFITS MULTITUDE
OF CALIFORNIANS IN NEED OF LONG
TERM CARE SERVICES AND SUPPORT.
AS YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA'S LARGE
AND RAPIDLY GROWING POPULATION
OF A TWO DISABLED INDIVIDUALS
AND THE OVER TWO MILLION USERS
OF LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS.
WOULD BENEFIT FROM OBTAINING
INFORMATION.
ABOUT.
A LONG TERM CARE SERVICES AND
SUPPORT FROM A TRUSTED AN EASILY
ACCESSIBLE A SOURCE.
SO CURRENTLY THERE IS A LACK OF
EASILY ACCESSIBLE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE AVAILABILITY QUALITY
AND COST OF LTE ASSIST PROVIDERS
TO ASSIST INDIVIDUALS IN GETTING
THE CARE THEY NEED THE QUALITY
OF PROVIDERS.
AND MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS
BASED ON THEIR PREFERENCES AND
CARE NEEDS. TO ADDRESS THE NEED
OF A COMPREHENSIVE INFORMATION
CAL QUALITY CARE WAS LAUNCHED
THROUGH A PARTNERSHIP THROUGH
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION AND THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SAN FRANCISCO IN.
TWO THOUSAND FOUR IT'S THE ONLY
WEBSITE IN THE COUNTRY THAT
PROVIDES A SINGLE PORTAL FOR L.
TSS INFORMATION THAT DISPLAYS.
FREE UNBIASED INFORMATION ON
ACCESS QUALITY IN COSTS ALONG
WITH QUALITY RATING.
THE WEBSITE USED BY THE OF MANY
INDIVIDUALS AND ORGANIZATIONS --
IT'S CARE GIVERS HEALTH PLANS
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS HOSPITAL
DISCHARGE PLANNERS CARE MANAGERS.
AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS THE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM FAMILY CARE
GIVER ORGANIZATIONS ADVOCATE
GROUPS AND OTHERS.
ENGAGING CONSUMERS IN THE IN
DECISION MAKING PROCESS CAN LEAD
TO BETTER OUTCOMES HEALTH
OUTCOMES SUCH AS SHORTER
HOSPITAL STAYS.
THE SELECTION OF HIGHER QUALITY
PROVIDERS FEW RE
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND APPROVED
HEALTH CARE FOR CALIFORNIANS.
WE'RE PROPOSING TO HAVE THE
WEBSITE OPERATED BY THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE PATIENT
ADVOCATE.
IN CONJUNCTION WITH UCSF.
THE WEBSITE IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE OPIATE CHARGE TO OFFER
REPORT CARDS ON HEALTH PLANS
COMMERCIAL MEDICAL GROUPS AND
MEDICAL GROUPS FOR MEDIC KERR
ADVANTAGE MEMBERS.
AND WOULD HAVE ON GOING
FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO MAINTAIN
THE DATABASE.
SINCE CAL QUALITY CARE IS
ALREADY DEVELOPED AND TESTED IT
CAN E UPDATED UPGRADED AND MADE
OPERATIONAL AND OPA WITHIN THE
FIRST YEAR.
THE ANNUAL FUNDS NEEDED FOR THE
WEBSITE IS A FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND OF FUNDING COULD BE
MADE AVAILABLE FROM THE OFFICE
OF THE PRIVATE PATIENT ADVOCATE
TRUST FUND THE CAL QUALITY CARE
WEBSITE INFORMATION IS A
VALUABLE RESOURCE FOR HEALTH
PLANS TO FOR MEMBERS TO LTE
ASSIST PROVIDERS.
AND TO SELECT LTE ASSIST
PROVIDERS FOR HEALTH PLAN
NETWORKS THANK YOU OKAY THANK
YOU COMMENTS REMOTELY -- FINANCE.
ALL RIGHT WELL THE OKAY
APPRECIATE THE WORK FROM -- AND
ON THIS -- WEBSITE AND IF WE CAN
KEEP IT ACCESSIBLE FOR PEOPLE
THANK YOU THANKS MUCH THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SO -- WE'RE NOW GOING
TO HEAR -- TAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS
ON ALL OUR VARIOUS IT ISSUES SO
THAT'S ISSUES ONE THROUGH.
SIX SO AGAIN AS PEOPLE TRY TO
KEEP THE COMES TO AND IT RIGHT
WELCOME.
YOUR CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF
THE QUALITY CARE REQUEST.
WELCOME CRITICS CALIFORNIA'S
DISABILITY RIGHTS WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE SINGLE PAYER
REQUEST AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT
DUMB THEY HAVE TRIED THIS BEFORE
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE OPTIONS
PROJECT WHEN GRAY DAVIS WAS
GOVERNOR.
AND THE DAY CAME OUT WITH THE
PROJECT AND WHEN THEY FINISHED
IT.
THE TURNED UP RICK BRAUN WHO IS
A SINGLE PAYER SYSTEM AND THE
ONE THAT SHE LIKE YOU'LL HAD
WHERE THE MOST EFFICIENT AND
THAT'S WHAT WE HOPE TO PROVE IN
THIS STUDY.
AND THAT'S SO THE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS I THINK IT'S ME WELL
WE'RE SPENT.
RIGHT THANK YOU.
WELCOME A MARTY MOTOR CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SENIOR COMMUNITY
ACTION NETWORK CALIFORNIA PERSON
CENTER AT FIFTY PARTNERSHIP --
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL COMMISSION
AND THE CAL QUALITY OF CARE DOT
ORG BUT ALSO STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE EVEY V. FACE.
TO PROPOSAL -- I THINK IT'S A
REALLY GOOD STEP.
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING -- YOU
KNOW.
SEE IN THE FALL WITH -- THE
DEPARTMENTS ALSO WANT SOMEONE OR
DO A SHOUT OUT FOR THE I OF VVV
PHASE ONE I REALLY APPRECIATE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES
REALLY DOING.
A GREAT JOB WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND REALLY.
WHILE WORKING WITH THE ANXIETIES
OF ALL THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
REALLY AFRAID THAT DID REALLY
GOOD JOB IN ADDRESSING THE
CONCERNS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD EVENING KERR'S LINE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION -- SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF ISSUE NUMBER.
FIVE ASEAN IS SUPPORT OF OF
STEPS THAT CLEARLY ARTICULATE IT
TOO PATHWAY TO A SINGLE PAYER
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THAT NUMBER THANK
EVERYONE TO GIVE PUBLIC COMMON
THAT'S MOVED ON TO THE
DEPARTMENT MANAGED HEALTHCARE.
SO IF TWO ITEMS HERE.
BOB IS THAT OF A NOTE THAT ALL
ITEMS ARE BEING HELD OPEN CELL.
SINCE BEGIN WITH ISSUE NUMBER
ONE OKAY SO FIRST OF ALL WE CAN
HAVE EVERYONE INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES AT THE TABLE.
WATANABE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
HEALTH POLICY INST ICAL
RELATIONS DEPARTMENT MANAGED
HEALTHCARE HE MAR TWO GREEN
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT
MANAGED HEALTHCARE.
RIGHT AND WILL THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I IT'S LORRAINE
CHUNG DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
CHECK A LAND OF ARMOR TO FINANCE
DOLLARS BOND ROBINETTE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY OKAY
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT LET'S BEGIN WITH THE
PHARMACY BENEFIT MANAGEMENT AB
THREE FIFTEEN ISSUE NUMBER.
ONE THANK YOU SO ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE FIFTEEN ESTABLISH A NEW
ARTICLE WITHIN THE KNOX KEEN ACT
EFFECTIVE JANUARY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY OUTLINING
CONTRACTUAL REQUIREMENTS THAT
MUST EXIST OF A HEALTH PLAN USES
A PHARMACY BENEFIT MANAGER OR
PBM.
THIS BILL REQUIRES P. B. M.'S
CONTRACTING WITH HEALTH PLANS TO
REGISTER WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL CREATES A
TASK FORCE WITHIN THE D. MHC TO
EVALUATE WHAT TYPE OF DATA
CONTRACTED P. B. M.'S OR HEALTH
PLAN SHOULD DISCLOSE RELATED TO
PHARMACEUTICAL COSTS TO THE
DEPARTMENT.
WILL REPORT THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE NO LATER THAN
FEBRUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
ON WHICH TIME THE TASK FORCE
WILL CEASE TO EXIST.
THE BILL ALSO ESTABLISHED A
PILOT PROJECT WITHIN CINNAMON
RIVERSIDE COUNTY TO BURKE FOR
BID CONTRACTUAL QUALITY
RESTRICTIONS ON PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS DISPENSED AT RETAIL
PHARMACY LOCATIONS.
BY JULY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
HEALTH PLANS REPORT ANNUALLY TO
THE DEPARTMENT INFORMATION DATA
RELATED TO CHANGES IN COST AND
UTILIZATION.
ATTRIBUTED TO THE HOPE THE
PROHIBITION ON THIS CONTRACT
TERMS WILL ALSO SOLICIT FEEDBACK
FROM STAKEHOLDERS ON THE IMPACT
ACOSTA UTILIZATION RELATED TO
THESE PILOT PROJECTS WILL
SUMMARIZE THE DATA.
AND PROVIDE A SUMMARY REPORT TO
THE GOVERNOR LEGISLATURE BY
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THE B. C. P. INCLUDES
AN INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
COMPONENT THAT REQUIRES THE
DAMAGE TO TO REPLACE TWO SYSTEMS
THE FIRST ONE IS OUR PROVIDER.
COMPLAINT SYSTEM TO ALLOW TO
ACCOMMODATE ACCEPTANCE PROCESS
SCENE AND REPORTING A PROVIDER
COMPLAINTS RELATED TO PP ARMS WE
ALSO WERE ARE REQUESTING REPLACE
NUMBER E. FILING SYSTEM RELATED
TO THE REGISTRATION OF PPL MEANS.
THE DAMAGE SEE IS REQUESTING TO
PERMANENT POSITIONS AND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY IN THE
AMOUNT OF APPROXIMATELY TWO
POINT TWO MILLION.
IN FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN TWENTY
NINE HUNDRED AND FOUR THOUSAND
IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND FISCAL YEAR. TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO SEVEN HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND ON
GIRL GOING TO ADDRESS THE
INCREASED WORKLOAD.
AND TO MEET THE REQUIREMENTS OF
AB.
THREE FIFTEEN THIS REQUEST
INCLUDES FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
THREE THOUSAND IN PLATFORM
LICENSING COSTS FOR FISCAL YEAR
NINETEEN TWENTY THE IT
CONSULTING FUNDS AND PLATFORM
LICENSING COSTS WILL BE MADE
AVAILABLE CONTINGENT UPON
APPROVAL OF THE PROJECT APPROVAL
THAT CONCLUDES THE OVERVIEW OF
ISSUE.
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS RIGHT THANK
YOU COUNSEL MILIEU.
THIS PROPOSAL APPEARS REASONABLE
TO IMPLEMENT THE PROVISIONS OF
AB THREE FIFTEEN THANK YOU
FINANCE.
LET'S TECHNOLOGY GOES OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU -- LET'S GO
I LIVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO
WHICH HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLAN
DISPLAY ACTIONS AB.
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY FOUR THE
ENACTMENT OF AB TWENTY SIX
SEVENTY FOUR PROTECTS THE
PROVIDER COMMUNITY BY HOLDING
HEALTH PLANS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR OBLIGATION TO PAY CORRECT
IN TIMELY CLAIMS.
MANDATING A PERIODIC REVIEW OF
ALL PROVIDER COMPLAINTS THE
DAMAGE RECESS DO YOU MIGHT SEE
RECEIVES FOR INDICATIONS OF
UNFAIR PAYMENT PATTERNS AND
PROVIDING THE TEAMMATES THE
AUTHORITY. TO INITIATE AUDIT AND
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS AS
APPROPRIATE.
AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTY FOUR
ESTABLISHES MANDATES FOR THE D.
I MIGHT DO YOU MIGHT SEE TO
REVIEW AT LEAST ANNUALLY ALL
COMPLAINTS SUBMITTED. TO THE
DEPARTMENT BY HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS ALLEGING A HEALTH PLAN
HAS ENGAGED IN UNFAIR PAYMENT
PATTERNS IN VIOLATION OF THE
KNOX KEEN ACT.
EXISTING LAW PROHIBITS HEALTH
PLANS FROM ENGAGING IN UNFAIR
PAYMENT PATTERNS TO FIND
GENERALLY AS LAWS THAT.
AS DEMONSTRATE ALL I'M JUST A
REPEATED PATTERNS OF THE LANE
REDUCING OR DENYING PAYMENTS.
OR NOT INCLUDED INTEREST TO THE
LATE PAYMENTS.
THIS B. C. P. INCLUDES AN
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY COMPONENT
THAT REQUIRES THE GMAC TO
REPLACE THE CURRENT PROVIDER
COMPLAINT SYSTEM.
DATABASE TO HANDLE THE INCREASED
NUMBER OF CASES ATTACHMENTS --
IN THE PROCESS IN SAVING OF THAT
ADDITIONAL DOCUMENTATION --
RELATED TO THE PASSAGE OF AB.
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY FOUR WE'RE
REQUESTING NINE PERMANENT
POSITIONS AND APPROXIMATELY TWO
POINT ONE MILLION IN FISCAL YEAR
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND I'M GOING TO MEET
THE REQUIREMENTS OF AB.
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY FOUR THIS
REQUEST INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED
NINETY SIX THOUSAND FOR IT
CONSULTING COSTS AND FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO THOUSAND
FOR PLATFORM LICENSING COSTS IN
FISCAL YEAR.
NINETEEN TWENTY THAT WILL BE
MIGHT BE AVAILABLE CONTENTION ON
APPROVAL PROJECT APPROVAL
LIFECYCLE.
THAT CONCLUDES THE OVERVIEW OKAY
THANK YOU OF LA -- COMMENTS.
AS BEFORE THE SPURS REASONABLE
TO IMPLEMENT LEGISLATION OKAY
FINANCE [inaudible]
MARGIE.
JUST WANNA MAKE A CLARIFICATION
ON BOTH THE SOLUTIONS FOR A. B.
THREE FIFTEEN IN AB -- TWENTY
SIX SEVENTY FOUR WANNA CREDIT
THE DEPARTMENT FOR LOOKING AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE ONE
SOLUTION THAT WOULD PROVIDE --
MEET THE GOALS AND OBJECTIVES
FOR BOTH -- ASSEMBLY BILLS -- SO
THE INVESTMENT MADE WOULD NOT
JUST BE FOR FOR ONE SYSTEM OR
ANOTHER BUT AN ENTIRE TECHNOLOGY
PLATFORM THAT CAN BE LEVERAGED
TO SOLVE BOTH NEEDS OKAY SO IT
IS SO I DID WANT TO CLARIFY
BECAUSE THE LIGHT -- IS IS THAT
WE'RE NOT JUST.
UPGRADING THE EXISTING ONE ARE
WE GETTING AND NOW. TO STRUCTURE
OF WHAT WHAT ARE WE DOING WITH
THE I. T. THEN THE EFFICACY OF
EXISTING SYSTEM YOUR AUGMENTING
IT TO TO HANDLE THIS OR ARE YOU
REPLACING SOMETHING.
OKAY IT IS A BRAND NEW SOLUTION
THAT WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED OKAY
THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT I WAS
HEARING IS IT'S ACTUALLY THIS IS
A NEW NEW SYSTEM THAT RIGHT TO
THE CURRENT BUT WE HAVE TWO
DISCRETE SYSTEMS THE FILING
SYSTEM THAT WE ADDRESSED AND THE
PROVIDER COMPLAINTS SYSTEM BOTH.
OF THEM OUR LEGACY SYSTEMS VERY
OLD HAND BUILT AND VERY
DIFFICULT TO MAINTAIN.
AND SO THE PROPOSAL IS TO
REPLACE BOTH SYSTEMS WITH --
ESSENTIALLY THINGS YOU CAN BUY
OFF THE SHELF THAT CAN BE
MODIFIED FOR USE AND THEN --
LEVERAGED AS OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
SAID FOR MULTIPLE SOLUTIONS
ACROSS THE DEPARTMENT SO WE ARE
CURRENTLY IN THIS STAGE TWO
ALTERNATIVES ANALYSIS.
LOOKING AT A SINGLE PLATFORM TO
RESOLVE BOASTS A PROP BOTH THE
TITLE ISSUES OKAY SITS BUT JUST
TO CLARIFY SINCE THIS IS OFF THE
BOOKS LIKE YOU'RE LOOKING AT OFF
THE SHELF SOLUTIONS THEN
[inaudible]
THE OF TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY
SIX THOUSAND OF FOR LEASE THIS
PARTICULAR ITEM -- IN ONE TIME
CAUGHT CONTRA COSTA UPGRADE THE
SYSTEM -- SO THIS ISN'T LIKE
THIS IS JUST THE INTRODUCTORY
AMOUNT OF MONEY TO THE AND I
MEAN I MEAN WE GOT TO SPEND MORE
MONEY TO BUY THE SYSTEM I GUESS
I MEAN IS THAT THE FUTURE
EXPENSE.
OF THOSE WHAT SO I SEE THERE'S
MAINTENANCE MONEY ON FOR A
PLATFORM LICENSING COSTS BUT
THAT BASICALLY WILL COVER THE
CENTURY THE NEW SYSTEM.
RIGHTSENATE CANDIDATE THESE ARE
AT THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A DIFFERENT
SOLUTION THAN THOSE THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT RIGHT SIGN.
DIFFERENT SIZE AND COMPLEXITY --
BASED ON THE SIZE AND COMPLEXITY
OF THIS EFFORT AT LEAST WHAT WE
KNOW AT THIS TIME -- IT'S IT'S
SUBSTANTIATED THAT THE
DEPARTMENT RECEIVED THE MONEY IN
THIS BUDGET YEAR -- BECAUSE WERE
EXPECTED TO GET PROJECT APPROVAL
THIS CALENDAR YEAR RIGHT OKAY SO
JUST TO CLARIFY WHAT WE'RE DOING
IS WE'RE BASICALLY LICENSING A
ON OFF THE SHELF PRODUCT TO
SERVICE FUNCTION WE DON'T
THEREFORE NOT INVESTING IN
BUYING A NEW SYSTEM AND SO.
THIS COVERS THE ENTIRE COST THAN.
IT DOES COVER THE ENTIRE COST
YEAH.
OKAY JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
OKAY.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT -- WITH THAT --
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
TO PROPOSALS.
SEEING NONE THANKS VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE IT [inaudible]
OKAY.
NOW MOVING ON TO DEPARTMENT
STATE HOSPITALS.
SO WE HAVE I THINK NINE ISSUES
FOR STATE HOSPITALS.
AND I DON'T THINK ANY OF THEM
INVOLVE I. T. ASSUME.
BUT ONE OF THOSE OF ALL RIGHTY
OKAY WE CAN AVOID IT.
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY.
SO I SEE A STATE HOSPITAL STAFF
YOU'RE ALWAYS.
HAVING TO SHELVE LEAD TO BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS ALWAYS IN
THE EVENINGS VERY -- HAPPY TO DO
IT OKAY WELL.
ALL RIGHT SO FIRST OF ALL LET'S
DO THE INTRODUCTIONS. FOR THIS.
GOOD EVENING STEPHANIE CLINTON
AN ACTING DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITAL
SEEKING.
AND GETTING GEORGE MAYNARD --
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES FOR
DEPARTMENT SAY HOSPITALS THANK
YOU ALEJO.
SORT OF BORED WITH A SALUTE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
THANK YOU FINANCE A BRAND FULLER
PART OF FRANCE.
CC FINANCE OKAY THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT SO LET'S GO AHEAD WITH
BEGINNING NUMBER ISSUE NUMBER
ONE METROPOLITAN CONSOLIDATION
OF POLICE OPERATIONS
REAPPROPRIATION.
YES THANK YOU GOOD EVENING
CENTER PAN AND MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE I'LL BE SPEAKING TO
THE D. S. H. CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROPOSALS -- WITHIN THIS PACKET.
AND CURRENTLY THE S. H. IS
REQUESTING A REAPPROPRIATION OF
NINE POINT FOUR TWO EIGHT
MILLION. FOR THE CONSTRUCTION
PHASE OF THE PATENT FIRE ALARM
SYSTEM UPGRADE PROJECT -- IN THE
SAME A SIMILAR PROJECT WE'RE
REQUESTING A REAPPROPRIATION OF
ONE POINT FIVE OH NINE MILLION
FOR THE WORKING DRAWINGS PHASE
OF THE METROPOLITAN
CONSOLIDATION OF POLICE
OPERATIONS PROJECT.
AND ADDITIONALLY WE ARE SEEKING
AN EXTENSION OF THE LIQUIDATION
PERIOD FOR TWO ADDITIONAL
PROJECTS -- THAT HAVE BEEN
COMPLETED -- BUT ARE PENDING
CLOSE UP BY D. G. S. DUE TO SOME --
CONTRACTOR -- ISSUES WITH
SUBCONTRACTORS ANSWER THAT WOULD
BE -- EXTENDING LIQUIDATION
PERIOD FROM EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TO
NINETEEN TWENTY FISCAL YEAR.
AND JUST AS A A BRIEF --
UNDERSTANDING OF THE PROJECT THE
PATENT FIRE ALARM SYSTEM ITSELF
IS -- THIS WOULD BE TO COMPLETE
THE WORKING DRAWINGS PHASE OF
THE PROJECT WHICH WOULD INCLUDE
THE ULTIMATE GOAL OF REPLACING
THE OUTDATED AND THAT ONE
SOUNDED JUST CLARIFIED AND WE
ARE COVERING ISSUE ONES BECAUSE
NOW YOU'RE TALKING TO ISSUE TOO
AND I SOME ISSUE THREE SINCE
YOU'RE TALKING LIQUIDATION.
YES I'M SORRY I DID THAT'S RIGHT
I JUST FOR ANYONE IS WATCHING
THIS HEARING I ONE OF THE SURE
IT'S CLEAR WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SO WE ARE ACTUALLY
COVERING ISSUES. ONE TWO AND
THREE AND YOUR PRESENTATION OKAY
FIRST OF ALL ALL OF FOCUS ON THE
INDIVIDUALLY -- SO SPECIFICALLY
FOR THE METROPOLITAN WHICH IS
OUR ISSUE -- ONE THIS IS A NEW
BUILDING CONSOLIDATE OUR STATE
HOSPITALS APARTMENT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES OUR OFFICE OF THE
SPECIAL INVESTIGATIONS AND
EMERGENCY DISPATCH CENTER --
THESE ENTITIES ARE CURRENTLY
LOCATED IN BUILDINGS THAT ARE
ARE WILL BE ON THE USEFUL LIFE --
SIGNIFICANT HEALTH AND SAFETY
ISSUES AND A NUMBER OF CODE
ISSUES THAT CANNOT BE BROUGHT UP
TO CODE -- THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT -- INCLUDED
THE EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF THE
ONE POINT FIVE ONE NINE MILLION --
FOR DESIGN WORKING DRAWINGS AND
UNFORTUNATELY ARE ANTICIPATED
SCHEDULE WAS THROWN OFF ON THIS
PARTICULAR PROJECT DUE TO LINK
THE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW PROCESS --
PRIMARILY DUE TO THE NEED OF THE
DEMOLITION PROJECT OF OR
DEMOLITION COMPONENT OF THE
PROJECT.
SO THIS REQUEST WOULD
SPECIFICALLY -- RE APPROPRIATE
THE ONE POINT FIVE OR NINE
MILLION FROM THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN TO THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET YEARS OKAY THANK
YOU.
ANY COMES FROM ILLEGAL
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
RIGHT LET'S MOVE ON THAT ISSUE
NUMBER TWO OF THIS ISSUE NUMBER
TWO IS OUR PATENT FIRE ALARM
SYSTEM UPGRADE A NATION I SHOULD
MENTION I WAS HERE LAST YEAR TOO
SO WE CAN BE REALLY BRIEF ABOUT.
HELLO.
THIS AGAIN IS A REAPPROPRIATION
AND THIS IS SPECIFICALLY FOR
FIRE LIFE SAFETY ISSUES WITH THE
DEFICIENT -- SIMPLEX GRINNELL
FIRE ALARM CONTROL PANELS AND
THIS IS -- REAPPROPRIATION
REQUEST OF NINE POINT FOUR TWO
EIGHT MILLION FROM TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TO NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET YEARS.
OKAY AND ACTUALLY WHAT HOLD IT
UP LAST YEAR OF THE JUST FIRE
MARSHAL OR SOMETHING THE THERE'S
BEEN A NUMBER OF REGULATORY YES
THE PROCESS OF GETTING PLAN
CHECK SO THAT THE WILD FIRES IN
THE FARMERS FROM BEING SPREAD X.
EXCEPTIONALLY.
EXCEPTIONALLY SHORT THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS HAVE CONTRIBUTED
TO THOSE THE LINK AS WELL ALL
RIGHT FIND HAVE.
VALUE COUNTY.
FINANCE ALL RIGHT.
OKAY WILL HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET TO
THAT IF YOU GOT THE PRIVILEGE IT
AND FROM.
AN ARTERY AVERY FAQ ON TRACKS IS
A SAY WE'RE BACK ON TRACK IN A
WEEK FRIENDLY ANTICIPATE THE
PROJECT TO PROCEED TO BID IN
OCTOBER OKAY.
AND I'M SORRY THAT WAS THE
PREVIOUS WERE ANTICIPATING --
WORKING TRYING TO BE COMPLETED
IN JULY TWENTY NINETEEN OKAY AND
CONSTRUCTION BEGINNING IN
SEPTEMBER SOUNDS GOOD OKAY SO
GOT THE PROVES ROLAND FOR OKAY
LIQUIDATION.
OKAY EXTENSION OF LIQUIDATION --
THESE TWO PROJECTS ARE VERY
SIMILAR AND METROPOLITAN NAPA
KITCHEN THAT.
DUE TO SOME STOP WORK ORDERS
ISSUED BY THE PRIMARY CONTRACTOR
IN WORKING OUT THOSE ISSUES WITH
THE SUBCONTRACTORS THE PROJECTS
HAVE BEEN COMPLETED THERE'S NO
MONETARY COSTS IN THIS WE'RE
JUST EXTENDING.
THE LIQUIDATION PERIODS SO THAT
THE DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES
CAN -- WRAP EVERYTHING UP ANY
BOW TIE ALL THE INVOICES AND
CLOSE THE PROJECT SOUNDS GOOD LA --
ANY QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS OKAY
FINANCE OKAY SOUNDS GOOD.
ALRIGHT LET'S MOVE ON ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR LOCATIONAL SERVICES
INPATIENT MINIMUM WAGE.
SO MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS.
RIGHT.
INTRODUCE YOURSELF FOR THE
RECORD.
GOOD EVENING.
GOOD EVENING CHRISTINE'S COUNTY
CHIEF COUNSEL FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF STATE HOSPITALS OKAY AND I'LL
BE SPEAKING TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
REGARDING VOCATIONAL SERVICES
AND STATE MINIMUM WAGE.
OKAY.
MARCELO WAKE UP.
CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER OKAY
THANK YOU ARE GONNA.
STATE HOSPITALS.
THANK YOU AND I THINK WE HAVE A
NEW PERSON AT FROM FINANCE AT
THE TABLE HERE.
I'M GOING TO BERMAN FINANCE
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
THESE BEGIN.
SURE THANK YOU.
THIS B. C. P. SIX ONE PERMANENT
FULL TIME POSITION AND A GENERAL
FUND AUGMENTATION OF THREE
MILLION THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS IN FISCAL
YEAR.
NINETEEN TWENTY AND THEN AN
ONGOING PREPARATION OF THREE
MILLION THREE AND FORTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS -- AS WELL AS
APPROVAL OF ASSOCIATED TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE AND THE PURPOSE OF
THIS PCP IS TO IMPLEMENT A NEW
AND COMPLIANT WAIT STRUCTURE.
FOR OUR VOCATIONAL
REHABILITATION PROGRAM.
THE GOALS ARE REALLY TO
STANDARDIZE THE PATIENT WHICH
STRUCTURE ACROSS OUR VOCATIONAL
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS -- TO
ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW AND TO REDUCE THE
RISK OF POTENTIAL ADVERSE LEGAL
ACTIONS ASSOCIATE WITH OUR
CURRENT NON STANDARDIZED WAGE
STRUCTURE -- THE PATIENT WORKERS --
ARE PART OF THE PROGRAM'S REALLY
THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS DESIGNED TO
GIVE THEM LIFE AND CAREER SKILLS
AND PREPARE THEM FOR DISCHARGE.
LOSE LIKE A STORY A WORKER
KITCHEN WORKER LANDSCAPER --
THEY'RE PAID A WAGE FOR THAT
WORK WITH THAT WEIGHT IS NOT
BEEN STANDARDIZED ACROSS THE
HOSPITAL'S NOR ACROSS THE
DIFFERENT PATIENT COMMITMENT
TYPES AND HASN'T BEEN CONSISTENT
FOR THE WORK PERFORMED -- SO
THIS PC P. SIX TO REMEDY THAT.
WAGE FOR THE PATIENT WORKERS
WITH TWO EXCEPTIONS THOSE WOULD
BE FOR THE CITY SORRY MATES
UNDER PENAL CODE SECTION TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY FOUR WHO ARE EXEMPT
AND WHO BE PAID ONE DOLLAR AN
HOUR.
AND AS WELL AS PATIENTS THAT WE
HAVE PARTICIPATING IN A
SHELTERED WORKSHOP AT ADIDAS
EACH NAPA.
THE ONE PERMANENT POSITION WOULD
BE TO STANDARDIZE -- THOSE
PEOPLE PROCESSES AND TO DO THE
REQUIRED WITHHOLDINGS.
AND THE TRAILER BILL IS TO
CLARIFY THAT THE PATIENT WAGES --
WOULD BE EXEMPT FROM THE STATE
MINIMUM WAGE AND AS WELL AS TWO
APPLY WORKERS COMPENSATION
BENEFITS IN CASE AND A PATIENT
WAS INJURED.
AND DISCHARGE SO THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE THOSE BENEFITS AVAILABLE TO
THEM.
THEY ALSO JUST WANT TO KNOW THAT
WE DID HAVE A SPRING FINANCE
LETTER WHICH WAS A TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT TO THIS PROPOSAL
WHICH REDUCES THE REQUEST BY
HUNDRED FIFTY ONE THOUSAND WAS
JUST DUE TO A CALCULATION ERROR
IN THE ORIGINAL PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU ALEJO [inaudible]
FINANCE.
SO I DO HAVE TO POSE A QUESTION
WHY A THE I KNOW IT'S LESS BUT
WHY THE FEDERAL MINIMUM WAGE IN
WHERE WEEKS AT THE SELF FROM THE
STATE MINIMUM WAGE SINCE IT THIS.
SURE SURE NO I I THINK THE IT'S
A LOGICAL QUESTION I WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE
IT'S REALLY DESIGNED TO CARE FOR
THINGS SUCH AS FOOD HOUSING
THOSE SORTS OF COST THAT PEOPLE
IN HER.
AND SO WHERE IS THE S. H.
PROVIDES HOUSING AND MEDICAL
CARE -- THOSE ARE ALREADY YOU
KNOW BUILT IN INTO OUR BUDGET TO
WHAT WE PROVIDE THE PATIENTS ARE
REQUIRED TO TO PAY FOR THOSE
EXPENSES SO THE STATE MINIMUM
WAGE WE THINK PROVIDES THE
APPROPRIATE BALANCING
COMPENSATING THEM FOR THE THE
ECONOMIC BENEFIT THAT THEY
PROVIDE BUT REALLY THIS IS A
THERAPEUTIC.
PROGRAM DESIGNED TO GIVE THEM
LIFE SKILLS.
SO I THINK THAT'S REALLY THE
FOCUS OF THE PROGRAM.
OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL I AND EIGHT
YES A UNDERSTAND YOUR RATIONALE --
THAT IS SOMEONE WHO SUPPORTED
OUR STATE MINIMUM WAGE INCREASE.
BE VERY CAREFUL ABOUT -- WHAT
MESSAGE FOR SENDING TO PEOPLE WE
TELL THEM THAT THEY CAN DOWN WE
HAVE A MINIMUM WAGE IN THE STATE
WE'VE -- THAT THAT SIGNED INTO
LAW ON THAT SAUDI CARE FOR
MESSAGE WE SAID THE PEOPLE ON WE
DON'T.
GIVE THEM THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE
AND I RECOGNIZE WHAT HE SAID
THAT.
THEY'RE ALSO GETTING OTHER
BENEFITS -- THAT ARE
INCORPORATED INTO THE WAGE --
BUT SEVEN EIGHT DALE.
SO I UNDERSTAND BUT NOT
NECESSARILY SURE -- FULL
AGREEMENT BUT OKAY THANK YOU.
RIGHT.
LET'S MOVE ON THEN -- O ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT.
OKAY INTRODUCE YOURSELVES FIRST
FOR THE RECORD.
AND KATE WERE WRITTEN ON THE
MEDICAL DIRECTOR FOR STATE
HOSPITALS.
AUDREY BASESTAR AND FINANCE
THANK YOU PLEASE BEGIN. FOR THIS
REQUEST -- WE REQUEST A
PERMANENT FULL TIME POSITIONS
AND ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION IN
FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN TWENTY TWO
POINT TWO MILLION IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWO POINT FOUR AND
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND TWO POINT SIX
MILLION.
ON GOING -- THIS IS THERE WAS
ALSO IS OFFERING FINANCE LETTER
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS -- PROPOSAL
WHICH REQUESTED -- PORTION OF
THAT FUNDING THREE AND SEVENTY
THOUSAND ANNUALLY IN
REIMBURSEMENTS AND THIS IS TO
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF A PSYCHIATRIC
RESIDENCY PROGRAM OUT DEPARTMENT
OF STATE HOSPITALS NAPA.
AND TO EXPAND RESOURCES FOR
NURSING RECRUITMENT AT THREE OF
OUR HOSPITALS.
AND WE DO EXPERIENCE RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION CHALLENGES FOR
BOTH PSYCHIATRY NURSING OUR
HOSPITALS ARE HIGH RISK --
EMPLOYMENT ENVIRONMENTS WITH
HIGH WITH PATIENTS WITH HIGH
ACUITY AND A SIGNIFICANT
VIOLENCE RESTS WE ALL HAVE HIGH
OCCUPANCY -- WITHIN OUR
HOSPITALS AND HIGHER CASELOADS
THAT OUR STANDARD -- WE ALSO YOU
KNOW THERE NATIONALLY.
THERE'S INDUSTRY SHORTAGES FIRST
MOST PSYCHIATRISTS THE NURSES
AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE -- PAY
DISCREPANCIES -- THIS PROPOSAL
HAS TWO COMPONENTS THE
PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENCY PROGRAM
WHICH WE PROPOSED TO PARTNER
WITH TORO UNIVERSITY TO DEVELOP
AN EMPLOYER CONSORTIUM COMPRISED
OF M. D. S. H. TORO IN AS WELL
AS TO ADDITIONAL COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO CREATE A
NEW PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENCY
PROGRAM.
THIS WE REQUEST ONE PROGRAM
DIRECTOR IN A PROGRAM ASSISTANT
TO ESTABLISH THE RESIDENCY
PROGRAM.
AND THE GOAL IS TO OPEN THE
RESIDENCY PROGRAM IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO OUR FIRST COHORT
OF FOR RESIDENTS AND THEN WE
WOULD GROW BY FOUR RESIDENTS PER
YEAR TO WE GET.
TO SIXTEEN AND WHILE THEY'RE IN
ROTATION WITH THIS WITH THIS IS
A GREAT BENEFIT TO US BECAUSE
THEY WILL BE THEY WILL HAVE
THEIR OWN PATIENT CASELOADS.
AS WELL AS WILL BE TOMORROW AND
DEVELOPING A COHORT OF
PSYCHIATRISTS THAT ARE ENTERED
INTEREST AND IN WORKING WITH OUR
FRIENDS AT POPULATION.
THE SECOND PORTION OF THIS IS
FOR NURSING INSTRUCTORS AND WE
ARE REQUIRED UNDER OR I'M ALL
FOR AN INSTITUTION CODE SECTION
FORTY THREE TWENTY TO ESTABLISH
AN EDUCATION TRAINING PROGRAM.
TO PROVIDE AN ADEQUATE SUPPLY OF
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS FOR
HOSPITALS AND SO WE DO PARTNER --
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WITH
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS THAT --
FOR THE TRAINING OF BOTH I AM
REGISTERED NURSES AND
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS AND SOME
OF THE PARTNERSHIPS ARRANGEMENTS
WE DO PROVIDE THE NURSING
INSTRUCTORS AS WELL AS
FACILITIES -- OUT OUR HOSPITALS
IN ORDER -- FOR TO OPERATE THE
TRAINING PROGRAMS.
AND SO WE ARE PROPOSING TO HIRE
FIVE NURSE INSTRUCTORS -- THIS
WOULD BE THREE IDEAS H.
ATASCADERO FOR A PARTNERSHIP
WITH CUESTA -- WHEN IT AT NAPA
FOR THE PARTNERSHIP AND NAPA
VALLEY COLLEGE AND ONE AT
COALINGA I'M FOR WITH WEST HILLS
COLLEGE?
AND THEY WILL HOSPITAL OUT REACH
CORNER PART NADER'S FOR
RECRUITMENT -- PURPOSES AND THEN
WE ALSO HAVE INCLUDED IN THIS
PROPOSAL -- ONE HEPA FOR THE
SACRAMENTO RECRUITMENT IN IT SO
THAT WE CAN EXPAND THEIR
FUNCTIONS TO FOCUS ON OUR END IN
PT RECRUITMENT AS WELL.
EXCELLENT.
ANY COMES FROM MILIEU.
YES -- WITH RESPECT TO THE
PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENCY PROGRAM WE
DO RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED THE
PROPOSAL HOWEVER GIVEN THAT IT'S
RELATIVELY COSTLY APPROACH TO
FILLING VACANCIES AND IT'S
UNCLEAR HOW MANY VACANCIES
ULTIMATELY BE FILLED.
WOULD RECOMMEND APPROVING IT ON
A SIX YEAR LIMITED TERM BASIS
THAT WOULD GIVE THE DEPARTMENT
ENOUGH TIME TO ESTABLISH IT IN
THE FIRST COHORT TO GRADUATE AND
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WOULD.
CHOOSE TO STAY TO FILL A STATE
VACANCY OR PLAYED MOVE ON
SOMEWHERE ELSE AND I WOULD GIVE
THE LEGISLATURE MORE INFORMATION
TO BE ABLE TO DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT THIS IS AN EFFECTIVE
APPROACH -- TO THE EXTENT THE
LEGISLATURE DETERMINED THAT IT
WASN'T AN EFFECTIVE APPROACH IT
WILL COULD -- CHOOSE TO CONTINUE
TO FUND THE PROGRAM TO ALLOW THE
RESIDENTS WORRY IN THE PROGRAM
TO FINISH FOR IT CAN PROVIDE ON
GOING FUNDING WE KNOW THAT THIS
APPROACH THE LIMITED TERM
FUNDING APPROACH WOULD BE
CONSISTENT WITH A SIMILAR
APPROACH THAT THE ADMINISTRATION.
HAS MADE FOR CDC ARE WHERE
THEY'RE DOING A RESIDENCY
PROGRAM FOR NURSE PRACTITIONERS
AND THAT WAS PROPOSED ON A
LIMITED TERM BASIS AGAIN. TO
ALLOW FOR EVALUATION -- WITH
RESPECT TO THE EXPANSION OF THE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ON THE SPRING
FINANCE LETTER THAT WAS
MENTIONED ESSENTIALLY WAS.
PUT IN PLACE TO RECOGNIZE THAT
WHEN THESE INSTRUCTORS ARE HIRED
THEY'LL INCREASE CLASS SIZES
WHICH WILL CREATE FUNDING FOR
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE THAT CAN
BE USED TO OFFSET THE PROGRAM SO
WE OBVIOUSLY RECOMMEND APPROVING
THE JANUARY PROPOSAL IN THE
SPRING DOWNWARD ADJUSTMENT
HOWEVER WE WOULD NOTE.
THAT TWO OF THE INSTRUCTORS
BEING PROPOSED THIRD THEY'RE NOT
PROPOSING TO OFFSET.
THOSE INSTRUCTORS FOR THE LIKELY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE INSTRUCTIONAL
FUNDING THAT BE GENERATED SO
WE'D RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REDUCE THE PROPOSAL
BY A FURTHER 200-407-0002
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT FUNDING. TO THE
EXTENT THE FUNDING ISN'T
ULTIMATELY PART OF THE AGREEMENT
THEY BROKER WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WE THINK THE DEPARTMENT
COULD ABSORB IT ON A ONE TIME
BASIS AND THEN REQUEST THOSE
FUNDS NEXT YEAR.
THANK YOU FINANCE -- YEAH I TO
BASIS FROM THE FINANCE --
NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD TO DS
AGES -- OVERVIEW OF THE PROPOSAL
JUST I WOULD NOTE THAT --
PSYCHIATRISTS ARE -- FAIRLY
EXPENSIVE ON THE AND WE HAVE A
SEVERE -- VACANCY RATE AND THE
PSYCHIATRIST DESERVES AT STATE
HOSPITALS WE ACTUALLY THINK THIS
IS ACTUALLY RELATIVELY LOW COST
WAY TO FILL VACANCIES AT OUR
STATE HOSPITALS -- I WOULD ALSO --
JUST NEW TO CONCERNED ABOUT FOR
THE MESSAGE IT SENDS ABOUT THIS
BEING SORT OF A LIMITED TERM
RESIDENCY PROGRAM.
I THINK -- ANY SORT OF
INSTITUTION AN EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTION WOULD BE LEERY ABOUT
SORT OF ENGAGING WITH US ON A
LIMóN TERM BASIS ON THIS -- AND
JUST IT IS A HOUSEHOLD HAS NO
INTEREST IN CONTINUING SOMETHING
IT'S NOT WORKING SO THE EXTENT
THAT THE RESIDENCY PROGRAM
DOESN'T WORK I THINK BOTH THE
UNIVERSITY ANSWERED HOSPITALS
ARE ARE NOT GONNA BE INCHING
CONTINUING IT -- TO SO I DON'T
THINK SORT OF SIGNALING THAT
THIS IS IN ANY WAY INTENDED TO
BE LIMITED TERM IS IS IS
NECESSARY.
OKAY AND ANY COMMENTS ON THE
VOICE SAID ABOUT THE THE BUDGET
ON THE NURSES -- AND IN TERMS OF
AND COMMITTEE COLLEGES.
YEAH AND JUST AS EASILY AS WE
COULD COME BACK AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO COME BACK AND
REQUEST FUNDS TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE'S ADDITIONAL --
REIMBURSEMENTS FROM THOSE
COLLEGES WE CAN JUST AS EASILY
TAKEN DOWN -- FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING -- THE DEPARTMENT
HAS BEEN ENGAGE WITH THOSE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND CURRENTLY
THE CONTRACT DOES NOT REFLECT
THOSE REIMBURSEMENTS FROM THEM.
OKAY.
RIGHT SO I WOULD MAKE NOTES --
YOU MAY NOT KNOW BUT I USED TO
SIT ON THE BOARD FOR THE
TRADITION COUNTS ON GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION AND I WAS A
RESIDENCY DIRECTOR SIDE PAYING A
LITTLE MORE ABOUT RESIDENCIES
THAN THE AVERAGE BEAR -- SO A
COUPLE COUPLE QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE RESIDENCY PROGRAM -- FIRST
OF ALL IS THE SECOND TO THE
PSYCHIATRIST AND PROGRAM
ASSISTANT OTHERS CAN BE STATE
EMPLOYEES YES OKAY SO BASICALLY
SO THE PROGRAM ALL AND DOES THE
AND THE STATE WILL BE THE ONE TO
OPERATE TO BE THE DESIGNATED
INSTITUTION THAT FOR THE
RESIDENCY.
WHERE IT WERE NEGOTIATING THAT
RIGHT NOW AND THAT MIGHT BE A
HEAVY LIFT TO GET RESIDENTS ON
THE GROUND NEXT YEAR WE HAVE
SOME PARTNERS AT THE TABLE WITH
TRUE UNIVERSITY WHO MAY BE
WILLING TO BE THE DESIGNATED
SITE AND WE WOULD BE THE
IMPATIENT AND FRIENDS LIKE
EXPERIENCE?
RESIDENCY TRAINING INCLUDES AN
INPATIENT AND OUTPATIENT RIGHT
WELL AS AN ALLY USUALLY THERE'S
A DESIGNATED SO TO XIN THAT'S
THE CENTRAL CONTRACTING AND THEN
EVERYONE ELSE'S AROUND OKAY
SORRY I'M GETTING A LITTLE IN
THE WAY BUT THE THE SO THIS THE
PROGRAMMING.
SO YOU HAVEN'T STARTED FOR A
PROGRAMS I CREDIT YET RIGHT
THAT'S RIGHT OKAY SO YOU'RE
GONNA SEE CREDIT ATION FOR THE
PROGRAM OKAY.
AND THEN I GUESS THE OTHER
QUESTION I WOULD MAKE NOTICES
THAT YOU EVENTUALLY WHEN YOU GO
TO SCALE YOU'LL HAVE SIXTEEN
RESIDENTS FOR EACH YEAR.
AND THE DATE AND THE INTENTION
IS IS THAT PER YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO BE IN LINE
WITH THE R. C. REQUIREMENTS THAT
THEY WILL BE SPENDING LOVE THEIR
IN PATIENT.
TIMED WITH THE STATE HOSPITALS
CORRECT THAT'S RIGHT.
OKAY SO I THINK -- THIS IS WHY I
A CERTAINLY -- YES -- FIRST OF
ALL I WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT
THAT'S A LOT MAN POWER RIGHT
THERE -- THAT YEAR ARE YOU DON'T
WORK FOR OUR AND SUCH AS MINUTES
MA'AM LIMóN BUT NOW IT'S IT
THAT'S A LOT OF WORK THERE SO
THERE'S A BIG SYSTEM WORKFORCE
FROM THE RESIDENTS THEMSELVES
BECAUSE THEY CAN PROVIDE
CLINICAL SERVICES.
RIGHT UNDER SUPERVISION BUT THEY
DEFINITELY PROVIDE SO.
SO IF YOU JUST COUNT THE
RESIDENTS ALONE BEFORE THEY EVEN
GRADUATE WHETHER THEY WORK FOR
YOU ARE NOT -- THAT REPRESENTS A
CERTAIN LEVEL OF CAPACITY THAT
YOU'RE BUILDING THERE NOW THEY
ARE TRAINEES THEY NEED TO BE A
SUPERVISION BUT I WOULD MAKE
NOTE RESIDENTS ARE GRADUATES OF
MEDICAL SCHOOLS THEY ACTUALLY
END UP HOLDING A LICENSE -- SO
THEY THEY CAN ACTUALLY BIRD AND
THEY ACTUALLY PROVIDE DIRECT
CLINICAL SERVICES SO CERTAINLY I
THINK WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
SUCCESS LEVEL THIS ONE HAS TO
RECOGNIZE THAT YOU'RE REBUILDING
CAPACITY IF YOU'RE ABLE TO GET
THE PROGRAM ACCREDITED -- YOU
KNOW I I ALSO THINK THAT.
CERTAINLY WHILE YOUR GOALS IS TO
GET MORE STAFF PSYCHIATRISTS --
AND I AND ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT
MAY COME UP THEIR TRADITIONS THE
YOU DO NEED TO HAVE ENOUGH
PSYCHIATRISTS ONSITE SUPERVISE
ALL THE RESIDENTS -- BUT EIGHT I
GUESS I WOULD CERTAINLY HOPE
THAT YOU GET MORE I MEAN I THE
IS THE EXPECTATION WOULD BE IS
LIKE ALL WELL EVERYBODY
GRADUATES GONNA END UP SIGNING
UP FOR STATE SERVICE I THINK
THAT WOULD BE AN UNREASONABLE
EXPECTATION BUT HOPEFULLY THAT
EXPOSURE.
WILL -- GET THE HELP YOU THE
OTHER THING THAT YOU MIGHT ALSO
WANT TO THINK ABOUT IS IS THAT --
COLLABORATIONS WITH OTHER
RESIDENTS IF YOU HAVE YOUR OWN
RESIDENCY PROGRAM YOU PRIDE
THEIR POSITION TO THINK ABOUT
COLLABORATIONS WITH OTHER
PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
OF PEOPLE ME WHY DO ROTATIONS TO
LEARN OF OUR ABOUT THAT SO ONCE
YOU HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE UP
IT'S A LOT HARDER DO IT IF YOU.
DON'T BUT IF YOU HAVE YOUR OWN
RESIDENT RATE OF YOUR OWN
INFRASTRUCTURE.
SO YOU MAY EVEN SOME OF THE
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS WHERE THEY
MAY SPEND DOWN TIME OVER AT
STATE HOSPITALS VICE VERSA YEAR
RESIDENTS MAY SPEND SOME TIME AT
THEIR HOUSE YOU KNOW TO TO LEARN
MORE ABOUT OTHER TYPES OF THINGS
BUT THAT.
HOPEFULLY THAT TREATS MORE
EXPOSURE ALSO CREATES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU TO RECRUIT --
MORE BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVE A MORE
FAMILIARITY IS WITH THE NATURE
OF THE WORK -- AT THAT STATE
HOSPITAL SO -- ON A PRE SHEET LA
AS PERSPECTIVE ON THE FUNDING
BUT I A ESTIMATE AS A EDUCATION
PROGRAM DIRECTOR [inaudible]
THE IN KNOWING THAT YOUR
FINDINGS GOT IT SAY SECURITY FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT EVERY TIME YOU
MIDDLE CLASS OKAY BECAUSE YOU
YOU CAN TRAIN PEOPLE IN THE
MIDDLE AND ACTUALLY THAT'S GOING
TO BE A FACTOR AND ACCREDITATION
DECISION.
TO THEIR ESSAYS ARE GOING TO BE
SUSTAINABLE SOURCE OF FUNDING.
AND OUR COMMITMENT I SHOULD SAY
IT'S NOT SO ITS COMMITMENT TO
THE TRAINING SO.
AND CERTAINLY IF IT TURNS OUT
THIS IS QUOTE NOT SUCCESSFUL YOU
KNOW YOU CAN WIND IT DOWN --
THERE'S GONNA BE SOME WORK THERE
BECAUSE AGAIN YOU CAN'T LEAVE
PEOPLE STRANDED -- AND SO.
A SO I THINK THE MAIN ISSUE IS
GOING TO BE IS THAT -- YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY.
THE YOUNG OPEN TO THINKING ABOUT
DOING THIS -- TO FIND THAT BUT
FIRST OF ALL YOU -- WE NEED TO
WE NEED REPORT BACK WHEN NOT HOW
YOU ACCREDITATION PROCESS GO
BECAUSE NO RECORDATION A
RESIDENCY RIGHT.
SO.
AND SO ANYWAY.
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY WELL AS PRIDE MORE THAN IF
I WANNA HEAR ABOUT IT BUT I
COULD GO ON FOR AWHILE.
I CAN EVEN PROVIDE CONSULTATION
HOW YOU GET YOUR RESIDENCY
PROGRAM.
BUT WE WILL DO THAT HERE TODAY
CAN RATHER LATE OKAY MOVING ON
THE ISSUE NUMBER SIX CORD
VALUATIONS REPORTS.
THIS ITEM REQUESTING FORTY THREE
PERMANENT FULL TIME POSITIONS
AND EIGHT POINT ONE MILLION IN
NINETEEN TWENTY AN ADDITIONAL
THIRTY FOUR POINT FIVE PERMANENT
FULL TIME POSITIONS AND FIVE
POINT NINE MILLION IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ADDITIONAL
SEVENTEEN POINT -- ONE PERMANENT
FULL TIME POSITIONS AND FOUR
POINT TWO MILLION IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO FOR A TOTAL OF NINETY
FOUR POINT SIX POSITIONS AND
EIGHTEEN POINT ONE MILLION ON
GOING.
THIS IS.
OBVIOUSLY BASED ON ACROSS THREE
FOR A YEARS -- INTO BEEN THIS IS
TO PROVIDE RESOURCES NEEDED TO
PERFORM THE FORENSIC SERVICES
WORKLOAD THAT IS ASSOCIATED WITH
COURT DIRECTED PATIENT TREATMENT
RELATED TO SERVING.
PATIENTS FOR COMMITTED TO US IS
EITHER INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL NOT GUILTY BY REASON AND
SANITY IN INDIA OR SB P.
PATIENTS -- THIS PROPOSAL WILL
PROVIDE RESOURCES THAT ARE
NEEDED TO PERFORM THE FORENSIC
WORKLOAD WHICH INCLUDES FRIENDS
YOU CAN BUY YOU ASIANS REPORTING
TO THE COURT.
COURT TESTIMONY FRIENDS A CASE
MANAGEMENT DATA TRACKING INNER
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSESSMENT AND
TREATMENT -- SEVERAL YEARS AGO
WE INITIATED A COMPREHENSIVE
EFFORT TO EVALUATE OUR STAFFING
AMONGST THE FIVE STATE HOSPITALS
AND FOR AND AND TO PERFORM
CLINICAL STAFFING STUDIES WHICH
WAS COMPRISED OF FOUR COMPONENTS.
AND THIS PROPOSAL IS AS THE POP
AIDS ESTABLISHES POPULATION
DRIVEN METHODOLOGIES THAT ARE
THE OUTCOMES OF ONE OF THOSE
COMPONENTS THE HOSPITAL FORENSIC
DEPARTMENT.
AND IT INCORPORATES ALL THE DATA
AND RESEARCH THAT WAS CONDUCTED
BY OUR DS EIGHT RESEARCH TEAM
DURING THE STOPPING STUDY AND
THROUGH THE COLLABORATION WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
RESEARCH ANALYSIS UNIT THROUGH
THE MISSION BASED REVIEW WITH
OUR DEPARTMENT.
AND ADDITIONALLY -- WE DID
CONTRACT WITH CORPORATE PERSONAL
SERVICES TO CONDUCT AN
INDEPENDENT BY IT VALIDATION OF
THE STAFFING STUDY DATA AND
METHODOLOGIES THAT WERE
PRESENTED.
THERE'S THREE MAIN COMPONENTS TO
THIS PROPOSAL A IT REQUEST FIFTY
THREE POINT ONE FORENSIC
EVALUATOR POSITIONS FOR THE
HOSPITAL FRIENDS EX SRVICE
DEPARTMENTS THAT'S BASED IN
ACROSS THREE YEARS.
OF THESE DEPARTMENTS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE FRIENDS AGO
VIOLATIONS OF COURT REPORTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE FRIENDS LIKE
A PATIENT'S -- THIS FUNCTION
REQUIRES FRANTICALLY TRAINED
PSYCHOLOGISTS OR PSYCHIATRISTS
AND UNDERSTAND THE INTERSECTION
BETWEEN THE LAW AND THE
PHILOSOPHIES OF THE PRACTICE CAN
FORMER FRIENDS BECAUSE SUSSMAN
OF A PATIENT WHICH CAN INCLUDE
MENTAL COMPETENCY SYMPTOMS
DIAGNOSIS PROGRESSION AND
TREATMENT.
AND VIOLENCE RESTORED SELF AND
OTHERS AND THE PREPARE REPORTS
THE COURT AND TESTIFY IN COURT
TO COMMUNICATE AN UNBIASED
CLINICAL PERSPECTIVE OF THE
PATIENT AS IT RELATES TO THE
STATUTORY CRITERIA DIRECTING THE
FRIENDS A COMMITMENT.
THIS IS A VERY SIGNIFICANT
FUNCTION FOR SYSTEM LAST YEAR WE
SERVED OVER NINETY EIGHT HUNDRED
FORENSIC PATIENTS AND MAINTAIN
AN AVERAGE DAILY CENSUS OF OVER
FIFTY THREE HUNDRED FRIENDS OF
PATIENCE. FOR EACH FRIENDS A
COMMITMENT TYPE THEIR
STATUTORILY REQUIRED REPORTS
THAT PRESCRIBED TIED TIME
INCREMENTS WITH AN INPATIENT
STAY AT OUR DEPARTMENT.
LAST YEAR WE FILED APPROXIMATELY
ELEVEN THOUSAND REPORTS THE
COURT REGARDING OUR FRIEND SICK
PATIENTS -- ALSO -- INCLUDED IN
THIS -- COMPONENT IS SIXTEEN
POINT THREE ADMINISTRATIVE
POSITIONS -- FOR FRIENDS A CASE
MANAGEMENT AND DATA TRACKING
PHASED IN OVER TWO YEARS.
AND WITH ALL THE ACTIVITY AND
REPORTS THAT REPORTED -- FOR
THESE FRIENDS ARE -- PATIENTS
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
DATA AND TRACKING OF WHEN
REPORTS ARE DUE -- TO INSURE
THAT THE REPORTS ARE FILED
TIMELY ADDITIONALLY MANY
CLINICIANS ARE SUBPOENA AND
CALLED TO TESTIFY IN COURT
REGARDING THEIR EVALUATIONS
WHICH IS ALSO A FUNCTION THAT
REQUIRES COORDINATION AND
TRACKING.
SO THIS PROPOSAL DOES
STANDARDIZE THE ADMINISTRATIVE
POSITIONS ACROSS OUR HOSPITALS
PERFORM THIS WORKLOAD AND ALSO
PROVIDES MY POSITION AT EACH
HOSPITAL TO LEAD THE SUBPOENA
AND TEST MAY IN THE DATA
TRACKING.
THE THIRD COMPONENT OF THIS
PROPOSAL INCLUDES TWENTY FIVE
POINT SEVEN POSITIONS FOR
NEUROPSYCHOLOGY ASSESSMENTS AND
COGNITIVE REMEDIATION PILOT
PHASED IN OVER TWO YEARS.
THIS RECOGNIZES THE NEED FOR
INCREASED COGNITIVE ASSESSMENT
REMEDIATION TREATMENT FOR
PATIENTS MANY OF OUR PATIENTS
HAVE SIGNIFICANT COGNITIVE
DEFICITS AND CONTRIBUTE TO
REDUCE IT EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
CLINICAL TREATMENT AGGRESSIVE
ACTS OR IN A COULD CONTRIBUTE TO
LONGER THINKS OF STAY.
A CURRENT RESEARCH IDENTIFIES
THAT APPROXIMATELY 50% OF ALL
NEW MISSIONS MAY ACTUALLY
REQUIRE SECONDARIES
NEUROPSYCHOLOGY TESTING AND CAN
CERTAINLY THIS FOR YOU -- THESE
REQUESTED RESORT RESOURCES WILL
PROVIDE FOR TESTING FOR UP TO
ABOUT 25% OF ADMISSIONS.
ADDITIONALLY IT WILL ALSO ALLOW
US TO IMPLEMENT AN OR A
PSYCHOLOGICAL KIND OF
REMEDIATION TREAT A PILOT AT
METROPOLITAN AND NAPA.
AND THIS IS A FOCUS TREATMENT
PROGRAM FOR PATIENTS WHO HAVE
BEEN IDENTIFIED AS HAVING SIR A
SERIOUS EXCUSE ME SEVERE
NEUROCOGNITIVE DEFICITS.
AND IT WILL PROVIDE PRIORITIZE
PATIENTS WHO ARE AGGRESSIVE
LIKELY TO ACHIEVE RAPID BENEFIT
FROM THE INTERVENTION AND ARE
LIKELY TO IMPROVE THEIR
FUNCTIONALITY.
AND TREATMENT WILL BE DELIVERED
VIA COMPUTER BASED -- TREATMENT
PROGRAMS AND TREATMENT AND THREE
TREATMENT GROUPS.
AT THE PROPOSAL WE'RE HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU COMMENTS MY LAYOFF.
YES SO WITH RESPECT TO THE
CLINICIANS WHO'D BE DEDICATED TO
THE EVALUATIONS ONE OF THE
PRIMARY JUSTIFICATIONS AT THE
DEPARTMENT GAVE FOR THESE
CLINICIANS IS.
TO RESOLVE THE CONFLICT OF
INTEREST THAT EXISTS WHEN THESE
CLINICIANS CARRY OUT EVALUATIONS
FOR THEIR OWN PATIENTS.
WE THINK A PROMISING ALTERNATIVE
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING THIS
ISSUE IS TO HAVE THE CLINICIANS
CARRY OUT THESE EVALUATIONS AND
RELATED WORKLOAD FOR OTHER
CLINICIANS PATIENTS.
SO WE WOULD RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE NOT APPROVE THE
FUNDING. TO ATTACH TO THE
CLINICIANS AND INSTEAD DIRECT
THE DEPARTMENT TO PILOT THIS
PEER REVIEW APPROACH THAT I
DESCRIBED ON IN ADDITION WITH
RESPECT TO THE FRIENDS A CASE
MANAGEMENT AND DATA TRACKING
POSITIONS -- THE DEPARTMENT
WASN'T ABLE TO PROVIDE US WITH
DATA SHOWING THAT THEIR EXISTING
STAFF WERE UNABLE TO HANDLE THE
WORKLOAD.
AND SO FOR THAT REASON WE'RE NOT
RECOMMENDING THAT IN ADDITION
THERE WAS -- SOME ADDITIONAL
STAFF THAT WERE BEING
RECOMMENDED TO HELP REFINE THIS
STAFFING STANDARDS THAT WOULD
DRIVE THE CLINICIANS AND I SPOKE
ABOUT EARLIER SINCE WE'RE NOT
RECOMMENDING APPROVING THOSE
POSITIONS.
pNECESSARY.
WITH RESPECT TO THE FUNDING
PROPOSED FOR THE NTERNAL
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSESSMENTS.
GIVEN THAT THIS CAN BE AN
EFFECTIVE WAY TO IDENTIFY
VIOLENT PATIENTS AND IMPROVE
TREATMENT WE DO RECOMMEND
FUNDING THAT PART OF THE
PROPOSAL.
AND FINALLY WITH RESPECT TO THE
COGNITIVE REMEDIATION PILOT WELL
WE THINK IT'S A PROMISING
APPROACH WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
ON GOING FUNDING FOR A PILOT AND
SO INSTEAD WE RECOMMENDED THAT
THE FUNDING BE PROVIDED ON A
LIMITED TERM BASIS.
AND THAT A REPORTING REQUIREMENT
BE PUT IN PLACE.
I THANK YOU FINANCE ALLEN'S ARMY
YES I I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
THIS -- THIS B. C. P. IS THE
OUTCOME OF A MISSION BASED --
REVIEW PROJECT -- TO WITH THAT
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS SO --
TO BERMAN FINANCE WAS OF MUCH
MORE ENGAGED IN SERVE HELPING
DEVELOP AND AND WORK THROUGH
THIS PROPOSAL THAN WE ARE WITH
MOST -- IN RESPONSE TO THE LA
GOES -- COMMENTS -- SO AND
MANAGING IS A PEER REVIEW IS
THAT THE WOULD HAVE A TREATING A
CLINICIAN BOTH SERVING THEIR OWN
PATIENTS AND THEN ALSO SORT OF
DOING THESE FRIENDS OF
VALUATIONS OF OTHER --
CLINICIANS PATIENTS -- BASICALLY
AT IT WITHIN THE CURRENT THE WAY
CURRENTLY CURRENTLY THAT WOULD
WORK THAT WOULD MEAN WE
BASICALLY NEED ADDITIONAL
PSYCHIATRISTS IN ORDER TO DO
THAT RIGHT TO HAVE A TREATING
CLINICIAN PSYCHIATRIST AND THEN
THAT PSYCHIATRISTS LITTLE
SWEETNESS FRIENDS CASE LORD.
CASELOAD I THINK ELLIE --
RECOGNIZES THAT WE WOULD NEED
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS FOR THAT
BECAUSE STATE HOUSE WAS NEVER
REALLY BEEN STOPPED FOR THIS
FORENSIC THIS THIS GREAT OF OUR
FRIENDS A CASELOAD -- WE JUST
KNOW THAT PSYCHIATRISTS ARE VERY
DIFFICULT TO GET ON THE AND
FORENSIC PSYCHOLOGISTS.
ARE US SIGNIFICANTLY EASIER TO
SORTOF HIGHER -- AND SO WE WE
THINK OUR PROPOSAL WOULD SORT OF
MEET THIS NEED -- MUCH MORE
EFFICIENTLY AND CHEAPER I MIGHT
ADD -- ON THE CASE MANAGEMENT
PIECE ON THE WAY THERE ARE
EXISTING STAFF WITH THE AND
STATE HOSPITALS ARE DOING SOME
OF THIS FRIENDS SIX OR THE
MINISTRY OF CASE MANAGEMENT
WORKLOAD AND WE DID ACCOUNT FOR
ALL OF THOSE EXISTING STOP IN
OUR PROPOSAL -- THIS OULD BE
ACCOUNTING -- FOR TIMES WHEN
THERE ISN'T DEDICATED STAFF TO
FRIENDS WORKLOAD IT'S KIND OF
BEING DIGGING UP AMONGST THE
POSITIONS OR ADMINISTRATIVE
STUFF THAT HAD OTHER DUTIES.
SO WE REALLY DID -- PLACE THESE
SORT OF CASE MANAGEMENT
ADMINISTRATIVE PEOPLE WHERE WE
DIDN'T REALLY HAVE EXISTING
RESOURCES I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT
THIS IS ALL THIS REPORTING TO
THE COURT AND ALL THE TRACKING A
HOUSE TO BE DONE IT'S NOT
OPTIONAL -- AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT YOU HAVE ADMINISTRATIVE
POSITIONS DOING IT IT'S MUCH
CHEAPER THAN HAVING CLINICIANS
DO IT -- AND ON THEN NEURO PSYCH
ON THAT WE DON'T HAVE ANY
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS ABOUT --
APPROACHING THIS ON A PILOT
BASIS.
SO I ACTUALLY ANY FURTHER OF
COLOR FELLOW FROM WHAT FINANCE
SAID.
THE ONLY THE ONLY THING I WOULD
SAY IT'S IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT
RELIC WHICH APPROACH WOULD BE
MORE OR LESS COSTLY THINK THAT'S
PART OF WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS
FIGURE OUT IN THE PILOT --
BECAUSE WE ALREADY HAVE
PSYCHIATRISTS CARRYING OUT THIS
WORKLOAD WE JUST HAVE THEM CARRY
OUT THIS WORK LOAD.
FOR OTHER PSYCHIATRISTS PATIENTS
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THAT COULD
CREATE A SITUATION WHERE -- IT
REQUIRES A LITTLE BIT OF
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD SO THERE MAY
BE ON THE MARGINS THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL PSYCHIATRIST BUT IT'S
NOT CLEAR TO US THAT THAT WOULD
BE MORE EXPENSIVE THAN THE
PSYCHOLOGISTS ARE RECOMMENDING.
OKAY SO JUST TO CLARIFY BECAUSE
CURRENTLY I MEAN THE RECOGNIZE
THAT.
THIS IS NOT AN ACCEPTABLE
SITUATION IS IS THAT
PSYCHIATRISTS ARE BOTH TAKING
CARE OF THEIR PATIENTS
[inaudible]
IN.
REVIEWING THE CASES RIGHT AND
YOU'RE SAYING WE NEED TO
SEPARATE THE TWO AND THAT MAKES
SENSE BUT IN TERMS OF WORKLOAD.
THEIR RATE DOING BOTH SO.
THAT'S ENTREES SO SO I MEAN IT'S
GREAT THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
NO SO I AM LOOKING AT THIS AND
SAYING THERE'S A LOT OF EXTRA
PEOPLE INVOLVED.
AND NOT SAYING THAT DOWN AND THE
THAT IS SO FROM A WORKLOAD
STANDPOINT.
THEN WE TAKE OFF THE PART THAT
THEY'RE REVIEWING AROUND
PATIENTS THAN EITHER THEY CAN
SEE MORE PATIENTS WITH THAT
EXTRA TIME OR THEY CAN REVIEW
SOMEONE ELSE'S THE CELL OR I
GUESS THAT'S ARE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HERE ARE YOU SAYING
THAT WELL ACTUALLY WE ARE SO
SHORT.
THEY'LL HAVE PLENTY OF EXTRA
PATIENTS TO SEE AN OWNERSHIP
THIS TO SOMEBODY ELSE.
I MEAN AT THE ESSENTIALLY YES I
MEAN WITH PSYCHIATRISTS ARE ARE
READY IS SORT OF COVERING MORE
THAN ONE UNIT WHERE IDEALLY WE'D
LIKE TO HAVE A PSYCHIATRIST PER
UNIT AND ON TOP OF THAT THEY'RE
DOING THIS FORENSIC -- CASELOAD
WHICH SOMETIMES REQUIRES THEM TO
ACTUALLY GO TO COURT AND TESTIFY
IN COURT WHICH THEN PULLS ME
AWAY FROM THE FLORIDA THOSE
THOSE CELLS LIKE ACTUALLY YOUR
SOLUTION IS.
TO REMOVE THE PSYCHIATRISTS FROM
THE COURT YEAH HE'S.
A PSYCHIATRIST TO DO THE
TREATMENT PART OF THEIR JOB AND
BE ABLE TO DO IT BETTER AND MORE.
SORT OF MORE EFFECTIVE USE OF
THE PSYCHIATRISTS THAT WE DO
HAPPENS REFUSAL LATELY JUST OKAY
YES FINANCE NO I WOULD JUST
ADDING CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG
HERE BUT I BELIEVE THESE --
CLINICIANS ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
WRITING THE REPRTS AND THEN
GOING TO COURT AND TESTIFYING.
ON THOSE PATIENTS AS WELL AND SO
THERE'S LIKE.
I THINK THAT I I NEED TO BE A
DIVIDE OF THAT CONFLICT OF
INTEREST OF THEM RIGHT IN THE
REPORTS I THINK.
DR WARBURTON PRICE BECAUSE UPON
A LITTLE BETTER THAN I JUST SOME
GENERAL POINTS ABOUT FRIENDS
LIKE A VALUATIONS THESE ARE --
ASSESSMENTS EVALUATIONS
REPORTING AND TESTIMONY WHICH
ARE ALL SKILLS AND ABILITIES
THAT ARE NOT TAUGHT IN ANY
GENERAL RESIDENCY OR PSYCHOLOGY
TRAINING PROGRAM -- IT REQUIRES
A LOT OF POST.
GENERAL TRAINING -- EITHER IN A
FELLOWSHIP OR IN A POST DOC OF
FRIENDS A POSTDOC EXPERIENCE SO
IN ADDITION TO THE ISSUES OF
DUAL AGENCY.
WHERE THE LITERATURES CLEAR THAT
IF YOU HAVE A PATIENT THAT
YOU'RE TREATING?
AND YOUR DUTY IS TO THAT
PATIENTS -- THERE'S A CONFLICT
IF YOU'RE ALSO DOING FRIENDS
EVALUATION WHICH YOUR DUTY IS TO
THE COURT -- SO YOU HAVE JUST
NOT JUST THE DUAL AGENCY ISSUE
WHICH I'M NOT SURE WOULD BE
RESOLVED BY THE LA -- SUGGESTION
BECAUSE OUR PATIENT MOVEMENT IS
SO COMPLEX NUMBER DEDUCTIBLE
THERE'S NO SAYING THAT IF YOU'RE
THE EVALUATOR TODAY WON'T BE THE
TRIGGER TOMORROW.
BUT THERE ARE THE ADDITIONAL IT --
ISSUES OF A LACK OF TRAINING --
THAT ARE A GENERAL PSYCHIATRIST
OR PSYCHOLOGIST HAS AS WELL AS
JUST SKILLS AND ABILITIES -- NOT
EVERYONE WHO ON THOSE INTO
MEDICINE IS GOOD AT DOING
FORENSIC VALUATIONS WRITING
REPORTS AND TESTIFYING IN WE HAD
HAD SOME ISSUES WITH THAT
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
SO.
SO WHY YOU USE USES A
PSYCHIATRIST THEMSELVES TO
SHOULD BE DOING ON THERE ARE
PATIENTS ARE DOING A GOOD JOB AT
IT.
IT WAS. TO A GENERAL SURGEON
DOING HER TRANSPLANT IT'S JUST
SOMETHING YOU HAVE SOME
FOUNDATIONAL TRAINING FOR BUT
YOU DON'T HAVE THE ADDITIONAL
SUBSPECIALTY TRAINING
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SO I GUESS WHAT'S HELPFUL IS TO
GET A BETTER SENSE OF REALLY
WHAT IS THE SONG I KNOW YOU WENT
THROUGH THIS TO TO THE BETTER
SENSE OF THE WERE THE EXACTLY
WHAT IS THE WORKLOAD SO WHAT.
I'M HEARING NOW AND I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER YOU GOT THE INFORMATION
FROM THE ALEJO'S IS THAT WHAT
YOU'RE WHAT YOU'RE REALLY DOING
IS SAYING OKAY WE WANT TO TAKE
THE PSYCHIATRISTS.
HAVING JUST FOCUS ON PATIENT
CARE RGHT.
RIGHT AND THEN BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH OF THEM SELL WOODS
SO WHY SHOULD WE OWE IT WILL
EXPAND OUR WORK FORCE WE WENT TO
BECAUSE THE CHARACTERS HAVE AND
JUST FOCUS ON THE PATIENT CARE
PIECE.
AND THEN THIS FORENSIC
EVALUATION PIECE WE'RE GOING TO
BRING IN A WHOLE BUNCH OF
FORENSIC PSYCHOLOGISTS NEW
PEOPLE.
AND HAVE THEM JUST DO THAT PARTS
WERE SIR BIFURCATING THE JOB
HERERIGHT AND TELLS THE
CHARACTERS TO THE PSYCHIATRY
PART AND HAVE THE FORENSIC
PSYCHOLOGIST TO THE FORENSIC
PIECE AND THEN.
YEAH.
SO YES SO ESSENTIALLY UNDER THE
LA -- APPROACH TO THIS -- WE'D
BE A LOT.
CLOSER TO OUR CURRENT SYSTEM THE
ONLY BIG CHANGES THAT.
CLINICIANS WOULD DO THAT
WORKLOAD FOR OTHER CLINICIANS
PATIENTS RATHER THAN THEIR OWN
SO WELL LET ME JUST POSE THE
QUESTION I MEAN.
SO THE THE OTHER BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE TWO IS IS THAT
ACTUALLY THE THE PARTS THEY
HOSPITALS ARGUING THAT.
THE CURRENT WORKFORCE ISN'T
SUFFICIENT ENOUGH TO START WITH
RIGHT SO WE'RE THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
ADDING PEOPLE RIGHT AND THEY SAY
THAT THE MOST EFFECTIVE THING IS
THAT FORENSIC PSYCHOLOGISTS
VERSUS.
GETTING MORE PSYCHIATRISTS SAID
THAT THAT.
I MEAN IS THAT IT DID WAS THAT
SOMETHING YOU LOOKED AT IN TERMS
OF SO I AGREE THAT YOU'RE
PROCESSING THAT ACTUALLY LEAVES
THE WORK FORCE ABOUT THE SAME
THEY'RE SAYING ACTUALLY ONE
EXPAND THE WORK FORCE -- AND AND
THIS IS OUR APPROACH TO DO IT
RIGHT RIGHT AND SO UNDER OUR
APPROACH WE WOULDN'T EXPAND THE
THE WORK FORCE AT LEAST NOT AT
THE TO THE EXTREME EXTEND IT
COULD BE THAT YOU NEED A FEW
ADDITIONAL TANK TO HANDLE IT --
BUT THAT BUT ESSENTIALLY -- WE
DIDN'T FEEL THAT WE WERE
PROVIDED WITH SUFFICIENT DATA TO
SHOW THAT THERE IS A NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL PSYCHIATRISTS THAT
THE CURRENT PSYCHIATRISTS ARE
ARE INSUFFICIENT.
AND NOW I UNDERSTAND YOU DID DO
A WHOLE BIG STUDY RIGHT YEAH WE
DID DO A WHOLE BIG STUDY -- AND
I DON'T REALLY STATE HOSPITALS
THAT DID A LOT OF GROUNDWORK
BEFORE WE EVEN GOT THERE RIGHT
SO WHAT THEY DID -- A LOT OF ON
ACTUAL SORT OF IN DEPTH ANALYSIS
OF WHAT ACTUALLY THE FORENSIC
WORKLOAD IS AND WE HAVE TONS AND
TONS OF METRIC SAYING EXACTLY
HOW MUCH TIME YOU SHARE THAT
WITH LA -- THEN TO THE WOULD
HAVE THAT INFORMATION IT'S THE
IT'S INCLUDED AS ATTACHMENTS TO
THE B. C. B. SO [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
YES.
YEAH.
ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE ARE LOOKING
FOR IS WHAT ADDITIONAL --
BENEFIT COULD WE EXPECT FROM
CLINICIANS BEING ABLE TO
DEDICATE MORE TIME TO THEIR
PATIENTS WOULD WE SEE LINK TO
STAY GO DOWN WHAT WE SEE
TREATMENT IMPROVE.
AND THAT WAS THE SORT OF THING
THAT WE'RE FOR A SO MAYBE WE CAN
HAVE SOME COMMUNICATIONS DECLARE
FITTED TO TO CLARIFY THE
BENEFITS SO.
OF THE EXTRA CLINICIAN HAPPY TO
MEET WITH LA ON THIS ONE ANYTIME
OKAY ALL RIGHT OKAY.
VERY HELPFUL OKAY [inaudible]
THAT'S A AND I THINK ON A EIGHT
I THINK ON THE PILE ON THE ISSUE
THE PILOT THAT CERTAINLY WE
WOULD I DEFINITELY WANT TO
REPORT.
ON THE PILOT SO IT'S A THE CARD
IN REMEDIATION PILOT CELL.
USUALLY A PILOT WOULD BE OF A
FIXED TIME WITH THE REPORT THEN
WE DECIDE WHAT DO I CONTINUE
FUNDING IT BASED ON THAT REPORT
CELL.
RIGHT.
OKAY ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN DIRECT
CARE NURSING [inaudible]
SABRINA.
WELCOME.
INTRODUCE YOURSELF FOR THE
RECORD.
MY CHANNEL OUTER A CHIEF OF THIS
GONE PROGRAM RESEARCH THANK YOU.
THIS ITEM REQUESTING THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE POINT
FIVE NURSING POSITIONS AND FORTY
FIVE MILLION.
A IN GENERAL FUND PHASED IN OVER
THREE YEARS TO SUPPORT THE
WORKLOAD OF PROVIDING THE TWENTY
FOUR HOUR CARE NURSING SERVICES
AT THE FIVE HOSPITALS.
THE REQUEST ALSO INCLUDES TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR TEMPAT
POSITIONS AND FIFTY
ADMINISTRATIVE POSITIONS HE'S
OUR POSITIONS ONLY NO DOLLARS.
TO IMPLEMENT THE STAFFING
STANDARDS IDENTIFIED IN THE
STAFFING STUDY.
AS WITH THE PREVIOUS STOPPING
STUDY WE JUST DISCUSSED THE
STAFFING STANDARDS PROPOSED --
ARE BASED ON DATA THAT WAS
COLLECTED AND AT THE RESEARCH
CONDUCTED BARI OUR RESEARCH TEAM
IS LED BY MISS LOUDER.
AND WORKED THEM WITH THEIR WORK
IN COLLABORATION WITH THE LAUGHS
I RESEARCH ANALYSIS UNIT AGAIN
THROUGH THE MISSION BASED REVIEW
PROCESS.
AND WE ALSO CONTRACTED WITH
UNIVERSITY OF IRVINE TO PERFORM
AN INTAMIN INDEPENDENT
VALIDATION OF THE DATA AND
METHODOLOGIES THAT WERE
PRESENTED IN THE BUDGET PROPOSAL.
CURRENTLY BUDGETED FOR NURSING
STAFFING RATIOS -- AT FOR Q. AND
SKILLED NURSING UNITS -- ON AM
AND PM AT ONE TO SIX AND FOR
KNOCK ONE TO TWELVE AN
INTERMEDIATE UNITS OF ONE TO
EIGHT ON AND I AM AND PM AND FOR
KNOCK.
ONE TO SIXTEEN THESE RE ISSUES
OR THE MINIMUM NURSING STAFFING
REQUIRED UNDER OR THEY'RE A CUT
CALIFORNIA CODE OF REGULATIONS
TITLE. TWENTY TWO TO MAINTAIN
REGULATORY COMPLIANCE HOWEVER
DUE TO OUR PSYCHIATRIC AND
MEDICAL NEEDS OF OUR PATIENTS.
AND THE VIOLENCE RISK ASSOCIATED
WITH THE PATIENTS ACTUAL NURSING
STAFF THAT WE DELIVER IS HIGHER
THAN WHAT WE'VE TO TRADITIONALLY
BEEN BUDGETED.
FOR THE STAFFING STUDY
CATEGORIZE OUR HOSPITAL
TREATMENT UNITS IN TWO GROUPS
BASED ON VARIABLES THAT DRIVE
STOPPING LEVEL SUCH AS TREATMENT
TYPE AND COMMITMENT TYPE.
AND WE LOOKED ACROSS -- SIX
MONTH OF ACTUAL STAFF A DELIVER
DATA TO CALCULATE SYSTEM WIDE
STAFF TO PATIENT REVIEWS FOR
EACH GROUP TO BE USED IN PLACE
OF THE CURRENT STAFFING RATIOS.
SO THE SPECIFIC COMPONENTS F
THE FUNDING IN POSITION REQUEST
INCLUDE -- FIRST OF ALL THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIAN POSITIONS AND THIS IS
INCLUDING RELIEF TO STAFF.
TWELVE OUR MEDICATION ROOM POSTS
ON A HUNDRED TWENTY UNITS
BUFFETS IN OVER THREE YEARS TO
PERFORM FUNCTIONS ASSOCIATED
WITH MEDICATION PASS.
A MEDICATION PASSED A CURSE FOUR
TIMES PER DAY AND MAY LAST UP TO
TWO HOURS PER PASS.
THERE'S MANY FUNCTIONS THAT
INCLUDE A FOR PREPARATION
ADMINISTERING AND DOCUMENTATION
AND ULTIMATELY MANAGING THE
MEDICATION.
DISTRIBUTION OF PROCESS --
WITHIN THE UNIT -- WE ALSO
CURRENTLY THE PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS THAT PERFORM THIS
FUNCTION ARE INCLUDED IN OUR OF
RATIOS AND WE ARE PROPOSING
BECAUSE THE AMOUNT OF TIME THAT
THEY NEED TO PERFORM THIS TASK --
TO PULL THEM OUT OF THE COUNT
AND PROVIDE THIS AS AN ACT
SENATE INTENTIONAL -- POSITION
ADD TO ALLOW MORE STUFF TO
REMAIN ON THE FLOOR AND TO
PROVIDE SERVICES IN ADDITION TO
THOSE POSITIONS THE PROPOSAL
INCLUDES FORTY FOUR POINT FIVE
SUPERVISING REGISTERED NURSE
POSITIONS INCLUDING RELIEF.
AND THIS IS TO STAFF ADDITIONAL
TWELVE HOUR POST TO PROVIDE ON
SITE SUPERVISION HONOR PM INOX
SHIPS AND THESE POSITIONS WHAT
ARE PROPOSED TO BE PHASED IN
OVER TWO YEARS.
CURRENTLY THE UNIT SUPERVISORS
AND SUPERVISING REGISTERED
NURSES SERVE AS THE FIRST LINE
SUPERVISORS FOR FACILITIES OF
WITH ONE ALLOCATED PER UNIT
HOWEVER THE SUPERVISORS ARE --
SCHEDULED FOR A FIVE DAY PER
WEEK POSITIONS AND SO BUT THEY
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
CONTINUOUS MANAGEMENT SUPERVISED
VISION ON THEIR UNIT ON A TWENTY
FOUR HOUR BASIS.
SO WHILE THERE ARE SHIFTS LEANS
ASSIGNED TO EACH UNIT THEY'RE
NOT SUPERVISORY POSITIONS SO
CURRENTLY FOR THAN I AM PM AND
KNOCK SHIPS WE DO USE AN ON CALL
POSITION TO PROVIDE THE THE
SUPERVISORY -- TO PERFORM
SUPERVISORY FUNCTIONS AND TO
ADDRESS PROBLEMS THAT OCCUR IN
THE NIGHT.
SO THIS PROPOSAL WENT OUT A
TOTAL OF SEVENTEEN TWELVE HOUR
I'M SUPERVISOR POSTS ACROSS THE
FIVE HOSPITALS TO COVER THOSE
SHIPS -- WHICH WILL EXPAND ON
SITE SUPERVISORS FROM EIGHT
HOURS TO TWENTY HOURS PER DAY
COVERAGE AT OUR FACILITIES.
IN ADDITION TO THOSE TO REQUEST.
FOR ADDITIONAL UNIT BASED
POSITIONS -- WE ALSO HOW ARE
REQUESTING THAT BY TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY FOUR TEN HELP POSITIONS
THESE ARE JUST -- POSITIONS ONLY
AND THIS IS TO INCREASE THAT ARE
TEMP HELP THE FORTY TO REGULATE
RECOGNIZE THE USAGE LEVELS WE
CURRENTLY THAT WE USE INTO IT.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
AND THEN ALSO POSITION FORTY
ONLY FOR FIFTY ADMINISTRATIVE
POSITIONS AND THIS IS WE ADDED
LOOKED ACROSS ALL OF OUR AND
MINUTE A NURSING CLASSIFICATIONS
TO SEE IF THEY WERE REPORTING --
POSITIONS THAT COULD BE BETTER
PERFORMED BY ADMINISTRATIVE
POSITIONS AS A THIS WOULD ALLOW
US I AM -- TOO FILL THOSE WITH
ADMINISTRATIVE FOLKS AND THEN
RETURN THE NURSING POSITIONS
BACK TO THE UNITS.
AND THEN FINALLY WE PROPOSE TO
REALIGN STOPPING RESOURCES
ACROSS THE HOSPITALS TO MEET THE
STAFFING LEVELS THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED IN THE STAFFING STUDY
WHICH INCLUDES BOUNCING ALL OF
OUR AUTHORIZED POSITIONS ACROSS
THE HOSPITAL SAID THAT THE
POSITIONS ARE MORE EQUITABLY
DISTRIBUTED.
THANK YOU COMMENTS FROM ILLEGAL.
YES SO WE RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS
A VERY IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD
FOR THE DEPARTMENT WE THINK A
LOT OF THE ADJUSTMENTS THAT ARE
BEING PROPOSED ARE.
A WAY TO BRING A LOT OF GREAT
GREATER DEAL TRANSPARENCY TO THE
BUDGET AND SO WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED THE
PROPOSED STANDARDIZATION OF
NURSING STAFFING RATIOS.
THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY FOR
TEMPORARY HELP POSITIONS IN THE
DEDICATED BUDGET FOR OVERTIME
AND THE FIFTY ADMINISTRATIVE
STAFF TO REDUCE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE WORKLOAD THAT'S
CURRENTLY CARRIED OUT BY NURSES.
HOWEVER WE ARE SOMEWHAT -- WE
WOULD NOTE THAT THE CURRENT
STAFF THEY OR THEIR STAFFING
RATIOS THAT ARE BEING PROPOSED
ARE REFLECTIVE OF CURRENT
PRACTICE WHICH HAS NOT BEEN
EVALUATED DETERMINE WHETHER OR
NOT IT'S OPTIMAL.
AND IN FACT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IRVINE RESEARCHERS
THAT WERE USED TO VALIDATE THE
STUDY NOTED THAT IT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO
REVIEW STAFFING IN THE FUTURE TO
ENSURE THAT IT IS OPTIMAL.
ARM AND SO WE'RE RECOMMENDING
THAT THE LEGISLATURE ALSO
DIRECTED THE DEPARTMENT TO
CONTRACT WITH AN INDEPENDENT
CONSULTANT. TO ASSESS WHETHER OR
NOT THE STAFFING BOTH FOR NURSES
AND FOR THE PART MORE GENERALLY
IS -- OPTIMAL AND TO REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT TO THE REPORT THE
READER THE RESULTS OF THAT
ANALYSIS.
WITH RESPECT TO THE PROPOSED
DEDICATED STAFFING FOR
MEDICATION ROOMS WERE
RECOMMENDING -- THAT INSTEAD OF
IMPLEMENTING THIS ON ON ACROSS
ALL FIVE HOSPITALS THAT WE DO IT
ON A PILOT BASIS BECAUSE IT
REPRESENTS A SUBSTANTIAL
INVESTMENT.
AND IT WASN'T CLEAR TO US THAT
THE BLAKELY BENEFITS THAT THAT
ARE THAT THE BENEFITS OF THE
DEPARTMENT IS HOPING FOR WOULD
BE OBTAINED.
SO WE'D RECOMMEND IS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED SEVEN POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS FOR THREE
YEARS WHICH WOULD BE.
ENOUGH TO STAFF -- TWENTY FOUR
MEDICATION ROOMS WHICH WOULD
GIVE THE DEPARTMENT ABILITY TO
STOP THESE PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS ACROSS A WIDE
VARIETY OF UNIT TYPES.
ON AND THEN EXAMINE WHETHER OR
NOT IT DOES RESULT IN THE
BENEFITS THAT ARE HOPE FOR LIKE
BUT YOU KNOW REDUCTIONS IN
VIOLENCE IN AN IMPROVEMENT IN
OUR COMES.
WITH RESPECT TO THE EVENING AND
OVERNIGHT SUPERVISORS WE THINK
THAT THIS IS A REASONABLE NEED
AND WOULD RECOMMEND APPROVAL.
THANK YOU FINANCE AND THIS WAS
ALSO ONE OF THE MISSIONBASED I
REVIEW PROJECTS WE WORKED ON
THIS -- KICKED OFF I BELIEVE IN
TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN WITH A
VERY ON LINKING ANSWER --
THOROUGH SURVEY OF THE STATE
HOSPITALS IN THEIR STAFFING
RATIOS -- AND THEN YOU SEE YOU
SEE IRVINE CAME IN FOR A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TIME
VISITED SEVERAL HOSPITALS -- AND
SPENT A LOT OF TIME WORKING WITH
STATE HOSPITALS ON THE PROPOSAL --
AND THEN -- MY TEAM CAME IN AND
AND SPENT ABOUT A YEAR WORKING
WITH STATE HOSPITALS ON THIS SO.
IN MY FIFTEEN YEARS OF FINANCES
IS PROBABLY THE BEST ANALYZE B.
C. P. I'VE I'VE EVER DONE IT SO --
I I DON'T KNOW THAT ANOTHER SORT
OF INDEPENDENT -- ANALYSIS OR
CONSULTANT ONE WOULD REALLY SORT
OF YIELD DIFFERENT RESULTS I'M
ALSO NOT SURE WOULD BE ABLE TO
FIND SOMEONE WITH THAT.
EXPERTISE ON STATE HOSPITALS TO
TO DO SUCH A AN EVALUATION --
IT'S A SORT OF A NICHE -- FIELD.
AND IT'S A GOOD USE IT TOOK A
LOT OF PEOPLE JUST A LONG TIME
TO GET UP SPEED ON SORT OF WHAT
THE OPERATIONS ARE OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE HOSPITALS -- I
WOULD ALSO.
NOTE THAT IT'S WHEN WE LOOK AT
SORT OF WHAT THE STATE HOSPITAL
STAFFING RATIOS WERE -- THEY ARE
FAR BELOW THE AVERAGE -- THAT
JUROR THAT HAVE -- PRIDING
DIRECT CARE STAFF BEING ON THE
UNITS -- AS COMPARED TO THE US
OR OTHER HOSPITALS IN THE
WESTERN PSYCHIATRIC STATE
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WE'RE SORT
OF AT THE BOTTOM OF THE PACK.
IN TERMS OF WRITING DIRECT CARE
TO PATIENTS -- I WOULD ALSO NOTE
THAT THE PROPOSAL -- BEFORE US
ALSO BRINGS -- US UP TO SERVE
THE AVERAGE -- STAFFING LEVELS
ARE PROVIDED ON PSYCHIATRIC
UNITS AT ACUTE CARE HOSPITALS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WAS BASED ON IT
UC DAVIS STUDY THAT WAS DONE.
SO -- AND THEN THIRDLY I WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT -- AT THE RATE
SAID AFTER MILLION WORKERS COMP
AMONG THE NURSING --
CLASSIFICATIONS IS A HOUSEHOLDS
ARE EXTREMELY HIGH SIGNIFICANTLY
HIGHER THAN THAT OF OUR
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS AT OUR
PRISONS -- AND WE FEEL LIKE A
COMBINATION OF ALL OF THOSE
MEANS THAT SOMETHING SIGNIFICANT
NEEDS TO BE DONE IT'S PROBABLY
NEED TO BE DONE FOR FOR QUITE
SOME TIME [inaudible]
HEY.
RIGHT WELL IT IS CERTAINLY A OF
CREATURE THAT THIS IS A VERY
THOROUGHLY ANALYZED THE C. P. --
AND EIGHT DAY PRE SHEET THAT.
SEE HOSPITALS I MEAN THE ONLY
THIS PROPOSALS FOR USEFUL
ANYWHERE THE REALLY LOOKING AT
THE STAFFING -- I WOULD.
THE I THINK WHAT I HEARD FROM
THE LA -- WAS NOT THAT LET'S
REDO THE EVALUATE BUT LET'S DO
OF AT ONCE AFTER WE IMPLEMENT
LET'S.
LET'S VALUE EIGHT HOW ALL THIS
IS GOING IS THE IS NOW THAT
WE'VE DONE THIS.
YOU KNOW HOW OR WHERE ARE WE
SELL MAEVE INVOLVED THE SAME
EVALUATORS WHO RIGHT NOW THOUGH
ALL THE PROCESS EASIER NOW THAT
YOU'RE ACTUALLY.
OF THE VETTING AND VARIOUS PUBS
CAN HAPPEN IN THE ROAD RIGHT SO
YOU CREEK VACANCIES YOU TALK
ABOUT RECRUITING HOUSE BECAUSE
WE IN THE RECRUITING -- THAT'S
ADDRESS ARE AND EIGHTIES PEOPLE
ARE NOW LOOKING AT IT THEN
THEY'RE GOING WELL MAYBE WE
COULD DO THINGS A LITTLE
DIFFERENTLY FEEL MORE EFFICIENT --
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT AND IT'S
GIVEN THE SIZE AND SCOPE OF OF
OF THIS.
EFFORT TO AND AND STAFFING --
ILL SOME REVIEW AFTER
IMPLEMENTATION TO SEE HOW HOW
THINGS ARE GOING WHERE WE
ACTUALLY ENDED UP SO I KNOW
YOU'RE ASKING FOR THE MONEY IN
THE POSITIONS NOW EXACTLY HOW
THAT ALL PLAYS OUT IN THE END.
THE IT IT THIS TRIAL THE THING
WORST SIDE REAL IT'S TAKES A
LITTLE MORE MONEY TO DO THAT.
YEAH I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT --
STATE HOSPITALS HAS A RESEARCH
UNIT ACTUALLY THAT RIGHT WAS
BASICALLY DIDN'T ALL THE HAVING
LIFTING ON THIS AND THAT IS THE
GOAL AND THE INTENTION IS TO
SORT OF CONTINUE TO EVALUATE.
HOW THIS IS WORKING WHAT IMPACT
DOES IT HAVE A VIOLENCE WHAT MAX
IS A HOUSE ON ON FMLA WORKERS
COMP ALL OF THOSE IS SO IT IS
OFFERING A BILL REQUIRING THE
REPORT VIOLENT INCIDENTS YES
SAVED THAT THE YEAH?
RIGHT SO SO -- SO THAT IS ALWAYS
BEEN SORT OF A GOAL IS SORT OF
CONTINUING TO LOOK AT THIS AND
ALSO AS POPULATIONS CHANGE MAY
BE YOU KNOW DOWN THE ROAD WE
HAVE A DIFFERENT MIX OF UNITS
THAN WE HAVE RIGHT NOW AND AND
WE NEED. TO SHIFT TO AND
REEVALUATE SO IT'S NOT INTENDED
TO BE SORT OF THE PERFECT
PICTURE OF WHAT THE STAFFING
NEEDS TO BE AND AND WE STAY ON
FOREVER MORE AT SECOND ROW THAT
WE GOT THIS METHODOLOGY RENT
CONTINUE TO EVALUATE AND SO SO I
GUESS I WOULD -- THAT'S THE AS
FOR DELLY IS RECOMMENDATION THAT
SOME FORM OF THE VALUATION POSE
STILL OVER THIS WILL BE IN THE
CLOSE OF LIMITATION BE DONE SO
WE CAN SEE THERE ARE SOME THINGS
MAY CHANGE I MEAN AFTER ALL
THERE.
ARE PROPOSALS EVEN TO TRY -- TO
SO IT WITH THINGS MAY CHANGE AND
AND THAT NOW THAT YOU FOR THE WE
APPROVE THIS.
THE BUDGET THEN AFTER ITS
IMPLEMENTATION EXACTLY HOW WHAT
HOW HOW YOU DOING RIGHT WHERE
WHERE WE AND MEAN IDEALLY -- YOU
PUT OUT THE OF MONEY AND YOU
PEOPLE YOU FIND PEOPLE AND THEY
FILL ALL THE POSITIONS RIGHT
AWAY AND EVERYTHING'S ALL HUNKY
DORY BUT THEN ALSO HAPPY RIGHT
AWAY THAT IS ACTIVE EXACTLY I I
I I KNOW IT DOESN'T DATE SO
ACTUALLY WHY WE DID THE OTHER
PROPOSAL.
ON RECRUITMENT AND TO HAVE
BECAUSE WE THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE TRYING TO GET INTO THESE
NURSING PROGRAMS ARE
COMMUNICABLE JUST WE JUST DON'T
HAVE.
ENOUGH SPACE IN THE CLASSES OF
THOSE REALLY TO KIND OF WENT
HAND IN HAND WITH THIS OFFICIAL
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY.
OKAY LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
FULL SCHOOL WHICH IS PHARMACY
MODERNIZATION.
GOOD EVENING I'M RAJAN SERVICE
CHIEF INFORMATION OFFICER FOR
THE DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS
THANK YOU AND IT IS EVENING.
IT IS INDEED IN FISCAL YEAR
NINETEEN TWENTY WE'RE REQUESTING
TWO POINT TWO MILLION FROM THE
GENERAL FUND.
THIS FUNDING WILL REQUEST WILL
SUPPORT THE COMPLETION OF THE
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFE CYCLE
STAGES TO MODERNIZE OUR PHARMACY
EQUIPMENT.
AND PROVIDE INVENTORY MANAGEMENT
SOFTWARE.
IN OUR EXISTING PHARMACY
OPERATIONS WE HAVE DESPAIRED
BACK AND SYSTEMS THAT CREATE
SILENT APPROACH TO PHARMACY
OPERATIONS.
WE MANUALLY TRACK MEDICATION
INVENTORY.
THE PHARMACISTS ARE EQUIPPED
WITH OUTDATED EQUIPMENT OR NONE
AT ALL.
AND THEY'RE UNABLE TO PROCESS
NEW NATIONAL DRUG CODES REQUIRED
FOR ACCURATE BILL IN.
AS A AS A RESULT WE ESTIMATE
ABOUT ONE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IN TRAVEL WASTAGE EACH
YEAR.
STAFF HAVE THE POTENTIAL FOR
ADMINISTERING MEDICATIONS AND
CORRECTLY AND MEDICARE PART D.
BILLING CLAIMS HAVE A LOW
REIMBURSEMENT RATE.
THE PROJECT PLANNING STAGES THAT
ARE INCLUDED WITH THIS REQUEST
WILL CONCLUDE IN FISCAL YEAR.
NINETEEN TWENTY AND POSITIONS
THE POSSESS THE DEPARTMENT TO
EXECUTE A PHARMACY SYSTEM THAT
WILL DEREASE DRUG WASTAGE.
INCREASE COST RECOVERY ENHANCE
OVERALL PATIENT CARE AND
PREPARES FOR AN ELECTRONIC
HEALTH RECORD.
OUR GOALS WILL BE ACCOMPLISHED
THROUGH STANDARDIZING OUR UNIT
DOSE REPACKAGING AN AUTOMATED
DISPENSING MACHINES INVENTORY
MANAGEMENT SOFTWARE DATA
INTEGRATION.
PATIENT SPECIFIC MEDICATION
BILLION AN OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCIES [inaudible]
COMPASS MILIEU -- YES WE DON'T
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL
BUT WE WOULD KNOW THAT THIS --
IS AN IMPORTANT PROJECT TO
SCRUTINIZE CLOSELY BOTH BECAUSE
THE SUCCESS OF THIS PROJECT WILL
DETERMINE WILL HELP DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THE ELECTRONIC
HEALTH RECORD REACHES ITS FULL
POTENTIAL.
AND ALSO WILL SERVE AS A TEST AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT THE DEPARTMENT
IS ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY IMPLEMENT
A LARGE IT PROJECT LIKE THIS AND
SO TO THE EXTENT YOU SEE
pPROBLEMS HERE.
IT WOULD ALERT YOU TO THE FACT
THAT YOU MAY RUN INTO PROBLEMS
WITH ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORD
AND LIKE WAYS TO THE EXTENT THIS
GOES SMOOTHLY THAT BODES WELL
FOR THE ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORD.
I THANK YOU FINANCE.
A DIFFICULT FIGHT THIS PROPOSALS
JUST FOR THE PLANNING TEAM REYES
IT'S NOT SEE THE ACTUAL TOWER
THIS PLANNING OKAY.
RIGHT VERY GOOD THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WISHES OKAY AND FINALLY
ISSUE NUMBER NINE TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS VARIOUS -- I THINK
WE DON'T NEED TO GO INTO.
DETAIL ON EACH ONE OF THEM I
WOULD NOT DO THAT -- SO THIS IS
JUST TO RECALL A REQUEST TO
REALIGN RESOURCES IN NINETEEN
TWENTY AN ON GOING GOING TO
PROPERTY A LINER BUDGET POSITION
AUTHORITY WITHIN OUR EXISTING
RESOURCES IT IS IN NET ZERO
PROPOSAL.
AND REALLY THESE ARE JUST
RECOGNIZING SOME ADJUSTMENTS
THAT NEEDED TO BE MADE --
PRIMARILY A I WOULD NOTE THAT WE
HAVE HAD -- SOME CHANGES IN OUR
BUDGET -- PRESENTATION AND
STRUCTURE OR I'M IN THE RECENT
YEARS -- MOSTLY AS WE PREPARED
TO MOVE TRANSITION TAPE HAS CAL
AS WELL AS TO BRING TRANSPARENCY --
GREATER TRANSPARENCY TO OUR
BUDGET AND SO -- AS WE MOVED IN
SHIFTED ITEMS ACROSS FROM --
WHEN STRUCTURE TO THE OTHER
THINGS I MAY HAVE GOTTEN PLACED
IN THE WRONG BUCKETS AND SO
WE'RE MAKING SOME ADJUSTMENTS
AND THEN THERE'S SOME OTHER
OPERATIONAL CHANGES THAT ARE
BEING AND ADJUSTED FOR AS WELL
IN THE SIDE TECHNICAL?
ADJUSTMENTS OKAY THANK YOU.
ANY COMMENTS ALL TECHNICAL RE
OKAY FINANCE NOW IT'S ALL RIGHT.
OKAY -- SO WITH THAT WE LOOK.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS ON THE
ISSUES RELATING TO THE APARTMENT
STATE HOSPITALS SO ONE THROUGH.
NINE RIGHT WELCOME FOR CHECKER
CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
ON THE STATE -- MINIMUM WAGE
PROPOSAL -- WE APPLAUD THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR MOVING
FORWARD TO FOR THESE PATIENT
WORKERS TO BRING THE BOTH THE
STANDARDIZATION BUT ALSO TO
BRING UP THE TO THE MINIMUM WAGE
I THINK YOU ASK THE RIGHT
QUESTION MISTER CHAIR -- WHY
WOULD WE GO TO THE FEDERAL
MINIMUM WAGE AS OPPOSED TO THE
STATE MINIMUM WAGE WE WOULD
SUGGEST THAT IT SHOULD BE?
THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE AND AND
NOT CREATE THIS -- EXEMPTION
THAT -- HAS IMPACTS BROADER --
THEN I THINK JONES THAN JUST
THIS PROPOSAL.
WE WOULD ALSO SUGGEST.
THAT THERE IS A A FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLAR CAP IN STATUTE DOWN FOR
THE AMOUNT THAT CAN BE RETAINED
IN THE PATIENT'S FUNDS OTHER WHY
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS THAT
OTHERWISE.
IN THE AMOUNTS THAT TO EXCEED
THAT CAN BE -- SWEAT FROM THE
ACCOUNTS FOR A COST OF TREATMENT
SO WITH THIS INCREASED AMOUNT WE
WOULD SUGGEST LIFTING THE CAP --
ALTOGETHER -- AND TO LET THE THE
PATIENTS A CREW FUNDS IN THOSE
ACCOUNTS -- AND BE USE FOR RE
ENTRY PURPOSES.
OTHERWISE SAY IF YOU LEAVE THE
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS -- NOT MUCH
BENEFIT THAT WOULD ACTUALLY BE
HAPPENING -- FOR THE THE WORKERS
ALSO -- THIRD POINT IS THERE IS
A GROUP OF I THINK -- LITTLE
OVER A AYE LITTLE UNDER A
HUNDRED WORKERS THAT HAVE BEEN
RECEIVING -- THIS THE STATE
MINIMUM WAGE AND WE WOULD
SUGGEST THAT THOSE INDIVIDUALS
BE GRANDFATHERED IN AND NOT HAVE
THE REDUCTION IF THE COURSE IS
TO GO TO THE FEDERAL MINIMUM
WAGE.
OKAY THANK YOU.
SO MAYBE IT'S DOES.
ACTUALLY FIRST OF ALL THE FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS ISN'T I MEAN.
I REALIZE THAT THERE THESE
PATIENTS ARE THERE TO IT BUT
THIS IS IS THERE A REASON WE
CAPPED OFF AT FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS I REALIZE THIS IS AN
OLDER POLICY.
YEAH THERE'S AN OLDER POLICY I
CAN KNOW WHAT THE WHAT THE FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR CAP PURPOSE SENSE
IN YEAH SO I MEAN IT PROBABLY
SOME IDEA IN THE PAST THAT
SOMEONE SAID WELL SINCE HERE
WE'RE PAYING FOR ALL THIS STUFF
FOR YOU ORDERS AGO RECLAIM IT
THAT THAT THAT.
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO ME AND I
MEAN FOR THESE PATIENTS I WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT FOR ME AS AS THAT
FIVE HUNDRED CAP A IT DOING IN
THE NINETEEN AND PARTS I DON'T
HAVE THE CALCULATION FIND ME BUT
THE NUMBER OF HOURS THAT OUR
PATIENTS WORK.
IS -- IS.
AT THE MOST ABOUT FIFTY HOURS
PER MONTH AND SO THE THE
CALCULATION OF THAT IS STILL-UNDERNEATH THAT FIVE HUNDRED CAP
FOR THE MONTHLY.
SOME FOR A MONTHLY. FIVE HUNDRED
PER MONTH THERE'S A FIVE HUNDRED
PERIOD.
YEAH IT'S FIVE HUNDRED AT THE
CITY SWEET BUT IT WOULD BE NICE.
BY MONTH SO ANYTIME ON ACCOUNT
EXCEEDS.
FIVE HUNDRED THE PATIENTS
NOTIFIED.
WE WILL BE SWEEPING YOUR ACCOUNT.
AND THEN TO LIVE SO EACH MONTH
THEY CAN ONLY MAKE FIVE HUNDRED
BUT THEY COULD CALCULATE FIVE
HUNDRED EACH MONTH SO I MEAN
IT'S UP TO FIVE HUNDRED SO YOU
GET A FIVE HUNDRED A THOUSAND
THOUSAND FIVE OR RIGHT BUT IT'S
NOT BASED ON EARNED.
YOU CAN RECEIVE MONEY IN OTHER
WAYS.
MEMBERS COULD FAMILY MEMBERS
RELATIVE RIGHT HANDS COULD SEND
MONEY AND SO ANYTIME YOU'RE
THRESHOLD GOES BEYOND.
FIVE HUNDRED THERE'S ATTEMPT TO
SWEEP.
WHY ARE WE DOING THAT?
COST OF TREATMENT THAT SMILE.
IT'S IN THE STANDING OUT.
MAYBE IT WELL.
IS THAT A COMMENTS FROM FINANCE
YES NO IS I I DON'T KNOW THE
EXACT WORDS BUT IT IT'S BASED ON
CONVERSATION IS MY UNDERSTANDING
THOUGH MANY OF THE TIMES THESE
PATIENTS ARE SPENDING THEIR
MONEY -- ADDED YOU KNOW CANTEEN
THERE'S FOOD THERE'S FOOD
VENDORS THAT THEY COULD SPEND
THEIR MONEY ON SO.
I MEAN THIS IS A THAT'S THEIR
DECISION RIGHT AT WHETHER THEY
WANT HI BUT I I SO I REALIZE
THAT.
WE HAVE THIS TO MY TO MY MIND A
LITTLE ANTIQUATED.
OF RIGHT I MEAN.
AND AND THEN.
I I I I I WOULD SUGGESTS LIVING
IN A REALIZE IS NOT PART OF THE
PROPOSAL'S BEEN SITTING THERE
BUT IN MY MIND WHILE WE JUST GET
RID OF THAT I AM NOT SURE WHY WE
HAVE IT'S IT'S SENS WRONG
MESSAGE TO PEOPLE RIGHT I MEAN
REALLY IF THEY WANT. TO SPEND
THEIR MONEY AND NOT HAVE ANYBODY
THAT'S THAT'S FINE IF THEY WANT
TO SAVE MONEY AND BUILD UP
SOMETHING FOR WHATEVER PURPOSE
THEY WANNA BUILD IT UP FOR I'M
NOT SURE WHY WE'RE DISCOURAGING
THAT BY SAYING THAT.
HIS YOU SEE MORE IN FIVE HUNDRED
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THE MONEY
FROM YOU THAT'S NOT THE KIND OF
MESSAGE YOU WANT TO SEND TO
PEOPLE.
SO WHY NOT JUST GET RID OF IT
AND LESS THAN JUST AS OF DOLLARS
OF FEDERAL REASON FOR HAVE IT
WHY SHOULD THE STATE BE DOING
THAT.
WE COULD TAKE A LOOK AT IT I DID
WANT TO SHARE THE ONE KNOWS.
I WAS TOURING AT METRO AND I
HAPPEN TO COME ACROSS A A
PAINTER PATIENT WORKER.
EARNING A DECENT AMOUNT MAYBE A
COUPLE HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH
BUT HE WAS AWARE OF THE FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR THRESHOLD.
SO ON PURPOSE EVERY TIME HE
EARNED HIS PAY HE PUT THE
REQUEST IN.
I'M GONNA SEND MY MONEY OUT AND
HE'S SENDING IT.
INTENTIONALLY TO MOM BECAUSE HIS
HIS -- GRAND DREAM IS I'M GOING
AT ONCE I GET OUT I'M GONNA HAVE
A POT OF MONEY TO HELP SUSTAIN
AFTERLIFE AT STATE HOSPITALS.
SO THESE PATIENTS AS CHRISS
MENTION BAIT THEY KNOW THE LAW
OR THE RULE AND THEY ARE USING
THAT MONEY OR FINDING IT BUYING
CANTEEN.
SO AVOID THE SWEEP YEAH SO WE
BUT LET'S GET RID OF THE SUITE.
I'VE REALIZED CAN WE GOING
THROUGH THAT IS ANOTHER PROPOSAL
GET RID THE SWEEP.
WE'LL TAKE A LOOK AT IT OKAY
THANK YOU I AND AND AND AND
PROBABLY COSTA SOME TIME AND
MONEY OR EFFORT ON THE STATE'S
PART TO DO THE SWEET ANYWAY SO
WHY ARE WE SPENDING MONEY ON
THAT SO.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT ANYTHING
ELSE OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE OF COURSE ALL THE
ITEMS ARE ON CALL ON HOLD RIGHT
NOW UNTIL.
MAY REALIZE THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH OKAY
[inaudible]
OUR CHAMPIONS TO COME IT CAME AT
THE VERY END.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
A COUNTY COMMISSION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YOU GET THE AWARD FOR LIKE
INSURANCE OF SITTING HERE
WAITING I DON'T KNOW HOW LONG
YOU ACTUALLY AT THE WAY THAT.
AND SENATOR THIS REMINDS ME OF
MY DAYS ON THE TRACK TEAM I WAS
OFTEN LAST.
BUT YOU ARE ALWAYS THERE RIGHT.
THAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
YOU DID NOT.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO WE HAVE TWO ITEMS
FOR YOU SO WE'LL START OFF WITH
ISSUE NUMBER ONE WHICH IS THE
INNOVATION INCUBATOR
IMPLEMENTATION.
YEAH PERFECT THAT THANKS VERY
MUCH TOBY EWING ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSE SERVICES OVER SEND COUNTY
COMMISSION.
SO -- AS IDENTIFIED IN THE
ANALYSIS.
LAST YEAR THE BUDGET INCLUDED
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
COMMISSION TO SUPPORT OUR WORK
ON INNOVATION HALF OF THAT THIS
YEAR HALF OF THAT NEXT YEAR.
AS ORIGINALLY ENVISIONED WE
INTENDED TO ESTABLISH A SORT OF
A THIRD PARTY THAT WOULD
FACILITATE THIS WORK IN IN
TALKING WITH THE COUNTIES IN
TALKING WITH PEOPLE WHO WORK IN
THIS SPACE LOOKING AT MODELS
AROUND THE COUNTRY AND ELSEWHERE.
THE COMMISSION ELECTED TO DO
THIS WORK IN HOUSE.
PRIMARILY SO THAT WE CAN
STRENGTHEN THE ALIGNMENT BETWEEN
THE FACILITATION AROUND
INNOVATION AND THE COMMISSION'S
APPROVAL AUTHORITY WITH THE
ASSUMPTION THAT TO THE EXTENT
THAT THE COMMISSION IS HELPING
TO SUPPORT.
THE DESIGN OF INNOVATIONS ON THE
FRONT END IT CAN WE CAN
STREAMLINE THE APPROVAL PROCESS
ON THE BACKEND.
AND SO WE'VE BEEN DOING THAT
WORK AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
THE COUNTIES WERE SUPPORTING --
AT THE MOMENT FOR INNOVATIONS
THAT WE INCOME AND IN PARTS WITH
THE COUNTIES ANTICIPATE WILL
FUNDAMENTALLY REDUCE THE
INVOLVEMENT OF KNOW HOW
CONSUMERS FOR THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM WHICH WILL HAVE
THE UP UPSTREAM.
DOWNSTREAM IMPACTS OF REDUCING
THE NUMBER OF FOLKS WERE RISK OF
A FELONY INVOLVEMENT IN THE US
AND COMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL --
DESIGNATION AND AND SO --
WORKING WITH FINANCE WE HAD
PROPOSED TO HAVE SOME INTERNAL
STAFFING TO STRENGTHEN THAT WORK
INTO THE PROPOSAL IS FOR TWO
POSITIONS FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS.
TO HELP MAKE THAT PROJECT WORK.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT LA ONLY COMMENTS FINANCE
GOVERNMENTS OKAY WELL.
CERTAINLY.
GOOD TO BRING STUFF IN HOUSE
RIGHT.
EXCELLENT -- THAT'S GONE ISSUE
NUMBER TWO COMMISSION BUDGET
REQUESTS AND PROPOSALS FOR
INVESTMENTS [inaudible]
THOUGH THE THE THE QUESTION IS
ASKING FOR THE NUMBER OF THINGS
HERE BUT I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE FIRST THREE OKAY BECAUSE
THEY COME AS A PACKAGE AND
THERE'S THERE'S A FOURTH PEACE
AND SO DURING THE TESTIMONY.
AT OUR LAST HEARING WE TALK WITH
YOU ABOUT THE COMMISSION'S WORK
IN LOOKING AT DATA.
AND SO WE HAVE TAX OF THE
ANNOUNCES TALKS ABOUT IT'S
ACTUALLY LIVE TODAY IT WENT LIVE
A COUPLE -- A COUPLE WEEKS AGO --
CURRENTLY YOU CAN GO ON THE
QUESTIONS WEBSITE AND AND GET A
LOT OF INFORMATION ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH DOLLARS -- YOU CAN DO
KEYWORD SEARCH AND DOWNLOAD
INFORMATION ON ABOUT TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED IMAGES A FUNDED PROGRAMS
ALL ACROSS THE STATE AND WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO IDENTIFY -- ONE
OUTCOME WHICH IS LOOKING AT FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS.
IN THE EXAMPLE OF FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIPS WERE FINDING A
LARGE PERCENTAGE OF FOLKS AREN'T
ARE DISCHARGING THIS IN ROLLING
FROM THESE SERVICES BUT NOT
MEETING GOALS.
LOTS OF REASONS FOR THAT THE
PEOPLE BEING SERVED BY FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS TEND TO BE
THE MOST DIFFICULT TO SERVE IN
COMMUNITY SETTINGS.
FULL SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS WERE
ORIGINALLY DESIGNED TO KEEP
PEOPLE OUT OF JAIL OUT OF STATE
HOSPITALS OFF THE STREETS AND
OUT OF OUT OF ER'S.
IN AND SO ONWE WANT TO CONTINUE
THAT WORK AND DO IT AND IN A IN
A WITH WITH A BROADER FOCUS.
THE COMMISSION CURRENTLY THE LAW
CURRENTLY STE TESTIFIES TO THE
COMMISSION'S AUTHORITY IS OVER
THE IMAGE TO SAY BUT ALSO THE
CHILDREN SYSTEM OF CARE DOSS
MCCARRON OLDER ADULTS SYSTEM OF
CARE.
OUR WORK HAS BEEN LIMITED TO THE
IMAGES SAY DOLLARS AND IMAGES
THEY PROGRAMS MOSTLY BECAUSE OF
RESOURCE CONSTRAINTS.
OUR ARGUMENT IS THAT TO CREATE A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM WE NEED TO
SEE ALL THE COMPONENTS OF THAT
IMAGE ESSAYS ABOUT 25% OF THE
MONEY.
AND ARGUABLY ABOUT 25% OF THE
SYSTEM.
IT'S VERY USEFUL TO KNOW A LOT
ABOUT ONE OF THE TIRES ON YOUR
CAR IT'S MORE USEFUL TO KNOW IF
ALL FOUR OF THEM ARE GOING TO
HOLD UP WHEN YOU'RE TAKING THAT
LONG TRIP ACROSS THE DESERT.
AS PART OF THAT.
AS THE COMMISSION IDENTIFIES
CHALLENGES WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
OFFER STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THOSE CHALLENGES SO IN THE
INSTANCE OF FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIPS WERE WORKING WITH
ABOUT A DOZEN COUNTIES TO DESIGN
A COLLABORATIVE INNOVATION
PROJECT.
THAT WOULD STRENGTHEN THOSE FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS ARE
PROPOSALS AROUND DATA ARE TO
STRENGTHEN OUR ABILITY TO TELL
THE LARGER STORY OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM DOLLARS SERVICES
AND OUTCOMES.
BUT AS WE DO THAT OUTCOMES WORK
WE WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THE
INNOVATION DOLLARS THAT WERE
AWARDED LAST YEAR AND MAKE THEM
ON GOING.
WE WE WANT TO SUPPORT THE
ABILITY OF COUNTIES TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY THE REASON FOR
THAT.
IS WE AS INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES
INVEST IN INNOVATIONS IN THEIR
SUCCESSFUL THEY'RE OFTEN SEEN AS
THE SANTA CLARA MIRACLE.
AND WHAT WE WANT IS TO BRING
TOGETHER GROUPS OF COUNTIES TO
WORK TOGETHER INITIATIVE SHARED
CONCERN PARTICULAR ISSUES OF
STATEWIDE CONCERN.
FULL SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS ARE
ABOUT AN EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR ANNUAL INVESTMENT UNDER
THE STATE'S RULES.
THE STATE HAS AN INTEREST IN
STRENGTHENING THAT AND SO OUR
PROPOSAL IS TO LEVERAGE THIS TWO
AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS TO
STRENGTHEN HOW THE COUNTY SPEND
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF AND
IF HAVE -- IMAGE TO SAY
INNOVATION DOLLARS.
RELATED TO THAT IS THE THIRD
ITEM ON HERE OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE.
WE E ARE OF THE MIND THAT IN
CALIFORNIA AND IN THE COUNTRY WE
HAVE THE EXPERTISE THE AWARENESS
THE CAPACITY. TO STRENGTHEN OUR
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM BUT THAT
CAPACITY ISN'T NECESSARILY IN A
COUNTY OR IN ALL COUNTIES.
AND SO THROUGH THE FACILITATION
OF INNOVATION THE ADDITION OF OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND THERE'S
A THIRD COMPONENT IT'S NOT IN
FRONT OF YOU AT THE MOMENT.
YEAH IT WAS ON THE AGENDA A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO TO TREAT US
DOLLARS AS INCENTIVE DOLLARS.
THE IDEA IS WE WOULD DO THE DATA
ANALYSIS IDENTIFIED CHALLENGES
AND BE ABLE TO INVEST INCENTIVE
DOLLARS T. A. AND FACILITATION
TO STRENGTHEN THOSE PROGRAMS
THAT NEED SOME WORK.
SO THAT SO THE THE THE DATA
WORKED INNOVATION SUPPORT THE TA
AND THE TRIAGE MONEY WE TALKED
ABOUT IT A PRIOR HEARING ARE
PART OF THAT STRATEGY.
SEPARATE FROM THAT IS A REQUEST
TO PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDS
TO STRENGTHEN ADVOCACY ON BEHALF
OF HAVING TO REFUGEES.
WE RECEIVED FUNDING LAST YEAR --
WE HAVE AWARDED THAT FOR THOSE
FUNDS WERE AWARDED LAST WEEK
WERE IN THAT APPEAL PROCESS AT
THE MOMENT.
BUT AS PART OF THIS WORK WE JUST
HEARD OVERWHELMING STORIES OF
THE STRUGGLES THAT IMMIGRANTS
AND REFUGEES ARE FACING IN
CALIFORNIA WITH REGARD TO MENTAL
HEALTH AND SO THE COMMISSION IS
ASKING TO AUGMENT THAT SUPPORT.
SO THAT WE CAN DO MORE WITH
THOSE DOLLARS.
THE LAST ITEM IN THE ANALYSIS IS
THE M. P. E. I REQUEST UNDER SB --
TEN FOR THE COMMISSION IS
DIRECTED TO ESTABLISH A
FRAMEWORK AND STRATEGY AND AN
EVALUATION COMPONENT FOR P. E.
I..
SIMILAR TO THE WORK WE'VE DONE
WITH INNOVATION TO TRY TO BRING
FOCUS TO THAT COMPONENT OF THE
ACT.
THIS IS REALLYIMPORTANT WORK IT
IS PERHAPS THE MOST IMPORTANT
WORK BECAUSE OUR ABILITY TO BE
EFFECTIVE THROUGH PREVENTION AND
EARLY INTERVENTION CAN REDUCE
OUR LONG TERM COSTS.
AND JUST AS A REMINDER UNDER P.
I'D THE LANGUAGE IS ABOUT
REDUCING HOMELESSNESS
UNEMPLOYMENT CHILD WELFARE
INVOLVEMENT SCHOOL FAILURE
SUICIDE AND OTHER ISSUES AND SO
WE SEE PROFOUND IMPLICATIONS IF
WE CAN SUPPORT THE WORK OF THE
COUNTIES.
REALLY FOCUS THE P. E. I.
STRATEGY TO STRENGTHEN OUR
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM AND MOVE
MORE TOWARDS A UP A CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE MENTAL HEALTH OF THE
PUBLIC.
RATHER THAN SIMPLY THE DELIVERY
OF MENTAL HEALTH THROUGH PUBLIC
DOLLARS AND SO WE'RE ASKING FOR
FOR POSITIONS TO MAKE THAT WORK
MORE STRATEGIC AND FOCUSED.
TRY TO BE QUICK I WASN'T A
SPRINTER BUT I DID MY BEST
TONIGHT.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU COMMENTS
REALLY EL [inaudible]
FINANCE [inaudible]
RIGHT.
OKAY THANK YOU -- THE APPRECIATE
THE STRATEGY -- PUBLIC COMMENT
ON EITHER ITEM FOR THE SO AGE
OKAY SAYING NO PUBLIC COMMENT.
THE THE THIS PROPOSALS AND
REALLY APPRECIATE THE ACTUALLY --
THE COMMISSION AND I SHE TAKING
ON IT'S A SAID -- I'VE ALWAYS
BEEN A LITTLE FRUSTRATED WE LOOK
AT MENTAL HEALTH WE OFTEN LOOK
AT THE SPOT THAT PINE WE'RE NOT
LOOKING AT ALL OF THEM TOGETHER
SO I APPRECIATE THE COMMISSION
TRYING.
TO DO THAT WITH THAT YOUR DATA
ELEMENTS AS WELL AS OF TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW.
TERMS OF PROMOTING INNOVATION
THAT BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER
COLLABORATE THANK YOU.
THIS ARE PUBLIC COMMENT SO WHERE
WAS SICK OR OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO WE DO HAVE A
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSAL THANK YOU
SORRY I MISSED MY NOTES RIGHT
WHEN TO COME UP HERE -- THROUGH
THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK.
AND SELL YES I AM VERY WELL
AWARE THAT I'M LAST.
CORRECT.
I'M HERE IN SAVAGE AND WE HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK SEE.
TEN AND WE'RE HERE AND BACK IN
MARCH WE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT SOME DATA AND COMMENTS
ON MENTAL HEALTH DISPARITIES
BEFORE YOUR OTHER COMMITTEE AND
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS WE
REALLY WANTED TO EMPHASIZE THAT
THE TIME IS WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
DATE ON MENTAL HEALTH.
DISPARITIES WE CONTINUE TO SEE
REALLY FAST AND ALSO PERSISTENT
DISPARITIES WE'RE NOT SEEING
THINGS IMPROVE OVER TIME.
AND SO WE REALLY WANT TO THINK
AB WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION ON HOW DO WE
PURSUE A REALLY FOCUSED STRATEGY
AROUND MENTAL HEALTH DISPARITIES
BECAUSE WE NEED TO SEE THEM GET
BETTER.
AND O WE FEEL LIKE THERE'S
REALLY TWO PARTS TO THIS ONE IS
AROUND ACCOUNTABILITY AND ONE IS
AROUND INVESTMENT.
AND AND SO THE AND THE
ACCOUNTABILITY PIECE WE HAVE A
BILL THAT'S MOVING THROUGH THE
PROCESS.
I'M ITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING
BUT THIS IS THE INVESTMENT PART
BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE THAT.
WE CAN HOLD COUNTIES TO A
STANDARD WE CAN SAY THESE ARE
THE BENCHMARK IN AND THAT IS OUR
BIG HOLE BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
GIVE THEM THE TOOLS IN THE
ASSISTANCE. TO DO BETTER AND SO
AND OUR PROPOSAL IS FOR FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS -- ON GOING FROM
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT --
ADMIN FIND IT FOR BASICALLY I'M
FOUR COMPONENTS OF A STRATEGY
AND REDUCING MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES SO BETTER DATA
COLLECTION THE DATA WE PRESENTED
TO YOU WITH VERY LIMITED BUT
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE RIGHT SO
BETTER DATA COLLECTION SO THAT
COUNTIES AND AND OTHER ENTITIES
CAN MAKE INFORMED PROGRAMMATIC
DECISIONS.
I'M TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WE'VE
TALKED TO PROBABLY HALF THE
COUNTIES IN THE FALL SAID WE
KNOW WE HAVE A PROBLEM WE WANTED
YOU BETTER WE NEED SOME HELP --
SO TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE VERY
MUCH ALIGNED WITH THE AC AND
WHAT MISTER EWING IS PROPOSING
AND THEN A COMPONENT AROUND
INNOVATION TO HELP PEOPLE TRY
OUT NEW THINGS THAT MIGHT WORK
BETTER THAN WHAT WE'RE DOING
TODAY RIGHT TRYING OUT NEW
THINGS OF VALUE EIGHT THEM AND
THEN SEE WHAT WE CAN.
SCALE -- AND INCORPORATE INTO
OUR SYSTEM AND THEN THE FINAL
PIECE AROUND INCENTIVES SO HOW
DO WE BOTH TELL COUNTIES THEY
NEED TO MEET SOME BENCHMARKS THE
NEED TO REDUCE DISPARITIES BUT
THEN REWARD THEM FOR DOING SO --
SO THAT'S OUR PROPOSAL IN A
NUTSHELL AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS I'M AND I DO KNOW
WILL BE SITTING DOWN WITH THE AC
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
LATER THIS WEEK ON IT.
OKAY -- SO ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMISSION WE WE'VE TALKED WITH
SAID WITH C. PAN AND AND THEIR
PARTNERS IN TERMS OF THIS
PROPOSAL AS YOU CAN SEE IT'S
VERY MUCH ALIGNED.
WITH A STRATEGY THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING I IN I THINK THAT --
YOU KNOW THE COMMISSION HAS NOT
FORMALLY ENGAGED IN THIS IT'S
VERY CONSISTENT WITH THE WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING WE VERY MUCH
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT DISPARITIES
WE'VE DONE A LITTLE BIT OF WORK
TO TRY TO MAP DISPARITIES USING
THAT MEDICAL CLAIMS DATA.
AND TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHETHER
OR NOT WE'RE REINFORCING
DISPARITIES TO ACCESS KINDS OF
STRATEGIES -- WE'VE REQUIRED
UNDER OUR P. I REGULATIONS THAT
THAT PROVIDERS REPORT OUT RACIAL
AND ETHNIC AND OTHER DETAILED
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION SO WE
CAN BETTER UNDERSTAND ACTUALLY
WHO IS RECEIVING CARE NOT JUST
WHO WE PLANS ARE BECAUSE WE
ACTUALLY SERVED.
PART OF THE CHALLENGES THOSE
THOSE THAT REGULATORY RULE ONLY
APPLIES TO P. I. INNOVATION
BECAUSE THAT'S THE LIMIT OF THE
COMMISSION'S AUTHORITY.
SO I I THINK THIS PROPOSAL IS IT
YOU KNOW SPOT ON VERY CONSISTENT
WITH THE WITH BOTH OUR STRATEGY
AS WELL AS OUR AREAS OF CONCERN.
I THINK YOU KNOW WE WOULD WANT
TO THINK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW
THE PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE AND
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSAL INTERACT
THEY CERTAINLY DON'T CONFLICT --
INLET BUT BUT AS YOU KNOW OUR
CONCERN WOULD BE IF YOU'RE IN A
POSITION OF DOING ONE OR THE
OTHER HOW WOULD YOU SORT OF
MANAGE THAT.
AND THAT'S A QUESTION OF ARE
THERE ADEQUATE RESOURCES AND
WITH EVERY SUPPORT AND AND I
THINK THAT'S THAT'S WHERE THE
CONVERSATION NEEDS TO MOVE
FORWARD TO UNDERSTAND HOW WE
MIGHT DO THAT OKAY.
RIGHT AWAY -- COMMENTS.
FINANCE OKAY SO I GUESS WE'LL
ONE THE QUESTIONS I'VE SEEN BOTH
THE THE FOR THE PROPOSALS IS
THAT.
SIR WAY THEY CAN KIND OF COME
TOGETHER -- BECAUSE FOR EXAMPLE
WE CAN HAVE A STAND ALONE
PROPOSAL LOOKING DISPARITIES BUT
WE NOW HAVE THIS DATA COLLECTION
ABOUT IT IS THAT I WELL CAN WE
INCORPORATE.
INTO THAT SO THAT WE'RE SO WE
DON'T HAVE TWO DIFFERENT SYSTEMS
RUNNING.
IN PARALLEL AND AND IN MANY WAYS
THE ONLY.
ONE THE THAT THAT'S VERY EASY TO
BE ONE OF YOUR DATA ELEMENTS IN
THE LARGER ONES YOU CAN FOLD
THAT IN BUT LOW AND AND DO YOU
HAVE CASH TO GET MORE OUT OF IT
THAT WAY SO IS THAT SOMETHING.
YOU'RE.
LOOKING AT TALKING ABOUT YEAH I
MEAN I THINK LIKE MOST HEARING
SAID THAT'S THE CONVERSATION
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE NEXT THEY
THINK -- WE WOULD VERY MUCH
AGREED DISPARITIES SHOULD BE A
PIECE OF THINGS I THINK WE ALSO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
REALLY A FOCUS OF ANY STRATEGY
BECAUSE I THINK WE'VE SEEN.
YOU KNOW WE'VE INVESTED. TWO
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IN MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT RIGHT AND
BECAUSE DISPARITIES HASN'T BEEN
AN EXPLICIT FOCUS OF MOST OF THE
WORK WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT
REDUCING DISPARITIES IN SOME
CASES FOR MAKING THEM.
WORSE I THINK WE CAN DEFINITELY
GO IN THAT DIRECTION WE JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT IS
BOTH YEAH YEAH YOU KNOW I THINK
WHAT YOU BUT YOU MAYES.
SEE IS RABBI THE DATA SIDE MAKES
SENSE TO INTEGRATE MAY THINK
ABOUT.
HAVING GAIL THE A COMPONENT OF
WHEN YOU START TALKING ABOUT
TECHNICAL SYSTEMS AND SO FORTH
THAT HAS MORE OF A DE CHARETTE
SPERRY'S HAS A STAND ALONE EL
HAS IS PARTICULAR FOCUS -- FOR
CERTAIN PORTION OF THAT -- SO
THAT -- DOESN'T GET LOST IN THE
SHUFFLE KIND OF THING BUT ALL
RIGHT WELL LIKE CHURCH THOSE
CONVERSATIONS VITAL ALSO DON'T
WANT TO HAVE LIKE.
STILL DEEPLY CATION AND AN
EFFICIENT USE OF RESOURCES SO.
WE AGREE COMPLETELY AND I AND I
THINK THAT -- YOU KNOW
CONCEPTUALLY VALUE WISE WE'RE
EXACTLY ON THE SAME PAGE THE
QUESTION IS WHAT'S THE PATH TO
GET THERE IN THE STRUCTURE OF
THE BUDGET.
SO THAT WEEK SO SO THAT IT'S NOT
TOO DISPARATE SYSTEMS.
THERE WERE ALSO NOT SORT OF YOU
KNOW TRUST US WE WILL TAKE THIS
ON RIDE INSIDE SO I DO THINK IN
IN A CONVERSATION WITH THE C.
PEN AND AND BUT IT CHAIR TAKING
ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE -- WE WE
WANT TO FIND THAT PATH AS WELL
WE JUST HAVEN'T DONE THAT YET
THEN I GUESS THE OTHER PIECE
RECOGNIZING THE LIMITATIONS OF
THE COMMISSION TO IN TERMS OF
DATA -- OR YOU ALSO LOOKING AT
AND AGAIN I DON'T KNOW WHY.
BECAUSE SUMMER TEAMS BILLS OVER
AND ASSEMBLY SEVEN CHANCE TO
LOOK AT IT.
IN TERMS OF DATA COLLECTION THAT
WE REALLY CAN'T MEDI CAL THE
MENTAL HEALTH -- DATA COLLECTION
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T CUTS I MEAN.
THE CELL TO BE SURE THAT -- WE
GET THE DATA YEAH THE AND
DEFINITELY I THINK THAT'S PART
OF WHAT WE'RE DOING IN THE BILL
AND WOULD HOPE TO BRING INTO
THIS TOO I THINK.
YOU KNOW WE'VE LOOKED AT A LOT
OF THE MEDICAL DATA THAT'S WHAT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO GET THROUGH
PREVIOUS LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS.
IN OUR BILL WE ALSO REQUIRE --
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IN THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
EQUITY AND THE SURGEON GENERAL
TO WORK TOGETHER ON THIS ARE
TRYING TO BRING FROM AN AGENCY
LEVEL TO ALL OF THE DATA INTO
ONE PLACE I THINK IT'S
DEFINITELY ARTICLE.
OKAY ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS.
SEEING NONE I WANT THANK YOU ALL
SO MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS.
AND REALLY APPRECIATE UP WILL BE
HOLDING THOSE ITEMS OPEN.
BECAUSE UNTIL AFTER A REVISED
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.
OKAY WELL AND BELIEVE THIS
CONCLUDES THE AGENDA OF THE
SENATE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER -- THREE AND
WITH THAT WE ARE ADJOURNED THANK
YOU